I THINK THEY LOWERED THE
TEMPERATURE SO WE CAN GET OUT OF
HERE FASTER. THAT WAS THE WHOLE
PLAN. HI. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
TWO FUN FACTS I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU. ONE, A PROBE IS
HAPPENING. HAPPENING RIGHT NOW,
AND I'VE TOLD MY TEAM NOT TO
TEXT ME ON WHAT BILLS DIED OF
MINE OR SURVIVED. SO I DON'T
HAVE TO GET FURTHER ANGRY DURING
THE SESSION ON WHAT BILLS DIED
FOR ME. SECOND FUN FACT CAL
MATTERS HAS A DIGITAL DEMOCRACY
WEBSITE AND IT RANKS THE MOST
TALKATIVE LEGISLATORS. AND RIGHT
NOW I'M NUMBER TWO. SO I THINK
I'M GOING TO REPLACE SENATOR
LAIRD AFTER THIS SUBCOMMITTEE AS
NUMBER ONE, BECAUSE THEY TAKE IN
ACCOUNT SUBCOMMITTEES. AND I
THINK THIS IS THE ONLY PLACE I
HAVE MY SPEECHES NOWHERE ELSE.
SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
NUMBER ONE AFTER THIS. OKAY FUN
FACTS OUT OF THE WAY, TODAY'S
PLAN IS TO DO AN OVERVIEW OF ALL
THE PROPOSED AND MAY REVISE NEW
BCP'S NEW BUDGET SOLUTIONS, AND
SO FORTH. UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE ANY REVISION OF
ANYTHING THAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET. THEY'RE ALL
STILL PRETTY MUCH INTACT.
UNFORTUNATELY, HERE WE'RE JUST
PILING UP ON TOP OF THAT, AND
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
HEALTH PORTION OF OUR HHS
COMMITTEE. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
DO PUBLIC COMMENT, AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO THE HUMAN
SERVICES PORTION OF IT. DURING
THE HUMAN SERVICES PORTION OF IT
, WE'RE GOING TO DO PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER MAJOR ISSUES. FOR
EXAMPLE, AFTER WE TALK ABOUT
CHILD CARE, WE DO PUBLIC COMMENT
SAYS PUBLIC COMMENT, FOSTER
SYSTEM. ANYTHING THAT IMPACTS
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT, AND SO
FORTH. JUST FOR THOSE KIND OF
PORTIONS. AND THEN WE'LL COME
BACK FOR THE FOLLOWING 2 TO 3
SESSIONS FOR, FOR VOTING. DID I
MISS ANYTHING? OKAY. THAT WAS MY
ALLERGY. I ASKED FOR OVERVIEW
SECTIONS, THAT DEAL WITH CASE
CHANGES AND, UPTAKES. AND SO
FORTH. THAT WOULD BE AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE, FOR THOSE KIND OF ON
THOSE ISSUES. AND THEN WE FOCUS
MORE ON THE PROPOSED BUDGET
SOLUTIONS AND BCP'S. OKAY. WITH
THAT, LET'S DIVE INTO CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AREA. WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
A MAY REVISION OVERVIEW. I ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, LAUP,
JOIN US. CHECK. ALL RIGHT, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. JOSEPH DAWSON,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, BEFORE WE
BEGIN, WE WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS TO
HIGHLIGHT THE OVERALL BUDGET
STRUCTURE OF THE MAY REVISE, IF
THAT'S OKAY, THE MAY REVISE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO BRIDGE
THE ADDITIONAL SHORTFALL THAT
HAS BEEN ESTIMATED SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN 2425, AS
WELL AS 2526, WHICH ALSO HAS A
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS, THE
ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZE
MAINTAINING CORE SERVICES SUCH
AS MEDI-CAL AND CALWORKS, WHILE
ALSO IDENTIFYING ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THAT COULD BE PULLED
BACK AS POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS. THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD EMPHASIZE
THAT THESE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
ARE NOT A VALUE STATEMENT OF
THESE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS, BUT
RATHER A WAY TO SOLVE THE BUDGET
PROBLEM AT HAND. AS NOTED BY THE
GOVERNOR, THE MAY REVISION PUTS
FORWARD A BALANCED AND
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET THAT PUTS US
ON A STRONG FOOTING GOING
FORWARD. SO THAT WE MAY CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT CORE PROGRAMS IN THE
FUTURE. LASTLY, THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOTE THAT
THE MAY REVISE IS A PROPOSAL,
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT HAVE
ALTERNATIVES TO SOME OF THESE
SOLUTIONS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE COME TO A
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT. AND WITH
THAT, I WILL HAND IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO PROVIDE UPDATES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR BRENDAN
MCCARTHY, HHS. I WILL GO THROUGH
THE MAY REVISION ITEMS FOR OUR
AGENCY. THE FIRST ONE IS OUR ONE
BUDGET SOLUTION AND AGENCY. THIS
IS THE PROPOSED REVERSION OF ALL
OF THE FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES INNOVATION
ACCELERATOR, WHICH WE'VE
DISCUSSED IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
BEFORE, IN TOTAL, IT REVERTS $55
MILLION OVER CURRENT YEAR,
BUDGET YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR PLUS
ONE, OUR OTHER ADJUSTMENTS IN
ACTION ITEMS IN THE MAY REVISION
IS, A TRANSFER OF THE OFFICE OF
EMPLOYMENT, FIRST FROM AGENCY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. THAT WAS AN
AUGMENTATION IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET, BUT WITH A DELAYED START
UP UNTIL THE TO JULY 2024, WE
ARE PROPOSING TO SHIFT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND FUNDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
BECAUSE WE THINK THEY HAVE MUCH
MORE PROGRAMMATIC EXPERTISE IN
THIS AREA TO QUICKLY STAND UP AN
OFFICE TO IMPLEMENT THE
EMPLOYMENT FIRST, POLICIES, SUCH
AS PHASING OUT OF SUBMINIMUM
WAGE. AND SO WE AT HHS WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR DDS
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT ANY POLICIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPED BY THAT OFFICE, THE
NEXT ITEM IS AN INCREASE IN OUR
FEDERAL FUNDS AUTHORITY OF $1.3
MILLION FOR THE PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT AWARD. THIS IS
JUST INCREASING FOR ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WILL BE
COMING DOWN IN THE BUDGET YEAR,
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
REAPPROPRIATING MONEY FOR THE Â
POST SYSTEM. THIS IS SOMETHING
AT MSA, PHYSICIAN ORDER FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT. THIS IS AN
ELECTRONIC SYSTEM TO COMPILE
THOSE, THEY ARE IN THE PLANNING
STAGE OF THIS, AND THIS IS JUST
A REAPPROPRIATION OF $6.3
MILLION TO CONTINUE PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT SYSTEM, WE
ALSO HAVE A REAPPROPRIATION ALSO
RELATED TO MSA OF $2.1 MILLION.
THIS IS PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMS CENTRAL REGISTER
REPLACEMENT PROJECT. THIS IS A
AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
TO CONSOLIDATE VARIOUS SYSTEMS
THAT THAT TAKE REPORTED DATA
FROM LOCAL EMS SYSTEMS, THAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT UP
TO THE STATE. AND HISTORICALLY,
THIS HAS BEEN DONE IN A SEVERAL
SYSTEMS. AND SO THIS IS A NEW
SYSTEM THAT WOULD CONSOLIDATE
ALL THAT REPORTING FOR MORE
EFFICIENCIES AND BETTER DATA
TRANSPARENCY. QUESTION ON THAT.
SO SYSTEM IS IT'S A BRAND NEW
SYSTEM. IT'S A REPLACEMENT FOR
SEVERAL EXISTING SYSTEMS. AND
WE'RE JUST CONSOLIDATING IT INTO
ONE YES, INTO ONE MODERN SYSTEM
SO THAT WE CAN RETIRE THOSE
OLDER EXISTING SYSTEMS. HOW WE
STARTED THE PROCESS. WE'RE IN
THE PLANNING STAGE. RIGHT OKAY.
IS THIS GOING TO HELP WITH THE
PLANNING? YES OKAY, AND THEN WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL. THIS IS PART OF
THE PROPOSAL, THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO REORGANIZE SOME OF
THE, ASPECTS OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. SO ONE OF
THOSE IS THAT, THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE TO ADVANCE PRECISION
MEDICINE WOULD BE TRANSFERRED
FROM OPR TO CAL HHS. AND SO THIS
IS IT'S GENERAL FUND OF 30 OF
$31 MILLION, AS WELL AS THE
STAFF SHIFTING TO CAL HHS TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK, WHICH IS
LARGELY BEEN FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING RESEARCH INTO
PRECISION MEDICINE AND
COORDINATION ACROSS STATE AND
LOCAL ENTITIES, AND THEN THE
LAST ITEM WE HAVE IS THE
TRANSFER OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
PROGRAMS FROM THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS TO OCR
WITHIN AGENCY. SO THIS THE
TRAILER BILL AND THE PROPOSAL
TRANSFERS ALL THE BALANCE OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS. SO THEY WILL
ALL PURSUANT TO EXISTING LAW,
THEY WILL ALL BE TRANSFERRED TO
CAL HHS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL,
WHERE IS THE $9.4 MILLION COMING
FROM, JOSEPH DOLAN, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO THE 9.3 MILLION
ADJUSTMENT THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISE, THIS IS A
REVISED GROWTH REVENUE
PROJECTION BASED ON THE GRANT
THAT WAS ALREADY INCLUDED AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO THIS IS
JUST A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
BASED ON PROJECTIONS OF WHAT
THAT FUNDING IS. SO THE FUNDING
WAS ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE
TRANSFER AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THIS IS JUST ADJUSTING THE
AMOUNT BASED AT MAY REVISE. I
THINK I'M GOING TO NEED THAT A
DIFFERENT WAY. I DON'T THINK I
ABSORB THAT WELL. SAY THAT AGAIN
. NO WORRIES. SO AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AT THE TIME, WE PROPOSED
ONLY A PORTION OF THE GRANTS
PROPOSED WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT WAS THE FIRST STEP.
YES. SO THE FIRST GRANT, WE HAD
THE AMOUNT BUILT IN FOR THAT
TRANSFER, WHICH IS A DIRECT
ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES. THIS
ADJUSTMENT REPRESENTS AN
ADJUSTMENT BASED ON GROWTH
REVENUE PROJECTIONS. AS AN
UPDATE TO MAY REVISE. SO IT'S
JUST ADJUSTING THE AMOUNT THAT
WE ALREADY INCLUDED AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO NO LESS
FUNDING IN GRANTS IS BEING
ALLOCATED I BELIEVE. SO I CAN
CLARIFY THAT. BUT THIS IS JUST
ADJUSTING THE AMOUNT BASED ON
THE PROJECTIONS. WE ALREADY
ALLOCATED THEM, OR WE ALREADY
ACCOUNTED THE ALLOCATION. WE
ALREADY ACCOUNTED FOR THE
ALLOCATIONS. THIS IS ADJUSTING
THAT AMOUNT. OKAY. JUST CAN WE
JUST DOUBLE CHECK THAT THERE'S
NO ABSOLUTELY. BECAUSE I THINK
ONE OF MY QUESTIONS AND I THINK
I'M PRETTY SURE WILL COME UP AND
MAYBE DIRECTOR CAN HELP ME THAT
WE'RE NOT VIOLATING LIKE PROP 30
IN REGARD IN RELATION TO OUR
MANDATE OR OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
BRING DOWN ALL THE FUNDS DOWN TO
THE COUNTIES FOR THIS
REALIGNMENT. SO THAT'S WHERE I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE
UNDERSTANDABLE. YEAH, WE CAN
DOUBLE CHECK GET CLARITY ON THAT
FOR YOU, REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE INNOVATION ACCELERATOR. I
THINK I USED THAT AS A EXAMPLE
FOR THE PAST THREE MONTHS OR
FOUR MONTHS ON WHAT WE SHOULD
CUT. I'M REALLY EXCITED THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO TRANSFER ALL THE
GRANTS OVER TO OIC, ARE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO US TAKING ON
THAT RESPONSIBILITY MORE AND
FURTHER HAVING ACCOUNTABILITY OF
HOW IT'S UTILIZED IN OUR
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH. I STILL
HAVE A QUESTION ON THAT. THIRD
TO LAST ONE, THE CENTRAL
REGISTRY. YOU KNOW, WE'RE YOU
KNOW, WE'LL PROCEED THROUGHOUT
THIS DAY AND YOU'LL SEE SOME OF
SOME CUTS THAT ARE LIKE 1
MILLION, 2 MILLION. SO
EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW,
SCRAPPING PENNIES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. HOW CAN AND AS WE'RE
LOOKING TO REAPPROPRIATE A LOT
OF FUNDS AND I SAW THAT THE
THINGS THAT ARE BEING CUT, IT'S
REAPPROPRIATION FOR WHETHER
UNSPENT DOLLARS OR, PROGRAMS
THAT HAVEN'T STARTED VALID, BUT
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE SKEWED
MAYBE, PERHAPS WHERE CERTAIN
THINGS WHO THAT ARE UNSPENT AND
ARE BEING REAPPROPRIATE DID GET
CUT, BUT OTHER THINGS DON'T. SO
I'M JUST WONDERING FOR THIS
EXAMPLE, CAN WE SURVIVE WITH
ANOTHER YEAR OR TWO YEARS OF NOT
REAPPROPRIATING TO CONSOLIDATING
THOSE SYSTEMS? AND MAYBE,
PERHAPS AS WE GO THROUGH LATER,
OTHER PROGRAMS? I KNOW IT'S NOT
DOLLAR TO DOLLAR. IF WE SAVE
HERE, IT DOESN'T DIRECTLY GO
INTO OTHER PROGRAMS UNDER HHS,
BUT JUST WONDERING IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW. THAT WOULD
BE MY QUESTION. YEAH, I, I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR, BUT I'M
HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
COST OF MAINTAINING THE EXISTING
LEGACY SYSTEMS VERSUS, A BIGGER
COST THAN THIS. OKAY. WE CAN
FOLLOW UP. HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON THAT. APPRECIATE,
SENATOR, ANY QUESTION ON THIS?
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THAT ISSUE OPEN. MOVE ON. MOVING
ON TO, SCHAFER. SCHAFER SCHAFER.
FIVE. AND THAT'S IT
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. OR GOOD MORNING.
CAROLYN ABUBAKAR, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FACILITIES FINANCING
AUTHORITY, ALSO KNOWN AS SHAFA.
SO AS A BUDGET SOLUTION IN THE
MAY REVISE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROPOSED ELIMINATING,
RATHER THAN DELAYING THE TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THE SPECIALTY DENTAL
CLINIC GRANT PROGRAM THAT WE
RECEIVED BACK IN TWO BUDGET ACTS
A TOTAL OF $50 MILLION FROM THE
2022 AND THE 2023 BUDGET ACT. AS
YOU RECALL, WE MENTIONED WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IN A
PREVIOUS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
AND BASICALLY IT INCREASES
ACCESS TO THE ORAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATIONS, WHICH ARE BASICALLY
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL, COGNITIVE AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES. SO SINCE
IN JANUARY, THE BUDGET PROPOSED
DELAYING IT TILL TILL 2526
BUDGET YEAR. AND NOW THE
PROPOSAL IS TO ELIMINATE THAT
FUNDING. AND SINCE THE JANUARY
BUDGET AND SINCE THE LAST
HEARING, THE DEADLINE PASSED
APRIL 1ST FOR THE APPLICATIONS
AND WE RECEIVED 101 APPLICATIONS
TOTALING $270 MILLION IN
REQUESTS FOR THE $50 MILLION.
AND SO WE JUST NOTIFIED EVERYONE
THAT THE PROGRAM IS ON HOLD AND
WAITING UPON THE DECISION ON THE
FINAL FUNDING OF THE PROGRAM.
AND SO, THAT'S BEEN REPORTED AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS PROGRAM. WHAT WAS THE
AVERAGE PER APPLICATION REQUEST,
THE MAXIMUM IS 5 MILLION, BUT
THE AVERAGE IS ABOUT IN THE 2
MILLION ISH, PER REQUEST. AND
101 APPLICANTS. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, HOW WOULD A TWO YEAR
DELAY IMPACT US? WHY WOULDN'T WE
DELAY THIS TWO YEARS? I KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING TO BALANCE PLUS
ONE, SO WHY DON'T WE JUST DELAY
PART. THAT'S PART ONE OF MY
QUESTION. PART TWO. IF WE
ELIMINATE IT AND WE COME BACK IN
THREE YEARS, DO WE HAVE TO BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ALL OVER
AGAIN VERSUS JUST DELAYING TWO
YEARS? AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
THERE? OR IF WE DELAYS OR
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO PAY TO
MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE?
T I. ALL RIGHT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, SO YOU'LL RECALL THAT
WE ORIGINALLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDED A DELAY FROM
CURRENT YEAR FUNDING TO BUDGET
YEAR PLUS ONE. SO A TWO YEAR
DELAY, YOU KNOW, BASED ON
CURRENT PROJECTIONS, WE BELIEVE
THAT THE GENERAL FUND DEFICIT IS
GOING TO EXTEND BEYOND THE
BUDGET YEAR, SO WE THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES $28.4 BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL WAS ALREADY
DELAYED TWO YEARS. YEAH, IT WAS
DELAYED FROM CURRENT YEAR TO
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE. SO THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A FULL
REVERSION OF THOSE DOLLARS. SO?
SO THE CURRENT DELAY FOR THE
JANUARY PROPOSED DELAY WAS FOR
THIS TO START AGAIN IN 2526.
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY. SORRY I
MEANT PLUS THAT. WHY IF WE
DELAYED FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS,
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR PLUS ONE
WHICH I KNOW WE'RE LOOKING TO
BALANCE, IF WE DELAY THOSE TWO,
IS THERE AN IMPACT AT OR WHAT IS
THE IMPACT OF DELAYING IT UNTIL
THAT UNTIL THAT OUT YEAR? YOU
KNOW, THE ADMINISTRATION MADE
THE DECISION TO REVERT THE FUNDS
FOR BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE TO HELP
SOLVE THIS ONGOING GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT, YOU KNOW, IF AN OUTYEAR
DEFICIT DOES NOT COME TO
FRUITION, THIS COULD ABSOLUTELY
BE SOMETHING THAT WE DECIDE TO
REINVEST IN IN THE FUTURE. SO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD STILL
BE THERE. WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
START AGAIN, PUT OUT AN RFA TO
ASK FOR APPLICATIONS AGAIN.
WELL, I CAN ANSWER THAT, SO WE
HAVE APPLICATIONS IN-HOUSE
OBVIOUSLY FROM NOW UNTIL 2 OR 3
YEARS, EVERYTHING'S GOING TO
CHANGE. WE CAN DEFINITELY I
MEAN, THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM, THE GUIDELINES AND THE
STRUCTURE OF HOW THE PROGRAM
WOULD WORK IS ALL THERE. WE
WOULD JUST HAVE TO REOPEN UP AN
APPLICATION PERIOD, ACCEPT
UPDATED APPLICATIONS. THAT WOULD
BE THE CHANGE, BECAUSE WHATEVER
WE HAVE IN HOUSE IN TWO YEARS
PROBABLY WOULD BE STALE. I MEAN,
WE CAN DEFINITELY ASK THE ONES
WHO'VE APPLIED, WHO'VE PUT THEIR
PLACE IN LINE TO UPDATE WHAT
THEY'VE PROPOSED. AND SO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT IS THERE AND WILL
STAY THERE. SINCE WE'VE ALREADY
WORKED VERY HARD TO DEVELOP IT,
THE STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM,
IT'S ALL THERE, AND IT CAN STAY
UNTIL THE FUNDING REPLENISHES.
SO DELAYING THIS TWO, THREE
YEARS WON'T HAVE MAYBE ALLOW.
THANK YOU. CHAIR RYAN MILLER
FROM THE LAO, WELL, YOU'RE VERY
MUCH ASKING KIND OF A BUDGET
STRUCTURE QUESTION. AND SO IF WE
MAY, I WAS GOING TO HOPEFULLY
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
OVERALL PERSPECTIVE SIMILAR TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THEN I CAN ANSWER THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO THE
SPECIALTY DENTAL GRANT PROGRAM,
WE AGREE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT THE STATE'S BUDGET
PROBLEM IS SERIOUS, AND THAT
IT'S MULTIYEAR IN NATURE. AND WE
ALSO AGREE THAT THE MAY REVISION
WOULD PUT THE STATE ON MUCH
STRONGER FISCAL FOOTING. AND ONE
OF THE KEY WAYS THAT THE MAY
REVISION DOES THAT IS BY
FOCUSING ON ALL THE OR TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN AT THIS
POINT, A LOT OF THE TEMPORARY
AND ONE TIME SPENDING THAT WAS
APPROVED IN IN THE SURPLUS
BUDGETS, THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER PROPOSALS SIMILAR TO THAT
THAT WILL BE HEARD TODAY, SOME
OF THOSE ONE TIME AND TEMPORARY
REDUCTIONS, LIKE THE ONE IN THE
PRIOR ITEM. I THINK WE WOULD
AGREE WITH THE CHAIR THAT THAT
WAS PROBABLY A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
TO BE LOOKING AT, AS A WAY TO
IMPROVE THE MULTIYEAR BUDGET
CONDITION, BECAUSE BY PRESERVING
THOSE RESOURCES NOW, WE THINK
IT'LL BE A LOT MORE LIKELY THAT
THE STATE CAN PRESERVE ITS CORE
SERVICES IN THE FUTURE, WHICH WE
THINK IS REALLY A PRIORITY. OF
COURSE, TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR A VAST NUMBER OF SIMILAR
TYPES OF REDUCTIONS THAT TAKE
WHAT WERE PERHAPS PREVIOUSLY
DELAYS AND CONVERT THEM TO
REDUCTIONS. ONE TIME SPENDING,
CONVERT THEM INTO REDUCTIONS AND
THERE CERTAINLY WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES FROM A LOT OF
THOSE. AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THAT WE IMAGINE THAT THERE WILL
BE ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
TODAY, THIS IS ONE WHERE
CERTAINLY EARLIER IN THIS YEAR,
THERE WERE A GOOD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE IMPACTS, AND CERTAINLY
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT CHARACTER OF THIS ONE,
GIVEN THE KIND OF ADVANCED
NATURE OF THE PROGRAM COMPARED
TO MAYBE SOME OTHERS THAT WERE
STILL KIND OF GETTING OFF THE
GROUND, BUT ALL THAT SAID, IN
GENERAL, OUR OFFICE IS VIEWING
THESE TYPES OF REDUCTIONS AS
REASONABLE. AGAIN, KEEPING THAT
MULTIYEAR CONDITION IN MIND, THE
LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY COULD
REVISIT THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AND DO A LONGER DELAY
AS YOU, AS YOU MENTIONED, BUT I
THINK THE KEY CONSIDERATION
THERE IS KEEPING THE MULTIYEAR
BUDGET CONDITION IN MIND. AND
THERE'S KIND OF ESSENTIALLY JUST
A, A RISK CALCULUS ABOUT HOW
MUCH DEFICIT YOU'RE KIND OF
WILLING TO, TO ACCEPT, BUT
CERTAINLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
ALTERNATIVE DECISIONS THAT CAN
BE MADE. AND, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
HERE TO ASSIST THE COMMITTEE IN
CRAFTING THOSE KINDS OF OPTIONS
AND ALTERNATIVES. OKAY THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. REFRESH MY
RECOLLECTION, THIS WAS A NEW
PROGRAM. THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM.
EXACTLY. AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY HANGING. WE'RE NOT
CUTTING ANYBODY OFF AT THE
KNEES. WE'RE JUST DASHING HOPES
THAT WE WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITH SOME BUDGET FUNDING, I
UNDERSTAND. WELL, I LISTEN, I,
FOR ONE, I, YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THE USE OF DEFERRALS
AND DELAYS, BUT AT SOME POINT IN
A DEFERRAL OR A DELAY BECOMES A
CUT. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
MANAGE EXPECTATIONS. IF WE'RE
MANAGING A BUDGET PROPERLY. AND
HOWEVER, HEARTBREAKING THAT IS
FOR, THOSE OF US WHO HAVE TO SIT
THROUGH THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE, I'LL TELL YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU
KNOW, SENATOR, I PUT OUT A CALL
IF ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES WANTED
TO JOIN ME HERE. NO ONE TOOK ME
UP ON MY OFFER. OKAY, YOU JUST
BRING THE KLEENEX DOWN A LITTLE
BIT. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE, OUR NEXT
DEPARTMENT. SO ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
HI. CHRISTINE. SHERMAN,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO, MSA
STAFF WERE NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT
TODAY, BUT WE'LL PROVIDE,
BETWEEN MYSELF AND MICHAEL MUTH
FROM OTS. I WILL PROVIDE THE
OVERVIEW, AND WE'LL DO OUR BEST
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MENGIBAR
AND HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
MY NAME IS MICHAEL MUTH. I'M
FROM THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY
AND SOLUTIONS INTEGRATION WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY, BEFORE WE GET
STARTED, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY, AS WELL AS
THANK YOUR STAFFERS FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS TO
ORGANIZE, INFORMATION IN THE
AGENDAS AND SO ON. SO AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE STATED, OUR COLLEAGUE
CRAIG JOHNSON FROM THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY IS
NOT HERE TODAY. I WILL BE
PROVIDING A DEPARTMENT OVERVIEW
AND THEN A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEWS
OF THE SPECIFIC PCP'S AND THEN
OVERVIEWS OF THE OTSI MSA, BCP'S
. SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND START
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OVERVIEW, IF
THAT WORKS. SO DEPARTMENT
OVERVIEW EMS WAS FORMALLY
ESTABLISHED BY THE. WE DON'T
NEED TO DO A DEPARTMENT DON'T
NEED OKAY. PERFECT ALL RIGHT. SO
FIRST STARTING OFF WITH THEIR
BUDGET OVERVIEW AS WELL AS THEIR
SPECIFIC MSSPS, THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET MAY REVISION FOR FISCAL
YEAR 2425 INCLUDES EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR 64.3 MILLION AND
121 POSITIONS. OF THIS AMOUNT,
38 MILLION IS DELEGATED FOR THE
STATE OPERATIONS AND 26.3
MILLION IS DELEGATED TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. THIS IS AN INCREASE
OF 6.7 MILLION OVER THE JANUARY
BUDGET, AND AN INCREASE OF 12
POSITIONS. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SEVEN BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR THE
MAY REVISE UNDER CONSIDERATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE. THE FIRST
PROPOSAL IS AROUND STAFFING
SUPPORT, RESOURCES REYES FOR Â
POST MSA REQUESTS POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR THREE ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYSTS.
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT THE ELECTRONIC
PHYSICIAN'S ORDER FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT OR E PULSE
REGISTRY SYSTEM. THESE POSITIONS
WILL BE FUNDED FROM THE ANNUAL
Â PULSE REGISTRY, GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION POLST ARE MEDICAL
ORDERS SIGNED BY BOTH A PATIENT
AND THEIR DECISION MAKERS, AND A
PHYSICIAN, NURSE PRACTITIONER OR
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT, BASICALLY
THAT SPECIFY END OF LIFE WISHES
FOR THOSE THAT QUALIFY THE
LEGISLATIVE BC FOR CHAPTER TWO
LEGISLATION. SO PROPOSAL TWO
AROUND COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE
AND TRIAGE TO ALTERNATE
DESTINATION PROGRAMS. SO AB 767
EMS REQUESTS ONE PERMANENT
POSITION AND 686,000. IN GENERAL
FUND FOR 2425, 606,025 26 AND
432,000 ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT
CHAPTER 27 STATUES OF 2023
ASSEMBLY BILL 767, ENTITLED
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE OR TRIAGE
TO ALTERNATE DESTINATION ACT.
THE REQUEST INCLUDES TEMPORARY
FUNDING FOR TWO YEARS OF ONE
TIME STAFF SERVICES OR ONE TIME
STAFF SERVICES MANAGER, ONE
SPECIALIST, AND ONGOING FUNDING
FOR TWO POSITIONS THAT WERE
PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED IN 2122
BUT ONLY FUNDED THROUGH 2324.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS, ESTABLISH UNIFORM
IMPLEMENTATION STANDARDS, MODIFY
EXISTING DATA COLLECTION SYSTEMS
TO ACCEPT CP TWO D DATA, AND
MANAGE OVERSIGHT OF THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT? BEFORE I MOVE
ON AND I MAY HAVE TO TAKE THE
QUESTIONS AWAY. THE QUESTIONS
MAYBE FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
SO 121 POSITIONS, THE 12 Tê.
IT'S APPROXIMATELY 11 TO 12%
INCREASE. I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSING ACROSS THE BOARD 8%
CUTS, BUT IF WE'RE DOING AN
INCREASE, IT'S KIND OF
OFFSETTING THE 8% CUTS ACROSS
THE DEPARTMENTS. HOW DO WE
JUSTIFY INCREASING DEPARTMENTS
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY SAYING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CUT ACROSS
DEPARTMENT STAFF OR JUST ADMIN?
ARE YOU REFERRING TO THE THREE
POSITIONS FOR Â POST
SPECIFICALLY? WELL, THERE'S A
COUPLE I KNOW. SOME ARE FOR
CHAPTER LEGISLATION, SOME ARE
FOR OTHER. I GUESS IT'S MORE OF
AN OVERALL, AS WE SEE SOME
DEPARTMENTS ARE ASKING FOR AN
INCREASE IN STAFF. AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE MAY REVISE IS
ASKING FOR AN 8% CUT. RIGHT.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE GOING TO
OFFSET WON'T IT. THEY, THEY WILL
OFFSET, I GUESS YOU CAN SEE IT
IN A WAY THAT THE, POSITION ONES
THAT WERE AUTHORIZED WILL,
SOFTEN THAT BLOW OF THE, THE
VACANCY, CUT THAT ALL
DEPARTMENTS WILL GET, BUT IN
TERMS OF Â POST THAT WAS
REQUESTED AS THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY,
POSITIONS DEDICATED TO Â POST,
THERE'S ZERO RIGHT NOW. AND SO
THEY'RE REQUESTING TO ADD THREE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT, AND, AND, FOR
THE OTHER POSITIONS, YOU KNOW,
WE SORT OF TOOK, A DEPARTMENT
WIDE APPROACH IN APPROVING THE
CHAPTER LEDGE, YOU KNOW, PRETTY
CLOSE TO MAY REVISE. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, FOR MOST OF THE CHAPTER
LEDGE OR MUCH OF THE CHAPTER
LEDGE, THERE WERE POSITIONS
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING TO
IMPLEMENT A LOT OF IT HAVING TO
DO WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
REGULATIONS OVERALL, NOT NOT
GOING INTO SPECIFIC REQUESTS
OVERALL. ARE WE GOING TO REALLY
SEE A SAVING OF A OF A OF 8? IS
THE 8% CUT REALLY GOING TO SHOW
US SOME SAVINGS IF A LOT OF
DEPARTMENTS IF THERE ARE STILL
REQUESTS FOR ADDING MORE STAFF,
DO WE HAVE THAT OUTLOOK YET? I
THINK WE'RE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THAT. OKAY, DID YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT? YEAH. SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL, WE LOOK AT
THEM EACH INDIVIDUALLY BASED ON
THE MERITS OF THAT PROPOSAL. SO
ONE THING TO NOTE ALSO WITH MSA
IS IT IS A SMALLER DEPARTMENT.
SO A LOT OF TIMES THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO ABSORB AS MUCH. SO YEAH
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T WANT TO DIVE
INTO SPECIFICALLY. IT WAS JUST
OVERALL AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
ALL DIFFERENT REQUESTS, AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO SHAVE AT THE
SAME TIME. IT KIND OF OFFSETS
SENATOR. WELL, I WAS JUST GOING
TO COMMENT. THE ONE THING THAT
IS NOT REFLECTED HERE IS SOME OF
THESE, ITEMS OF CHAPTER
LEGISLACIÓN ARE DESIGNED TO
PRODUCE SAVINGS IN OTHER PARTS
OF STATE GOVERNMENT. I MEAN,
COMMUNITY TRANSFERS TO
ALTERNATIVE DESTINATION ACT,
WHERE YOU I ASSUME THAT'S THE
ONE WHERE WE DIVERT INDIVIDUALS
FROM ACUTE CARE GENERAL
HOSPITALS TO OTHER SETTINGS,
ISN'T IT? YES. AND I AND I AND I
ASSUME THAT THE AMBULANCE
PATIENT OFFLOAD TIME MAY BE 40
IS ALSO DESIGNED TO REDUCE WALL
TIME AT HOSPITALS AND PRODUCE
SAVINGS IN OTHER PARTS OF OUR
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
NONE OF THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
IN THE FTE COST OF THESE. THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AM I AM I
THINKING CORRECTLY? IN OTHER
WORDS, WE'RE APPROVING POSITIONS
TO IMPLEMENT LEGISLATION THAT'S
DESIGNED TO SAVE ON THE OTHER
END OF THE PROCESS. MAYBE NOT,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN THAT IT'S
DESIGNED TO SAVE? WELL, WHAT ARE
WE DOING WHEN WE'RE REDUCING
PATIENT OFF LOAD TIME? WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT HAVING SOME
EMPLOYEE, WHETHER IT'S A COUNTY
EMPLOYEE, A STATE EMPLOYEE, OR
SOME OTHER GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE
HANGING ON THE WALL WAITING FOR
SOMEBODY TO SIGN OFF ON THEM IN
AN ACUTE CARE GENERAL HOSPITAL.
RIGHT. SO THERE'S A SAVINGS
BUILT FREEING UP RESOURCES.
RIGHT. THERE'S ON TO THERE'S A
SAVINGS BUILT INTO THESE
PROPOSALS THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS
NOT REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET
STUFF THAT WE LOOK AT. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT A RAW EXPENDITURE
WITHOUT A CORRESPONDING, SAVINGS
OFFSET, I SEE. RIGHT. I'M NOT A
FINANCE PERSON. I DEFER TO YOU
ALL TO DO THAT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, OFTENTIMES SOMETIMES
THESE SAVINGS CAN'T BE SEEN
UNTIL A LITTLE BIT LATER. AND
SO, RIGHT, UNTIL IT'S KNOWN WE
CAN'T REALLY PUT THESE SAVINGS
INTO OUR, ACTUAL FISCALS. I'M
NOT BEING CRITICAL. I'M JUST
TRYING TO ADDRESS MY CHAIR'S
QUESTION TO YOU. HOW ABOUT I
I'LL STOP TALKING NØ. IF NOT,
I'M GOING TO GET TO THAT FIRST
PLACE FASTER. SO I NEED YOU TO
SPEAK TO IT, I'M SEEING HERE. SO
WE JUST IN THE, IN THE PREVIOUS,
DEPARTMENT, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
REQUEST FOR SOME SAYS THE
CENTRAL REGISTER REPLACEMENT.
SEE ANOTHER REQUEST HERE. SO
IT'S NOW AMOUNTING TO A LITTLE
OVER 5 MILLION, IS ARE THESE IS
THIS THIS REAPPROPRIATION TO
HELP CONSOLIDATE ALL INTO ONE?
IS THIS TWO STEPS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN AT THE SAME TIME? IS THIS
ONE STEP NEEDS TO HAPPEN FIRST
VERSUS, YOU KNOW, MICHAEL ÖTZI,
TO CLARIFY, MADAM CHAIR, ARE YOU
GOING TO THE, THE KI¾M S¼
CENTRAL REGISTRY, BCP THE
REAPPROPRIATION? YES. OKAY.
PERFECT. SO THE AND I'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND JUMP RIGHT TO THAT ONE
AS WELL, SO THE CENTRAL REGISTRY
REPLACED PART OF THE CURRENT
LEGACY SOLUTION AS WELL AS THE
RE PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES. SO
THIS IS A REAPPROPRIATION OF $3
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND AS WELL
AS PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
AUTHORIZING CONFERENCE AND
EXPENDITURE THROUGH JUNE OF
2026. AND SO THIS IS MEANT TO
ACHIEVE TWO KEY ACTIVITIES. ONE
IS TO CONTINUE THE PLANNING AND
PROJECT WORK ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CENTRAL REGISTRY PROJECT. SO
CURRENTLY THAT'S IN IN STAGE TWO
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY'S PAL PROCESS OR
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE
PROCESS. AND THE CURRENT LEGACY
SYSTEM IS NO LONGER IT BASICALLY
NO LONGER MEETS THE CURRENT
TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS. THERE'S
QUITE A NUMBER OF MANUAL
WORKAROUNDS THAT ARE NEEDED. IT
IT IS AT A POINT WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE REPLACED. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S OVER 90,000, PARAMEDICS,
LICENSURES CAREGIVERS AND SO ON
THAT USE THAT SOLUTION EITHER
FOR CURRENT OR FUTURE EMPLOYMENT
WITHIN THE HEALTH CARE OR OR,
EMPLOYMENT SPACE THAT REQUIRE
THAT CERTIFICATION. THE OTHER
KEY ACTIVITY IS AROUND
REPROCUREMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
INFORMATION SYSTEM. AND JUST
GIVEN THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO GO THROUGH A
PROCUREMENT CYCLE WITHIN THE
STATE, WE NEED TO BEGIN THOSE
ACTIVITIES AS SOON AS JULY OF
2024, THE CURRENT, EXISTING
CONTRACT HAS A BASELINE END OF
AUGUST 31ST, 2024, BUT WE HAVE
TWO OPTIONAL EXTENSION
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXTEND THAT OUT
TO 2026. I BELIEVE THAT IS
ACTUALLY PART OF THE FALL. BCP'S
REQUESTING, FUNDING FOR THOSE
TWO OPTIONAL YEARS. AND SO THIS
REQUEST JUST, BASICALLY WILL
HELP ENSURE MSA MEETS ITS
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
COLLECTION AND EVALUATION OF EMS
PERSONNEL, LICENSING,
CERTIFICATION, INVESTIGATORY AND
LEGAL DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AS
REQUIRED IN THE CALIFORNIA CODE
OF REGULATIONS, AS WELL AS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE, AND
ESSENTIALLY WITHOUT THESE
RESOURCES, MESSAGES WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THE PLANNING
EFFORTS FOR THE CENTRAL REGISTRY
PROJECT, ESSENTIALLY PUTTING AT
RISK, THAT'S, YOU KNOW, THE
USERS THAT USE THAT SYSTEM RELY
ON IT, AND, AND, YOU KNOW, IT
ALSO FEEDS INTO THEIR OVERALL
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES FOR DATA
COLLECTION. I I DEFINITELY WISH
THAT WAS A MINDSET. AND WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING INTO NOT EVEN
TALKING TO YOU, BUT I'M JUST
OVERALL I WISH THAT WAS A
MINDSET. AS WE LOOK INTO HUMAN
SERVICES THAT IT PUTS AT RISK
THE USERS OF THIS SYSTEM,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE GOING INTO THE CUTS. AND
WHAT YOU JUST SAID IS PERFECT
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE HERE
FIGHTING FOR THIS BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO PUT AT RISK THE PEOPLE
WHO USE THE SYSTEM, THE THINGS
THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR CUTS, ARE
GOING TO PUT THE AT RISK. THE
PEOPLE WHO USE THOSE PROGRAMS
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THESE SYSTEMS, I THINK
ABOUT MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS THAT
WORK AS FIREFIGHTERS,
PARAMEDICS, EMTS. I THINK ABOUT
MY GRANDPARENTS THAT, YOU KNOW,
WANT THEIR END OF LIFE WISHES
HONORED. SO THAT'S WHAT I THINK
ABOUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT THESE
REQUESTS. IT'S I THINK ABOUT
THOSE SAME PEOPLE WHEN WE'RE
CUTTING SENIOR NUTRITION,
GRANDPARENTS WILL ALLOW ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS WILL OWNS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. REGARDING THE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE PART OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PIECE, WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THOSE AT THIS TIME.
HOWEVER, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
PREPARED TO ASSIST THE COMMITTEE
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO, SENATOR, GOING TO HOLD
THAT, THOSE ITEMS OPEN, MOVE ON
TO THE HCAI. THANK YOU SO MUCH
.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR ALBERT
PINEDA WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE MAY REVISION
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE.
ACCESS AND INFORMATION. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES VARIOUS HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE REDUCTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTFALL, AND
BUILDS ON THE RELATED WORKFORCE
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE MAY
REVISION, REDUCES APPROXIMATELY
855 MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER
FIVE YEARS DUE TO THE SHORTFALL
301,000,000 IN 2324, 302.7
MILLION IN 20 2425, 216.4
MILLION IN 20 2526, 18.8 MILLION
IN 20 2627, AND 16,000,000 IN 20
2728 AND ONGOING. THESE
REDUCTIONS IMPACT THE FOLLOWING
PROGRAMS NURSING, SOCIAL
WORKERS. COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. SONG BROWN, CALIFORNIA
MEDICINE SCHOLARS, AND THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS. CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO REDUCES 189.4
MILLION MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS, ELIMINATING FUNDING FOR
ADDICTION PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIPS, UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE GRANTS FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS, MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK SLOTS EXPANSIONS,
AND LOCAL PSYCHIATRY. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. THE STATE IS PURSUING
INVESTMENTS IN NEW FUNDING OF
2.4 BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
HIGH PRIORITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
WORKFORCE AND ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH THE PROPOSITION ONE AND
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COMMUNITY
BASED, ORGANIZED NETWORK OF
EQUITABLE CARE AND TREATMENT
DEMONSTRATION BEGINNING JULY
1ST, 2026. THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES 300 MILLION IN
PROPOSITION 98, IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FOR NURSING. OVER FIVE
YEARS, WITH 60 MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN 20 2425 AND THE MAY
REVISION ALSO RETAINS 268
MILLION GENERAL FUND FROM PRIOR
YEAR AND CURRENT YEAR
INVESTMENTS, INCLUDING FOR
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL MEDICINE SCHOLARS. THE
NURSING INITIAL OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE, SONG BROWN COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS ADDICTION
PSYCHIATRY AND PSYCHIATRIC
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION. I'LL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES AT HCAI
TO SPEAK TOWARDS THE BCP'S AND
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. YES. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR
ROTH. ELIZABETH LANDSBERG WITH
HCAI. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO
THROUGH EACH OF THE PROPOSED
CUTS OR WHAT? WHAT'S YOUR
PLEASURE? NÓ OF THE 12 PROPOSED
CUTS OF EACH DIFFERENT,
WORKFORCE? YES. I THINK YOU SAID
WE'RE MAINTAINING SOME FUNDING,
CAN YOU GO OVER WHICH ONES ARE
GOING TO MAINTAIN SOME FUNDING
IN THEM AGAIN? SO IN TERMS OF
WE'RE REMAINING IN ONE TIME,
FUNDING WOULD BE 267 MILLION,
208 MILLION WOULD BE IN THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. SO THERE ARE
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS TO, TO FUND
THE CERTIFIED WELLNESS COACHES,
THE NEW PROFESSION THAT WE
CREATED UNDER THE UNDER THE
INITIATIVE. SO THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS FOR THAT, AS
WELL AS SOME OTHER SIBAI FUNDS.
OKAY, SO 208 OUT OF THE 267.
CORRECT. WHERE'S THE OTHER ONE
GOING? WHERE WHERE'S THE REST
GOING? 15.8 MILLION FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH FOR THE
CLINICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS.
SO THIS INCLUDES FUNDING FOR A
WARM LINE AND SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
PROVIDERS COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE,
INCLUDING ABORTION SERVICES. SO
THIS IS NOT OUT OF NOT FUNDING
ANY OF THE 12. THIS IS SOMETHING
NEW. NO. THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED
THAT WERE ARE MAINTAINED. SO IS
THAT YOUR QUESTION. IS THE 267
THAT'S MAINTAINED? YEAH THAT
CONSTITUTES YEAH. OF THE OF THE
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE THE
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS C.H.W
NURSING INITIATIVE SOCIAL WORK
INITIATIVE. ALL THOSE I WONDER
IF ANY OF THOSE 12 ARE ARE GOING
TO HAVE ANY DOLLARS REMAINING IN
ANY OF THEM. YES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. SO, THE SOCIAL WORK
DOLLARS ARE PROPOSED FOR
ELIMINATION AND THEIR ENTIRETY,
BOTH THE INITIATIVE AND THE
SLOTS. CORRECT. OKAY FOR THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS,
PROMOTORAS AND TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVES, THERE'S A
PROPOSAL TO CUT ALMOST $250
MILLION AND TO RETAIN 15 MILLION
IN IN CURRENT YEAR. SO 15
MILLION WOULD BE RETAINED FOR
ONE YEAR, THERE'S 5 MILLION
RETAINED FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND THEN THERE IS A
SMALL AMOUNT RETAINED FOR SONG
BROWN RN THE NURSING NOT THE
RESIDENT OR THE. THERE'S TWO THE
SONG BROWN NURSING AND THE SONG
BROWN RESIDENCY. CORRECT. SO
SONG BROWN NURSING 1 MILLION FOR
SONG BROWN NURSING OKAY. AND
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL CUTS TO
THE SONG. BROWN PHYSICIAN THÀNH
FUNDS, OKAY. AND REGARDING TO
PROP ONE I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
USE THERE'S THE 4% COMING TO
HCAI TO BE ABLE TO DO WORKFORCE.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD LAST
TIME WAS, ARE WE RECREATING THE
WHEEL? WE ALREADY HAVE? I CAN
IMAGINE APPLICANTS IN THESE
VARIOUS, SECTIONS. ARE WE
RECREATING THE WHEEL OR ARE WE
GOING TO MAYBE, PERHAPS USE THAT
FUNDING TO ALREADY SELECT SOME
OF THE APPLICANTS THAT CAME IN
FOR THESE KIND OF SECTIONS?
YEAH, IT'S CERTAINLY A VERY
CHALLENGING SITUATION TO HAVE TO
DO THESE CUTS IN TERMS OF THE
PROP ONE WORKFORCE DOLLARS. SO
3% OKAY, COMES COMES FROM
WORKFORCE AND THEN WITH THE
WAIVER, THERE'S $480 MILLION A
YEAR. FOR FIVE YEARS, HCAI HAS
STARTED A STRATEGIC PLAN PROCESS
FOR THOSE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE DOLLARS. I THINK IT'S
LIKELY WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO,
OF COURSE, SUPPORT SOCIAL
WORKERS, SUPPORT PSYCHIATRIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY LEVERAGE THE
STRUCTURES THAT WE'VE SET UP
PREVIOUSLY. YEAH, BECAUSE I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID
LAST TIME WAS LIKE, WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM IN PLACE. WE HAVE ALREADY
PEOPLE APPLYING WHAT I DON'T
WANT TO SEE IS UTILIZING SOME OF
THE FUNDING TO LIKE, RECREATE A
WHOLE NEW PROGRAM WHERE WE CAN
JUST USE PROP ONE MONEY. I THINK
UNLESS I'M SEEING THIS SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU THINK IT'S SO EASY,
IT'S NOT REALLY. AND JUST
SUPPLEMENT PROP ONE INTO THESE
PROGRAMS ALREADY, JOSEPH
JOHNSON, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS PROP ONE
FUNDING IS STILL BEING
RESEARCHED AND DETERMINED THAT I
THINK IT'S IT WOULD BE A LITTLE
PREMATURE TO CONSIDER THIS
SUPPLANTING OR POTENTIALLY
BACKFILLING. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THIS IS NEW
POTENTIAL INVESTMENTS THAT WE
COULD BE USING FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. IT MAY HAVE
COMPLEMENTARY USES SIMILAR TO
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
UP FOR SOLUTIONS. BUT I THINK
FOR US, WE'RE STILL IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT FUNDING
COULD BE. AND NOTE WHICH WE'LL
GET TO THE BCP RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, THAT THAT IS
KIND OF LAYING THE GROUNDWORK
FOR BOTH PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION PURPOSES FOR IF
THAT FUNDING MATERIALIZES. BUT I
THINK JUST WHILE WE'RE NOTING
THAT THE MAY REVISE IS PLANNING
FOR THAT INVESTMENT, IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TAKING THE
MONEY IN THIS BUCKET AND DUMPING
100. SO JUST REALLY WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT PROCESS AND THE
PROP ONE FUNDING, WE WON'T SEE
IT FOR LIKE ANOTHER ALMOST TWO
YEARS, RIGHT. FOR THIS KIND OF
FUNDING OR NO, WE ANTICIPATE IT
SOONER THAN THAT. YES. I JUST
DON'T WANT WHOEVER IS IN THIS UP
NEXT YEAR BE LIKE LOOKING AT A
BCP. HEY, WE WANT TO DO A
WORKING GROUP TO SEE WHAT THE
BEHAVIORAL WORKFORCE NEEDS ARE.
NO, WE'RE ABSOLUTELY GOING TO
LEVERAGE ALL THE EXPERTISE THAT
WE'VE GAINED WITH THE CHILDREN'S
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND OTHER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PEOPLE TO JUMP IN. YES.
OKAY. YES, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OR MAYBE YOU TOO. MY QUESTION
IS, AND IT'S THIS KIND OF LIKE
THE SAME QUESTION WE'RE REDUCING
12 DIFFERENT, PROGRAMS. RAIMES
FOR WORKFORCE. IT'S A HUGE
WORKLOAD, BUT WE'RE ASKING FOR
MORE STAFF IF WE'RE REDUCING
WHAT ARE WHAT PROGRAMS IS HE
GETTING THAT NEEDS MORE STAFFS?
IF WE'RE REDUCING A BIG WORKLOAD
AMOUNT, CAN YOU CLARIFY REQUEST
FOR MORE STAFF JUST. YEAH. SO
WE'RE WE'RE ASKING FOR 12 MORE
POSITIONS FOR HCAI, BUT WE'RE
REDUCING 12 DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
UNDER AGE. Kò. CAN THE CURRENT
STAFF WORK ON THE NEEDS FOR THIS
CHAPTER LEGISLATION? IF WE'RE
REMOVING 12 DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
OUT OF HCAI FOR THEM THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE RUNNING
ANYMORE, I THINK THIS WILL BE
PART OF A BIGGER KIND OF
ADMINISTRATIVE STRATEGY OF
UNDERSTANDING THE CURRENT
RESOURCES THE DEPARTMENT HAS, AS
WELL AS KIND OF PROJECTED
WORKLOAD, I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S STILL AN
ONGOING PROCESS AS WELL AS SOME
OTHER KIND OF STATEWIDE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL. SO IN TERMS OF KIND
OF A DIRECT ANSWER RIGHT NOW,
I'M NOT SURE IF WE HAVE THAT
DATA AVAILABLE. BUT IN BOTH OUR
COLLABORATION WITH HCAI AS WELL
AS DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE,
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
ONGOING DISCUSSION OF WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE AMIDST THIS SITUATION. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE IF I MAY, MADAM
CHAIR, THAT WITH THE ONE WITH
THE SIGNIFICANT, ADDITIONAL
FUNDS THAT WE GOT OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, WHICH WERE ONE TIME
FUNDS, WE'VE USED A VARIETY OF
FLEXIBLE STAFFING OPTIONS. SO WE
DO HAVE SOME TEMP HELP AND THE
LIKE. SO I UNDERSTAND, AS YOU
KNOW, THE QUESTION TO BE IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE GETTING RID OF
ALL THESE DOLLARS, DO WE STILL
NEED THE SAME STAFF? AND SO I
THINK WE YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW,
WE STILL HAVE THE SONG BROWN AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER KEY PROGRAMS.
WE STILL DO THE RESEARCH DATA
CENTER. WE STILL HAVE THE
WORKFORCE COUNCIL, THE PRIMARY
CARE OFFICE, BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY
BE MINDFUL OF THE STAFFING NEEDS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND THANK
YOU. AND IT'S THAT CONVERSATION.
WHERE IS THAT YOU'RE SAYING
WE'RE STILL HAVING NOW? OR IS
THIS LIKE, OH, IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR, WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
TO SEE HOW ELSE, THERE. THE
PROCESS IS OCCURRING RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, IT'S AN ONGOING PROCESS,
BUT OBVIOUSLY WHEN THINGS BECOME
WHEN THINGS MATERIALIZE OF WHAT
THE FINAL DIRECTION IS OBVIOUSLY
WILL KEEP APPRIZED OF WHAT THAT
DIRECTION IS. BUT, JUST NOTING
THAT, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE, PLANNING
PROCESSES. AND THEN MY, MY LAST
QUESTION IS, ARE WE IMPLEMENTING
SOMETHING FOR THE NEXT TIME
DAUGHTERS COME TO HCAI THAT WE
GET THEM OUT THE DOOR SOONER? SO
WE'RE NOT BACK HERE BECAUSE IT'S
UNSPENT. IT'S ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK. NOW, IS THERE SOMETHING I
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS JUST WANT TO KNOW, JUST
LIKE MOVING FORWARD AND MAYBE
JUST OVERALL, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE'RE CUTTING ARE
UNSPENT. THEY DIDN'T GET OUT THE
DOOR. WHAT WE'RE DOING, WHAT WE
MIGHT DO DIFFERENTLY TO MAKE
SURE THESE DOLLARS ARE OUT THE
DOOR SOONER. SO THEY'RE NOT UP
FOR GRABS. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY,
MADAM CHAIR. AND SO WHEN THESE
PROPOSED CUTS CAME DOWN, WE, YOU
KNOW, MY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND I DID TALK TO TALK TO OUR
STAFF. WE WHEN WE'RE GIVEN FIVE
YEAR EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY, WE
ASSUME WE HAVE SOME TIME, BUT WE
HAVE SPENT 75% OF THE FUNDS
GIVEN TO US. SO THIS IS THESE
ARE SOME OF THE FUNDS THAT WERE
NOT SPENT. BUT SIGNIFICANT FUNDS
WERE SPENT. AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT SOME OF THE FUNDS PROPOSED
TO BE CUT FOR CURRENT YEAR.
ACTUALLY, WE'VE ENTERED INTO
CONTRACTS WITH, YOU KNOW, WITH
ENTITIES FOR SONG BROWN FUNDS
AND THE LIKE. SO THEY WERE NOT
OFFICIALLY ENCUMBERED, NOT OUT
THE DOOR, BUT WE HAD ENTERED
INTO CONTRACTS. BUT IT'S ALWAYS
OUR INTENT. AND I THINK THE TEAM
HAS DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF
TRYING TO GET THE MONEY OUT TO
ITS ITS INTENDED PURPOSE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET AN IDEA OF I REALIZED WE
HAVE TO CUT, AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION DID A WE CAN
DISAGREE ON WHAT WHAT'S BEEN
CUT. BUT I THINK, YOU KNOW, WHEN
IT'S 27 SOMETHING BILLION
DOLLARS, YOU HAVE TO CUT. I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON
WHAT'S LEFT ON THESE ITEMS ON
EIGHT AND NINE ON OUR AGENDA. SO
THERE'S 15 MILLION LEFT ON THE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE IN YOUR
POT OF MONEY TO SPEND, WORKFORCE
REDUCTIONS FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS, I DIDN'T CATCH WHAT WAS
LEFT IN THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE REDUCTIONS HAVING TO
DO WITH THE NURSING INITIATIVE.
IS THERE ANY MONEY LEFT IN THAT?
NO. ALL GONE 210 MILLION GONE.
OKAY AND THEN SOCIAL WORK ALL
ELIMINATED. ADDICTION
PSYCHIATRY, MEDICINE FELLOWSHIPS
AND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AT UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE GRANT ALL GONE. THOSE
ARE ALSO ELIMINATED IN THEIR
ENTIRETY. OKAY, AND THEN ON, THE
I ASSUME THE EXPANSION OF
MASTER'S IN SOCIAL WORK SLOTS.
THAT'S GONE. YES, SIR. SO THIS
QUESTION ON THIS NEXT QUESTION
APPLIES TO SEVERAL OF THEM.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE
REDUCING EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE,
MASTERS AND SOCIAL WORK OF 30
MILLION, WHY WOULD WE REDUCE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES? ARE WE
SENDING THAT MONEY SOMEPLACE
ELSE? I MEAN, THAT'S NOT YES. I
MEAN, THAT'S A FUND THAT'S TO BE
USED FOR SPECIFIC THINGS. RIGHT?
SO WHERE IS THAT MONEY GOING?
CORRECT. SO I THINK THE OVERALL
REDUCTION AND WE MENTIONED IN
THE OPENING STATEMENTS THAT
THERE IS A REDUCTION OF A 189.4
MILLION OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
FUNDS FOR THESE VARIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVES.
IT'S MORE RELATED TO THE GENERAL
STATE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND AS COMPARED TO,
YOU KNOW, GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED AND OTHER GENERAL FUND
FUNDED INITIATIVES. SO RELATED
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
FUND, EVEN THOUGH AT THE MAY
REVISE, THERE IS A MINOR
INCREASE IN REVENUES COMPARED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE FUND
COULD NOT SUSTAIN THIS FULL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WAS
INITIALLY DELAYED INTO THAT
FISCAL YEAR FOR THE 189.4
MILLION, AND ADDITIONALLY, AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S OVERALL
PROPOSAL FOR ADDRESSING THE
BUDGET SHORTFALL, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
USE 90 MILLION IN AVAILABLE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND TO
OFFSET ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
FOR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE
HOUSING PROGRAM IN 2526. SO IT'S
INTERCONNECTED TO SOME OTHER
ISSUES RELATED TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. SO IT'S WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A PIPELINE OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING. WE
DELAYED PROJECTS FROM ONE BUDGET
YEAR INTO THE NEXT. AND WHEN WE
DID THE TOTAL REQUIRED FOR OUR
LINE ITEMS IN THE BUDGET EXCEEDS
THAT. AND THAT YEAR'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND. CORRECT.
WHAT YOU SAID. YES. SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CUT. BUT HOW WHY
ARE WE TAKING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUNDING AND SHIFTING IT
TO BRIDGE HOUSING. THAT. IS THAT
A PERMISSIBLE USE UNDER THE
CURRENT, UNDER THE OLD MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT RULES, I
WOULD IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC MIX
OF THE PROGRAM, I WOULD DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES WITHIN DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES JUST
BECAUSE IT'S NOT DIRECTLY
ADMINISTERED BY HCAI. HOWEVER
NOTING THAT THAT WAS WHAT WAS
INCLUDED WITHIN THE MAY REVISION
OF HOW TO UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS.
SO EVEN DESPITE THE FACT THERE
WAS A MINOR INCREASE IN REVENUES
AT MAY, REVISED, THIS FUND STILL
WAS UNABLE TO SUSTAIN THOSE
189.5. I GET THAT ONE. IT'S JUST
THE IT'S JUST THE SHIFT IN USE
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT. AND I UNDERSTAND PROP ONE,
BUT MAYBE YOU COULD GET BACK TO
IT'S NOT MY POSITION TO BE ABLE
TO ASK, BUT MAYBE YOU COULD GET
BACK TO MY CHAIR AND SHE CAN
SHARE IT WITH ME IF SHE CHOOSES
TO DO SO, SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE PSYCHIATRY AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. WAS ANY PART OF
THAT RETAINED? NOT A LOT OF
MONEY THERE, BUT IT'S AGAIN,
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND.
IT'S A NEW IT'S A NEW PROGRAM.
AND IT'S PROPOSED TO BE CUT IN
ITS ENTIRETY. OKAY. AND THEN THE
MEDICINE SCHOLARS PROGRAM, AND I
THINK I READ THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS CAREER OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM. BOTH OF THOSE ARE FULL
CUTS. RIGHT. IS THERE SOME THE
CONTINUES SCOTT. THERE'S ALSO,
SB 395. SO THERE'S A SMALL
AMOUNT FOR THE HEALTH CAREER
PROFESSIONS OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM
ONGOING. BUT YES. YES. SO TO
ELABORATE ON IT, THROUGH THE SB
395, WHICH IS A TAX, AN EXCISE
TAX ON ELECTRONIC CIGARETS
THROUGH THE REVENUE STREAM,
THERE IS SOME FUNDING THAT COMES
TO HCAI ANNUALLY. IT'S
APPROXIMATELY, AND I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU ON THE EXACT NUMBERS
ON THIS, BUT I BELIEVE IT'S
APPROXIMATELY 2 MILLION A YEAR
THAT GOES TO HCAI FOR THE
SPECIFIC WORKFORCE PROGRAM. SO
THAT FUNDING THAT'S COMING
THROUGH THAT EXCISE TAX IS STILL
BEING MAINTAINED. HOWEVER THE
APPROPRIATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICINE SCHOLARS PROGRAM OF 2.8
MILLION EACH YEAR IS BEING
PROPOSED FOR THE REDUCTION. SO
THAT 2 MILLION THAT'S STILL
COMING FROM THE EXCISE TAX IS
STILL BEING RETAINED. SO THERE
IS SOME FUNDING STILL FOR THE
PROGRAM. BUT THE APPROPRIATION
MADE FOR THE PROGRAM IS BEING,
PROPOSED AS REDUCTION. OKAY.
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. YEAH IT DOES. THANK
YOU. AND THANKS FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO GO THROUGH THEM.
OBVIOUSLY. SORRY, SENATOR, IF
IT'S COMING FROM THE SPECIAL
FUND, HOW IS IT BEING PROPOSED
TO BE? SO THERE'S TWO SEPARATE
FUNDING STREAMS. SO FIRST THERE
WAS A GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
FOR THE PROGRAM, THAT'S
INDEPENDENT OF THE SB 395 THAT
THE SPECIAL FUND AMOUNT IS IT'S
PARALLEL FUNDING, BUT IT'S
DIFFERENT FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
SO THE FUNDING THAT'S COMING
FROM SB 395 IS STILL BEING WE'RE
JUST NOT MATCHING IT ANYMORE IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. IT'S NOT
IT'S TWO SEPARATE. WHEN I IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY, THE
APPROPRIATION FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND THE FUNDING THAT CAME
THROUGH SB 395, THEY WERE
INDEPENDENT POLICIES THAT CAME
THROUGH. THEY WEREN'T KIND OF
INTERLOCKED, OF IF THIS IS
FUNDED THIS AMOUNT, WE THEN
MATCH IT. IT JUST IT'S A
COINCIDENCE THAT THE CURRENT
FUNDING IS ROUGHLY 2 MILLION,
AND THEN THE AMOUNT RIGHT NOW IS
2.8. SO IT'S THERE. IT'S NOT
DIRECTLY, CONNECTED. THANK YOU.
JUST I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
GOING THROUGH THESE. OBVIOUSLY,
THESE WERE ALL PROGRAMS THAT,
THOSE OF US HERE WERE INVESTED
IN. SO JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT'S
LEFT ON THE TABLE WHEN WE TAKE
THE MACHETE TO THE BUDGET, I
ASSUME, THAT THERE'S, THERE'S A
TOTAL OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND THAT DOES EXIST
THAT'S BEING REDIRECTED TO THIS
BRIDGE HOUSING PROGRAM. YOU'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE THAT TO THE
CHAIR. IT'S NOT 189.4 MILLION,
BECAUSE THAT'S A REDUCTION. WE
CAN DEFINITELY GET BACK ONTO
THAT. AND I BELIEVE OUR
COLLEAGUES, WHEN WE GET TO
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, THEY CAN ALSO PROVIDE
MORE INFO. BUT IF NOT, WE CAN
DEFINITELY CIRCLE BACK TO GET
MORE CLARITY ON THAT ISSUE.
PERFECT. THANK YOU. DIDN'T MEAN
TO BELABOR THIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR, OKAY. I THINK THERE'S A
COUPLE OTHER THINGS ON HERE. WE
CAN GO UNDER THE OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS THAT MAY REVISION. I
DON'T THINK WE'VE DOVE DOVE INTO
THOSE YET. THANKS, MADAM CHAIR,
SCOTT CHRISTMANN HCAI. SO THE
FIRST ONE ON CALOREX TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT, IS, IS ACTUALLY AN
ACCOUNTING ERROR THAT WAS
APPLIED. SO WE'RE WE'RE, WE HAD
RESULTED IN EXPENDITURES BEING
OVERSTATED BY 5.2 MILLION IN FY
22, 23. SO IT'S A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO CORRECT THE ERROR.
NO NET CHANGE, THE TECHNICAL
PARDON? CAN YOU SAY THAT TO ME
AGAIN? SURE, SURE. SO IT THE 5.2
MILLION ADJUSTMENT WAS AN
OVERSTATEMENT, AN ACCOUNTING
ERROR WE MADE THAT WE HAD 5.2.
CORRECT. JUST IN NUMBERS.
CORRECT NO NET CHANGE TO THAT,
BIOSIMILAR INSULIN INITIATIVE,
WHICH STILL HAD THE $50 MILLION
INVESTMENT. OKAY AND THEN THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS ON THE
TRANSFER TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING FUND, THIS
WAS ESSENTIALLY A INDIVIDUAL
LINE ITEM ENACTED IN 2022, 10
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS. AND
THE IDEA WAS TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES BY PAYING FOR
CERTIFICATION FEES. WE HAD
ORIGINALLY COME TO HIS BUDGET.
WE WERE GOING TO TRANSFER THAT
THROUGH INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT.
WE FOUND THAT THAT WE WERE
UNABLE TO DO THAT. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO SPEND OVER
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
FOR THE LICENSING BOARD. AND SO
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A TRANSFER
TO PUT THE DOLLARS INTO THEIR
BUDGET. YEAH. AND THEN THE THIRD
ONE, WHICH WE'VE TOUCHED ON,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRANSFORMATION, THIS IS A BCP
HCAI IS REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS AND $631,000 FROM THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
TO SUPPORT PLANNING,
IMPLEMENTATION AND OVERSIGHT FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES, AS DISCUSSED UNDER
SB 36, PROPOSITION ONE. SO
AGAIN, WE'RE EXCITED TO BEGIN
THAT PLANNING AND DEVELOP A
STRATEGY TO APPLY THAT WILL BE
INFORMED BY ALL OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST IN THE
AREA OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
INCLUDING SOCIAL WORK AND THE
LIKE. I CAN TOUCH ON THE TWO
BCP'S IF YOU'D LIKE. YES. SO IN
TERMS OF CHAPTER LEGISLATION, SB
779, THE CLINIC DATA
MODERNIZATION ACT WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR, SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
LICENSED CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA
TO SUBMIT DATA TO HCAI, WHICH
ARE THEN POSTED FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY PURPOSES, IT ALSO
EXTENDS THE APPLICATION OF THIS
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, TO
ADDITIONAL CLINICS. SO WE'VE
ALWAYS COLLECTED UTILIZATION
DATA FROM PRIMARY CARE CLINICS,
THIS ALSO INCLUDES INTERMITTENT
CLINICS. SO IT KIND OF DOUBLES
THE COLLECTION ADDS A NUMBER OF
NEW DATA ELEMENTS. SO WE'RE
WE'RE TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW.
WE'RE REQUESTING PERSONNEL TO
ADMINISTER THE REPORT
SUBMISSION, REVIEW AND EVALUATE
THE DATA REPORTS, PERFORM
STATISTICAL DE-IDENTIFICATION ON
ADDITIONAL DATA COLLECTED,
PERFORM COMPLIANCE ACTIVITIES
AND THE LIKE. SO WE ARE ASKING
FOR 15 PI OVER A THREE YEAR. SO
FIVE PI IN THE 2425 BUDGET YEAR
AND THEN EIGHT ADDITIONAL IN THE
FOLLOWING, AND THEN TWO IN
GENERAL FUND. RIGHT? NO. THIS IS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
PLANNING DATA FUND. YEAH, AND
AGAIN, TO THE EARLIER POINT, I
MEAN, THE WORK IN COLLECTING AND
MANAGING DATA IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THAN MANAGING THE WORKFORCE
GRANT. SO THIS IS DEFINITELY AN
EXPANSION OF THIS, OF THIS
PARTICULAR AREA. AND THEN THE
SECOND, IS ALSO FROM THE SAME,
AREA OF OUR ORGANIZATION,
IMPLEMENTING, AB 1392, WHICH
AMENDS EXISTING LAW RELATED TO
THE HOSPITAL SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
REPORTING PROGRAM, AND REQUIRES
SPECIFIED HOSPITALS TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO HCAI ABOUT THE
HOSPITAL'S MINORITY WOMEN, LGBT
AND DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROCUREMENT EFFORTS.
SO SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SUPPLIERS.
THIS BILL EXPANDS THE SCOPE OF
THOSE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
ALSO REQUIRES US TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL OUTREACH
AND SUPPORT TO HOSPITALS,
MANUFACTURERS, VENDORS, AND
DIVERSE BUSINESS ENTERPRISES, TO
WORK WITH HIS HOSPITAL SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY COMMISSION DEVELOPING.
IMPLEMENT NEW GUIDELINES TO
ASSIST HOSPITALS IN ENHANCING
PROCUREMENT EFFORTS TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION FROM DIVERSE
BUSINESSES. GREAT YEAH. SO THE
REQUEST THERE IS FOR, A TOTAL OF
FIVE PI FOR IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND ONE IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT LAW. OKAY.
THANK YOU. AND THEN ONE
REMAINING LEFTOVER FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGET. OH, THAT'S ON
THE, I THINK THAT'S ON STATE
HOSPITAL. IT'S THE PSYCHIATRY
PSYCHIATRY PAYMENT PROGRAM
REVERSION. DID YOU WANT TO TOUCH
ON THAT, IN TERMS OF WHAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THAT'S STILL BEING
THAT'S STILL ON THERE. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT? YEAH. JASON
CONSTANDUROS LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, AS MY
COLLEAGUE NOTED IN THE PREVIOUS
ITEM, YOU KNOW, OUR OFFICE IS
GENERAL RECOMMENDATION IS TO
FOCUS ON PULLING BACK A LIMITED
TERM SPENDING TO ADDRESS THE
BUDGET PROBLEM BEFORE ADDRESSING
, YOU KNOW, CORE SPENDING. THIS
PROPOSAL LARGELY ALIGNS WITH
THAT. IT FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON
LIMITED TERM SPENDING. I DID
WANT TO NOTE TWO THINGS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP AN EYE ON,
THE FIRST IS WE LEARNED THAT
FOR, YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS IN THE CURRENT YEAR,
23 TO 24 AND SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS, THE DEPARTMENT INDICATES,
HAD BEEN OBLIGATED OR COMMITTED
FOR CERTAIN CONTRACTS OR
COMMITMENTS. SO WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE, GET MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT TO ASSESS
THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THAT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW TO GET MORE
INFORMATION. AND THEN WE ALSO
WE'RE PULLING IT BACK. YES. THE
ONES THAT GOT AWARDED ALREADY,
SO IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME AWARD
COMMITMENTS MADE, BUT THE FUNDS
WERE NOT ENCUMBERED. AND SO THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD INVOLVE,
PULLING BACK SOME OF THOSE
COMMITMENTS THAT HAD BEEN MADE.
AND THEN WE ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE IS SOME ONGOING BASE
SPENDING IN THIS SOLUTION, TOO.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, THE YOU
DISCUSSED EARLIER, HCP THAT THAT
WAS A PROGRAM THAT THAT THAT
GENERAL FUND AMOUNT HAD BEEN
ONGOING. AND SO BECAUSE THERE'S
SOME ONGOING ITEMS IN HERE AND
THOSE WERE INTENDED TO BE
ONGOING WHEN THEY WERE ENACTED,
THAT THAT COULD BE SOMETHING FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP IN MIND
TOO, AS IT'S, AS IT'S WEIGHING
ITS FINAL DECISIONS. OKAY MADAM
CHAIR, MAY. WELL, I ASSUME THAT
WE TOOK THAT INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
WE MADE DECISIONS, WHEN SOMEBODY
MADE DECISIONS TO RECOMMEND THAT
, MONIES BE REVERTED OR WHATEVER
THE TERM IS WE WANT TO USE. FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU HAVE A MEDICAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAM, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IN THE
PIPELINE TO GET THE MEDICAL
RESIDENT THROUGH THE PROGRAM. SO
IF IT'S THREE YEARS, WE CAN'T BE
CUTTING A MEDICAL RESIDENCY
PROGRAM AND LEAVING MEDICAL
RESIDENTS WITHOUT THE MONEY TO
FINISH OR THE SCHOOLS WITHOUT
THE MONEY TO FINISH THE PROGRAM,
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO, WHEN
IT COMES TO PSYCHIATRIC LOAN
REPAYMENT, IF WE'VE MADE IF
WE'VE IF WE HAVE HIRED
PSYCHIATRISTS IN STATE HOSPITALS
JUST TO PICK ONE ON THE ON THE
PREMISE THAT IF THEY WORK, THEY
GET THEIR LOAN REPAID AND
THEY'VE TURNED OTHER JOBS DOWN
BECAUSE OF THAT, THEN THAT
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME EITHER. SO
AND THAT'S NOT YOUR FAULT, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SORT
THROUGH THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, BECAUSE THAT IS A
DISASTER. AND WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MEDICAL RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS, THAT'S A REAL
DISASTER, BECAUSE ONCE YOU HAVE
A MEDICAL RESIDENT IN A PROGRAM,
IT WE
THEN THE PROGRAM GOES AWAY
BECAUSE WE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THAT MEDICAL RESIDENT TO
FIND ANOTHER RESIDENCY BECAUSE
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. AND ON MATCH DAY,
THERE ARE PHYSICIANS WHO DON'T
GET ONE. AND SO THEY'RE STILL IN
THE POT. SO SOMEBODY WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW THIS PROCESS
SHOULD WORK IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH THAT AND THEN
PROVIDE US WITH A REPORT, IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING,
MR. ELLIOTT, THAT WE'VE GOT SOME
OF THESE, DANGLING WHATEVER OUT
THERE, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TIDY IT UP, YEAH. WELL, OUR
POINT IS THAT IT WOULD BE GOOD
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO GET MORE
INFORMATION. WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHICH OF THE OF
THE FUNDS HAD BEEN OBLIGATED. SO
THAT'S THE KIND OF THE FIRST
PRIORITY IS TO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, WHICH PROGRAMS THESE ARE
AFFECTING AND THEN TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHAT THE SORT OF
IMPLICATIONS ARE OF THAT OF
WELL, WE KNOW WE'VE CUT
RESIDENCY FUNDS, WE KNOW WE'VE
CUT SONG BROWN RESIDENCY FUNDS.
YEAH AND IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THOSE ARE THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE OBLIGATED FUNDS WERE FOR
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. CORRECT. SO
WE'VE WE'VE OBLIGATED $81
MILLION IN SONG BROWN
SPECIFICALLY. AND WE HAVE 19
PHYSICIANS WITH WHOM WE'VE MADE
AWARDS FOR LOAN REPAYMENT AWARD
LETTER OR THE AWARD LETTERS.
THOSE ARE POTENTIALLY GOING TO
BE PULLED BACK. THOSE ARE
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION UNDER
THE CURRENT YEAR DOLLARS. WE'RE
GOING TO I MEAN, WE'VE COMMITTED
AND WE'RE GOING TO PULL THEM
BACK. YEAH. 19 AND THEN AND THEN
WHAT THE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
WE'RE GOING TO WE'VE COMMITTED
WE'RE GOING TO PULL THAT MONEY
BACK. THAT'S WHAT'S PROPOSED
UNDER THE MAY REVISION. SENATOR.
THIS IS IN THE CURRENT YEAR. SO
THIS IS 23, 24 AMOUNTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD BEEN IMPLEMENTING
. AND THEY'RE PROPOSING TO PULL
THE BACK THE FUNDS. BUT THEY'VE
THEY'VE MADE AWARDED THE LETTER.
I THINK THAT'S A DISASTER. SO I
THINK I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR
THIS HEARING WITH THIS. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SOME CONVERSATIONS EITHER
OFFLINE OR IN ONE OF THE LATER
HEARINGS WHEN YOU WHEN SOMEBODY
COMES IN WITH SOME MORE DATA, I
MEAN, I UNDERSTAND BY I
UNDERSTAND TERMINATING A PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE MONEY, BUT
TO COMMIT TO PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING AND THEN
PULL IT BACK, OR TO TELL SCHOOLS
THAT THEY HAVE MONEY, HERE'S
WHATEVER IT IS, $75,000 FOR YOUR
THREE YEAR OR $175,000 FOR YOUR
THREE YEAR INTERNAL MEDICINE
RESIDENCY. AND TO TELL US A
MEDICAL GRADUATE THAT THEY HAVE
A RESIDENCY IN THE MEDICAL
GRADUATE SHOWS UP BECAUSE THAT'S
PAY. AND THEN TO SAY, OH, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DO IT ANYMORE. I
DIDN'T WORK FOR ME. SO I'LL
CLOSE MY LIPS AND NOT TALK
ANYMORE. SO I MEAN, WE DON'T WE
HAVE A VERY SHORT WINDOW. I MEAN
, WE HAVE LIKE THREE
SUBCOMMITTEES LEFT. I THINK IT'S
THIS IS A GOOD TIME. WELL
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GET
BACK TO US. I MEAN, THE LAO
RAISE THE ISSUE AND THAT'S WHAT
FLAGGED IT FOR ME. I ASSUME THAT
WE WERE THAT WE WERE CUTTING
THIS THING AT APPROPRIATE POINTS
TO CUT. AND IT MAY BE THAT WE'VE
WE NEED TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THAT. NO CRITICISM MA'AM. YOU
ALL DO A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I ALSO
MEANT TO POINT OUT THERE WAS A
QUESTION ABOUT SORT OF WHAT'S
LEFT IN THE HCAI BUDGET, AND I
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT AS
YOU'RE AS SORT OF THE TOP OF
YOUR AGENDA NOTES ON THE TOP OF
PAGE EIGHT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S AS
A RESULT OF THE, YOU KNOW, MAY
REVISION, YOU KNOW, IN 2024,
SORT OF ABOUT $70 MILLION IS
LEFT IN HCAI FOR GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT. AND THAT'S REALLY, YOU
KNOW, THE CORE OF THAT IS
SUPPORTING ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM. SO SOME
FUNDING FOR THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM WOULD REMAIN. IT'S ABOUT
33 MILLION. IT'S ONGOING, AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY THAT WOULD
SORT OF REMAIN THE CORE OF ITS
ONGOING BUDGET. OKAY. AND SOME
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
OTHER NON WORKFORCE RELATED
ITEMS. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD IT OPEN.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE
.
YEAH THEY'RE GOOD MORNING MARY
WATANABE, DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE, I'LL JUST START QUICKLY
WITH THE CHANGE IN OUR BUDGET
SINCE JANUARY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE'S BUDGET
INCREASED FROM 163 MILLION TO
178.4. PROPOSED BUDGET MILLION
BUDGET AND INCREASE IN POSITIONS
FROM 724 AUTHORIZED POSITIONS TO
783 AUTHORIZED POSITIONS. THAT'S
A 9.4 INCREASE IN OUR BUDGET AND
8.15 INCREASE IN POSITIONS. WE
HAVE SEVEN BèC THAT ARE PROPOSED
THAT I'LL RUN THROUGH QUICKLY,
THREE OF THESE ARE RELATED TO
WORKLOAD. ONE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT AND THREE ARE RELATED
TO LEGISLATION IMPLEMENTATION,
THE FIRST IS RELATED TO
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SECURITY,
K¾T AND WORKLOAD, AS YOU'RE
AWARE, CYBER ATTACKS, INCLUDING
DATA BREACHES AND RANSOMWARE
ATTACKS ARE EXPONENTIAL
INCREASING, ESPECIALLY IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE, IN JUNE OF
2021, THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT, THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY,
CONDUCTED AN ASSESSMENT AND
FOUND THAT THE DMHC HAS A NUMBER
OF SECURITY AND COMPLIANCE AREAS
WHERE WE NEED TO IMPROVE OUR
COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. WE'RE
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE REQUIREMENTS, AS WELL AS
TO OVERSEE OUR SECURITY.
REMEDIATIONS AND SYSTEMS. WE'RE
REQUESTING NINE POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF 1.9
MILLION AND 2425, AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. I'M SORRY, WE CAN
ZOOM THROUGH THESE. THE FIRST
THREE ARE FROM THE SPECIAL FUND.
RIGHT. SO THE DEPARTMENT IS ALL
SPECIAL AND WE GET NØ GENERAL
FUND. I KNOW THIS OKAY. I'LL GO
REALLY QUICKLY. THE NEXT ONE IS
TO ADD POSITIONS FOR EXECUTIVE
AND MANAGEMENT SUPPORT. AS WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY GROWN, WE'RE
LOOKING TO REALLY KIND OF RIGHT
SIZE OUR ORGANIZATION AND COMPLY
WITH KELEHER'S SUPERVISOR TO
STAFF RATIOS, THE BIGGEST ONE
HERE IS OUR HELP CENTER WORKLOAD
AUGMENTATION, WE'VE SEEN A
NEARLY 50% INCREASE IN THE CORE
FUNCTIONS THAT OUR HELP CENTER,
WE'VE GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY. WE'LL
HAVE ALMOST 200 POSITIONS. SO
WE'RE LOOKING TO SPLIT THE HELP
CENTER UNDER TWO DEPUTY
DIRECTORS. SO THIS IS RELATED TO
THAT, WE ALSO HAVE A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT RELATED TO A PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION RELATED TO OUR FINES
AND PENALTIES. WE NEED
ADDITIONAL TIME TO MOVE THE
FUNDING AND GET A CONTRACT IN
PLACE. SO WE'RE LOOKING JUST FOR
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO ALLOW
US MORE TIME TO DO THAT. AND
THEN MOVING ON TO OUR
LEGISLATION IMPLEMENTATION,
THERE WAS A BILL, AB 1048 THAT
WILL HAVE THE DEPARTMENT DOING
RATE REVIEW OF DENTAL PLANS AND
DENTAL RATES. SO THIS WOULD BE
POSITIONS AND AUTHORITY TO SET
UP A DENTAL RATE REVIEW PROGRAM.
AND THEN WE HAVE DOOLAS AB 904.
THE PLANS WILL BE REPORTING TO
US ON THEIR DOULA COVERAGE AND
PROGRAMS. WILL BE PREPARING A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. SO
WE'RE LEGISLATURE REQUESTING
RESOURCES AND POSITIONS TO DO
THAT WORK. AND THEN LAST BUT NOT
LEAST, BIOMARKER TESTING UNDER
SB 496, THE PLANS WILL HAVE NEW
COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
COVERING COVERING BIOMARKER
TESTING. SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
POSITIONS AND AUTHORITY TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN. MOVING ON TO,
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. STOP.
HELLO. ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHELLE BASS,
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES 164.1 BILLION
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND 4688
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. OF THAT AMOUNT, ABOUT
1.4 BILLION IS FOR STATE
OPERATIONS. AND THEN THE VAST
MAJORITY, 162.7 BILLION, IS FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE. PREDOMINANT
THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. YOUR
AGENDA HAS DOES A GREAT JOB KIND
OF COMPARING, GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TO MAY REVISION. SO I WILL MOVE
ON TO, SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AS YOU KNOW,
THE STATE IS FACING A
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
CHALLENGE. 26.20 7.6 BILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND 28.4 BILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR, PLUS ONE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS A GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE OF ABOUT $36
BILLION AND REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND SPEND. AS
SUCH, WE'LL GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS PROPOSED AS PART
OF MAY REVISION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT, WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ARE PROPOSALS AND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
WILL WORK TOGETHER OVER THE
COMING WEEKS TO ACHIEVE A
BALANCED BUDGET TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS IN TERMS OF THE
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE TAX, OR
MCO TAX, AS PART OF MAY
REVISION, WE ARE PROPOSING
MODIFICATIONS TO THE MCO TAX
EFFECTIVE APRIL 1ST, 2024, TO
ACCOUNT FOR MEDICARE REVENUE AS
PART OF THE MODEL. AND BY DOING
SO, WE CAN INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
AGGREGATE TAX ALLOWABLE WHILE
STILL MEETING FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. THE MAY REVISION
ASSUMES 689.9 MILLION IN NET
REDUCED GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR, 950,000,000 IN
20 2526 AND 1.3 BILLION IN 2627.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO AMEND OUR
REVISED OUR MCO TAX MODEL TO NOW
ALLOW OR INCLUDE MEDICARE
REVENUE AS PART OF THE
CALCULATION. THIS ALLOWS US TO
INCREASE OUR TAX ON MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS. THERE IS NO
IMPACT TO OUR COMMERCIAL PLANS,
AS WE ARE ONLY PROPOSING TO
INCREASE THE TAX ON THE MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE LIVES. ARE WE SURE
THIS IS THE MAX? SO I WILL SAY,
YOU KNOW, AS PART OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WE SUBMITTED OUR THE
AFTER EARLY ACTION AT THE END OF
MARCH, AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH CMS ON ON THE MCO TAX. THEY
PROVIDED CLARIFICATION TO US
JUST AT THE END OF APRIL,
RELATED TO THE ABILITY TO WHAT
CAN BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
6% REVENUE THAT CAN BE INCLUDED.
AND SO WE JUST RECENTLY RECEIVED
THIS CLARIFICATION FROM CMS THAT
WE CAN INDEED INCLUDE MEDICARE
REVENUE, AS WE THINK ABOUT OTHER
SOME OF OUR OTHER PROVIDER
TAXES, IT'S REALLY THINKING
ABOUT THE CLASS OF THE PROVIDER
AND NOT JUST NECESSARILY THE
REVENUE OF COMMERCIAL AND
MEDI-CAL. AND SO THIS IS A
RECENT CLARIFICATION BASED ON
ACTUALLY A RULE FROM 2008 FROM
CMS. AND SO THIS IS IT IS A
NEWER UPDATE FERM. SO HOPEFULLY
SO WHEN WE APPLY FOR THE NEXT
ONE, WE'LL BE ABLE TO INCLUDE
THIS NEW CALCULATION. YES.
CORRECT. OKAY DIRECTOR. SO THE
BREAKDOWN EACH YEAR THAT I'M
SEEING HERE, ALL OF IT FOR THE
OUTGOING YEARS WILL BE GENERAL
FUND. CORRECT. OKAY. THE ONE
THING AND I KNOW I'M GOING TO
JUMP A LITTLE AHEAD, I DIDN'T
HAVE ON MY BINGO CARD 115
MILLION FOR CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FROM MCO TAX. I DON'T THINK
ANYONE DID. WHERE DID THIS COME
FROM? SO THIS IS A NEW PROPOSAL
RELATED TO CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
AND IT'S TO CREATE A DIRECTED
PAYMENT USING OUR MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT ESSENTIALLY
TO OUR CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS AS
THEY CARE FOR THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE AND SICKEST CHILDREN.
MAYBE, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GOING
TO DISAGREE OR CONTEST THE VALUE
OF OUR CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL, BUT
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN PART OF THE
CONVERSATION IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS OF WHERE THE NEED IS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I MISS THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT WHERE DID WE
WHAT NEED ARE WE ADDRESSING
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS
SITUATION? SO CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS WERE AS JUST AS A
HOSPITAL. WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE PART OF THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. THE OUTPATIENT. SO
SOME OF THE CATEGORIES THAT WE
HAD PROPOSED FOR 2025 RATE
INCREASES. SO ALWAYS PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT MAYBE NOT
SINGLED OUT IN TERMS OF THE
PARTICULAR NEED, BUT JUST BASED
ON CONVERSATIONS AND THE KIND OF
THE NEED FOR SOME OF THEIR, YOU
KNOW, THEIR COSTS ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH FOR SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SICKEST CHILDREN.
SOME OF THE KIND OF WHAT WE CALL
OUTLIERS OF THE WAY WE THINK
ABOUT SOME OF THE COSTS FOR SOME
OF THOSE CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE MAKING THIS
PROPOSAL. AS WE WERE HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WELL, NOT
THAT AS WE WERE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, I'M WONDERING,
YOU KNOW, RURAL HOSPITALS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
THIS DISTRESSED HOSPITAL AND SO
FORTH. I MEAN, I JUST HAD A REAR
ADMIRAL COME INTO MY OFFICE
YESTERDAY. RIDGECREST HOSPITAL,
JUST ANOTHER LABOR AND DELIVERY
DELIVERY JUST GOT CLOSED. AND
THE CLOSEST ONE IS 80 MILES AWAY
, I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
I GUESS I'M STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE CHOOSING
SOME OF THESE THINGS. AND I KNOW
WE HAVE TO CHOOSE SOME OVER THE
OTHER, BUT IF I DON'T KNOW IF I
HAVE A QUESTION THERE, I WILL
JUST SAY, THIS IS OUR PROPOSAL
AND WE HAVE WEEKS TO WORK
TOGETHER ON, YOU KNOW, REVISIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
EXPLORE. OKAY. YOU KNOW, MADAM
DIRECTOR, I DO AGREE THAT THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION. THEY
THEY'RE MEDI-CAL PATIENTS.
CORRECT FOR THE MOST PART, VAST
MAJORITY. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE THE BREAKDOWN, LINDY. I
DON'T HAVE THE BREAKDOWN WITH
ME, BUT, YES, WE DO HEAR THAT
THEY HAVE A HEAVY, MEDI-CAL
POPULATION AND THE COST OF
PROVIDING CARE WITH, FIRST OF
ALL, THE THEY REQUIRE A
PEDIATRIC SPECIALIST SPECIALTY
PHYSICIANS, WHICH ARE IN HIGH
DEMAND. AND THERE'S A SHORTAGE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THEY
ALSO MOST OFTEN HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE SICKEST OF THE SICK.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
KIDS AND OUR ACUTE CARE GENERAL
HOSPITALS, FOR THE MOST PART,
THERE MAY BE SOME EXCEPTIONS,
HAVE NO PEDIATRIC UNITS ANYMORE.
FOR WHATEVER REASON. AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO PRESERVE
THIS CAPACITY, HOWEVER LIMITED
IT IS, TO TRY TO TAKE CARE OF
KIDS WHO NEED THAT TYPE OF CARE,
I ALSO DO THINK, HOWEVER,
THOUGH, THAT I REALIZE THIS IS A
PROPOSAL WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE SORT OF PUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY IN A
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL FUND THIS
YEAR, AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE
FIND IT IN A YEAR WHERE WE'RE
CUTTING PROGRAMS THAT NOT ONLY
BREAK OUR HEARTS, BUT UNDO WORK
THAT MANY HAVE BEEN SPENDING
YEARS AROUND HERE TRYING TO DO.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
MONEY IN A DISTRESSED HOSPITAL
FUND TO TIDE OUR RURAL HOSPITALS
OVER UNTIL WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO WITH MONEY TARGETED MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT HELP
SOME OF THEM MAKE THE LINES
CROSS. HOW WE PERSUADE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP US BY
, PROVIDING SOME ADDITIONAL, YOU
KNOW, DISH ON STEROIDS FOR RURAL
HOSPITALS, AND IN THE CASE OF
HOSPITALS THAT ARE IN RURAL
AREAS THAT SERVICE, MILITARY
MEMBERS, CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES AND
THEIR SPOUSES AT REMOTE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS, HOW THEY HELP US,
HELP THEM BY SUPPLEMENTING THE
MONEY THAT WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
IN THE STATE TO THOSE HOSPITALS,
TO HELP THEM KEEP THE DOORS
OPEN, TO PROVIDE CRITICAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO THOSE PERSONNEL WHO
CAN'T GET IT ANYWHERE ELSE. SO I
JUST THAT'S A COMMENT, NOT A
QUESTION. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DO. I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. NO, 100. I THINK
HE SAID IT MORE ELOQUENTLY.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY,
BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
LABOR AND DELIVERY UNITS ARE
GETTING CLOSED ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE, AND CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ARE GOING TO GET AN INFLUX OF
MORE KIDS BECAUSE MORE
COMPLICATED PREGNANCY OR
DELIVERIES ARE GOING TO HAPPEN.
IF WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING OR
CLOSING THAT GAP THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. SO WHEN IT COMES TO ONE
OF SOME OF THOSE DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS, I THINK WE DO NEED TO
PERHAPS FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE,
I SHOULDN'T SAY FOCUS MORE.
THINK ABOUT AS WE'RE ALLOCATING
115 OUT OF THIS FOR MAYBE
INCLUDING A LITTLE BIT MORE STAY
WITHIN THE ZONE OF HOSPITALS. I
KNOW IT'S ONGOING CONVERSATIONS.
I MEAN, WE HAD A WHOLE HEARING
ON THIS WHOLE THING AND MOOT
POINT NOW, BUT, JUST THROWING
THAT OUT AS WE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. DIRECTOR PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY, ADDITIONALLY, AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION, WE'RE
MAINTAINING THE 2024, TARGETED
RATE INCREASES THAT WENT INTO
EFFECT JANUARY 1ST, 2024, AND
THOSE AGAIN, WERE ARE FOR
PRIMARY CARE, NON SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH AND MATERNITY
CARE, BRINGING THOSE TO 87.5% OF
MEDICARE. WE ARE ELIMINATING,
FINALLY WE ARE ELIMINATING THE
2025 RATE INCREASES THAT WE'VE
SPOKEN ABOUT PREVIOUSLY IN
SUBCOMMITTEE AND USING THOSE
DOLLARS AND THE RESERVE FUND TO
OFFSET GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. NOW MOVING ON
TO SOME OF THE OTHER SOLUTIONS
OR, SURE, MAYBE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, HELP ME UNDERSTAND THIS
IS MORE IN THE WEEDS. YOU'RE THE
EXPERTS ON THE STRUCTURE OF THE
BUDGET, REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WE'RE BALANCING WE'RE
SOLVING FOR CURRENT FOR,
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR PLUS ONE.
SO THAT GETS US INTO 2627.
CORRECT. DO I HAVE THAT SO FAR?
NO, NO. THAT GETS US INTO 2526
OKAY. A LOT OF PROPOSED
SOLUTIONS ARE CUTS INTO YEAR
THREE, YEAR FOUR OR LIKE MCO,
WE'RE ALREADY ALLOCATING GENERAL
FUND FOR YEAR THREE, YEAR FOUR.
EXPLAIN TO ME THE TECHNICAL K¾T
OR THE MATH BEHIND WHY DO WE
SOLVE FOR YEAR THREE AND FOUR?
WHY? WHY DO WE HAVE TO ALLOCATE
FOR THAT? NOW? IF WE'RE ONLY
DOING NEXT PLUS ONE? A DETAIL
RELATED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
THE ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZED
SORT OF ONE TIME OR SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS GIVEN THE BUDGET
SITUATION. BUT FOR SOME OF THEM,
I MEAN, WE HAVE PROPOSED MORE
OUT YEAR SOLUTIONS, AND JUST
GIVEN THE DIFFICULTY OF THE
BUDGET SITUATION, THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE MCO TAXES FOR THE OUT
YEARS, IS THERE A MATHEMATICAL
REASON LIKE WE HAVE TO BALANCE
OUT YEAR THREE, YEAR FOUR, OR WE
, I GUESS I FEEL LIKE I'M
LOOKING FOR MORE OR LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW, WHAT'S THE REASON
FOR BALANCING THREE AND FOUR, I
THINK THAT WHILE, LIKE THE
BUDGET YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER
THAT WERE DEFINITELY HEAVILY THE
PRIORITY, I MEAN, WE, GIVEN SOME
OF THE SPENDING, WE MIGHT BE
FACE A, YOU KNOW, ADDITIONAL
PROBLEMS IN THE OUT YEARS. AND
SO, FOR THIS PROPOSAL, BEALL,
THE, OUT YEARS ARE ALSO A PART
OF THE SOLUTION OR WHY DO WE
LOCK OURSELVES INTO THE NUMBERS
FOR THREE AND FOUR WHERE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THINGS ARE GOING
TO LOOK LIKE IN THREE AND FOUR
OR. YEAH OR WE'RE LOCKING
OURSELVES INTO THREE AND FOUR.
RIGHT. IF RIGHT HERE THE REQUEST
IS FOR UP TO 26, 27. WE WHILE I
MEAN THIS IS CURRENTLY LIKE THE
ESTIMATE FOR YEARS THREE AND
FOUR, SO WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
UPDATE AND REVISE THOSE NUMBERS
AS THE BUDGET PROCESS CONTINUES
OVER THE OVER THE OUT YEARS.
OKAY. SO OKAY. MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM, JUST WANTED TO TOUCH
ON SOME OF THE BUDGET SOLUTIONS
RELATED TO THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A REDUCTION OF 337.1
MILLION TO KHÎI. THESE
ADJUSTMENTS ARE FIRST, A RIGHT
SIZING OF SOME OF THE FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS AND WILL NOT HINDER
THE DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT TO
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
GROUNDBREAKING WORK TO DATE.
JUST FOR CONTEXT, WE'VE AWARDED
248 MILLION IN SEBIHI GRANT
FUNDING TO 424 ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS 58 COUNTIES TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO EVIDENCE BASED AND
COMMUNITY DEFINED PRACTICES AND
PROGRAMS. WE'VE ALSO DISTRIBUTED
110 MILLION IN FUNDS TO 58
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. IN
TERMS OF THE SOLUTION, WE ARE
PROPOSING A ONE TIME REDUCTION
OF 140 MILLION FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH VIRTUAL
SERVICES PLATFORM. THIS WILL
ESSENTIALLY RIGHTSIZE THE BUDGET
BASED ON THE WAY WE'VE
CONSTRUCTED THE CONTRACT,
BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON
UTILIZATION. AND WE JUST STARTED
IN JANUARY. SO YEAR ONE OF
UTILIZATION IS NOT GOING TO
MATCH YEARS TWO, THREE AND FOUR.
SO REALLY, REALLY IT'S MORE OF A
RIGHT SIZING OF THE CONTRACT IN
THE WAY WE'VE SET IT UP. SO
SUCCESSFUL I'VE HEARD IT'S NOT A
WELL MAYBE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. HOW SUCCESSFUL IS
THIS. NOT A LOT OF UTILIZATION,
WE'RE TRACKING I THINK ABOUT
20,000 REGISTRANTS, ABOUT 2800
COACHING SESSIONS HAVE OCCURRED.
SO YOU KNOW, IT JUST CAME OUT IN
JANUARY. REALLY? I MEAN, NOW IS
THE PART OF KIND OF GETTING THE
WORD OUT AND WORKING WITH ALL OF
OUR PARTNERS, OUR SCHOOLS, ETC.
TO GET THE WORD OUT. WE DO
PROJECT, YOU KNOW, UTILIZATION
TO GROW, OVER THE YEAR. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY, AS A SCHOOL YEAR
STARTS AS WELL, THAT'S A NEW WAY
TO KIND OF REALLY BRING OUT THE
KIND OF THE EFFORT ON ONGOING,
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. YES, YES. HUM, WHAT IS
LEFT AFTER WE'RE PROPOSING TO
TAKE OUT 140 MILLION? I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT.
BUT I WILL SAY OUR CONTRACT GOES
THROUGH JUNE 30TH, 2027. SO OKAY
. SO WE ALREADY HAVE A CONTRACT
FOR THE PLATFORM. YEAH. 2027.
HOW MUCH ARE WE ALLOCATING
ANNUALLY? NATE WILLIAMS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO JUST
TO CLARIFY, SO YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR KIND OF JUST THE ANNUAL
ONGOING AS WE KIND OF REACH THE
FULL, FULL IMPLEMENTATION. OKAY.
27 HOW MUCH DID FOR THE FOR THIS
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS PLATFORM,
IT WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY 178.9
MILLION THAT WE'VE ALREADY
COMMITTED TO THIS VENDOR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO FOR THREE,
THREE MORE YEARS. WELL, THAT
WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE JUST THE
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE PROJECTING TO
BE THE YEARLY ONGOING COST, AS
FAR AS WHAT WE'VE INCLUDED. AND
SO SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
THE BUDGETED DOLLARS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, IN 24, 25, WE HAVE
ALMOST 220 MILLION BUDGETED. SO
THAT INCLUDES SOME PAYMENTS THAT
ARE STILL DUE, AS WELL AS KIND
OF THE ONGOING FUNDING AS WELL,
I GUESS I'M WONDERING, DIRECTOR,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THIS JUST
STARTED IN JANUARY. I THINK
THAT'S BEEN KIND OF LIKE OUR
SOMEWHAT OF OUR GUIDING LIGHT
FOR THINGS THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR
CUT THINGS THAT ARE NOT SUPER,
SUPER NEW. SO I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THERE'S ROOM TO GET OUT, BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A
CONTRACTOR. WE DO HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE TWO VENDORS,
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT, HAS WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS. A
SCIENTIFIC WORKGROUP, REALLY THE
PLANNING TO DEVELOP AND KIND OF
LAUNCH THESE THESE PLATFORMS WAS
A SIGNIFICANT EFFORT. IT LASTED
OVER, I THINK CLOSE TO TWO
YEARS. REALLY ALL THE
STAKEHOLDER WORK, THE ENGAGEMENT
WITH YOUTH TO REALLY DESIGN AND
KIND OF COME TO THESE PRODUCTS.
AND SO A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK HAS BEEN DONE TO
ESSENTIALLY LAUNCH THESE
PLATFORMS AND WORK WITH THE
VENDOR TO, TO IMPLEMENT AND
RELEASE IN JANUARY. VÆ. OKAY
OKAY, THE NEXT TWO RELATED ITEMS
ARE THE SCHOOL LINKED HEALTH
PARTNERSHIP AND CAPACITY GRANTS
FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
OUR CSUS AND UCS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. A REDUCTION
IN 100 MILLION IN GRANTS, SPLIT
BETWEEN 2324 AND 2425 AND THEN
ALSO A REDUCTION FOR OUR CSUS
AND UCS OF 50,000,000 IN 24, 25.
WE MAINTAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH OUR INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH REGARD TO
IMPLEMENTING THE FEE SCHEDULE,
WHICH WILL GO LIVE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE FALL
OF THIS YEAR, AND THEN FOR OUR
UCS AND CSUS STARTING IN JANUARY
OF 2025. SO CONTINUE THE WORK ON
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
GETTING READY FOR THESE
ENGAGEMENTS. BUT THESE ARE A
REDUCTION IN SOME OF THE
CAPACITY GRANTS TO SUPPORT THEM.
ALSO, A REDUCTION IN THE
EVIDENCE BASE AND COMMUNITY
DEFINED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM GRANTS. THIS IS A
REDUCTION OF 47.1 MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR, WE'VE WHEN WE
INITIALLY DEVELOPED THIS, KIND
OF THIS GRANT PROGRAM, WE HAD
PLANNED FOR SIX ROUNDS OF GRANTS
WITH THE LAST ONE BEING REALLY
FOCUSED ON EVIDENCE BASED AND
COMMUNITY DEFINED PRACTICES. BUT
ALL PREVIOUS GRANTS, ROUNDS OF
GRANTS HAVE INCLUDED THAT FOCUS
AS WELL. AND SO JUST GIVEN THE
STATE'S FISCAL SITUATION,
RECOGNIZING, THIS IS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION WITH REGARD TO THE
NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION PROJECT
FUNDING AND MEDICATION ASSISTANT
TREATMENT, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO REDUCE BY 57.3
MILLION GENERAL FUND FROM LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND 3.7 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND FROM STATE
OPERATIONS, AS THIS REFLECTS THE
REDUCTION OF 35 MILLION FOR THE
NDP PROGRAM AND THEN ABOUT 22
MILLION RELATED TO THE
MEDICATION ASSISTANT TREATMENT
EXPANSION PROGRAM. I WILL SAY
WITH THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT OF
CAL RX AS THE STATE'S NEW
PARTNERSHIP THAT ALLOWS THE
STATES TO PURCHASE KALACH KALACS
BRANDED OTC OVER-THE-COUNTER,
EXCUSE ME, NALOXONE FOR $24 A
LOT CHEAPER THAN WHAT WE ARE
PURCHASING TODAY. AND SO THIS
REDUCTION AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL
8 MILLION IN OPIOID SETTLEMENT
FUNDS, WE DO NOT THINK THERE
WILL BE A REDUCTION TO THAT
PROGRAM WITH REGARD TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATE ROUND SIX OF THIS
PROGRAM. NO AWARDS OR
ANNOUNCEMENT HAS BEEN MADE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS, SO THERE ARE NO
GUARANTEES THAT WILL BE IMPACTED
BY THE REDUCTION OF THIS. I WILL
NOTE EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED THE RELEASE
OF OUR PROGRAM GUIDANCE FOR THE
BISHOP BOND ONE, OUR BOND ROUND
ONE FUNDING, WHERE WE WILL BE
RELEASING 3.3 BILLION IN BISHOP
DOLLARS RELATED TO THE BOND.
THIS SUMMER. AND SO THIS WEEK WE
RELEASED THE GUIDANCE. SO OUR
GRANT OR POTENTIAL AWARDEES
REALLY KNOW WHAT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE PROGRAM WILL BE AND WILL
BE READY ONCE THE NOTICE FOR
REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS COMES
OUT THIS SUMMER, WE'RE LEAVING
APPROXIMATELY LIKE 30 MILLION ON
THE TABLE FOR BISHOP. WHY THAT
IS RELATED TO, CONTRACTS WE HAVE
RELATED TO EMERGENCY
STABILIZATION UNITS THAT WE'VE
WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ON JUST TO
FINISH OUT THE CONTRACT.
CORRECT. OKAY AND THEN FOR THE
OTHER ONE, WE LEFT SOME MONEY AS
WELL. THE BRIDGE HOUSING. OH
YEAH. SO I'LL GET TO THAT ONE.
YEAH. SORRY. AND THEN IN TERMS
OF THE BRIDGE HOUSING, THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE
HOUSING, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO REDUCE FUNDING BY
132 MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 20
2425, AND 275,000,000 IN 2526.
SO FOR BUDGET YEAR, ESSENTIALLY
A REDUCTION OF THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL OR THE ORIGINAL FUNDING
BY A HALF, AND THEN FOR BUDGET
YEAR PLUS ONE, THIS IS WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
REPLACE SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT, OR MHSA FUNDING, WHICH WAS
DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM
WITH, HCAI. AND SO USING 90
MILLION FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT, STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS TO FUND
BRIDGE HOUSING. AND MADAM
DIRECTOR, THAT'S RELATED TO PROP
ONE AND THE RECHARACTERIZATION
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND. THIS THESE ARE ACTUALLY
DOLLARS THAT ARE REALLY STILL
UNDER MHSA Þ AS BRIDGE HOUSING
ARE PERMITTED USE. YES, MA'AM.
WE HAD, AS PART OF GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE HAD ALREADY PROPOSED
A SHIFT IN SOME GENERAL FUND TO
MHSA DOLLARS. AND THIS IS A
FURTHER, SHIFT. OKAY, AS PART OF
THE MAY REVISION, WE ARE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE A PORTION
OF THE EQUITY AND PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PROGRAM OR GRANTS
, ESSENTIALLY ONLY USING THE
AMOUNT THAT WAS APPROPRIATE AS
PART OF THE 2022 BUDGET ACT.
THIS RESULTS IN ABOUT $280
MILLION IN REDUCTION REDUCED
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES, AS A
RESULT, OUR COHORT ONE, WHICH
WAS ANNOUNCED IN JANUARY, WE
WILL NEED TO REVISE THE PROGRAM
MILESTONES AND PROGRAM GUIDANCE
GIVEN THE REDUCTION IN FUNDING
FOR THOSE GRANTEES. WE ARE
PROPOSING ALSO TO ELIMINATE THE
HEALTH ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS,
THE FINAL YEAR OF FUNDING FOR
THOSE THOSE CONTRACTS. THAT
PROGRAM BEGAN JULY 2022. IT
PROVIDES FUNDING TO COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
SERVE HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI-CAL. THESE DOLLARS ARE USED
FOR OUTREACH, APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE, ENROLLMENT, RETAINER
ASSISTANCE WITH
REDETERMINATIONS, ETC. OKAY, WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE,
ADULT ACUPUNCTURE. IT'S AN
OPTIONAL BENEFIT IN THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. THIS IS A GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS OF 5.4 MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND 13.1 MILLION
ONGOING, THIS BENEFIT WAS
ELIMINATED IN 2009 AND RESTORED
BACK IN 2016. BUT AS AS
MENTIONED EARLIER BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
INTENT OF SOME OF THESE
REDUCTIONS IS REALLY JUST TO
FOCUS ON CORE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE 2 MILLION
IN ONGOING GENERAL FUNDS FOR
FREE CLINICS. AB 128 STATUTES OF
2021 PROVIDED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
FREE AND CHARITABLE CLINICS.
THESE ARE TAX EXEMPT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOT
MEDI-CAL PROVIDERS OR DO NOT
QUALIFY AS MEDI-CAL PROVIDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT DISTRIBUTES THESE
FUNDS TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FREE AND
CHARITABLE CLINICS, WHO THEN
DETERMINES THE ALLOCATION OF
THESE DOLLARS TO CLINICS. WE DUG
DEEP FOR THIS ONE? THIS IS 2
MILLION FOR FREE CLINICS. OH MY
GOSH, THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE 2
MILLION FOR THIS CENSUS THING
THAT I TALKED ABOUT. THAT'S
WELL, OKAY, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO FREEZE FUNDING
LEVELS FOR COUNTY ADMINISTRATION
OF MEDI-CAL ELIGIBILITY FUNDING.
THIS IS A REDUCTION ABOUT 20
MILLION, IN 2024, 25 ONGOING. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS HAS BEEN
DONE IN PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN THE
STATES FACED FISCAL CHALLENGES
STARTING IN 22,008, NINE GOING
THROUGH 20 1718, AND THEN WAS
RESTORED IN 1819 AND PROPOSING
TO AGAIN FREEZE THAT AS PART OF
THE MAY REVISION. WILL THE
DEPARTMENT COME BACK IN 2627 TO
LOOK AT IF WE STILL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FREEZE THE 65
MILLION IN THE 88.8? SO AS PART
OF THE TRAILER BILL, EVERY YEAR
WE NEED TO ADD THE YEAR. AND SO
IT IS A CONVERSATION EVERY YEAR
TO FREEZE. THAT'S YES, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM WITH
REDUCED GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 23
MILLION ANNUALLY, STARTING IN
2425. THESE GRANT FUNDS SUPPORT
REALLY PREVENTION AND PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES THAT ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
AMERICAN INDIAN, PATIENTS AND
ARE PROVIDED IN A PRIMARY CARE
SAVINGS SETTINGS. MANY OF THESE
DOLLARS ARE USED TO SUPPLEMENT
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER SALARIES.
I WOULD NOTE THIS PROGRAM WAS
ELIMINATED IN 2009 TEN, AS AS A
RESULT OF THE STATE'S FISCAL
SITUATION AND WAS RESTORED IN
THE 20 2223 BUDGET. SO RECENTLY
RESTORED, AND IT'S GETTING CUT
AGAIN. DIRECTOR, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WEREN'T HERE DURING THAT
TIME, BUT I WONDER AMONGST YOUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE RECESSION WE
HAD AND ALL THE CUTS WE DID, TO
CORE SERVICES. I MEAN, THE
IMPACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO START
SEEING. I MEAN, ARE WE REALLY
PREPARED FOR THAT? LIKE THIS? I
MEAN, WE WON'T SEE IT. MAYBE
WE'LL START SEEING IT NEXT YEAR,
BUT THIS IS GOING TO COST US A
LOT OF MONEY ON THE OUT YEARS.
LIKE, I'M WONDERING STRUCTURALLY
HOW THE DEPARTMENT IS PREPARING
FOR THAT. I MEAN, WHAT CREATIVE
THINGS ARE WE COMING UP WITH
WITHIN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
CAN OFFSET SOME OF THESE REALLY
NEGATIVE IMPACTS? I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S JUST ANY
INSIGHT TO YOUR GENIUS BRAIN OF
LIKE, WHAT YOU'RE THINKING. I
THINK FOR SOME OF THESE, YOU
KNOW, WHERE WE WERE REALLY
MAKING A TARGETED EFFORT TO
REALLY REDUCE DISPARITIES OR
REALLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE NEEDS
OF SOME OF THE STATE'S
POPULATIONS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
REALLY ADDRESSED BEFORE. WE WILL
NEED TO THINK ABOUT, EVEN JUST
FROM A QUALITY PERSPECTIVE, HOW
WE CAN JUST KEEP OUR EYE ON THE
DATA AND KEEP OUR EYE ON KIND
OF, YOU KNOW, OTHER
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE OUR
HEALTH PLANS MAY BE ALSO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT. AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE
THINKING THROUGH. MADAM. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MADAM
DIRECTOR, I TRIED TO ASK THIS IN
ANOTHER SECTION, PROBABLY
INARTICULATELY, BUT DO WE, WHEN
WE ELIMINATE THIS MONEY TO
PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE SERVICES
REYES IN THIS CASE TO TRIBAL
MEMBERS? ISN'T THAT GOING TO PUT
A BURDEN IN TERMS OF PERHAPS
UNCOMPENSATED CARE ON OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEM AT SOME LEVEL?
AND OR INCREASE THE COST OF THE
CARE ON OUR ACUTE CARE GENERAL
HOSPITAL SYSTEM AND DO WE TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND TRY TO
QUANTIFY WHAT THAT INCREASE IS
VERSUS WHAT THE WAS IT $23
MILLION, THE 23 MILLION THAT
WE'RE CUTTING? AND SO IT'S
CHEAPER TO CUT THE 23 MILLION.
AM I MAKING SENSE? OH
DEFINITELY. I MEAN, I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY HAS HAD SUCH A
FOCUSED EFFORT OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, PARTICULARLY WITH OUR
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY STRATEGY
AND EVEN WITH OUR TARGETED RATE
INCREASES WITH THE MCO ON
PRIMARY CARE AND PREVENTION AND,
AND THESE THESE TYPES OF
PROPOSALS. YOU KNOW, WE WILL
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THEM BECAUSE
THERE IS SUCH THERE'S SO MUCH
EVIDENCE, RIGHT, IN TERMS OF
PREVENTION AND PRIMARY CARE AND
HOW THAT REDUCES HOSPITAL STAYS,
HOW THAT REDUCES E.R.
UTILIZATION. AND SO, YES, WE
WILL HAVE TO THINK THROUGH THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS ANYTHING. AND
WE'RE DEALING OF COURSE, IN THIS
COMMITTEE. THIS CHAIR DEALS WITH
THE MOST VULNERABLE ALL OVER THE
STATE, ALL THE TIME, BUT IN THE
CASE OF, FOR EXAMPLE, THE INDIAN
HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM, WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOT ONLY THE MOST
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE, BUT
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE THAT
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN THE MOST
IGNORED OR SOME OF THE MOST
IGNORED IN OUR IN OUR STATE, WE
PROBABLY NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. YEAH.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. PLEASE
CONTINUE. DIRECTOR, WE ARE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE THE MAJOR
RISK MEDICAL INSURANCE PROGRAM,
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS MR. MYP.
AND REDIRECT 78.9 MILLION FROM
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICES FINES
AND PENALTIES FUNDS TO PAY FOR
MEDI-CAL COSTS. WE ARE PROPOSING
. DIRECTOR. HAVE A QUESTION ON
THAT ONE. HOW ARE WE? THERE'S
GOING TO THERE'S STILL SOME
PEOPLE ON MR. MYP THAT IS
CORRECT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE,
APPROXIMATELY 400 PEOPLE
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM. MY NAME
IS SARAH BROOKS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. APOLOGIES SO WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO NOTIFY THEM THAT IN,
LIKE, TWO WEEKS, THEY'RE GOING
TO LOSE THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE?
WELL, CERTAINLY WE WON'T
ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM IN TWO
WEEKS, WE'LL PROVIDE ADEQUATE
TIME AND NOTICE TO THEM TO NOTE
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH NOTICE THAT
SO THAT THEY CAN TRANSITION TO A
NEW PROGRAM, WE WILL SET UP JUST
AS WE DO WITH OTHER TRANSITIONS.
WE'LL PROVIDE NOTICE TO THEM, WE
WILL ASSIST THEM WITH PROVIDING
WITH ASSIST THEM TO TRANSITION
TO OTHER PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
COVERED CALIFORNIA, ABOUT
MEDICARE, ABOUT OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM THAT
THEY CAN ENROLL IN. I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY, ANYTHING OVER MR. MIP
IS GOING TO BE BETTER HEALTH
INSURANCE. I'M I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE OUT HERE.
SO WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT THEY
WON'T FALL OFF UNTIL WE GET A
HOLD OF THEM AND LET THEM KNOW
WE CERTAINLY WILL BE NOTICING
THEM AND PROVIDING INFORMATION.
YES, WE WILL. WE WILL GO THROUGH
OUR NORMAL PROCESS OF NOTICING
INDIVIDUALS. AND THAT WILL BE,
CERTAINLY. YES. OF COURSE. OKAY
SO THESE THIS SAVINGS HERE WON'T
REALLY GO INTO FULL EFFECT IF IT
TAKES US LIKE A MONTH OR SO TO
GET A HOLD OF THEM. AND NOTIFY
THEM THAT THEY'RE GETTING OFF.
MR. MIP SO I WOULD DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT DUFF WITH RESPECT
TO THE SAVINGS IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENT ATION TIMELINE, BUT I
DO WITH RESPECT TO YOUR
QUESTION, MADAM CHAIR, YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT WE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY TRANSITION
INDIVIDUALS OFF OF THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE WOULD NEED TO ALLOW
ENOUGH TIME TO NOTICE THEM AND
TO GIVE THEM TIME TO IDENTIFY A
NEW PROGRAM TO TRANSITION INTO,
OKAY. ISABELLA ALITO, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, YES. SO THE SAVINGS
REFLECT THE FUND BALANCE OF WHAT
WE HAVE NOW FOR MR. MIP SO THE
PROGRAM WOULD HAVE TO BE
ELIMINATED. AND THEN THOSE FUNDS
TRANSFERRED. SO THERE COULD BE A
NOT A DELAY NECESSARILY, BUT
THAT WOULD ALL DEPEND ON WHEN
IT'S FULLY ELIMINATED. OKAY.
YEAH. BUT BUT WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY A YEAR AT LEAST TO
HIT THE FULL REACHING OUT TO
EVERYBODY. AND THEN WE COULD
POTENTIALLY EVEN JUST SCORE THE
78.9 FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR. JUST
ANY TIME THIS WHOLE YEAR. OKAY.
SO IT GIVES US SOME TIME TO
REACH OUT TO EVERYBODY. WE DO
HAVE SOME TIME TO REACH OUT, AND
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
TRANSITION TO NEW PROGRAM. OKAY.
THANK YOU, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES, WITH REGARD TO PROP
PROPOSITION 56, A BACKFILL, AS
YOU KNOW, IN RECENT YEARS,
PROPOSITION 56, REVENUES HAVE
BEEN HAVE NOT BEEN SUFFICIENT TO
FULLY COVER THE COST OF THE
PROPOSITION 56 SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. AND SO MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO USE 145 MILLION FROM
THE MCO TAX TO SUPPORT MEDI-CAL
FAMILY PLANNING, WOMEN'S HEALTH
AND PHYSICIAN SERVICES.
SUPPLEMENTAL PROPOSITION 56
PAYMENTS IN 20 2425. SO BY DOING
SO, WE ARE NOT REDUCING OUR 2024
TRY RATE INCREASES, THERE WILL
BE NO REDUCTION. AND THEN ALSO
USING 64 MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
2425 TO FULLY FUND THE DENTAL
SERVICES. PROPOSITION 56
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS, THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROPOSES TO
INCREASE DIRECTED PAYMENTS TO
PUBLIC HOSPITALS THROUGH
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE ENHANCE
PAYMENT PROGRAM AND THE QUALITY
INCENTIVE POOL. IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THIS, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO INCLUDE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE ON
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TRANSFERS
RELATED TO THESE DIRECTED
PAYMENT PROGRAMS. RAIMES. TAKEN
TOGETHER, THESE ACTIONS ARE
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND REIMBURSEMENTS OF 37
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
74 MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR, PLUS
ONE AND ONGOING. WE WILL HAVE
TRAILER BILL TO IMPLEMENT THIS
TODAY. WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE ON SOME OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS WITH OUR PUBLIC
HOSPITALS. AND SO MIRRORING THAT
TYPE OF FRAMEWORK WITH REGARD TO
THESE PROGRAMS AND THE EP AND
SCHIP, THE ACRONYMS THERE, BUT
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
REALLY BRING IN ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS TO OUR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS. NOT USING ANY OF THIS,
NOT USING STATE FUNDS. OKAY, AND
THEN IN REGARD TO THE OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE, PROPOSED AS OUTLINED
ON PAGE 15 OF YOUR AGENDA, WE
ARE PROPOSING, THE FIRST ITEM
THERE IS REALLY A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT RELATED TO RECEIVING
ADDITIONAL, FEDERAL GRANTS
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS, WE HAVE
A PROPOSAL RELATED IN LOCAL
ASSISTANCE RELATED TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TRANSFER TRANSFORMATION
OR PROPOSITION ONE AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
YOU TALK TO ME MORE ABOUT THAT.
SURE. HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT
PROP ONE WAS GOING TO HELP FUND
EVERYTHING RIGHT? SO AS PART OF
A 2011 REALIGNMENT AND
PROPOSITION 30, WHEN THE STATE
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS EXACTLY
ON COUNTY DEPARTMENTS, THE STATE
NEEDS TO ADJUST COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OR TO OUR COUNTIES.
AND SO AS PART OF SB 326, THERE
WAS ACTUALLY LANGUAGE IN THAT
BILL REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORK WITH CSAC AND THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION TO WORK THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO IMPLEMENT PROPOSITION ONE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND SO THE 85
MILLION, 50 MILLION GENERAL
FUND, REFLECTS THE YEAR, ONE OF
WHAT WE THINK THE COST MIGHT BE
TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION AND
PREPARATION FOR, PROP POSITION
ONE. OKAY, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND ONE LAST
QUESTION. THE CHILDREN, OF
COURSE, GOING BACK TO, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, THE PURPOSE OF THE MCO
OUTSIDE OF HELPING BALANCE THE
BUDGET, TO ADDRESS EQUITY. SO
WHAT ARE WE SEEING? ARE WE
SEEING ARE KIDS NOT GOING TO
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL? LIKE, WHAT
ARE WE NOT SEEING PROVIDERS
WORKING HERE? I KNOW THE SENATOR
BROUGHT THAT UP. I THINK, AGAIN,
I THINK IT'S AS YOU LOOK AT THE
COST OF PROVIDING CARE TO THOSE
SICKEST CHILDREN AND BEING ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THOSE SERVICES. THEY
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS. AND SO
THIS WAS OUR ATTEMPT TO, HELP
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES. DIRECTOR,
TO THAT CAN HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. GET THOSE 1000
KIDS ON THE WAITING LIST OUT OF
THE HOSPITALS. WELL THIS IS THIS
THIS IS THE ISSUE WITH THE, THE,
THE PLANS, NOT WANTING TO REFER
TO THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL, BUT
TRYING TO KEEP, CHILDREN IN THE,
IN THE PLAN SYSTEM IS THAT IS
THAT AN ISSUE? I HAVE NOT HEARD
THAT ISSUE, SENATOR ROTH, THAT
HAS NOT BEEN RAISED TO ME. OKAY.
WELL, JUST I DID ASK. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND, I BELIEVE SO.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT, THE
AUGMENTATION OF THE 8 MILLION IN
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS, THE
NEXT ITEM, THE DIRECTOR ON THAT,
CAN YOU GIVE ME AN UPDATE ON
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR? WE
APPROVED OUT OF THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUND, FUNDING INTO
THE, HARM REDUCTION THÀNH UNDER
IT WAS LIKE FOR COMMUNITY, MAYBE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE, HOUSE. DO
YOU REMEMBER WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT? YES, I BELIEVE YOU WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT. SORRY. NATE
WILLIAMS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THROUGH CDF, OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD, I THINK THIS WAS,
COMMUNITY REQUEST. IT WAS A
PROPOSED, IT WAS IN. YEAH, IT
WAS THE HARM REDUCTION
INITIATIVE. YES, YES, YES. OKAY,
THAT'S ON PAUSE. RIGHT. OR WE
WERE ABLE TO ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING TO THEM. KNOW THAT
THERE'S STILL FUNDING BUILT INTO
OSF FOR THAT PROPOSAL, LET ME I
CAN LET ME FIND MY CHART HERE.
YEAH. SO IN IN THE CURRENT YEAR,
WE HAVE 15.25 MILLION, IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WE HAVE 13.35
MILLION. AND THEN 13.65 MILLION
BUDGET YEAR ONE. DID WE TAKE A
CUT EARLIER THIS YEAR IN JANUARY
FROM IT BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH IN THE OSF OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUND? YES. CORRECT.
YES. SO AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
THERE WAS, A REDUCTION TO THE
REVENUE PROPOSED FOR THE OSF.
AND SO THERE WERE MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS TOOK FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
IS THIS FROM THE FUND? THIS 8.3
MILLION IS FROM THE OSF. YES. SO
THE SO THE 8.3 MILLION
AUGMENTATION TO NDP IS COMING
FROM ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT ARE
NOW AVAILABLE IN THE OSF. ARE WE
WITH THE ADDITIONAL FUND RIGHT
SIZING, WHAT WE TOOK AWAY FROM
THE HARM REDUCTION INITIATIVE?
NO, WE DID NOT. THE GOVERNOR'S
OR THE MAY REVISION DID NOT
PROPOSE TO REINSTATE. I'M
DEFINITELY INTERESTED BECAUSE
THOSE ARE COMMUNITY ON THE
GROUND INITIATIVES, FOR THIS,
I'M INTERESTED IF LOOKING AT
DECREASING THIS NUMBER AND
OFFSETTING FOR WHAT WE TOOK FROM
THE COMMUNITY, INVESTMENT
PROGRAM, JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT,
I THINK. WHAT EXTRA MONEY? JUST.
YES YEAH. WHEN LOOKING AT
ALLOCATING THE ADDITIONAL OSF
REVENUE, OUR FIRST PRIORITY WAS
TO LOOK AT THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT. AND WITH
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING, THAT WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT TO SOLVE
FOR THE GENERAL FUND CONDITION,
WE DECIDED TO AUGMENT THAT SO
THAT WE WOULDN'T LOSE, THE
ACTUAL MEDICATION THAT'S GOING
OUT FROM THE NDP. SO WE CAN HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THE SAME NUMBER OF
UNITS SUPPLIED WITH THE LOWER
COST. I'M LOOKING AT THIS AND
NOT NÓ NOT CRITICIZING THE
DEPARTMENT, BUT WOULDN'T WE WANT
TO TAKE OUT THE MIDDLE PERSON?
WHY DON'T WE JUST DISTRIBUTE THE
FUNDING TO THE COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE ACTUALLY ON THE GROUND DOING
THIS, VERSUS PROVIDING MORE
FUNDING TO DIRECTLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT, WHO PERHAPS IS THEN
GOING TO REACH OUT TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SAYING, HEY, WE HAVE
THIS AMOUNT. HERE YOU GO. CAN
YOU DISTRIBUTE NALOXONE IN THE
COMMUNITY? THAT'S HOW I'M
LOOKING AT IT. SO WHY WOULDN'T
WE INVEST MORE INTO THE
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE LAST YEAR
SAID, HEY, WE'RE DISTRIBUTING
THIS. WE NEED THIS RIGHT NOW ON
THE GROUND. THEY THEY'RE DOING
THE SAME THING DISTRIBUTING
NALOXONE IN COMMUNITIES. ONE
GOES THE MONEY TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND THEN MAYBE FUNNELS DOWN. THE
OTHER INVESTMENT GOES STRAIGHT
TO THE COMMUNITIES, INTO THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE THAT NEED IT, I
GUESS I WOULD SAY THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT IS ACTUALLY
CONTRACTED TO PROVIDE THE
MEDICATION. SO IT WOULD GO TO
THESE ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE. SO
WHY DON'T WE JUST REMOVE THE
MIDDLE PERSON AND GIVE THE
FUNDING TO HARM REDUCTION
INITIATIVES? THAT GOES STRAIGHT
TO THE COMMUNITY. ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE, WHY DO WE NEED TO PUT
FUNDS TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
DISTRIBUTE IT? WHY AM I MAKING
SENSE WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THE
HARM REDUCTION PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, THE
NDP, REALLY THE EFFICIENCIES OF
THE STATE BEING ABLE TO PURCHASE
AT BULK AND DISTRIBUTE, I THINK
IS A VALUE. BUT AGAIN, NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE HARM
REDUCTION INITIATIVE DOES. I
DON'T WANT TO COMPARE, BUT I'M
NOT SURE. AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
I COULD SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
ALL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS, BUT
I'M NOT SURE THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE THE SAME COST. SO IF
THEY HAD TO PURCHASE, WE'LL SEND
UP SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AND
THEN WE COULD COME BACK ON
MONDAY OR NEXT THURSDAY TO DIVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO THIS.
YEAH. OKAY THEN RELATED TO THE
NEXT ITEM, THE CI NEXT
GENERATION VIDEO SERIES SERIES
AND DIGITAL SUPPORTS, WE WILL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ACTUALLY
ON THIS ITEM, CI GENERALLY HAS
EXEMPTION AUTHORITY. AND THIS
WAS SOMETHING WE CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR CONSULTANT ON. AND
THEN THE MCO TAX GENERAL OFFICE.
AND THIS IS JUST A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT. ADJUST IT RELATED TO
MCO DOLLARS. WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN. AS JUST THE AS THE WAY THE
NUMBERS KIND OF THE ACTUAL TAX
REVENUE COMING IN, THE PAYMENTS
TO THE MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS, IT'S JUST A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT ON HOW THOSE DOLLARS
COME IN. OKAY AND THEN, PAGE FOR
CHAPTER LEGISLACIÓN. WE DON'T
NEED TO GO THROUGH EVERYTHING. I
JUST HAVE A QUESTION ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRANSFORMATION. YES. FOR SB 326.
SO WE GAVE 40 MILLION LAST YEAR.
AND WE'RE, I THINK WE'RE
PROVIDING THE SAME AMOUNT FROM
MSA. WE NEED ALL THIS ADDITIONAL
MUCH AS WELL. YES. WE ARE
BUILDING AN ENTIRE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT OUR
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF THE COUNTY
INTEGRATED PLANNING PROCESS, THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
OUTCOME AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT. AND SO A LOT OF THESE
DOLLARS ARE ACTUALLY FOR IT
INFRASTRUCTURE, BOTH AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL, TO
SUPPORT, REALLY THE ABILITY TO
KIND OF GATHER THE DATA AND
UNDERSTAND IT. SYSTEM BLACK HOLE
SUCKS IN ON THAT. I GET IT. OKAY
OKAY. I THINK THAT COVERS, ONE
OTHER QUESTION ON CHAPTER
LEGISLATION, AB 1163 THAT
THROUGHOUT TODAY I THINK IS THE
MOST CHAPTER LEGISLATION IS
GETTING THE MOST AMOUNT OF
MONEY. I THINK EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING FUNDING
FOR THIS. IT'S GREAT. BUT MY
QUESTION IS, SO THE LGBT
DISPARITIES REDUCTION ACT IS
LOOKING TO, TO SUPPORT
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY THE
STATE. WE HAD A CONVERSATION
EARLIER THIS YEAR REGARDING SOME
OF THE WE CAN'T COLLECT SOME OF
THAT DATA PRIVACY ISSUES. AND SO
FORTH. I JUST WHAT I DON'T WANT
IS ALLOCATE FUNDING AND THEN
COME NEXT YEAR AND SAID, HEY, WE
GOT ALL THIS FUNDING, BUT WE
COULDN'T COLLECT ANY OF THIS
DATA BECAUSE THE PRIVACY ISSUES
ARE WE GOING TO ENCOUNTER SOME
OF THESE ISSUES? YOU DON'T HAVE
TO ANSWER NOW, BUT I'D LIKE TO
GET AN ANSWER NEXT WEEK. AGAIN
DON'T WANT TO ALLOCATE AND THEN
THE DATA IS NOT GOING TO BE
COLLECTED BECAUSE WE'LL GET THE
SAME PRIVACY ISSUES EXCUSE. THAT
WAS MY ONLY THING FOR THAT ONE.
OKAY WE CAN BE PREPARED NEXT
WEEK FOR THAT. AND THEN ON PAGE
18, MAINTAINING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO TRANSFER THE
ABOUT 14.9 MILLION IN, DOLLARS
FROM THE CLINIC, WORKFORCE
STABILIZATION PAYMENTS THAT WERE
UNUSED TO THE GENERAL FUND.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO HOLD ALL
THOSE ITEMS OPEN. MOVE ON TO,
ISSUE NUMBER TWO, WHICH ZOOM
THROUGH. OKAY, REALLY, I THINK
WE COVERED MANY OF THE LARGE
ITEMS RELATED TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. JUST A COUPLE QUICKLY
TO NOTE. IN ADDITION, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES REVISED
PROJECTED ESTIMATES FOR THE 2026
TO 49 UNDOCUMENTED EXPANSION.
THIS ADJUSTMENT REFLECTS A TOTAL
IMPACTED POPULATION JUST FOR
YOUR, ABOUT 739,000,
INDIVIDUALS, THAT'S AN INCREASE
OVER THE NOVEMBER ESTIMATE, AND
JUST KIND OF A REFLECTION OF
UPDATED COSTS THERE. OKAY. IS
THIS WHERE IS THIS IS AMONGST
THESE NUMBERS? IS THIS WHERE
YOU'RE CALCULATING, LIKE THE
PROPOSED REDUCTION OF THE IHSS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED, THAT IS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
BUDGET. SO YOU WON'T SEE IT IN
THE. SO IT DOESN'T COME OUT OF
THE MEDI-CAL CASELOAD OR THEY
CARRY IT. GOT IT. OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE ITEM OPEN.
MOVING ON TO NUMBER THREE. AND
THEN FINALLY THE FAMILY HEALTH
LOCAL ASSISTANCE ESTIMATE. THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES FAMILY
HEALTH SPENDING, THIS IS AGAIN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES PROGRAM. THE
GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED PERSONS
PROGRAM OF, 259 MILLION. IN THE
CURRENT OR THE BUDGET YEAR,
SORRY, IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
276 MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
OKAY. PUTTING THE ITEM OPEN,
MOVING ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. CDF.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
NOT ON. THERE WE GO, BRANDON
NUNES, I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY FOR
OPERATIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, JUST REAL QUICK
OVERVIEW OF OUR BUDGET. WE HAD A
PROPOSED ROUGHLY $5 BILLION
BUDGET AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, OUR
PROPOSAL NOW IS 4.8 BILLION. THE
MAJORITY OF THAT CHANGE IS
COMING FROM THE GENERAL FUND,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY WE'LL BE HAVING
SOME CONVERSATIONS THERE. WE HAD
PROPOSED 815, 815 MILLION AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AND WE'RE NOW
AT 470, AT MAY REVISION, I CAN
KIND OF RUN THROUGH SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS, OBVIOUSLY THE LARGEST
PIECE OF THAT REDUCTION FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS AN
ELIMINATION OF THE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDING, THERE'S TWO
TECHNICALLY TWO PROPOSALS. THIS
IS FUNDING THAT'S BEEN IN OUR
BUDGET SINCE 22, 23. THERE'S
SOME REVERSION OF CURRENT YEAR
DOLLARS TOTALING 52.5 MILLION,
ROUGHLY 11 MILLION OF THAT
COMING FROM LOCAL ASSISTANCE AND
THE BALANCE FROM STATE
OPERATIONS. YOU MAY RECALL THERE
WAS 100 MILLION FOR STATE
OPERATIONS, 200 MILLION LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. SPLIT BETWEEN THAT
300 MILLION. AND THEN ONGOING
BEGINNING IN 2425, A FULL
LIMITATION OF THE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH 300 MILLION. SO LET'S GET
INTO THIS A LITTLE BIT. DOCTOR
PAN, BEFORE COVID WAS ALWAYS
ASKING ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE WE READY?
ARE WE READY, AND WE WEREN'T
READY. AND IT WAS KIND OF LIKE A
TOLD YOU SO MOMENT FOR HIM.
RIGHT? ARE WE READY IF SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENS AND ELIMINATING THE
SURFACE STRUCTURE, HOW WE BUILD
CAPACITY TO BE READY. YEAH YOU
KNOW, THERE WERE SOME
INVESTMENTS THAT OCCURRED DURING
COVID THAT KIND OF HELPED
BOLSTER THAT ABILITY TO BE
PREPARED. HOWEVER, A LARGE PIECE
OF THIS 300 MILLION WAS TO
ASSIST WITH PREPAREDNESS
ONGOING, OBVIOUSLY, AT BOTH THE
STATE AND THE LOCAL LEVEL, SOME
OF THIS FUNDING WAS PUT INTO OUR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS OFFICE.
IT WAS PUT INTO COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS. WE LEARNED FROM COVID
THAT COMMUNICATION WAS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF COMMUNICATING
WITH THE PUBLIC WAS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE RESPONSE, AS WELL
AS SOME INVESTMENTS THAT WE PUT
IN OUR REGIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICE, WHICH HELPS KIND OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING BETWEEN
OUR DEPARTMENT AND THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ONGOING. SO
IT'S TRUE, IT'S OBVIOUS KIND OF
THAT THIS WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THAT IN SOME WAYS, THIS KIND OF
BROUGHT PUBLIC HEALTH UP TO A
BASELINE. HOWEVER, GIVEN THE
CURRENT FISCAL SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN, THERE'S DEFINITELY
SOME DIFFICULT DECISION MAKING
THAT HAS TO BE MADE, AND THIS
WAS ONE OF THOSE, YOU KNOW,
DOCTOR TOMAS, YOU KNOW, A COUPLE
OF TIMES CAME HERE, TALKED
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, OUR VALUES OR
GOALS, MEET EQUITY, ADDRESS
EQUITY ISSUES. IT KIND OF TAKES
AWAY THE CONFIDENCE IN BEING
ABLE TO ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES.
IF WE'RE SLASHING, ELIMINATING
FUNDING FOR THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND ONE THING IN
PARTICULAR, THIS IS NOT JUST FOR
COVID 19, RIGHT? THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT, SILICOSIS,
THAT IS KILLING MEN IN THEIR
20S. AND THIS FUNDING WOULD
ESSENTIALLY WIPE OUT THE ABILITY
TO COMBAT THAT. UNLESS YOU THINK
THERE'S AN INFRASTRUCTURE AT
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT'S GOING TO
HELP ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE
SILICOSIS IN MY BACKYARD. YEAH,
NO, I MEAN, I'LL JUST GO BACK TO
WHAT I SAID. I MEAN, THIS THIS
CLEARLY WILL IMPACT A LOT OF THE
PREPAREDNESS CAPABILITIES THAT
WE IN THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS HAD, AGAIN, I
GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY THAT THIS
IS ALSO A STARTING POINT, AS THE
GOVERNOR MENTIONED IN SOME OF
HIS COMMENTS, A STARTING POINT
AS FAR AS CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS IN THIS
SPACE WITH YOU AS WELL. BUT
AGAIN, RIGHT NOW, GIVEN THE
BUDGET SITUATION. SO WE'RE
MOVING AWAY FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
SMARTER PLAN. THIS THERE WERE
ELEMENTS OF THIS THAT WOULD HELP
SUPPORT THE SMARTER PLAN,
THERE'S ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT
REMAINS IN THE BUDGET TO KIND OF
HELP SUPPORT SOME OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT WERE STOOD UP DURING COVID.
THAT KIND OF HELP, FEED INTO
COULD YOU SHARE SOME OF THOSE
WITH US, I COULD GET YOU A LIST
OF THOSE SYSTEMS. THE ONE THAT
KIND OF POPS, INTO MIND IS THE
SAPPHIRE SYSTEM AND SOME OTHERS.
BUT I CAN GET YOU DEFINITELY A
LIST OF SOME OF THOSE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE INVESTED IN THROUGH THE
SMARTER PLAN. IN REALITY, HOW
ARE COUNTIES WHAT TO ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TO
COUNTIES LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO OUTBREAKS?
XYZZY YEAH, IT'S AGAIN, IT WILL
IMPACT THAT ABILITY. LIKE I
MENTIONED, PART OF THE 100
MILLION THAT CAME TO THE STATE
WAS FOR OUR REGIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE. IT BUILT SOME OF
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND WAS ABLE
TO KIND OF PROVIDE SOME OF THOSE
BEST PRACTICES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONGOING
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN US IN THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTION UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL, THAT PARTICULAR
OFFICE WOULD BE ELIMINATED, AND
SO IT WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT
THERE. IT'S AND STAFF LAYOFFS.
ARE WE DO HAVE 400 POSITIONS AT
THE STATE LEVEL. AND ROUGHLY I
THINK IT'S ROUGHLY 1300 AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IF I'M REMEMBERING
THE NUMBER. RIGHT, RAMPING UP
HIRING, IT'S TRUE, WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS. WHEN WE
RECEIVED THE FUNDING IN 22, 23,
BOTH WE AT THE STATE AND THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ARE
ROUGHLY AT ABOUT 80% HIRED. OF
THE STAFF THAT I MENTIONED. AND
SO, IT WILL WE WILL DEFINITELY
NOT BE ABLE TO DO THE THINGS
THAT WERE IN THIS ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL. HOWEVER, WE DO HAVE
SOME VACANCIES IN THE
DEPARTMENT. WE WOULD BE LOOKING
TO MOVE FOLKS INTO SOME OF THOSE
VACANCIES, BUT THOSE ARE FUNDED
WITH SPECIAL FUNDS AND OTHER
AREAS THAT CAN'T REALLY BACKFILL
THIS EFFORT. SO BUT IT IS A IT
IS A FOCUS AND DEFINITELY AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TO KIND OF LOOK
AT PLACING THOSE STAFF
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT. PROP
ONE IS GIVING PUBLIC HEALTH SOME
FUNDING. I GET THEM CONFUSED
WITH 3 OR 4, CAN THAT HELP WITH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WITH SOME
OF THESE INITIATIVES? YEAH, I
THINK IT'S A PIECE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DEFINITELY HAVE TO LOOK
AT. I KNOW THAT THERE WAS SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW PROP ONE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BACKFILL IN
SOME OTHER AREAS. I THINK THAT'S
A PIECE THAT, KHÎI. I THINK WAS
ONE OF THEM. I MEAN, IT'S
DEFINITELY AN AREA THAT WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT. IT'S STILL, I
THINK, KIND OF SOON TO SEE HOW
PROP ONE WOULD COME TO US AND
HOW IT WOULD BE USED. WHAT ARE
YOU ABLE TO SHARE WITH ME AND I
APOLOGIZE, I FORGOT YOUR SORRY,
BRANDON NUNEZ WITH THE. YEAH.
DIRECTOR, CHIEF DEPUTY FOR
CHIEF. DEPUTY? YEAH. WHAT IS
PUBLIC HEALTH? HOW ARE WE BEING
CREATIVE? WHAT ARE WE DOING
WITHIN OUR CURRENT, CAPACITY TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG OF SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'RE GOING TO BE,
SEEING, LIKE, ARE WE HOW ARE WE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH? ARE WE WHAT
DO WE WHAT DO WE WHAT ARE WE
DOING OR WHAT WILL WE BE DOING?
YEAH, I THINK THAT THOSE ARE
PROBABLY SOME CONVERSATIONS THAT
LIKE WHEN WE HAVE HEARINGS NEXT
WEEK AND DOCTOR ARAGON IS ABLE
TO ATTEND, I THINK HE'D BE ABLE
TO KIND OF FILL IN BETTER. I
KNOW, FROM, YOU KNOW, A
TECHNICAL PERSPECTIVE, SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING ON
KIND OF THE OPERATIONS SIDE IS,
YOU KNOW, PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT EFFICIENCIES IS
DEFINITELY AN AREA THAT WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT. AND SO TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR CONTRACTING METHODS,
OUR HIRING METHODS, ETC, ARE
SOME AREAS THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
BECOME MORE EFFICIENT AND SAVE
DOLLARS AND WHATNOT. BUT AS FAR
AS KIND OF THE RELATIONSHIP,
LIKE YOU MENTIONED, ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE OF THINGS AND
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS, I WOULD
PROBABLY DEFER TO DOCTOR TOMAS
WHEN HE COMES BACK NEXT WEEK.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THIS IS
ANNUALLY. WHY AGAIN, ARE WE
CHOOSING TO CUT IT COMPLETELY
VERSUS JUST FOR THE NEXT TWO
THREE YEARS? DELAY SOMEONE. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. NICK
MILLS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
PROBLEM. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SOLVING THE BUDGET PROBLEM AND
PUTTING THE STATE ON A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE PATH WAS TO PROTECT
CORE SERVICES LIKE MEDI-CAL AND,
THIS COULD LEAD TO PRESSURES ON
DEFICITS IN THE OUT YEARS. SO
OUR WHAT'S PROPOSED TODAY PUTS
THE STATE ON A RESPONSIBLE
FISCAL PATH. BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE
ALTERNATIVE WAYS FOR SOLVING THE
BUDGET PROBLEM. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. YOU KNOW, IN THE FROM AN
OPERATION STANDPOINT, IN THE
MILITARY, WE CALL IT THE TOOTH
TO TAIL RATIO. WE'RE THE TAIL
AND THE TEETH REALLY ARE IN THE
COUNTIES. SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR WHEN WE
GET INTO THE DETAIL IS WHETHER
WE'VE MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT,
RECOGNIZING WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CUTS TO BE MADE, CONSCIOUS
EFFORT TO DRIVE AS MUCH MONEY
DOWN TO THE COUNTIES IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AREAS WHERE THE
WHERE THE. SOME COULD ARGUE THE
REAL WORK IS DONE. NOT THAT WE
AREN'T WORKING UP HERE, BUT
SIGNIFICANT WORK IS DONE AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL TO RETAIN
PERSONNEL. FOR EXAMPLE, PEOPLE
THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO HIRE. AND
WHEN THE DISASTER HAPPENS OR THE
VIRUS OCCURS, WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF TIME TO RAMP UP. AND SO
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF CAPABILITY. I
THINK, AT THE COUNTY LEVEL, AND
WE CAN PROBABLY ADJUST UP HERE.
SO PERHAPS NEXT TIME WE GATHER
AT THE RIVER, YOU ALL CAN TALK
TO ME ABOUT HOW IN OUR PLANNING
FOR THIS REDUCTION IN THIS
PARTICULAR SECTION, WE'VE
PLANNED TO DRIVE AS MANY
RESOURCES AS WE CAN IN DURING
THE REDUCTION DOWN TO THE COUNTY
LEVEL AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. SURE, ABSOLUTELY, I
CAN COMMENT ON THAT. CHRISTINE
SHERMAN, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
SO NOT TO, YOU KNOW, EVERY EVERY
CUT IS A, IS A CUT TO CAPACITY.
SO NOT TO DISMISS ANY OF THAT,
BUT I, JUST WANTED TO, TO, JUST
POINT OUT THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT A CUT TO OUR ENTIRE CAPACITY
TO RESPOND TO PUBLIC PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS. RIGHT. SO WE
STILL MAINTAIN 1.4 BILLION IN
THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASES, OF WHICH TWO 214.6
MILLION IS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND 945.2 MILLION WILL GO TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE, AND MR. NUNEZ MENTIONED
SAPPHIRE EARLIER. THAT IS STILL
SOMETHING THAT IS IN PLACE, IS A
PART OF OUR DISEASE SURVEILLANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE, IN ADDITION,
TELL ME ABOUT SAPPHIRE AGAIN. I
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO. YEAH. DO YOU
WANT TO GET INTO THAT? GOOD
AFTERNOON. ADRIAN. SORRY TO CUT
YOU OFF. BEFORE I FORGET THAT
QUESTION. NO. NO WORRIES, SO
SAPPHIRE IS ESSENTIALLY A
GATEWAY, THAT SERVES TO
FACILITATE THE TRANSFER OF OUR
DATA. SO IT RECEIVES THE DATA,
TRANSFERS IT TO OUR SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM. CALREDIE AND THEN OUR
DOWNSTREAM, CONTACT TRACING
SYSTEM AND CONNECT THAT. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OH, SENATOR ROTH, DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION ON THAT? WELL, I
JUST IS WHEN YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS, THEN MAYBE I
MISSED IT. YOU KNOW, I'VE ASKED
ABOUT IMPACT ANALYSIS BEFORE.
MAYBE YOU COULD TOUCH ON WHAT
THE IMPACT OF WHAT IS IT, $300
MILLION FOR ONGOING, ONGOING,
REDUCTION IS GOING TO HAVE ON
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES WHERE
THE PEDAL HITS THE METAL, WHICH
IS AT THE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL?
HAVE WE WHAT'S THE IMPACT OF THE
300 MILLION? I MEAN, IS IT IS IT
INSIGNIA? IT IS MOST OF THE CUT
IMPACTING UP HERE. THAT WAS MY
QUESTION EARLIER. WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN IN THE 58 COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE AS A RESULT OF
A $300 MILLION REDUCTION? IS IT
A LOSS OF TWO TWO? WE CALL THEM
SOMETHING ELSE HERE. WE USED TO
CALL PRIVATE SECTOR. WE CALL
THEM FTES. IS IT TWO POSITIONS A
COUNTY? IS IT IS IT WHAT? YEAH.
SO NOW I INTERRUPTED YOU, MA'AM.
SO I'M GOING TO STOP TALKING AND
LET YOU. LET'S HAVE. IF YOU CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FIRST AND
WE'LL GO BACK. YEAH, SO THE
SPLIT OF THE 300 MILLION WAS 100
MILLION STAYED AT THE STATE
LEVEL. 200 MILLION WENT TO THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. A
LARGE, JUST LIKE IT WAS WITH THE
STATE LEVEL. A LARGE PROPORTION
OF THAT WENT TO FUND STAFF AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO, YOUR FTE
QUESTION, I BELIEVE IT WAS
ROUGHLY 1300 FTES ACROSS THE
STATE, OF WHICH 80% ARE ROUGHLY
FILLED AT THIS POINT. SO YOU GOT
YOUR FTE EQUIVALENT AND BUT
ACTUALLY PEOPLE IN POSITIONS AND
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY EACH LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTION HAD
PRIORITIES ON HOW THEY USE THE
FUNDS. THEY WERE THEY UTILIZED
PLANS WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
KIND OF HAD THAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD USE IT WAS
OBVIOUSLY A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
IN EACH LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTION, BUT THAT'S ROUGHLY
A STATEWIDE IMPACT. IS 1300 A
LITTLE OVER 900 POSITIONS HAVE
BEEN FILLED STATEWIDE. SO I
GUESS I NEED OCCASIONALLY THE
CHAIR ASKS THIS QUESTION, SO I'M
GOING TO ASK IT. I NEED A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY. SO IF 80% OF THE
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN FILLED, IS
THE 200 MILLION THEN ACCOUNTED
FOR THE BY ELIMINATING THE 20%
OF VACANT POSITIONS? YOU KNOW
WE'RE CUTTING 200 MILLION.
SORRY. WE'RE CUTTING 200 MILLION
OUT OF THE COUNTY'S RIGHT. SO
CAN WE CUT 200 MILLION OUT OF
THE COUNTIES, AND THEY JUST
ELIMINATE VACANT POSITIONS? OR
IS IT GOING TO CUT INTO THE 80%
OF THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
FILLED? I WOULD I MEAN, THAT'S
DEFINITELY A CONVERSATION WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS, AS I
MENTIONED, LIKE AT OUR LEVEL.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME WHO
MAY TESTIFY TODAY, BUT I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE, AT OUR LEVEL,
WILL BE LOOKING TO REPURPOSE OR
MOVE FOLKS INTO VACANCIES. YOU
MAY YOU MAY NOT HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT WITHIN LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS,
PARTICULARLY ON THE SIZE SOME
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. THIS
IS THE FUNDING THEY USE TO
SUPPORT THESE STAFF. SO IT'S
GOING TO VARY BY LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTION, BY LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTION. BUT FOR THE MOST
PART, I WOULD IMAGINE IT'S GOING
TO BE A DIFFICULT THING TO
ABSORB. AND I MEAN, I MEAN,
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE. DID OUR
CONTRACT CONTACT TRACING, RIGHT,
IN MANY CONTACT TRACING APPS,
POSSIBLY LAB AGAIN, IT'S GOING
TO DIFFER, WELL, THAT'S WHY
WE'RE CONCERNED. I MEAN, WE JUST
NEED TO KNOW AND THEN THEN IT'S
ON US. IF WE IF WE DAMAGE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES TO A
SIGNIFICANT DEGREE IN OUR 58
COUNTIES AND SOMETHING HAPPENS
AND THEY'LL LOOK TO US. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WE'LL TRY
THIRD TIME. OKAY SO JUST TO
MENTION A FEW OTHER, PARTS OF
OUR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ARE STILL IN PLACE TO RESPOND TO
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS,
PARTICULARLY INFECTIOUS DISEASES
, SO I, WE TALKED ABOUT SAPPHIRE
, AND THERE'S ALSO AN ONGOING
THING, 60, 61.8 MILLION
APPROPRIATION FOR THE DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE READINESS,
RESPONSE, RECOVERY AND
MAINTENANCE OF IT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM, THAT YOU WILL SEE IN
THE BUDGET SOLUTIONS THAT THERE
IS A CUT OF 6.9 MILLION. IT
STILL LEAVES ABOUT 54 MILLION.
AND THOSE CUTS ACTUALLY BEGIN IN
THE OUT YEARS IN 25, 26. AND SO
WE DECIDED TO WITHDRAW THE CUT
FROM BUDGET YEAR IN RESPONSE TO
SOME CONCERNS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THERE'S A SMALL
CUT OF 3.8 MILLION IN FROM A
REVERSION OF SAVINGS FROM
CURRENT YEAR, THERE'S ALSO, 18.1
MILLION, IN BUDGET YEAR AND 8.1
MILLION ANNUALLY THEREAFTER IN
THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY, DATA
SCIENCE AND INFORMATICS
FRAMEWORK FOR A 21ST CENTURY
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. IT'S A
LONG NAME, PROGRAM. AND, THAT
ALSO SUPPORTS, RESPONSE TO
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT AND I
THINK ALSO, YOU KNOW, MR. NUNEZ
ALSO MENTIONED THAT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A STARTING POINT, RIGHT,
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S WHAT'S ON THE
TABLE FOR MAY REVISE. AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE, YOU
KNOW, LIKE THERE'S CONCERNS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY, RIGHT? LIKE
SILICOSIS IS A IS A HUGE THREAT
IN YOUR COMMUNITY. SO I THINK
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, PART OF THE
PROCESS, IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
GIVE US GUIDANCE, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WHAT ARE THE
WHAT ARE THE PRIORITIES THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP AND
HOW CAN AND KIND OF TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THE RESOURCES
THAT WE DO STILL HAVE IN PLACE.
AND IS THIS SUFFICIENT TO KEEP
THOSE PRIORITIES FUNDED? AND IF
NOT, WHAT DO WE NEED TO MOVE
AROUND? AND SO WE'RE TOTALLY
OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION. NO,
THANK YOU FOR THAT. YEAH. I
THINK, IT'S WORRISOME. AND I
THINK YOUR HONESTY HONESTLY, AND
SAYING LIKE THIS WILL HAVE A, AN
IMPACT. WE DON'T KNOW HOW BAD
IT'S GOING TO BE, BUT IT IS
GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT. I MEAN,
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT PERSONALLY ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MY BACKYARD,
BUT JUST, ON PREPARATION. THÀNH.
RIGHT. SO IT DEFINITELY IN THE
NEXT COUPLE IN THE NEXT WEEK OR
TWO, COMING BACK TO THIS
CONVERSATION, PLEASE PROCEED,
MOVING THROUGH, THE CB FUNDING,
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
AREAS WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT, THE
CRISIS RESPONSE PILOT PROGRAM
THERE WAS ORIGINALLY WAS A $35
MILLION INVESTMENT. THERE'S A
$1.5 MILLION REDUCTION IN, 24,
25, I'M SORRY, 13.5 MILLION. I
THINK IT WAS IN 22. YEAH. SORRY.
2223, AND SO THIS WAS ORIGINALLY
FOR THE SUICIDE PREVENTION,
PIECE OF IT, AS FAR AS DATA
COLLECTION WENT, WE THOUGHT THAT
THERE WOULD BE SOME SYSTEMS THAT
WE COULD UTILIZE THIS FUNDING
FOR, BUT ULTIMATELY WE DIDN'T
FEEL THE SYSTEMS LIKE CALCONNECT
AND OTHERS WERE THE RIGHT
SYSTEMS TO DO THE DATA
COLLECTION. SO WE WEREN'T GOING
TO UTILIZE THIS PARTICULAR
FUNDING. SO WE WERE ABLE TO, ARE
WE STILL GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THE DATA, DO YOU KNOW
THE ALTERNATIVE, SO IT ACTUALLY
COMES DOWN TO OUR INABILITY TO,
TO COLLECT THE DATA BECAUSE IT'S
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS ARE NOT A
REPORTABLE CONDITION. SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT IT DRIVES DOWN TO.
TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT MORE,
BECAUSE THIS IS AN LGBTQ PLUS
CAUCUS PRIORITY. SO I'D LIKE TO
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION, ON THIS. SO THE
GOAL IS TO START TO HAVE THIS BE
A REPORTABLE ITEM SO WE CAN
TRACK IT. IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE AND SO FORTH, SO, SO TELL
ME, IN THE PAST TWO YEARS, WHAT
WAS WHAT WERE WE DOING IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS TO START
COLLECTING THIS DATA? SO WITH
REGARD TO THE DATA THAT WE CAN
COLLECT INTO CALREDIE, WE'RE
REALLY BOUND TO WHAT'S IN HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SECTION 12 0130.
AND SO AND ALSO TITLE 17 DEFINES
ALL OF THE INFECTIOUS DISEASES
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO COLLECT INTO
CALREDIE, THERE WERE ALSO SOME
PRIVACY CONCERNS FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING WITH, UTILIZING
CALCONNECT, AS IT WOULD INVOLVE
IDENTITY AND PRIVACY CONCERNS
FOR THIS PRIVACY THING FOR LGBTQ
PLUS PEOPLE. AGAIN COMES UP.
THAT'S HOW ARE WE GOING TO
ADDRESS MY THE ISSUES IN MY
COMMUNITY. IF I DON'T I DON'T
UNDERSTAND NOT FOR YOU OVERALL
TO ALL DEPARTMENTS AND HAS LIKE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE LIKE MY
LITTLE QUEER KIDS ARE DYING.
THEY'RE DYING BY SUICIDE. AND WE
NEED TO FIND A WAY TO GET AHEAD
OF IT BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE TO
DIE BY SUICIDE. I THINK WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB IN FIGURING
OUT AND GOING PAST THAT EXCUSE,
BECAUSE WE NEED TO COLLECT THIS
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO STOP
IT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING LIKE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS MADE UP OF, YOU KNOW,
WONDERFUL GENIUSES THAT KNOW
THAT WE NEED DATA TO EXAMINE AND
TO ADDRESS. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THEM, I MENTIONED THIS IS A
CAUCUS PRIORITY FOR US, SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IN THE NEXT TWO
SUBCOMMITTEES WE'LL BE BRINGING
BACK, AND I'D LIKE A LITTLE BIT
MORE I WOULD LIKE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THIS ISSUE. UNDERSTOOD
THAT, MOVING ON TO THE NEXT TÚI
ISSUE, THE PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
CHANGE CAMPAIGN, WE RECEIVED
100,000,001 TIME FROM THOSE
FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT THIS
CAMPAIGN, WE'RE PULLING BACK
SOME OF THAT FUNDING. SO IN
2324, THERE'S A REVERSION OF
28.8 MILLION. AND THEN AN
ONGOING OR. SORRY. WELL A
REDUCTION OF THE ONE TIME
FUNDING, 40,000,000 IN 24, 25
AND 5,000,000 IN 25, 26. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, DID WE SKIP A STEP OR
IS THAT DOWN YOUR LIST LATER?
THE ESTIMATE. OH, SORRY. THE 500
MILLION FROM THE EARLY ACTION.
SORRY, YES. THAT WAS THE LOAN
THAT WAS PROPOSED AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE PROPOSED A $500
MILLION LOAN, THAT WAS ADOPTED
THROUGH EARLY ACTION. AND WE DO
HAVE SOME OTHER LOANS TO DISCUSS
AS FAR AS SOLUTIONS HERE, BUT
THERE'S NOT ANOTHER EIGHT APP
LOAN RELATED TO THAT, DO WE?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, MAYBE
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR YOU. DO
WE HAVE OF THE FOR AND I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS ONE.
WE WERE ABLE TO THE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR THE ADDITIONAL 23
MILLION TO, FOR THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM ENHANCEMENTS FROM THE
END UP AND THE EPIDEMIC REQUEST
OF THAT LIST. DO WE HAVE AN IDEA
OF WHAT ONE OF THOSE JESUS
CHRIST, DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA,
WHICH OF THOSE PERHAPS IS
INELIGIBLE TO BE FUNDED THROUGH
ADAP? YEAH. SO CURRENTLY THE
ADAP REBATE FUND IS, ESSENTIALLY
THERE ARE STATE STATUTE REALLY
LIMITS THE SERVICES THAT CAN BE
PAID FROM THAT FUND, OF THE WHAT
IS IT, SIX PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PUT FORWARD, THE HARM REDUCTION
CLEARINGHOUSE INCREASE OF 10
MILLION WOULD REQUIRE A
STATUTORY CHANGE AS WOULD THE
TGI WELLNESS AND EQUITY FUND
PROPOSAL FOR 5 MILLION ONGOING,
AND THE LET ME SEE HERE THE
THERE WAS 5 MILLION FOR SB 954.
THAT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A
STATUTORY CHANGE. THERE ARE
OTHER PROPOSALS THAT ARE MORE
CLOSELY CONNECTED TO THE INTENT
OF THE REBATE FUND, SUCH AS
INCREASING THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL FROM 500% TO 600% OF THE
OR THE ELIGIBILITY, RATHER
RATHER TO 600% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. THAT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE A STATUTORY CHANGE,
POTENTIALLY, BUT FROM AN
IMPLEMENTATION PERSPECTIVE, MUCH
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD, AND THEN
THE HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUM
CAP, SHOULD ALSO BE A, AN ITEM
THAT WOULD BE MORE EASILY
IMPLEMENTED. OKAY BUT WHAT WE
COULD DO IS JUST POTENTIALLY ADD
UP THE AMOUNT FOR ALL OF THIS OR
A LITTLE LESS, JUST ADD UP HOW
MUCH THIS IS GOING TO COST AND
ADD THAT TO THE LOAN. RIGHT.
BECAUSE IF YOU JUST SAY, HEY, I
WANT $515 MILLION FROM ADAP LOAN
, AND THEN THE 15 MILLION IS TO
FUND THE OTHER THINGS THAT CAN'T
NECESSARILY BE FUND FROM THAT
LOAN. DOES THAT MEET STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE WOULD HAVE
TO CONSULT WITH OUR OUR LEGAL
DEPARTMENT. BUT I BELIEVE THERE
IS ONE, $5 MILLION, FOR SB 954
IS STRUCTURED IN THAT IN THAT
MANNER. WHAT DO YOU MEAN? SO IT
WOULD BE PULLING FROM THE LOAN
AMOUNT ACCORDING TO. YEAH BUT I
THINK THE SPECIFICS AROUND IT
MIGHT BE GETTING WORKED OUT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, CAN WE
COME BACK TO SEE ON THE LEGALITY
AND. SURE ON THAT ONE. OKAY
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU
, THE NEXT ISSUE, THE OFFICE OF
RURAL HEALTH BACKFILL AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, WE RECEIVE 30
MILLION FROM PROP 56 FUNDING FOR
THE OFFICE ORAL HEALTH PROGRAM
AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO SUPPORT
KIND OF A DEFICIT OF PROP 56
FUNDS. WE DID A BACKFILL OF 4.6
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND,
GIVEN THE BUDGET SITUATION, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR SORRY MAY
REVISION, WE'RE PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE THAT BACKFILL ONGOING.
SO THE 4.6 MILLION WILL COME
OUT, SIMILAR ON THE SIMILAR ISH
ON THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
AUDIT SHIFT AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE HAD PROPOSED A ONE
TIME SHIFT OF $4 MILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO OUR SPECIAL
FUND. THIS IS NOW A PROPOSAL TO
DO THAT FROM AN ONGOING
PERSPECTIVE. BEGINNING NOW IN
2526. SOME FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVED FOR CLIMATE HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS, $10
MILLION BACK IN 22, 23, WE'RE
DOING A REVERSION OF SOME OF
THAT FUNDING. SO 3.1 MILLION ON
GOING, BEGINNING IN 24, 25 FROM
THAT ORIGINAL 10 MILLION THAT WE
RECEIVED, AND THEN SOMETHING
THAT WAS MENTIONED, EARLIER AS
FAR AS KIND OF ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH, SOME
FUNDING WAS PROVIDED FOR
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS FOR
OUR IT SYSTEMS THAT WERE STOOD
UP DURING THE COVID RESPONSE, WE
WERE ABLE TO, SO 61.8 MILLION IS
AVAILABLE ONGOING TO SUPPORT
THOSE SYSTEMS, WE DID IDENTIFY
SOME SAVINGS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. SO THERE'S
A, OF THAT AMOUNT, THERE'S A
$3.8 MILLION REVERSION THAT'S
COMING OUT OF 23, 24. BUT THEN
THERE IS A PROPOSAL FOR AN
ONGOING REDUCTION. NOT THIS
YEAR, NOT THE BUDGET YEAR, BUT
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AND 2526.
THERE'LL BE AN ONGOING REDUCTION
OF 6.9 MILLION OUT OF THAT FUND
OR. SORRY, FROM THOSE FUNDS AND
THEN, SIMILAR AGAIN ON THE IT
SIDE, NOT ONLY DO WE RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS, BUT WE RECEIVED
FUNDING TO MODERNIZE OUR IT
SYSTEMS, THERE WAS 18.1 MILLION
THAT WAS SUPPORTING 33 POSITIONS
ONGOING, BEGINNING IN 25, 26. SO
WE'LL KIND OF HAVE A YEAR TO
PREP FOR THIS. HOW IT WILL
IMPACT THERE'LL BE, THOUGH, A
$10 MILLION REDUCTION ONGOING TO
THAT FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED.
AND, AND THEN AS I KIND OF
MENTIONED, SIMILAR TO THE ADAP
REBATE FUND LOAN THAT WAS
PROVIDED AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
THERE'S $140 MILLION THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED FROM LOANS FROM
VARIOUS SPECIAL FUNDS, THE
LARGEST OF WHICH YOU'LL SEE
THERE IS THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION FUND, OF WHICH 70
IS COMING FROM THAT, THIS WILL
BE LOANED TO THE GENERAL FUND IN
24, 25. AND THEN WITH A
REPAYMENT SCHEDULE OF 2627. OKAY
AND THEN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF,
MISCELLANEOUS KIND OF
ADJUSTMENTS, WE RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
JEWELS LAB SETTLEMENT, THAT YOU
SEE THERE IN THE AGENDA, THERE'S
ADJUSTMENTS TO SOME
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY THAT WE
GET FROM EPI AND LAB CAPACITY,
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WAS USED TO
SUPPORT COVID AND OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH INITIATIVES. AND THEN
EVERY, EVERY MAY REVISION, WE DO
UPDATES TO OUR TOBACCO TAX
FUNDING. SO YOU SEE THERE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR PROP 99 FUNDS
BASED ON UPDATES TO REVENUE,
MISCELLANEOUS ADJUSTMENTS OF IN
VARIOUS DIFFERENT, PROP 99
HEALTH ACCOUNTS THAT WE HAVE
UNDER THE CHAPTER LEGISLATION. I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION, THE
CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRY.
WE'RE POTENTIALLY FUNDING,
POSITIONS FOR TO REPORT OUT TO
THE REGISTRY THAT COULD
ESSENTIALLY GO AWAY IF WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO FUND IT. AM I
UNDERSTANDING THAT CORRECTLY?
WE'RE EARLIER THIS YEAR, WE
HEARD A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
INTO THE REGISTRY BECAUSE
FUNDING IS RUNNING OUT. SO BUT
WE'RE GOING TO FUND A POSITION
TO REPORT TO THE REGISTRY. BUT
THE REGISTRY IS NOT GETTING
SUPPORTED. AND IT COULD CLOSE.
YEAH. AND I THINK I'LL ASK OUR
PROGRAM FOLKS TO COME UP AND
WEIGH IN ON THAT ONE A LITTLE
BIT, BECAUSE THERE IS SOME
FUNDING THAT, LIKE, I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES TO KIND OF
FUND THE REGISTRY. I BELIEVE IT
WAS 800, 800,000 TO FULLY FUND
THE REGISTRY, BUT I'M NOT SURE
IF IT WOULD FULLY GO AWAY OR
NOT. DO YOU WANT YOU CAN CALL
UP? SORRY ABOUT THAT. NO, NO,
THIS IS OUR PROGRAM, FOLKS.
HELLO, YES. NO WE ARE LOOKING AT
OTHER WAYS TO FUND THE CANCER
REGISTRY TO KEEP IT FLAT FUNDED.
SO WE'VE REDIRECTED SOME FUNDING
THIS YEAR FROM ONE OF OUR OTHER
PROPOSITION 99 ACCOUNTS. AND SO
WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT OTHER
SOLUTIONS TO KEEP IT WHOLE. BUT
WE HAVE ABOUT AN $800,000
DEFICIT RIGHT NOW OKAY. SO ARE
WE GOING TO SEE THAT. AM I WE'RE
STILL LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS
RIGHT NOW OKAY. BUT THERE'S
POTENTIAL. SEE SOMETHING COMING
OUT IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS FOR
IT. WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT WAYS
TO. YEAH OKAY. BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
FUND A POSITION FIRST THAN
FUNDING THE ACTUAL REGISTRY.
YEAH, WE'LL DEFINITELY TAKE IT
BACK. OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY QUESTIONS, NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS. JUST ON THE
TOPIC THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER, THE HARM REDUCTION
INITIATIVE. I'M LOOKING TO SEE
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO RIGHTSIZE
THEM. YEAH, I NOTED THAT
CONVERSATION. I'LL HAVE TO GO
BACK AND HAVE OUR PROGRAM FOLKS,
BUT DEFINITELY CAN BE AVAILABLE
IF YOU HAVE KIND OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS NEXT WEEK AS WELL.
WE CAN HAVE THEM AVAILABLE.
GREAT. OKAY. THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ITEMS OPEN.
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO,
GREAT. REALLY ZOOM THROUGH
BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT IT A
LITTLE BIT ALREADY, BUT
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE SOME VERY
ROUTINE CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS. SO
FOR CURRENT YEAR, THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF
20.1 MILLION IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE
, AND IN BUDGET YEAR, IT
REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF 10.7
MILLION IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
OKAY WELL THE ITEM OPEN. MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE, I
BELIEVE IT'S THE SORRY I BELIEVE
IT'S THE WICK ESTIMATE, VERY
SIMILAR TO THE ARP ESTIMATE,
SOME CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS, WE'RE
PARTICIPATING HAS BEEN CHANGING
SLIGHTLY IN CALIFORNIA
NATIONALLY, THIS BUDGET
ESTIMATE, THE CURRENT YEAR
REVISED ESTIMATE IS 990,000
PARTICIPANTS. A MONTH, WHICH IS
A 0.22% DECREASE. AND THEN, 1
MILLION, IS PROPOSED ROUGHLY 1
MILLION PARTICIPANTS IS PROPOSED
FOR BUDGET YEAR. AS A NOTE, IN
APRIL OF 2024, WE SERVED 1
MILLION RECIPIENTS, WHICH WAS
THE FIRST TIME SINCE AUGUST OF
2018 THAT WE'VE SERVED, A
MILLION RECIPIENTS. AND PART OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS ARE RELATED TO
DECREASE IN FOOD EXPENDITURES,
BASED ON SLOWING FOOD INFLATION
RATES, AND DECREASES RELATED TO
OR SORRY FROM THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDE A DECREASE OF 2.55%
COMPARED SORRY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SO OKAY, HOLD IT UP.
ANYTHING AND THEN I BELIEVE THE
NEXT ONE IS FOR THE GENETIC
DISEASE SCREENING PROGRAM, SO
THE MAYOR REVISION ESTIMATE, FOR
GVSHP. AGAIN, SIMILAR CASELOAD
CHANGES FOR 20 2324 WILL BE
164.8 MILLION, WHICH IS A
DECREASE OF 3 MILLION COMPARED
TO THE 2024 GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND FOR BUDGET EXPENDITURES IN
2425, TOTALING 176.8 MILLION.
IT'S A NET DECREASE OF 4.7
MILLION COMPARED TO THE 2425,
AND DECREASES IN BOTH YEARS ARE
PRIMARILY ATTRIBUTED TO LOWER
PRENATAL SCREENING PROGRAM AND
NEWBORN SCREENING PROGRAM
CASELOAD THAN WAS PREVIOUSLY
PROJECTED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND THEN FINALLY, IN OUR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES OR
SORRY, CHC C¯ ESTIMATE, WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT, CHANGES
RELATED TO THOSE ISSUES, THERE'S
$4 MILLION ONGOING OR SORRY,
SORRY, THERE'S FUNDS IN THERE
THAT'S GOING TO SUPPORT MANDATED
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO MONITORING
AND ENFORCING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY MINIMUM STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS. WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT ONGOING SHIFT.
THE 4 MILLION, AND THEN WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
LOAN. THAT'S, AGAIN, COMING FROM
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
AUDIT OR SORRY, SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FUND TO THE, THE
GENERAL FUND. SO JUST SOME
SIMILAR BUT MINOR CHANGES TO
THINGS THAT WE'VE ALREADY KIND
OF DISCUSSED WITH YOU. I THINK
THAT KIND OF IS A HIGH LEVEL OF
OUR ESTIMATES. SORRY, I JUST
LOST TRACK A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER
HERE. OKAY. CAN I GO OUT OF
ORDER? YEAH IT'S OKAY, IT'S
OKAY. PERFECT. SO THAT WAS YOUR
LAST. THAT WAS, IN THE
DEPARTMENT. WELL ANY COMMENTS
OVERALL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH, WILL
OAN LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SO SO, WE HAVE SOME KIND
OF GENERAL OVERVIEW COMMENTS,
KIND OF ECHOING WHAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE OVERALL
BUDGET AS WELL AS MAYBE SOME
SPECIFIC COMMENTS AS RELATED TO
THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
PROPOSED ELIMINATION, SO, SO, AS
KIND OF MENTIONED, THE GIVEN THE
STATE'S BUDGET SITUATION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION INCLUDES
NOT JUST ONE TIME AND LIMITED
TERM, FUNDING REDUCTIONS, BUT
SOME REDUCTIONS TO ONGOING
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS, AS YOU
KIND OF HEARD EARLIER WITH LIKE
THE INDIAN HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM,
FOR EXAMPLE, AS WELL AS NOW HERE
WITH THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DOLLARS. SO THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT SOME OF
THE TRADE OFFS, SPECIFICALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE REDUCTION. IN
FUNDING FOR THESE ONGOING
PROGRAMS, ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO CORE SERVICES LIKE
THIS. THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDING, I'M SURE YOU
KNOW, BUT JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT, HOW THIS FUNDING
CAME ABOUT IS, EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC, THERE WAS KIND OF
CREATED THIS FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK GROUP THAT PROVIDED
A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW A POTENTIAL INFUSION OF
FUNDING COULD BE USED TO HELP
SHORE UP THE STATE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM. PARTICULARLY,
THEY FOUND THAT, THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM, AFTER
DECADES, THE FUNDING HAD BEEN
RELATIVELY STAGNANT,
PARTICULARLY WITH GENERAL FUND
PRIOR TO THIS, DOLLAR AMOUNT. I
THINK THE IT AVERAGED AROUND
LIKE 5% OF THE OF THE BUDGET FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WAS GENERAL FUND. SO THE FUNDING
HAD BEEN STAGNANT AND WAS ALSO
RELATIVELY INFLEXIBLE. A LOT OF
THIS FUNDING IS FROM SPECIAL
FUNDS FOR VERY SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS, VERY SPECIFIC
DISEASES, THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
IT KIND OF LIMITED THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND THAT KIND OF CAME
UP, AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE. SO
GIVEN THE PROGRAMMATIC AND
PLANNING EFFORTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY GONE UNDERWAY, BECAUSE
OF THIS FUNDING, PRIMARILY, AS
THE SENATOR NOTED, THERE'S A LOT
OF WORKFORCE. THE MAJORITY OF
THE STATE'S $100 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND IS FOR WORKFORCE,
AND COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO
SPEND 70% OF THEIR ALLOCATION.
OF THAT $200 MILLION ON
WORKFORCE, AS WELL. SO WITH THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS FUNDING, IT
COULD, DEFINITELY CAUSE SOME
DISRUPTION TO PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTIVITIES. AND AS I MENTIONED,
THESE ARE CORE ACTIVITIES, THE
300 MILLION THE INTENT OF THE
FUNDING WAS TO BRING PUBLIC
HEALTH MONNING UP TO A BASELINE
SERVICE LEVEL, WHEREAS PRIOR TO
THAT IT HAD HAD VERY LIMITED TO
STAGNANT FUNDING, LIKE I SAID.
SO SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE
TRADE OFFS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER. AND OUR OFFICE
IS AVAILABLE TO KIND OF WEIGH
AND HELP ASSIST IN ASSESSING
SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF WHAT
ELIMINATING THIS FUNDING WOULD
BE. AND I THINK YOU HAD ALSO
ASKED ABOUT PROPOSITION ONE
FUNDING, PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE OFFSETTING SOME
OF THE IMPACTS OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS FUNDING. SO
PROPOSITION ONE, THE PORTION FOR
UP TO 4% FOR, THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS SPECIFICALLY
FOR POPULATION BASED PREVENTION
SERVICES, AS RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, WHEREAS THE
CURRENTLY THE $100 MILLION FOR
THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS,
WHILE I'M SURE INCLUDE INCLUDE
SOME PREVENTION SERVICES IN THE
DEPARTMENT COULD SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT MORE TO THAT IS BROADER,
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE INFECTIOUS
DISEASE LABORATORY IT SERVICES,
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT KIND OF
EXTEND BEYOND JUST POPULATION
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
PROGRAMING. SO BUT WITH THAT,
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. WILL SENATOR. SO I GUESS
THE KEY QUESTION FOR US IS HOW
DO WE MAINTAIN ESSENTIAL
CAPABILITY TO DEAL WITH THE NEXT
CRISIS. WHATEVER THAT ESSENTIAL.
AND HOW MUCH IS IT GOING TO COST
, ESSENTIAL CORE CAPABILITY THAT
WE HAVE ON HAND TO DEAL WITH THE
NEXT CRISIS? IT COULD BE
TOMORROW. AND HOW MUCH IS IT
GOING TO COST AND HOW LONG WILL
IT TAKE US TO RAMP UP WITH THE
ADDITIONAL CAPABILITY THAT IT
WILL TAKE TO FULLY MEET THE
CRISIS? AND WE'VE JUST HAD WE
JUST HAD A PANDEMIC. SO WE IT'S
NOT LIKE WE HAVEN'T HAD
SOMETHING THAT, YOU KNOW, IS ON
A MASSIVE RELATIVE MASSIVE
SCALE. SO THAT'S WHAT YOU ALL
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HELP US
DEAL WITH AND MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT, BECAUSE WHEN WE DEAL WITH
RAW NUMBERS, IT'S VERY EASY TO
SAY, WELL, YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT
$27 BILLION DEFICIT. WE'RE GOING
TO CUT AND IT'S 300 MILLION HERE
AND IT'S 200 MILLION THERE. BUT
YOU KNOW, WE REALLY ARE. WE
REALLY OUGHT TO BE TAKING A
LITTLE MORE GRANULAR LOOK AT AT
AT WHAT WE'RE CUTTING AND
WHETHER WE HAVE TO KEEP
SOMETHING BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET
IT UP TO SPEED FAST ENOUGH TO
DEAL WITH A MAJOR INCIDENT IN
THE STATE AND WHATEVER THAT
LEVEL IS, IF IT'S 80% OR IF IT'S
70, AND THEN WE KNOW HOW MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO TELL US HOW MUCH
THAT'S GOING TO COST, AND THEN
TO GET TO BE FULLY CAPABLE. HOW
LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE US TO
GET FROM HERE TO THERE, AND HOW
MUCH WILL THAT COST? AND THEN WE
CAN MAKE I THINK THESE ARE IN
SEMI INTELLIGENT QUESTIONS. IT'S
THE ONLY WAY I KNOW TO ASK THEM.
AND THEN IT'S NOT FOR TODAY. BUT
WE'LL BE REVISITING THIS I'M
SURE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING ON TO
OUR NEXT DEPARTMENT, STATE
HOSPITALS
.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON.
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS. AND I'M JOINED
BY CHRIS EDENS, WHO IS OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM
SERVICES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR FISCAL YEAR 2425. TOTALS 3.4
BILLION, WHICH IS A DECREASE OF
55.6 MILLION, OR 2, FROM THE
2425 GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, WITH 25
PROPOSED POSITIONS AND BUDGET
YEAR WITH THE MAJORITY OF THESE
REFLECTING CONVERTING LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS TO PERMANENT. WE
ALSO REFLECT CURRENT YEAR
SAVINGS OF 151.2 MILLION RELATED
TO CHANGES IN IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINES FOR NEW PROGRAMS AND
BED CAPACITY THAT'S APPROVED IN
PRIOR BUDGET ACTS, AMONG OTHER
SAVINGS. WE ARE PROPOSING THE
REVERSION OF AN UNUSED CURRENT
YEAR FUNDS AS A GENERAL FUND
SOLUTION. THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSES TO REPLACE EXISTING
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF 1.9 MILLION FOR THE
WORKING DRAWINGS PHASE OF THE
CENTRAL UTILITY PLANT
REPLACEMENT PROJECT AT OUR DSH
METROPOLITAN STATE HOSPITAL,
WITH 1.9 MILLION OF EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION FUND. THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO AUTHORIZE THE STATE PUBLIC
WORK BOARD TO ISSUE BONDS TO
FINANCE THE COST OF THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
PROJECT, FOR A BRIEF SUMMARY OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S MAY REVISION
PROGRAM AND CASELOAD UPDATES AND
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS.
OVERALL, THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROJECTING A CENSUS OF 8163 BY
THE END OF FISCAL YEAR, THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR, AND 9267
ACROSS ITS PROGRAMS BY THE END
OF BUDGET YEAR. THIS INCREASE IS
PRIMARILY RELATED TO CONTINUING
EFFORTS TO EXPAND CAPACITY FOR
THE TREATMENT OF INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL INDIVIDUALS FOR DSH
METROPOLITAN INCREASED SECURE
BED CAPACITY PROJECT, WE ARE
REFLECTING AN ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME SAVINGS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
OF 3,901,000, DUE TO CHANGES IN
TIMELINE FOR COMPLETING THE WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY ROOFING PROJECT
FOR THE ENHANCED TREATMENT
PROGRAM STAFFING, WE'RE
REFLECTING 281,000 IN CURRENT
YEAR SAVINGS FOR THE ENHANCED
TREATMENT PROGRAM UNIT AT DSH
PATTON, AND THIS IS A UNIT TO
TREAT PATIENTS WHO ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK OF VIOLENCE AND
CANNOT BE SAFELY TREATED IN A
STANDARD TREATMENT ENVIRONMENT.
THIS SAVINGS REFLECTS THE
CURRENT ANTICIPATED TIMELINE FOR
COMPLETION OF THE CONSTRUCTION
FOR THIS PROJECT IN JULY OF
2024. FOR THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW, DIRECT CARE NURSING AND
TREATMENT TEAM AND PRIMARY CARE
PROPOSALS, WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TO HIRE THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED
BY THESE PROPOSALS FOR NURSING.
WE ARE REFLECTING AN ADDITIONAL
SAVINGS OF 3.6 MILLION IN
CURRENT YEAR AND FOR TREATMENT
TEAM AND PRIMARY CARE POSITIONS,
WE ARE REFLECTING AN ADDITIONAL
CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS OF 3.1
MILLION. THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
PROPOSES TO DELAY 34.4 TREATMENT
TEAM POSITIONS THAT ARE
SCHEDULED TO PHASE IN DURING
2425 UNTIL JULY 1ST, 2027, WHICH
RESULTS IN AN ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS OF 8.2 MILLION
ANNUALLY. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS
RECRUITMENT ON THE ESTABLISHED
POSITIONS AND PHASE IN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AT A LATER
DATE. THE DEPARTMENT IS ALSO
PROPOSES TO REVERT 6.6 MILLION
GENERAL FUND THAT'S ALSO TIED TO
THE MÀ TREATMENT TEAM PROPOSAL,
AND THIS WAS FOR THE PROCUREMENT
OF TRAILERS FOR ADDITIONAL
OFFICE SPACE FOR THE PATIENT
DRIVEN OPERATING EXPENSE AND
EQUIPMENT. THE DEPARTMENT IS
REFLECTING A SAVINGS ADJUSTMENT
OF 1.6 MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR
AND 632,000 IN BUDGET YEAR, IN
ONGOING. THIS ADJUSTMENT IS DUE
TO UPDATED CENSUS PROJECTIONS
THAT MAY REVISION AND THE
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM FOR
OUR NON SVP CLIENTS. THE
DEPARTMENT IS REPORTING A
CASELOAD OF 960 AND 23, 24,
NINE, 38 AND 2425 AND ARE
REPORTING A CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS
OF 2.6 MILLION ASSOCIATED WITH
HIRING CHALLENGES BY OUR
PROVIDERS FOR CLINICAL STAFFING,
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
SOLUTIONS. WE ARE REPORTING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME CURRENT YEAR
SAVINGS OF 118.3 MILLION IN
CURRENT YEAR AND 45 MILLION OF
THAT WAS REAPPROPRIATED FROM THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2022, AND AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
49.9 MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR
ASSOCIATED WITH UPDATED
ACTIVATION TIMELINES FOR THE
JBC, TÊ OR JAIL BASED COMPETENCY
TREATMENT AND COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION AND DIVERSION
PROGRAMS, AND FOR COUNTY
STAKEHOLDER WORK GROUP GRANTS
THAT WERE NOT YET EXECUTED.
ADDITIONALLY, THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSES TO SHIFT 129.5 MILLION
FROM 2526 TO FISCAL YEAR 2627.
TO BETTER ALIGN WITH, ANTICIPATE
FUTURE IST PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINES AND THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO MAKE
GREAT PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING
IST SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE TIMELY
ACCESS TO TREATMENT FOR IST
INDIVIDUALS AND TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION AND
DIVERSION OPPORTUNITIES. AS A
MAY REVISION, THE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED AN IST PENDING
PLACEMENT LIST OF 397, WHICH WAS
A 21% REDUCTION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
FOR EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND
STAFF BENEFITS. WERE REQUESTING
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF 108,000 IN CURRENT
YEAR AND 145,000 ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER, TO REFLECT REVISED
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION COSTS AND
ALSO REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF 9000 IN
CURRENT YEAR AND 11,000 ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO REFLECT REVISED
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT COSTS, THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS. TWO 2023
BUDGET ACT REVISIONS. THE FIRST
IS 7.2 MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS DUE TO
UPDATED PROJECT TIMELINES AND
2.2 MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER NETWORK.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES THREE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE POSITION
AUTHORITY ONLY REQUESTS NO
FUNDING IS REQUESTED. THE FIRST
IS FOR THE DATA IS FOR DATA
COMPLIANCE. WE'RE REQUESTING
EIGHT POSITIONS IN BUDGET YEAR
AND ONGOING TO SUPPORT DATA
LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE, DATA
OPERATION AND DATA COMPLIANCE.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE GREATER DATA
INSIGHTS TO BETTER INFORM
DECISION MAKING FOR THE
PROVISION OF TREATMENT ACROSS
OUR INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND THIS REQUEST WILL
WILL MAKE PERMANENT SIX TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED IN 2223 TO
ESTABLISH A DATA LEADERSHIP TEAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT AND AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POSITIONS NEEDED
TO MEET ENHANCED DATA
CAPABILITIES REQUIRED BY RECENT
LEGISLATION, POLICY AND EQUITY
INITIATIVES ACROSS BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL. AND THE JOINT
COMMISSION, WHICH IS DSHS
ACCREDITING BODY, WE HAVE THE
LAST BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL WAS
FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
STAFFING ADJUSTMENT. WE'RE
REQUESTING POSITION AUTHORITY
FOR THE CONVERSION OF SEVEN
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY AUTHORIZED IN THE
2122 FISCAL YEAR TO MAKE THEM
PERMANENT AND ONGOING TO ADDRESS
WORKERS COMPENSATION, WORKLOAD.
OH, SORRY. THERE'S A THIRD ONE,
THE SB 1034 INCREASED WORKLOAD,
DSH REQUESTS TEN POSITIONS AND
BUDGET YEAR AND ONGOING TO
SUPPORT INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS
CONTRACTED PROVIDER FOR THE
FORENSIC CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM FOR SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS, RESULTING FROM THE
PASSAGE OF SB 1034, SB 1034
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONVENE A COMMITTEE OF SPECIFIED
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES TO OBTAIN
RELEVANT ASSISTANCE AND
CONSULTATION. REGARDING SECURING
A SUITABLE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR EACH SVP PATIENT
APPROVED FOR CONDITIONAL
RELEASE. THESE COMMITTEES ARE IN
EFFECT FROM THE DATE OF THE
CONREP ORDER TO THE DATE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL'S PLACEMENT INTO
CONREP. THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS
RESULTED IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
NEW COUNTY SPECIFIC HOUSING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT ARE OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC AND INCREASED
NUMBER OF COURT HEARINGS, TASK
AND CRITERIA TRACKING, REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, AND INTERAGENCY
COORDINATION ACROSS MULTIPLE
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE. WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD TO SUPPORT THESE
COMMITTEES TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BAGLEY-KEENE OPEN
MEETING ACT. AND LASTLY, AS IT
RELATES TO CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
THE COALINGA NEW ACTIVITY
COURTYARD, THE DEPARTMENT
REQUESTS A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION OF GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF 1.1
MILLION AND 2425, DUE TO
PROCURING A NEW GENERAL
CONTRACTOR AND ASSOCIATED
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS. I THINK YOU
DID THAT IN ONE BREATH. YOU
WANTED IT QUICK. TWO QUESTIONS
ON THE SAME TOPIC. THE, MBER THE
MISSION BASED REVIEW TREATMENT
TEAM. YES WE'RE DELAYING 31.4,
AND I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
10,000 VACANT POSITIONS WE'RE
LOOKING TO, REMOVE. MAYBE YOU
HAVE THREE QUESTIONS HERE.
OVERALL, I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHICH
OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE UNDER
HHS. TWO. WHICH ONES ARE WAY
MORE THAN TWO QUESTIONS. OKAY, I
HAVE FOUR. TWO, ARE ANY OF THOSE
POSITION ONES CONNECTED TO ANY
CHAPTERED LEGISLATION? WILL IT
IMPACT ANY OF THEM? AND THEN IN
GOING BACK TO THIS, PROPOSAL
ADJUSTMENT, I'M SEEING HERE AN
EXAMPLE THAT WE CAN DELAY THINGS
OUTWARDS OF THREE YEARS. SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS DELAYING IT TO 2027.
AND FOR THE PAST TWO HOURS I'VE
BEEN ASKING, WHY CAN'T WE DELAY
OTHER THINGS OUTWARDS? THREE AND
FOUR. AND I'M GETTING THE
RESPONSE IS THAT WILL OUR YEARS.
WE NEED TO BALANCE EVERYTHING
AND EVERYTHING. I WOULD LIKE A
UNIFORM APPROACH IF YOU'RE
COMING TO US AND SAY, THIS IS
WHAT WE WANT TO DO, YOU CAN'T
PICK AND CHOOSE SOME OF THEM TO
BE ABLE TO DELAY, DELAY SOME OF
THEM TO 2027 AND OTHERS WE CAN'T
DO. SO. WHY CAN WE DELAY THIS TO
2027, BUT OTHERS WE CAN'T,
JOSEPH DAWSON, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK EVERY
DEPARTMENT, WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT KIND OF THEIR BUDGETS AND
THEIR OPERATING EXPENSES AND THE
CONTEXT OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET, I
THINK IT'S SOMETIMES HARD TO
VIEW THINGS WITHIN A UNIFORM
APPROACH. OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE
APPROACHES WITH DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS THAT MIGHT
DIFFER FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
WHILE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DELAY
THINGS TO A DEGREE TO THIS LEVEL
WITH STATE HOSPITALS, THAT MAY
NOT ACTUALLY IT MAY NOT BE
FEASIBLE WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALL DEPARTMENTS HOLISTICALLY,
BUT SOMETIMES TAKING A SAME
APPROACH OR A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
IS NOT ALWAYS FEASIBLE BASED ON
HOW EACH DEPARTMENT OPERATES. I
AGREE, YOU'RE RIGHT, DEFINITELY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE COMMENTS OF
NOTING THE DIFFERENCES OF
SOLUTIONS. SO I DEFINITELY
AGREE. YOU'RE RIGHT. NOT
EVERYTHING IS THE SAME AND
DIFFERENT PLATFORMS AND ALL
THAT, CAN BE DIFFERENT. IT MAY
BE MORE FEASIBLE, LIKE YOU
MENTIONED, FOR THIS DEPARTMENT
THAN THAN THE OTHER ONE. I GUESS
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE IMPACT WILL BE ON OUR
BUDGET IF WE JUST DELAY VERSUS
CUT AND THEN STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CUT IN TWO YEARS, IF
THE BUDGET IS STILL WE'RE STILL
IN THAT DEFICIT HOLE. I THINK IT
DEPENDS ON WHEN LOOKING AT
DIFFERENCES OF ITEMS THAT WERE
PROPOSED FOR REDUCTION OR
PROPOSED DELAYS. IT IT'S HARD TO
KIND OF GIVE AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON OF WHY THOSE
DECISIONS WERE MADE ACROSS THE
BOARD. YOU KNOW, WITHIN THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE MAY
REVISE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE FOR BOTH FOR BUDGET
YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR ONE, AS
WELL AS TRYING TO PUT OURSELVES
IN A GOOD FINANCIAL FOOTING
GOING FORWARD, YOU KNOW, BASED
ON HOW, WE STRUCTURED THE
ADMINISTRATION, STRUCTURED THE
MAY REVISE, IT WAS BASED ON THE
ITEMS FOR STATE HOSPITALS. IT
JUST WORKED THAT SOME OF THESE
THINGS COULD BE DELAYED, WHEREAS
OTHER DEPARTMENTS, DETERMINATION
WAS TO HAVE THESE ITEMS REDUCED.
SO, WE CAN DEFINITELY PROVIDE
MORE DETAILS ON, ON KIND OF
DIFFERENCES. BUT I THINK JUST
REITERATING THAT FOR A LOT OF
THESE DEPARTMENTS, IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO COMPARE
APPLES TO APPLES WITH HOW SOME
OF THESE SOLUTIONS WORK BECAUSE
THEY JUST OPERATE SO
DIFFERENTLY. BUT DEFINITELY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE IS A,
THAT DIFFERENCES OF HOW CERTAIN
DEPARTMENTS ARE, HANDLED. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT, SENATOR ROTH OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
APPOINTMENT. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. ARE WE CHANGING OUR
NAME? ARE WE CHANGING NAMES?
JANUARY. PROP ONE, RENAMED THE
COMMISSION AS THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION, WHERE
WE HAVE A VARIETY OF SORT OF
INFORMAL EXPRESSIONS, THE OAC OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COMMISSION,
MADAM CHAIR, THANK YOU. TOBY
EWING, ON BEHALF OF THE SOON TO
BE NAME CHANGE TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COMMISSION. WELCOME BACK.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR THE
CHANCE TO JOIN YOU TODAY, SURE.
THE THE BUDGET PROPOSES THREE
NEW POSITIONS AND SOME RELATED
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION UNDER THE REFORMS
THAT WERE ADOPTED WITH PROP ONE,
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
STRATEGIES FOR INNOVATION. SO AS
YOU MAY RECALL, UNDER THE
CURRENT SETUP, UNDER THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT, COUNTIES
RECEIVE FUNDS AND THEY MUST SET
ASIDE 5% FOR INNOVATION. AND THE
COMMISSION HAS A REVIEW AND
APPROVAL AUTHORITY THAT WAS
STRUCTURED TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS WERE ACTUALLY USED TO
DRIVE TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE IN
INNOVATION STRATEGY THAT'S
CHANGING. THE COUNTY IS NO
LONGER SET ASIDE THOSE FUNDS FOR
INNOVATION. THE COMMISSION DOES
RECEIVE 20 MILLION A YEAR,
INITIALLY FOR FIVE YEARS, TO
SUPPORT A MORE STATE DIRECTED
INNOVATION STRATEGY, WITH THE
INTENT OF STRENGTHENING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND OTHER
PARTNERS TO REALLY SUPPORT A
CONTINUED TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE STRATEGY. WE'RE STILL
WORKING WITH PARTNERS AT FINANCE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION THÀNH TO
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE CHANGES
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE REFORMS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS MAY NOT BE
THE YEAR TO ASK FOR FUNDS TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THOSE CHANGES,
BUT WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. OKAY. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, MY QUESTION, HOW
MUCH IS IN GMSF LEFT, NOT LEFT.
BUT I KNOW IT'S ONGOING, BUT HOW
MUCH DO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW? SO
THE SORRY NATE WILLIAMS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, IF SO, IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE FUND
BALANCE FOR THE END OF THE
BUDGET YEAR, WE'RE PROJECTING
APPROXIMATELY 18 MILLION, WHICH
IS, SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN
WHAT WE'VE TRADITIONALLY,
HISTORICALLY HAD AS A PRUDENT
RESERVE. YEAH IS THIS THE SAME?
REMIND ME, IS THIS THE SAME FUND
THAT SENATOR ROTH WAS TALKING
ABOUT THAT WE WERE PULLING FROM,
FROM SOME OF THE BEHAVIORAL
WORKFORCES? YES. SO, YES, IF
YOU'RE REFERRING SO THERE WERE
SOME WORKFORCE PROPOSALS THAT,
SOME OF THE FUNDING WAS REMOVED.
YEAH. WHAT IS A HEALTHY, END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR, NUMBER THAT WE
WERE USED TO BEFORE, I DON'T
HAVE THOSE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF
ME RIGHT AT THE MOMENT, WE WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON WHAT
KIND OF IS A HISTORICAL NUMBER.
I THINK IF I RECALL, FROM 2023
BUDGET ACT, IT WAS SOMEWHERE
NEAR 70 MILLION, WHICH WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN WHAT
HAD HISTORICALLY BEEN KEPT IN A
PRUDENT RESERVE, BUT BUT, YOU
KNOW, I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON SPECIFIC NUMBERS. WHAT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE DIFFERENCE? THE
REDUCTIONS. JUST REFRESH MY
MEMORY. IT'S THE TAX ON THE.
YEAH. SO JUST KIND OF OVERALL
THE MHSA FUND IS THAT TAX ON THE
1. IS IT 1% TAX ON INDIVIDUALS
MAKING OVER $1 MILLION? I MEAN,
SO IT'S A REDUCTION IN THE TAX
REVENUE. CORRECT? OKAY. THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE BALANCE. YES.
AND THEN CORRESPONDING
EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD THEN
COME OUT OF IT. YES NOT ENOUGH
MILLIONAIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY.
OKAY. WELL ANYTHING ADDITIONAL,
NOTHING ON THIS ITEM AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. HOLDING THE ITEM
UP AND MOVING ON TO OUR LAST
DEPARTMENT COVERED CALIFORNIA.
THANKS, TOBY. COVERED CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE BOARD
MEETING RIGHT NOW. GOT IT. SO
FINANCE IS GOING TO PRESENT.
YES. THIS IS ALL FINANCE STUFF
ANYWAY.
ALBERT PINEDA, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE DEPARTMENT IS NOT
HERE, BUT I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET PROBLEM, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS TO
SOLVE THE DEFICIT. IT INCLUDES
AN ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE LOAN OF
$62 MILLION FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND TO
THE GENERAL FUND IN 20 2425,
UNDER THE CONTROL SECTION 13.4
FROM RESOURCES NOT REQUIRED FOR
CURRENTLY PROJECTED OPERATIONAL
PROGRAMMATIC PURPOSES. THIS LOAN
WILL NOT IMPACT CURRENT PROGRAM
SERVICES. IT ALSO INCLUDES A
DELAY OF THE REPAYMENT OF THE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE LOAN OF 600 MILLION THAT
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED VIA TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE, AND IT WOULD
SPREAD THE REPAYMENTS OVER OVER
THE FISCAL YEARS 20, 26, 27, 20
2728 AND 20 2829 IN INCREMENTS
OF 200 MILLION. IT ALSO INCLUDES
A PARTIAL INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
PENALTY TRANSFER, SO THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES AN
ANNUAL REVENUE TRANSFER OF 109
MILLION FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND TO
THE GENERAL FUND STARTING IN 20
2526, AND ONGOING AND THESE ARE
THE RECEIPTS OVER AND ABOVE THE
AMOUNT BEING RETAINED TO SUPPORT
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF SPENDING.
SO THE THREE INCLUDED SOLUTIONS
FOR COVERED CALIFORNIA. DO NOT
IMPACT CURRENT AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAMS OR REDUCE THEIR CURRENT
APPROPRIATIONS. SO CALIFORNIA,
COVERED CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS 165
MILLION FOR A COST SHARING
AFFORDABILITY PROGRAM AND
MAINTAINS THE $2 MILLION FOR THE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. DURING
LABOR DISPUTES, COVERED
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A LANGUAGE
ONLY REQUEST FOR THE 2025
PROGRAM DESIGN IMPLEMENTATION,
WHICH WOULD, JUST ADD A
CLARIFYING PROVISION. GREAT.
WE'RE MAINTAINING THE 165. BUT
WHAT IF WE GET MORE
BENEFICIARIES UNDER COVERED
CALIFORNIA THAN MEET THE
ELIGIBILITY? IN TERMS OF IF IS
THE QUESTION, CLARIFY IS THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
165 165 MILLION ONGOING COULD
SUBSTANTIATE AND INCREASE, I
THINK RIGHT NOW, BASED ON WHERE
AND APOLOGIES, COVER COVERAGE IS
NOT PRESENT FOR THE PROGRAMMATIC
SIDE OF THINGS, BUT, BASED ON
THE CURRENT APPROPRIATION,
THAT'S WHAT'S BEING MAINTAINED.
THE MAY REVISE THAT, YOU KNOW,
DOWN IF THAT SITUATION DOES
ARISE, WE WOULD HAVE TO REASSESS
THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO SEE
IF IT WOULD NEED TO BE ADJUSTED.
BUT RIGHT NOW, THE BUDGET
MAINTAINS THE 165 MILLION
ONGOING FOR THIS PROGRAM. LAST
YEAR THIS WAS LIKE ONE OF MY.
HOW THE SAUSAGE WAS MADE MOMENT.
MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE, I WAS LIKE, WOW,
WE'RE PROVIDING A NOT PROVIDING.
WE'RE ASSESSING A FEE ON PEOPLE.
WE SAID, WE'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING WITH IT, AND WE'RE NOT
DOING IT. LAST YEAR WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE DID IT, AND IT WAS
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT. BUT
WE CAN DO SO MUCH MORE LIKE WE
CAN INCREASE THE ELIGIBILITY FEE
AND REMOVE DEDUCTIBLES,
CO-PAYMENTS FOR WAY MORE PEOPLE
UNDER COVERED CALIFORNIA. I AM
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THIS
PREMATURE, ONGOING, ALLOCATION
OF 109 MILLION BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
NOVEMBER. AND WHAT IF A
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
AS FRIENDLY WITH US? WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE TO DIP
INTO THIS FUND TO COVER
INSURANCE FOR BENEFICIARIES
UNDER COVERED, COVERED
CALIFORNIA. WHAT WOULD WE DO
THEN IF THAT IS THE CASE? I
THINK SO TO THAT POINT, THESE
THE THESE PROPOSALS ARE BASED
OFF THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES WOULD BE
EXTENDED. OBVIOUSLY. THAT IS AN
UNCERTAINTY OF WHETHER OR NOT
THAT WOULD BE EXTENDED BEYOND
25, 26, OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT IT WILL EXTEND
UNDERSTANDING THAT IF YOU KNOW
THINGS CHANGE ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE, WE WOULD HAVE TO, REASSESS
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA, BUT JUST TO
KIND OF CIRCLE IT BACK INTO KIND
OF THE ORIGINAL COMMENTS MADE OF
THE STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET OF,
YOU KNOW, UNDERSTANDING THE
NEXUS OF NEED TO ADDRESS THE
BUDGET PROBLEM AND MAINTAIN CORE
RESOURCES THAT WITH THESE
SPECIFIC SOLUTIONS, WHILE THERE
ARE, YOU KNOW, USING THESE
UNUSED RESOURCES AT THIS TIME TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM, WE'RE ALSO
NOT IMPACTING WHAT'S CURRENTLY
BEING OFFERED BY COVERED
CALIFORNIA. SO YOU KNOW, IT'S
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT HAPPY
MEDIUM AS BEST AS POSSIBLE AND
WILL BE HOW MUCH. AND I FORGOT,
CAN YOU REMIND ME, JOSEPH, I
FORGOT HOW MUCH WE GET ON
AVERAGE EACH YEAR. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE INDIVIDUAL
PENALTY? YES PLEASE, SO THE
PENALTY HAS BEEN DECLINING OVER
THE YEARS, BUT THE. THAT'S
GREAT. THE REVENUE FOR 20 2425
IS 298 MILLION, APPROXIMATELY.
AND TO GIVE A LITTLE MORE
CONTEXT TO THAT. SO EVEN WITH
THESE UPDATED REVENUES THAT WE
JUST NOTED THAT ASSUMING WITH
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THESE
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS WOULD BE
ENACTED, PART OF THE FINAL
BUDGET THAT WOULD PROVIDE A FUND
BALANCE AT THE END OF 24, 25 OF
14.5 MILLION, AND THEN IN 2526,
A FUND BALANCE OF 30.3 MILLION.
SO EVEN WHEN DEVELOPING THESE
SOLUTIONS, IT WAS WE ENSURED
THAT THERE WOULD BE A PRUDENT
FUND BALANCE FOR UNCERTAINTY. SO
WITH THESE SOLUTIONS, WE REALLY
TRY TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE WITH
ALL THESE CONSIDERATION ACTIONS.
OKAY. AND I GET IT. YOU'RE
RIGHT. WE'RE KEEPING THE 165.
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM TO DO MORE.
AT MINIMUM, WE'RE KEEPING THE
165 COMMITMENT FOR THOSE LIVES.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE STILL MEETING, THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE COMING INTO COVERED
CALIFORNIA, THAT WE CAN CAPTURE
THEM UNDER THE 165 OR GROW A
LITTLE BIT AS WE SEE FIT, AS IS
NEEDED. I'M ALSO NOT REALLY
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
ALLOWING AN ANNUAL TRANSFER. I
KNOW IF WE'RE LOOKING TO BALANCE
FOR NEXT YEAR, THEN HAVE THIS
JUST BE A REQUEST FOR NEXT YEAR
AND HAVE THE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
COME BACK, AND REEVALUATE SO WE
CAN REEVALUATE FOR AN ONGOING
BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING IF WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE AN ENEMY, ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE. ALEJO THANK YOU. RYAN
MILLER. ELIO, JUST BRIEFLY,
ADDING ON TO THAT CONVERSATION,
YOU KNOW, AS WE SAID EARLIER, WE
DO THINK THAT THE BUDGET PROBLEM
IS MULTIYEAR IN NATURE. AND SO
IT'S REASONABLE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SOME MULTI
YEAR TYPES OF ACTIONS. BUT AS WE
SAID EARLIER AS WELL, YOU KNOW,
THE SORT OF CHARACTER OF
DIFFERENT ACTIONS CAN CAN BE
VIEWED DIFFERENTLY. AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS ONE THAT COULD BE
PREMATURE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT FOR THE REASONS THAT'S
BEEN, THAT ARE, HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED. THIS RESERVE FUND WAS
ESSENTIALLY SET UP ESSENTIAL AS
A CONTINGENCY IF THE CONGRESS
DOES NOT EXTEND THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES. AND THOSE SUBSIDIES,
WE DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE, BUT
WE BELIEVE THEY'RE PROBABLY
TOTALING NEAR $2 BILLION A YEAR,
THAT WOULD BE A TREMENDOUSLY
DIFFICULT THING FOR THE STATE TO
BACKFILL. AND THERE WOULD BE
CERTAINLY PRESSURE FOR THE STATE
TO BACKFILL THAT IN SOME WAY.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THIS COULD
PUT THE LEGISLATURE IN A PRETTY
POOR POSITION. SHOULD THAT BE
THE SCENARIO THAT PLAY OUT? ALL
THAT SAID, THIS WOULD BE A
SIZABLE, CHANGE TO THE MAY
REVISION STRUCTURE, IN TERMS OF
THE AMOUNT OF THE SOLUTIONS IN
THE OUT YEARS. AND SO WE WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE TO
HELP DEVELOP SOME ALTERNATIVES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, RYAN.
SENATOR. NO. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE INTO
PUBLIC COMMENT. BEFORE YOU BEGIN
. MÐI. WE STILL HAVE LIKE SIX
MORE HOURS TO GO AFTER THIS. SO
NO. SO I WILL I WILL LIMIT YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY TO, LIKE, 45
SECONDS. OKAY ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON, MICHELLE
GIBBONS WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS OPPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR THE
GREAT QUESTIONS. I WANT TO
PROVIDE ANSWERS ON BEHALF OF
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS RELY ON
WORKFORCE, SO WE WILL BE AT
LEAST 900 PEOPLE LESS PREPARED,
UPDATED COUNTS OF CLOSE TO 1100
PEOPLE LESS PREPARED IN
CALIFORNIA THAN WE ARE TODAY,
THE DOLLARS HAVE ALREADY HELPED
WITH RESPONSE IN L.A. COUNTY, IT
FUNDS THOSE THAT ARE CONDUCTING
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AND WORK
SITES AROUND SILICOSIS
AWARENESS, PREVENTION, WORKERS
RIGHTS AND REFERRALS TO HEALTH
SERVICES, AS IN ADDITION TO
COMMUNITY OUTBREAK TEAMS
RESPONDING TO THE HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK IN RIVERSIDE, THERE
WERE TEAMS ESTABLISHED THAT
DETECTED OUTBREAKS BEFORE THEIR
TRADITIONAL SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM.
SO THEY'RE BEING PUT TO GOOD
USE. THEY'RE NEEDED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. FINANCE MENTIONED OTHER
FUNDS. THEY'RE NOT FLEXIBLE. WE
CAN'T USE THOSE FUNDS IN THE WAY
THAT WE DO WITH THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
STACY HARIMOTO WITH REMCO. THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION, ALSO
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND GOOD
QUESTIONS TODAY, WE ARE VERY
OPPOSED TO THE CUTS IN THE
SEBIHI, THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE,
BECAUSE FOR ONE REASON THEY THEY
ARE THEY FUND, THEY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE THE MAJOR
FUNDING SOURCE FOR PROGRAMS THAT
UTILIZE CDPS OR COMMUNITY
DEFINED EVIDENCE PRACTICES. CDPS
ARE COST EFFECTIVE, AND THEY ARE
THE TYPES OF APPROACHES OR
PROGRAMS THAT PEOPLE IN BIPOC
AND LGBTQ COMMUNITIES PREFER
OVER MAINSTREAM MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE. TWO COMPONENTS, IN
PARTICULAR OF THE SAIBAI THAT
SHOULD NOT BE CUT ARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY, PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN AND THE
SAIBAI ROUND SIX FOR COMMUNITY
DEFINED EVIDENCE PRACTICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ELIZABETH ESPINOSA,
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, WITH A COMMENT ON
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANTS
TRANSFER THAT YOU DISCUSSED
UNDER ISSUE ONE. OUR FOCUS
CONTINUES TO BE ON THE CERTAINTY
AND STABILITY OF FUNDING THAT
SUPPORTS EXISTING CORE PROBATION
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE LIGHT OF THE
MOST RECENT REALIGNMENT OF
RESPONSIBILITY THAT PLACES THE
CARE AND TREATMENT OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE, IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
BETH CAPELL HERE ON BEHALF OF
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE ON
HEALTH CARE FOR STRIKING WORKERS
. CONTRARY TO WHAT FINANCE SAID,
IF THE TEAMSTERS UPS STRIKE HAD
HAPPENED LAST YEAR, 35 TO 40,000
TEAMSTERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WOULD HAVE LOST COVERAGE AND
NEEDED MORE HELP THAN IS
AVAILABLE IN THE CURRENT BUDGET.
SIMILARLY, THIS YEAR, ON BEHALF
OF UNITE, HERE WE ARE FACING
HOTEL STRIKES UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA. THEY HAVE NOT
HAPPENED YET. WE HOPE THEY
WON'T. BUT WE'RE COUNTING ON
THIS BEING THERE IF THEY DO.
SECOND, THIS COMMITTEE, WE LED
THE EFFORT TO ASSURE THAT THE
MONEY WAS BORROWED AND NOT
TRANSFERRED. BUT AGAIN, FINANCE
PROPOSES TO SWEEP THE MONEY,
UNDOING THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS
REACHED LAST YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MATT,
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK QUICKLY ON
THE MCO TAX, AND WE URGE THE
REJECTION OF THIS PROPOSAL,
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE CRISIS WITH 500,000
HEALTH CARE WORKERS SHORTAGE.
THESE INVESTMENTS IN THE MCO TAX
PROPOSAL WERE CRITICAL TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CARE,
PARTICULARLY HIGHLIGHTING THE
INVESTMENTS FOR THE PUBLIC.
HOSPITALS GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING, ESPECIALLY GIVEN SOME
OF THE CUTS TO THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM. HOW IMPORTANT IS TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE PIPELINE, WE MUST
CONTINUE TO LIFT UP OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER ON OUR CARE GOALS, AND
DELAYS IN CARE RESULT IN WORSE
PATIENT OUTCOMES, HIGHER COSTS
IN THE LONG RUN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE MEDI-CAL
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, LINDA WEI WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE OPPOSE THE
DEVASTATING CUTS TO THE SAFETY
NET PROGRAM AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO THINK OF REVENUE SOLUTIONS.
MEANS WE'RE PARTICULARLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT SHARE OF COST
REFORM WAS NOT INCLUDED, MEANING
MANY SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES STILL HAVE TO PAY
OVER $1,000 A MONTH TO ACCESS
MEDI-CAL AND SO URGE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS. ALSO DISAPPOINTED
THAT MULTI YEAR CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY WAS NOT INCLUDED AND
OPPOSE THE CUTS TO ENROLLMENT
NAVIGATORS BOTH HELP PEOPLE KEEP
COVERAGE AT A TIME WHEN PEOPLE
ARE BEING TERMINATED. AND
FINALLY, WE WILL ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
RELATED TO COVERED CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. I AGREE LINDA LINDA I
AGREE. CHAIR AND MEMBERS CATHY
MOSSBERG OF ITEMS
QUICKLY, ON BEHALF OF THE END,
THE EPIDEMICS A COALITION
APPRECIATE THE FORWARD TO HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION. BEEN TRYING
TO HAVE IT. WE THINK ALL OF
THOSE PROPOSALS SHOULD FIT
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE ADAP
FUNDS FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ON THE REGISTRY. WE
HAD A CONVERSATION AFTER WE
THINK WE'RE CLOSE, BUT THERE IS
A GAP TO FILL THAT'S LEVEL
FUNDING, NOT PERFECT, BUT IN
THIS BUDGET. TOTALLY UNDERSTAND,
ALSO VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH, FUNDING
CUT. HOPE WE CAN WORK TO RESTORE
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION. WILL ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH MISS WEI'S COMMENTS
ON CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY. AT
LEAST HOPE THE DEPARTMENT CAN
ASK FOR THE WAIVER BEFORE WE SEE
A NEW ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN
FINALLY, ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS, VERY MUCH
CONCERNED WITH THE MCO TAX
PROPOSAL, WE KNOW WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
GREATER ACCESS AND INCREASE
QUALITY WITHOUT THOSE DOLLARS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, AUTUMN OGDEN SMITH
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
, CANCER ACTION NETWORK HERE.
WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH FY ON THE CALIFORNIA CANCER
REGISTRY. THIS IS SUCH A
CRITICAL PROGRAM. WE NEED TO
FUND IT. IT HELPS GUIDE US IN
CREATING POLICIES FOR
PREVENTION, TREATMENT AND
CONTROL. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING TO KEEP THE FUNDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
SENATOR ROTH, KATHY SONDERLING
MCDONALD FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
AND URGING YOU TO REJECT THAT
CUT AND ELIMINATION OF THAT
IMPORTANT FUNDING. AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY, THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED
TO HIRE ALREADY, OR THEY ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF HIRING 39 STAFF.
AND THOSE STAFF ARE ACROSS THE
BREADTH OF ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY DO IN PUBLIC HEALTH, FROM
LAB WORK TO COMMUNITY OUTREACH
AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. IT
WOULD WE USE THE WORD
DEVASTATING A LOT, BUT THEY USE
IT WITH ME. THIS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO THEIR ABILITY TO
STAY AHEAD AND EVEN JUST KEEP
AFLOAT OF THE WORK THAT THEY
NEED TO DO. SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU. THANKS,
KATHY. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, TIM
MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY,
WERE OPPOSED TO THE MCO. TACS
ELIMINATION OF THE TWO 2025
INCREASES, AS I KNOW YOU KNOW
VERY WELL THE GOAL THAT WAS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. WE BELIEVE
THIS WILL JUST MOVE IT IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION, PARTICULARLY
COUPLED WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
CHANGES IN THE BUDGET AS IT
RELATES TO WORKFORCE AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS, TO ONCE AGAIN TRY
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS. WE SEE
ANYONE THAT COMES IN THE FRONT
DOOR. SO HOW WE MANAGE THE
SITUATION IS IT REALLY
DETERMINES HOW MANY EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS WE MAY HAVE ON A
SHIFT AT A GIVEN TIME. WITH THE
INCREASE, WHEREAS TODAY WE MAY
HAVE ONE. WITH THAT INCREASE, WE
COULD HAVE TWO, WHICH IMPROVES
THROUGHPUT THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. AND JUST AS A QUICK
REMINDER, THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TREATS ALL PATIENTS,
NOT JUST MEDI-CAL. SO ANYONE
COMING IN TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THIS. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BETH MALINOWSKI WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR REALLY INTENTIONAL
CONVERSATION TODAY AROUND THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING,
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT YOU
ASKED TODAY. THESE AREN'T JUST
ANY JOBS THAT WILL BE
ELIMINATED. THESE ARE JOBS THAT
ARE REALLY KEEP OUR ECONOMY
MOVING FORWARD, KEEP FOLKS GOING
TO WORK, KEEP FOLKS GOING TO
SCHOOL AS SHARED BY OTHERS.
THESE ARE POSITIONS THAT WILL
GET ELIMINATED BECAUSE THEY ARE
FUNDED TODAY ONLY THROUGH THESE
DOLLARS. FLEXIBLE DOLLARS THAT
ALLOW OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO DO CORE FUNCTIONS
THAT OTHERWISE ARE NOT SUPPORTED
BY OUR DISEASE SPECIFIC OR
PROGRAM SPECIFIC FUNDING, SO FOR
THESE REASONS, WE STAND WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION
COLLEAGUES AND PARTNERS AND
ASKING THAT YOU REJECT THIS CUT.
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE REMARKS BY
MY COLLEAGUES FROM LABOR ON
CULVER, CALIFORNIA, AND STANDING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF MAINTAINING
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
STRIKING WORKERS. AGAIN, WE
CANNOT BALANCE THIS BUDGET ON
THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS OF
STRIKING WORKERS. THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA, ON BEHALF ON TWO
ISSUES. FIRST, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS,
WERE OPPOSED TO THE MCO TAX
PROPOSAL. PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS ARE THE CORE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH SAFETY NET.
STATEWIDE, THESE HOSPITALS
PROVIDE 35% OF MEDI-CAL AND
UNINSURED HOSPITAL CARE. DUE TO
THE LOW RATES IN MEDI-CAL AND
HISTORICAL UNDERFUNDING OF THESE
SYSTEMS, THEY ARE FACING A $4
BILLION DEFICIT WHILE ALSO
STRETCHING TO MEET AN
UNPRECEDENTED DEMAND FOR
SERVICES AND FULFILL THEIR
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN SERVING THEIR
COMMUNITIES. HOPE TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATION ON THIS NEXT. ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
RIVERSIDE AND VENTURA COUNTIES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE ELIMINATION
OF THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING. THE FUNDING THAT WE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
RECEIVED IN 2022 GOT US BACK TO
THE WORKFORCE LEVEL THAT WE WERE
AT IN 2006. WE HAVE NEVER FULLY
RECOVERED FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION. WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
OUR MISTAKES IN THE PAST AND
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. PAUL BHATTACHARJEE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. I
WORK UNDER ADRIN CHILTON AND WE
REPRESENT 165 DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HELP SERVE FOSTER YOUTH.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE
CUTS OF SAIBAI, SPECIFICALLY,
THE COMMUNITY DEFINED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAM GRANTS. THERE ARE
HUGE DISPARITIES IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE, AND THESE PRACTICES
ARE ONE OF THE ONLY FUNDING
SOURCES WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY DEFINED PRACTICES
WHICH SUPPORT PROGRAMING FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. CUTTING
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL
TO YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE IN NEED OF THESE SERVICES
MORE THAN EVER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. EACH THANK YOU IS ADAM ME
CLOSER. GETTING ME CLOSER TO THE
FIRST PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. JOLIE
ONODERA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
REPRESENTING ALL 58 COUNTIES,
HERE TO COMMENT ON TWO ISSUES,
FIRST, WITH REGARD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, WE
REQUEST A REJECTION OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING AND WOULD
REQUEST CONSIDERATION OF THE
POTENTIALLY FUTURE GREATER COSTS
AND LONG TERM IMPACTS OF
ELIMINATING THAT FUNDING. AND
THEN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES, WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION TO BE CHEAP AND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING
PROGRAM FUNDING, AND THEN DO
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
FUNDING FOR COUNTIES FOR THE
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION ONE, BUT DO LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS ON MAKING SURE
THERE'S ADEQUATE FUNDING NOW AND
ONGOING FOR COUNTIES. THANK
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA, I WANT TO
BASICALLY ECHO WHAT SEIU SAID,
BUT WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING,
AFSCME REPRESENTS THE
PHYSICIANS, PSYCHIATRISTS,
DENTISTS AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS SPACE. AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES. AND DUE TO THIS
CHRONIC DISINVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH, THE WORKFORCE HAS
SUFFERED MASSIVE VACANCY RATES
UP TO 70% IN SOME AREAS. STILL,
AND IT WILL ONLY BE COMPOUNDED
BY THE ELIMINATION OF THIS
FUNDING. ALSO WANTS TO MENTION
THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MCO TAX,
FUNDING THAT WAS AGREED UPON AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, AND THEN
ALSO JUST CONCERNED WITH THE
ELIMINATION OF A LOT OF THE
WORKFORCE FUNDING AND HCAI,
PARTICULARLY THE SONG. BROWN I
THINK IF YOU COUPLE THE MCO TAX,
ELIMINATION AND THIS FUNDING, IT
COULD REALLY IMPACT THE
WORKFORCE. THANK YOU. CHRISTINE
SMITH FROM HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA, WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH BACK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO BORROW
$62 MILLION FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND THIS
BUDGET YEAR, AND TO SWEEP $109
MILLION ONGOING STARTING THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THIS FUND
COLLECTS REVENUE FROM
CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED AND HAS
BEEN PRESERVED FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE COVERAGE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE, WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO INSTEAD
SUPPORT THE HEALTH FOR ALL
COALITION REQUEST TO USE THIS
FUND TO OPEN COVERED CALIFORNIA
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND EARN TOO MUCH
FOR MEDI-CAL. WE ALSO URGE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEDI-CAL
SHARE OF COST REFORM, AND URGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PRIORITIZE
THIS INVESTMENT. THANK YOU. I
CæA VIRGINIA HEDRICK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH AND A MEMBER OF
THE YUROK TRIBE, ASKING YOU ALL
TO REJECT THE ELIMINATION OF THE
STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM AND
ASK THE GOVERNMENT TO MAINTAIN
ITS OBLIGATION TO AMERICAN
INDIANS AND ALASKA NATIVES, AND
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION EARLIER,
AMERICAN INDIANS AND ALASKA
NATIVES HAVE LOST MORE THAN
EIGHT YEARS OF LIFE EXPECTANCY
SINCE THIS PROGRAM'S ELIMINATION
IN 2009. THANK YOU. JAMISON. HI,
I'M DOCTOR MARK LEBOW. I'M A
CITIZEN OF THE PIT RIVER NATION
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M
THE CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
INDIAN HEALTH BOARD. I HERE
TODAY TO INFORM YOU WE HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP OF 68 FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES, THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND 20 TRIBAL CLINIC
SYSTEMS. WE URGE COMMITTEE TO
REJECT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES, DESIRE TO
COMPLETELY ZERO OUT THE INDIAN
HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM. NATIVE
AMERICANS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITHIN
THE STATE. AND COLLECTIVELY, WE
NEED TO DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT THEM AND ENHANCE THEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. HI, MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE DHCS PROPOSAL TO ROLL BACK
THE COMMITMENTS TO INVEST IN
HEALTH CARE, INCLUDING SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE,
THROUGH THE MCO TAX. WE NEED TO
MAINTAIN INVESTMENTS IN THE
MEDI-CAL SYSTEM TO HELP
STABILIZE CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY
NET PROVIDERS AND ENSURE WE CAN
PROVIDE CARE TO THE 15 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT RELY ON
MEDI-CAL. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
COMPOUNDS OTHER CUTS AROUND
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE, SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU BOTH ON
ENSURING ACCESS TO CARE. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. YASMIN
PELLETT, ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE
AND AGING, WE'RE REALLY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE DELAY TO
IMPLEMENT THE MEDI-CAL SHARE OF
COST REFORM. THE CURRENT
MEDI-CAL SHARE OF COST REFORM,
OR CURRENT MEDI-CAL SHARE OF
COST PROGRAM FORCES OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO
LIVE ON $600 A MONTH IN ORDER TO
GAIN ACCESS TO MEDICAID SERVICES
, WHICH I THINK EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM CAN AGREE. YOU CAN'T LIVE
ON $600 A MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE CUTS
TO ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS AND
MEDI-CAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. JESSICA MORAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. OAN HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE CHARGE FOR
SPECIALTY CLINIC GRANT PROGRAM.
AGAIN, 101 APPLICATIONS ÓRDENES.
THEY VARY FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE. READY TO BREAK GROUND ON
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WHENEVER
THAT IS ALLOCATED. HOPING WE SEE
SOME CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO GET
AT LEAST SOME OF THAT FUNDING
OUT THE DOOR, AND CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ELIMINATE THE CONTINUOUS,
BACKFILL FOR THE OFFICE OF ORAL
HEALTH, YOU KNOW, IT IS IN TBL
THAT IT IS CONTINUOUS BACKFILL.
SO JUST HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE WAY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS INTERPRETING THAT
STATUTE, SO HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN REJECT THAT
PROPOSAL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
STEPHANIE ROBERSON, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION FOR DENTAL
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS, ALIGNING
MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION, ECHOING THOSE
COMMENTS, WE ALL KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO EVEN CONSTRUCTION
COSTS, DEFINITELY IN THE HEALTH
CARE SPACE, THE LONGER WE DELAY,
THE MORE IT COSTS LATER. SO WE
REALLY NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF SAFETY NET
SERVICES FOR THIS MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION, BECAUSE
WE WILL PAY FOR IT LATER. SO
URGING NOT ONLY THE DELAY THAT
WE OPPOSE. I WAS BACK HERE A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, BACK HERE
AGAIN ON THE ELIMINATION. SO WE
URGE OPPOSITION TO THIS. THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. SARAH BRIDGE, ON
BEHALF OF MAXIM HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING SERVICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE A RATE INCREASE FOR
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING IN THIS
BUDGET. WE ARE COGNIZANT OF THE
BUDGET SITUATION. HOWEVER, WE
WERE ONE OF THE FEW PROPOSALS
THAT SAVES WITH A SMALL FRONT
END INVESTMENT $175 MILLION A
YEAR WHILE REMOVING MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN FROM THE
HOSPITAL AND TO BE HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES, WE SINCERELY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIRMAN NORA LIN.
WITH CHILDREN NOW, TWO ISSUES
UNDER DC'S, WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
EVIDENCE BASED AND COMMUNITY
DEFINED PRACTICE GRANTS. GRANTS
THAT ARE VITAL TO SUSTAINING THE
WORK COMMUNITIES ARE DOING TO
TAKE CARE OF YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH. WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO RESTORE THESE CUTS AND
MAINTAIN THE WORK CBOS ARE ABLE
TO DO IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THE PROPOSED CUTS
TO THE YOUTH SUICIDE REPORTING
AND CRISIS RESPONSE PILOT ARE
SHORTSIGHTED, AS WE STILL
STRUGGLE WITH SUICIDALITY AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RECONSIDER THESE
CUTS AND CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD
WITH BEING ABLE TO BETTER TRACK
AND RESPOND TO YOUTH
SUICIDALITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION, ADVOCATES HERE TO
OPPOSE SEVERAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, OPPOSE THE CUTS TO THE
MCO TAX, A HISTORIC INVESTMENT
IN MEDI-CAL. WE'RE LOSING THIS
OPPORTUNITY, ALSO OPPOSED TO THE
CUTS IN THE HEALTH CARE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM, PARTICULARLY
FOR THE CLINICS, WE HAVE
EXISTING 107 CONTRACTS WITH
CLINICS ACROSS THE STATE AND TEN
REGIONAL CONSORTIA. ALSO
OPPOSING THE CUTS TO THE EQUITY
AND PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION
GRANTS. ABOUT 30% OF THE COHORT
ONE WERE HEALTH CENTERS THAT
WERE ALREADY AWARDED GRANTS,
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE MONEY BUT
AWARDED GRANTS, AND ARE RELYING
ON THESE GRANTS, ALSO OPPOSED TO
THE STATE. INDIAN HEALTH CUTS ON
THE HIGH SIDE. JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THE CUTS
FOR THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE,
PARTICULARLY THE SONG BROWN AND
CUTS FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. THANKS, JANICE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, VANESSA KAHINA.
FIRST, ON BEHALF OF COMPROMISO,
THE STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
PROMOTORAS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS, VERY DISAPPOINTED BY
THE CUTS, PROPOSED TO THE HCAI
WORKFORCE GRANTS FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. THIS REPRESENTS
A HISTORIC INVESTMENT TO TRY AND
GET PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
TRADITIONALLY BEEN PART OF OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE TO GET
INTO IT, AND TO DO SO WITH
EQUITY. ALSO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PANETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK, POSED TO A LOT OF
THINGS. WE'VE DONE SO MUCH
BUILDING OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS, AND TO BE HERE NOW IS
VERY DISAPPOINTING. OPPOSED
SPECIFICALLY TO THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS AND TO THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. RYAN SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OB GYNS, THE CALIFORNIA
PODIATRIC MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA RADIOLOGICAL
SOCIETY, AND OCEAN, ALL IN
OPPOSITION AND EXPRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THE DHS PROPOSAL
TO ROLL BACK THE MCO TAX. A
REVENUE THAT WILL BE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES AND FOR OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS. BUT FOR
INTEREST OF TIME, I'D JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT THE REASONS ARE
PREVIOUSLY STATED BY MY FRIENDS
AT CALIFORNIA. THE CPCA FAMILY
PHYSICIANS, AND THE OTHERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND SENATOR ROTH.
BRANDON TATE WITH THE YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH EQUITY COALITION
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CDF'S CHI MENTAL HEALTH,
CHILDREN AND MENTAL HEALTH
CHANGE CAMPAIGN, THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY. THIS
CAMPAIGN EDUCATION CAMPAIGN IS
THE ASPECT OF CHC. MOST FOCUSED
ON PREVENTION. AND WE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE STOP FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION. WE SEE THE PROBLEMS
FOR DECADES TO COME, WE HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS, CBOS ACROSS THE
STATE AND YOUTH ALREADY INVOLVED
IN THIS EFFORT. THERE WERE CUTS
TO A LOT OF ASPECTS OF CIHI. THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM
WAS THE ONLY ONE COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED, WHICH IS NOT IN LINE
WITH THE STATE'S COMMITMENT FOR
EQUITY. I'M PROUD TODAY THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF MEMBERS OF
OUR COALITION HERE, INCLUDING
SOME MEMBERS OF YOUTH, AND THEIR
PARENTS ARE GOING TO YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
THEM. SO I'LL LET YOU HEAR FROM
THEM DIRECTLY. THANK YOU. HELLO,
I'M KARLA, I'M DENIA, AND WE'RE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO, REPRESENTING
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH ADVISORY
BOARD IN WHICH WE SERVE. THIS IS
FOR THE PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
CHANGE CAMPAIGN. AS A TEENAGER,
I KNOW HOW HARD IT CAN BE TO
NAVIGATE THE UPS AND DOWNS OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND LIFE IN GENERAL.
THERE ARE MANY TIMES I FELT
OVERWHELMED AND LOST. BUT THE
TRUTH IS, AS MUCH AS IT COULD
FEEL THIS WAY FOR US, WE'RE NOT
ALONE. WE KNOW THAT FOR US,
HAVING ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES HAS MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE. IT'S HELPED US FIND
OUR WAY. WHEN WE FELT LOST, AND
WHEN WE'VE LEARNED THAT IT'S
OKAY TO ASK FOR HELP. WE KNOW
THAT NOT EVERYONE HAS THE SAME
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT WE DO.
THAT'S WHY YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS ARE SO IMPORTANT. THEY
PROVIDE A SAFE SPACE FOR US TO
OPEN UP, SHARE OUR STRUGGLES,
AND GET THE SUPPORT WE NEED. SO
LET'S PUSH FOR MORE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES. LET'S CREATE A
WORLD WHERE IT'S OKAY TO NOT BE
OKAY, AND WHERE WE CAN SUPPORT
EACH OTHER WITHOUT FEAR OF
JUDGMENT. THANK THANK YOU.
THANKS Y'ALL. HELLO, MY NAME IS
ANGELA JOHNSON, AND THIS IS
REGARDING RELATING TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN.
AS A MOTHER TO TWIN TEENAGE
GIRLS, I SEE FIRSTHAND THE
EFFECTS THAT DAILY STRESS PLAYS
ON THEIR MENTAL HEALTH. MY
DAUGHTERS HAVE BEEN A PART OF
THE BUILDING. BUILDING THIS
CAMPAIGN WITH THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY, AND THEIR AIM HAS
BEEN TO ADDRESS DAILY STRESSORS
TO YOUTH AND HEALTHY WAYS TO
MITIGATE THEM SO THEY DON'T TURN
INTO EVEN BIGGER ISSUES.
REMOVING FUNDING FROM THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL HAVE AN ADVERSE
EFFECT ON OUR COMMUNITY AND ALL
CALIFORNIA TEENS. THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE TO ASK NOT TO REDUCE THE
FUNDING FOR THESE VITAL
PROGRAMS. WE ARE IN A TIME WHERE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOR YOUTH
AND YOUNG ADULTS IS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH, AND REMOVING THE
FUNDING WILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON THE FUTURE OF OUR
GENERATION OF POTENTIAL
CALIFORNIANS TO COME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MY
NAME IS OTTO PACHECO, AND I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR FROM LA MESA,
SAN DIEGO. AND THIS IS RELATING
TO THE PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
CHANGE CAMPAIGN. IN APRIL OF
2022, I WAS TAKEN INTO RADIUS
CHILDREN HOSPITAL AFTER MAKING
AN ATTEMPT ON MY LIFE. AFTER
THIS, I WAS REFERRED OUT TO AN
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM CALLED
KICKSTART, WHICH IS A STATE
FUNDED INTENSIVE CARE PROGRAM
FOR YOUTH WITH PSYCHOSIS. THEY
DEAL WITH BOTH PREVENTATIVE CARE
AND EDUCATION, AND THERAPIES.
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM, I DO NOT
KNOW WHERE I WOULD BE. WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THESE ESSENTIAL LIFE
SAVING PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH ALL
ACROSS THE ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING MYSELF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY WITH US. GOOD
AFTERNOON, KYLIE COSTA. THIS IS
RELATED TO THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN. AS A
SOPHOMORE IN HIGH SCHOOL, A
MEMBER OF THE FFA PROGRAM AND A
STATE DELEGATE FOR OUR FFA
CHAPTER. I AM HONORED TO HERE. I
AM HONORED TO BE REPRESENTING MY
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP AND PEERS. I
STAND BEFORE YOU TO SHED LIGHT
ON A CRITICAL ISSUE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH IS NOT
JUST A BUZZWORD. IT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECT OF OUR
WELL-BEING AND IT AFFECTS US
INDIRECTLY AND DIRECTLY.
TOUCHING THE LIVES OF OUR
CLIENTS, FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
ALIKE. YET DESPITE THE
IMPORTANCE, YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
IS OFTEN STIGMATIZED AND
OVERLOOKED. IT DOES NOT HAVE TO
BE THIS WAY. WE HAVE THE POWER
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE, STARTING
WITH THE PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO US LIKE THE ONES
OFFERED BY THE YOUTH. THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WE CAN PROMOTE MENTAL
WELLNESS AND MENTAL WELLNESS AT
ALL LEVELS OF OUR COMMUNITY. WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND DESTIGMATIZE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THROUGH
FUNDING YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS. AS A LOCAL MEMBER
MEMBER OF OUR JUNIOR FAIR BOARD,
I HAVE BEEN I HAVE SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE IMPORTANCE THAT A
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY CAN HAVE ON
AN INDIVIDUAL STRUGGLING ON
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES. BY
COMING TOGETHER, WE CAN CREATE A
NETWORK OF SUPPORT THAT EXTENDS
FAR BEYOND JUST OUR SCHOOL
WALLS, REACHING EVERY CORNER OF
OUR COMMUNITY. SO LET'S MAKE A
COMMITMENT TODAY TO PRIORITIZE
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH, TO SUPPORT
ONE ANOTHER, AND TO ENSURE THAT
NO ONE SUFFERS IN SILENCE.
TOGETHER, WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
THERESA KENNEDY AND I HAVE A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO THE MENTAL
WELL-BEING OF OUR YOUTH. DRAWING
FROM MY OWN JOURNEY, NAVIGATING
FAMILY RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES, I BELIEVE URGENT
ACTION IS NEEDED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
VÀ I HAVE JOINED THE ADVISORY
BOARD OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY, PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
CHANGE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE AS A
PARENT INVOLVED IN HOME
SCHOOLING AND STATEWIDE
EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVES, I HAVE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLES OUR
YOUTH FACE. BEING A CAREGIVER TO
A TEENAGER, I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF INITIATIVES LIKE
THIS. IT IS VITAL TO EQUIP OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH TOOLS TO
SAFEGUARD THEIR MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT IS WHY CAMPAIGNS, THOSE
CAMPAIGNS LED BY THOSE OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY, ARE
INDISPENSABLE. I IMPLORE THE
SENATE TO NOT CUT FUNDING FOR
THIS ESSENTIAL INITIATIVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS TIFFANY. THIS IS TO THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND CHANGE
CAMPAIGN. STUDIES SHOW 1 IN 6
YOUTH BETWEEN AGES SIX AND 17
SUFFER FROM A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER. I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
MY SON, WHO IS 14 YEARS OLD, WHO
IS AT SCHOOL TODAY, WHO HAS
SUFFERED FROM BULLYING PRESSURES
AND INFLUENCE OF SOCIAL MEDIA,
CHANGES WITH PUBERTY AND MAJOR
LIFE CHANGES. HE IS A DIRECT
BENEFICIARY OF THESE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN AND OUT OF
THE SCHOOL AND IT HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN OUR
LIVES. OUR STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
AS THERE ARE A LOT OF YOUTH WITH
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES. HIS
ASKING TO NOT REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THE FUNDING OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO THAT OUR YOUTH HAVE
A FIGHTING CHANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY. HELLO, MY
NAME IS SONIA SCOTT. THIS IS
RELATED TO THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN. I'M A
STUDENT STUDYING PSYCHOLOGY AT
SAN JOSE STATE, AND MENTAL
HEALTH IS SOMETHING THAT'S
GREATLY EMPHASIZED WITHIN MY
MAJOR IN SCHOOL, THE
CONVERSATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
HAS STARTED BECOMING MORE OF A
CONVERSATION, AND MORE PEOPLE
ARE TAKING IT SERIOUSLY AND
TAKING THE PRECAUTION. I'VE SEEN
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES NOT BEING
TREATED WITHIN MANY ASPECTS OF
MY LIFE, AND I'VE SEEN HOW IT
CAN ESCALATE IN ONE'S LIFE. I'VE
PERSONALLY USED MANY MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES WITHIN MY
SCHOOLS, AND I CAN IMAGINE THIS
BEING DEFUNDED AND LOWERING THE
ABILITIES OF ME AND OTHER
STUDENTS TO OBTAIN THE SUPPORT.
PLEASE RECONSIDER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THIS IS
RELATED TO THE CDF, CB, PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN.
MY NAME IS ERIN SHAW AND I'M A
HEALTH BEHAVIOR RESEARCHER FOR
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CAMPAIGN.
THROUGH THE EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
WE'VE DONE FOR THE FORMULATION
OF THIS CAMPAIGN, WE'VE LEARNED
THAT THE AREA WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON MOST IS GIVING YOUTH THE
TOOLS TO MANAGE THEIR DAILY
STRESS IN HEALTHY WAYS. THIS
CAMPAIGN IS FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION, AND ENSURES THAT
THIS DAILY STRESS DOESN'T BECOME
AN EVEN BIGGER ISSUE IF LEFT
UNTREATED. BY STOPPING THE
FUNDING FOR THIS WORK, WE ARE
ALMOST GUARANTEEING AN EVEN
BIGGER MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOR
CALIFORNIA YOUTH, WHICH ARE
ALREADY IN DIRE NEED OF
ASSISTANCE. CONTINUING TO
ADVANCE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT MENTAL
HEALTH WILL ALLOW US TO PREVENT
POSSIBLE HEALTH IMPLICATIONS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
UNMANAGED AND CONTINUOUS
EXPOSURE TO STRESS, INCLUDING
PHYSICAL, PSYCHOLOGICAL, AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES. TEENS
TODAY NEED HELP TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RELATED TO BEING
JUDGED, DISMISSED, OR EVEN BEING
A BURDEN TO OTHERS WHEN REACHING
OUT. THEY REQUIRE SPACE TO
PROCESS THEIR EMOTIONS, TO
DECIDE WHAT APPROPRIATE ACTION
TO TAKE AND RELEVANT INFORMATION
THAT CAN HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
THEIR FEELINGS. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON, KATIE LAYTON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION HERE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED SWEEPS OF THE MCO TAX
DOLLARS, LOW MEDI-CAL RATES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO A SEVERE
PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND AS A
RESULT, CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
COMPLEX CONDITIONS ARE OFTEN
WAITING MONTHS FOR AN
APPOINTMENT. URGENT. LAST YEAR,
A COMPREHENSIVE REPORT WAS
PUBLISHED BY THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE AND A KEY
RECOMMENDATION OF THIS EXPERT
ANALYSIS WAS THAT RATE PARITY AT
OR ABOVE MEDICARE FOR ALL
PEDIATRIC PHYSICIAN CODES IS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE ACUTE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGES. THE
TARGETED RATE INCREASES MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE MCO TAX WOULD
BRING US CLOSER TO THIS GOAL.
AND SO WE DO URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SWEEP OF
THESE CRITICAL FUNDS. AND THEN
JUST QUICKLY, ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FOR THE
SPECIALTY DENTAL CLINICS. THIS
IS ANOTHER AREA OF VERY HIGH
NEED, WITH NOT ENOUGH CLINICS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY CARE.
HELLO, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
EMILY MCCLINTOCK AND I'M WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE, A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS AND BUILDS THE CAPACITY
OF COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF
MAINTAINING CRITICAL FUNDING FOR
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE. I
WANT TO ECHO THE WORDS OF THE
YOUTH AND PARENTS WHO HAVE COME
UP HERE AND ADVOCATED TODAY AS
PART OF THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
CHANGE CAMPAIGN, 28 COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SELECTED TO RECEIVE THESE
GRANT DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT LOCAL
LEVEL, YOUTH LED PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, AND THESE FUNDS ARE
NOW ELIMINATED. THROUGH THIS
PROPOSAL, OUR FY TEAM HAS
ALREADY PUT IN HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF HOURS TO LAUNCH THE
LOCAL LEVEL CAMPAIGN, AND CBOS
HAVE BEEN HIRING TRAINING STAFF,
FIND WORK PLANS, ASSEMBLING
YOUTH ADVISORY GROUPS AND
PROGRESSING ON TRACK. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
PROJECT IS ALREADY IN MOTION.
WORKING WITH YOUTH, PARENTS,
CAREGIVERS AND COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ADDRESS MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WITH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR ROTH. CHLOE STUCK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. WE WANT TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH BACK ON
PROPOSED CUTS THAT UNFAIRLY
TARGET IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING THE PROPOSAL TO CUT
IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED. THE
PROPOSAL UNDERMINES THE HEALTH
FOR ALL PROGRAM BY SPECIFICALLY
ROLLING BACK EXISTING SERVICES
FOR THIS POPULATION. IHSS IS
ESSENTIAL CARE THAT ALLOWS
THOUSANDS OF SENIORS AND
PERSONS. BUT WE'RE NOT. WE
HAVEN'T DISCUSSED THAT ISSUE
YET. PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THAT
WILL WILL COME AFTER SOUNDS
GOOD. I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
REGARDING THE BORROWING FROM THE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE FUNDING. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TAISHA WATTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS HERE TO OPPOSE
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE BUDGET
CUTS ON THE MAY REVISION, THE
MAY REVISION IS ATTACK ON
PRIMARY CARE, WHICH IS
HISTORICALLY BEEN UNDERFUNDED.
THE MCO TAC SPECIFICALLY WAS A
MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PROVIDER, OUR PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS, WERE RECEIVING
ADEQUATE RATE INCREASES, AND BY
ELIMINATING THAT BUDGET
ALLOCATION IN 2025, WE'RE GOING
TO SEE AN INCREASE OF THE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
AND ADDITIONALLY, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN UP OUR
PRIMARY CARE WORKFORCE, WHICH IS
MY SECOND POINT TO THE HCAI
SLASHING $10 MILLION FROM THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM. THE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THE SONG FOR THE
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ARE CAPPED. SO OUR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA MAINLY
SOLELY RELY ON THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM. SO PLEASE RECONSIDER
WHEN YOU'RE CUTTING THAT FUNDING
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
DETRIMENTAL AMOUNT OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO HAVE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS OUR MEDI-CAL POPULATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AMY WESTLING FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES. WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE SPECIALTY
DENTAL CLINIC PROGRAM, BECAUSE
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
SPECIALTY CARE TO POPULATIONS
WHO FIND DENTAL CARE VERY HARD
TO ACCESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS KOBE
PEZZATI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS. WE REPRESENT
ROUGHLY 3000 PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS WORKING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
WE ARE THE LARGEST DIRECT LEVEL
OF CARE PROVIDERS TO THE
PATIENTS IN THAT SYSTEM.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE SUFFER FROM
AROUND A 30% VACANCY RATE. AND
WITH THE PROPOSED WIPING OF
VACANT POSITIONS, THE GOVERNOR
IS NOW EFFECTIVELY LOCKING IN
THE OUTSOURCING OF STATE JOBS
AND THAT IS CURRENTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING. A PSYCH TECH MAKES
ABOUT $38 PER HOUR. AN
OUTSOURCED PSYCH TECH MAKES
ABOUT $55 PER HOUR, PLUS $900 A
WEEK TRAVEL PER DIEM PLUS
BENEFITS. SO SO AS YOU CAN SEE,
IT IS KIND OF A WASTE OF MONEY
TO BE LOCKING IN THAT. SO WE'RE
ASKING, YOU MEAN IN IN REMOVING
THE 10,000 VACANT POSITIONS? WE
ARE NOW GOING TO OUTSOURCE WAY
MORE. WAY MORE. WELL, YOU
CURRENTLY ALREADY ARE
OUTSOURCING TO FILL BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A LICENSED FACILITY THAT
HAS TO MEET MINIMUMS, RIGHT. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT, YOU HAVE TO
OUTSOURCE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
JOBS. YOU'RE EVEN IF WE REMOVE
THE VACANT SPOTS, WE STILL HAVE
TO MEET, RIGHT? SOME RATIO.
THAT'S RIGHT. THE ISSUE NOW IS
NOBODY IS GOING TO COME WORK FOR
THE STATE. THEY'RE GOING TO GO
WORK FOR THE UMMAH. THE
OUTSOURCING AGENCIES BECAUSE
IT'S JUST A BETTER DEAL. YOU GET
BETTER MONEY FOR IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI, KELLY. AFTERNOON,
KELLY LARUE WITH RESILIENT
ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF OF TWO
CLIENTS, THE FIRST BEING THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION. WHILE WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE SWEEP OF
THE 2025, TRY MCO RATE PACKAGE,
YOU KNOW, WE UNDERSTAND THERE
WILL BE DIFFICULT DECISIONS MADE
OVER THE COMING WEEKS. WE ARE
HOPEFUL AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE CAN BE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE 2024
PACKAGE, AND WE'RE ALREADY
BILLING SOME OF THOSE CODES, BUT
WE'RE NOT INCLUDED AS ONE OF THE
ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS. SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, PINKEYE IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE COULD BE GETTING
AN INCREASED REIMBURSEMENT RATE
ON. THE SECOND IS THE AIR
AMBULANCE COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, THERE WAS A SPECIAL
FUND AND A FEE ON MOVING
VIOLATIONS THAT WAS ENDED SO
THAT FUND THAT FUNDED AUGMENTED
RATES FOR THOSE TRANSPORTS IS NO
LONGER ABLE TO BE PAID. SO THE
COST BEING REIMBURSED IS ABOUT
20% OF THE COST OF AN AIRLIFT
FOR A MEDI-CAL ENROLLEE. AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT FUND CAN
BE SUPPORTED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR ROTH,
RAND MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF AVIANA
HEALTH CARE, MADAM CHAIR, YOU
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD EARLIER
WHEN YOU RESPONDED RELATIVE TO
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING IN THE IN
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE $150
MILLION INCREASE FOR THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS, $175
MILLION THAT WE WOULD SAVE
REPRESENTS MORE THAN 10% OF THAT
$150 MILLION. THAT'S NOW GOING
TO CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. THEY
NEED IT. BUT WE CAN TAKE A LOT
OF THAT BURDEN OFF OF THEM. IF
THEY WOULD PUT MORE KIDS INTO
THE INTO THE COMMUNITY, INTO
THEIR HOMES. AND BOTTOM LINE IS,
IT'S UTTERLY PERPLEXING WHEN YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
KIDS AND SAVE THE STATE MONEY
THAT WE ARE MET WITH STONY
SILENCE OUTSIDE OF THIS ROOM, TO
BE PERFECTLY HONEST. AND WE HOPE
THAT OTHER PEOPLE ARE HEARING
THIS AND WE'LL DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SEEING NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE HEALTH PORTION OF
THIS COMMITTEE, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A TEN MINUTE RECESS STRETCH
OUR LITTLE LEGS, AND THEN COME
BACK FOR THE FUN PART.
ALL RIGHT. FOR THOSE WHO WERE
HERE FOR THE FIRST PART. UPDATE.
I DID REALLY GOOD IN A PROBES.
SO GOOD NEWS. I COULDN'T WAIT
THE WHOLE TIME. I WENT UP TO
FIND OUT BECAUSE I WAS GETTING A
LOT OF TEXTS. THEY DID NOT
LISTEN TO ME SAYING, DON'T TEXT
ME ABOUT IT. ALL RIGHT? ENTERING
THE MORE SERIOUS TONE, THE NEXT
PART NOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IS,
DEPARTMENTS ON THE HUMAN
SERVICES SIDE AND I WANTED TO
START OFF WITH SOME THINGS HERE
THAT, A COUPLE OF PEOPLE, HAVE
SAID IS THAT THERE ARE NO CUTS
TO CORE SERVICES. WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, IF SOMEONE TELLS ME
THAT ONE MORE TIME BECAUSE THERE
ARE AND IF YOU INDULGE ME ON,
YOU DON'T HAVE ANOTHER CHOICE.
BUT I'M GOING TO READ YOU SOME
DEFINITIONS I FOUND ON GOOGLE OF
WHAT A CORE SERVICE IS, AN
ACTIVITY THAT PROVIDES
MEASURABLE VALUE TO INDIVIDUALS,
BENEFITS RECEIVED, SERVICES
DELIVERED TO INDIVIDUALS.
SERVICES THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SERVICES ARE A FUNDAMENTAL TO
MEET CORE COMMUNITY. ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. AND SO ON AND SO ON
ARE SERVICES TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN. YOUTH WHO ARE
IMMINENT RISK OF THE ENTIRE
ALPHABET. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
OVER AND WHEN NUMBERS STOOD OUT
TO ME THE MOST IS 28 CUTS IN
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
28. AND I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF OTHER DEPARTMENTS
HAVE THAT LONG OF LIST OF CUTS
AS WELL. 15 CUTS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT,
12 CUTS TO HEALTH CARE
BEHAVIORAL WORKFORCE THAT WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT. THESE ARE
SUCH DEEP CUTS TO OUR PROGRAMS
THAT IN THE FIRST HALF I EVEN
TALKED ABOUT LIKE, WE'RE EVEN
CUTTING 2 MILLION. LIKE THAT'S
WE'RE GOING IN SO DEEP THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT SMALL OF A,
OF A PROGRAM TO CUT RESPECTFULLY
ASKING EVERYBODY THAT'S COMING
UP HERE, LET'S IN CASE YOU HAVE
NEVER BEEN ON CALFRESH, IN CASE
YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN ON CALWORKS,
IN CASE YOU HAVE NEVER HAD A
COUCH SURF, RESPECTFULLY ASKING,
DON'T COME UP HERE AND
DISRESPECT CALIFORNIANS AND SAY,
WE ARE NOT CUTTING CORE SERVICES
BECAUSE THIS COULD BE A CORE
SERVICE TO SOMEBODY. THAT MAY
NOT BE FOR ME OR FOR YOU. TAKING
AWAY $10 FROM CALFRESH, AS WE'LL
SEE LATER DOWN THE ROAD, MAY NOT
MEAN NOTHING TO US, BUT COULD
MEAN SO MUCH TO A CALIFORNIAN.
THAT IS MY ASK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THE NEXT 5 TO 6.
WHATEVER HOURS ON THIS IS THAT
WE ARE VERY SENSITIVE IN THE
WORDS THAT WE USE AND HOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT THESE CUTS. AND I
KNOW A LOT OF US ARE, BUT PLEASE
DON'T SAY THESE AREN'T CORE
SERVICES. THAT IS MY BOTTOM LINE
. ASK AS WE MOVE INTO THIS. OKAY
SO LET'S BEGIN. WE'RE GOING TO
START FIRST, STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IS
.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AARON
CARRUTHERS, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES,
JOINED TODAY BY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR KEN DEROSA. WE HAVE
FOUR PROPOSALS FOR YOU. WELL
FIRST OF ALL, CONGRATULATIONS ON
DOING WELL IN SUSPENSE. IT
MATTERS, ON A PERSONAL NOTE, AS
A FORMERLY HOMELESS YOUTH, THANK
YOU FOR THE DEFENSE OF CORE
SERVICES YOU JUST GAVE, REALLY
TOUCHING. THANK YOU, OUR
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU, THERE ARE
FOUR OF THEM. THEY'RE LARGELY
TECHNICAL, SOMEWHAT SIMILAR, AND
HAVE NO IMPACT ON THE STATE.
STATE FUNDS. SO I COULD PRESENT
THEM IN A STREAMLINED FASHION,
OR I CAN GO ONE BY ONE,
WHICHEVER YOUR PREFERENCE IS, DO
ALL FOUR. I KNOW THE FIRST TWO
FOR SURE HAVE NO IMPACT ON
GENERAL FUND. THE SECOND TWO
ALSO THE OTHER. CORRECT? OKAY
REALLY QUICK. YES, MA'AM. THE
FIRST REQUEST IS TO GET
INCREASED FEDERAL FUNDING
AUTHORITY TO CREATE A SUPPORT
SERVICES ASSISTANT. THIS IS A
POSITION IN STATE SERVICE THAT
FUNCTIONS TO SUPPORT OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES. TO SUCCEED IN
THEIR WORK. THEY PROVIDE
REASONABLE, NECESSARY SUPPORTS
TO SUCCEED IN THEIR PROFESSION
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH AND
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH
FEDERAL DOLLARS THROUGH A
FEDERAL GRANT. THE SECOND ONE ON
THE LIST IS THE STATE COUNCILS
REQUESTING INCREASED
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY AND ONE
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING TO CONDUCT THE
STATEWIDE SELF-DETERMINATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THE THIRD
REQUEST IS AN INCREASE IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY AND TWO
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE THE
ORIENTATIONS AND TRAININGS
RELATED TO THE
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM THAT
WE PROVIDE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND LAST
IS A REAPPROPRIATION AMOUNT OF
$365,000 IN AUTHORITY TO SPEND
FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVED AS A
GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION TO PROVIDE
ABOUT 5000 EMERGENCY GO KITS
THAT WE PROVIDE TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES WHEN WE DO
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS TRAININGS
. OKAY ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. THANK YOU. WE'RE ON TO
CDA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
SENATOR ROTH AND COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS. I'M SUSAN DMORRIS,
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
WALK THROUGH OUR BCP'S THAT,
PLEASE? OKAY WE'RE PLEASED THAT
THE ITEMS THAT ARE IN YOUR
AGENDA DO NOT HAVE ANY GENERAL
FUND IMPACTS, THAT WE ARE
INCREASING OUR AUTHORITY, OUR
POSITION, AUTHORITY FOR THE MSSP
PROGRAM, AND WE ARE, EXPANDING
OUR AUTHORITY AROUND THE
CALFRESH PROGRAM, A PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. ARE WE
SKIPPING ISSUE ONE AND GOING
INTO ISSUE TWO? THE BUDGET
SOLUTIONS FIRST. Þ. OKAY. THAT'S
THANK YOU. THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I
WANT TO START. OKAY. PLEASE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE MAY
REVISION CUTS TO CDA PROGRAMS,
I, WE HAVE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET, THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES TWO PROPOSED
CUTS, BOTH OF THESE ARE ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
SPENT. THE FIRST IS A TOTAL
REDUCTION OF $111 MILLION IN THE
MODERNIZING THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT. WE REFER TO
THAT AS MOD OCA, AND THE SECOND
IS $35.4 MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS FOR THE OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE, SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO PROPOSED CUTS
TO OUR DEPARTMENT, ON THE
ELIMINATION OF SENIOR NUTRITION
AND OTHER SENIOR SERVICES. ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE MEALS
ON WHEELS PROGRAMS? YES YES. SO
IN IN THE SECOND QUESTION WHERE
WE'RE ASKED ABOUT THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION FUNDING FOR THE,
FUNDING FOR OLDER ADULT
NUTRITION IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE SUPPORTED. BASE
FUNDING AT THE LEVEL OF $166
MILLION IN COMBINED OLDER
AMERICANS ACT AND STATE GENERAL
FUND. THE PROPOSED CUT OF THE
MOD OCA IS $37.2 MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS, AND THAT IS EXPRESSLY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF SENIOR NUTRITION,
SO THAT COULD INCLUDE CONGREGATE
MEALS IN A SENIOR CENTER. IT
COULD INCLUDE HOME DELIVERED
MEALS THROUGH MEALS ON WHEELS.
SO WE'LL HAVE 166 MILLION
ONGOING THROUGH THESE OTHER,
AVENUES REVENUES. YES. TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THIS, DO WE SEE
A PROGRAM IMPACT IN THIS? ARE WE
GOING TO WITH JUST THAT, OUTSIDE
FUNDING, SEE A DECREASED AMOUNT
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN GET THESE
MEALS? OR ARE PEOPLE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE TOLD THAT THEY CAN NO
LONGER RECEIVE THE SERVICE?
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE IN A POSITION
OF FLEX BECAUSE WE HAVE NEVER
HAD MORE, FEDERAL DOLLARS
INVESTED IN SENIOR NUTRITION
COMING OFF OF THE COVID
PANDEMIC. THOSE DOLLARS EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. SO THE
COMBINATION OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS EXPIRING AND THIS
PROPOSED CUT, OUR AREA AGENCY ON
AGING PARTNERS WILL HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS LOCALLY ABOUT HOW THEY
, ALLOCATE THEIR REMAINING
DOLLARS, WHETHER THEY LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF MEALS PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS SO THEY CAN SERVE
MORE PEOPLE, OR THEY FOCUS MORE
INTENSELY ON A, ON A SMALLER,
SUBPOPULATION. A COUPLE OF
THINGS CAME TO MIND WITH THIS.
AS YOU KNOW, YOU COMPILE THE,
YOU COMPILE THE DIFFERENT CUTS
ON A CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHIC. SO I
THOUGHT ABOUT TWO THINGS. TWO
THINGS. THE FOOD BANKS HAVE COME
IN HERE A COUPLE OF TIMES, WE'RE
ON. LET ME SEE IF I GET THIS
RIGHT. LIKE NOT BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE AT CAPACITY. AND THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WRAPPED AROUND
FOR FOOD, FOR FOOD AND THE
INCREASE OF SENIORS AT THESE
FOOD BANKS. SO IF WE'RE NOT
HELPING FUND THAT, I'M LIKE,
OKAY, THAT'S FINE. WE HAVE MAYBE
SENIOR MEALS IF WE'RE NOT
HELPING CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THAT. I THOUGHT ABOUT, A HUGE
WIN I GOT LAST YEAR FOR
CALFRESH. THE INCREASE TO $50
MILLION TO 50. I WISH TO $50 A
MONTH BECAUSE MY FOCUS WAS ON
SENIORS. BUT THAT'S ALSO BEING
CUT. I'M WONDERING WITH THESE
ADDED CUTS TO POTENTIALLY SENIOR
MEALS, IS THERE ANYTHING OTHER
PROGRAM THAT YOU KNOW EXISTS
THAT CAN SUPPLEMENT THE WORK
THAT THIS FUNDING WAS DOING? SO
LEAPING AHEAD TO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING, WHICH IS A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH. SO WE DO
HAVE SORT OF THE LEVERS THAT WE
HAVE FOR OLDER CALIFORNIANS. WE
HAVE FOOD BANKS, AS YOU NOTED.
WE HAVE THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT.
WE HAVE THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS
ACT, WE HAVE CALFRESH, AND WE
ALSO HAVE CALAIM MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS THROUGH THE ONE
OF THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
OFFERED THROUGH CALAIM. AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST USED I
HEARD IN CAL AIM. YES OKAY, SO I
WILL SAY YES TO COUNT YET
COUNTING, BUT I DON'T KNOW
CALFRESH BECAUSE THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE MAKING ONLY
GETTING $23 A MONTH, RIGHT?
THAT'S NOWHERE NEAR WHAT THEY
WHAT THEY NEED. BUT CAL-AIM
COULD BE COULD SUPPLEMENT THIS,
ARE WE PROVIDING SOME TO OUR
TRIPLE A'S JUST TO SAY, HEY,
JUST GET THEM CONNECTED, TO CAL
AIM SO WE CAN DO MEALS THAT WAY?
YES, ABSOLUTELY. AND THAT'S A
KEY ROLE THAT OUR AND WE'RE
CONSULTING WITH OUR TRIPLE A
PARTNERS ABOUT EXTENDING ANY
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WE CAN AFFORD
TO THEM THROUGH THEIR THROUGH
THEIR EXISTING CONTRACTS AND
EXISTING DOLLARS SO THAT THEY
CAN MAXIMIZE THEIR, THEIR SENIOR
NUTRITION FUNDING, BUT ALSO
THAT'S A KEY PART OF THE
INFORMATION ASSISTANCE AND
REFERRAL THAT OUR TRIPLE A
PARTNERS PROVIDE STATEWIDE IS TO
CONNECT INDIVIDUALS TO ALL OF
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR. OKAY. AND THEN THE
SAME QUESTION I'VE BEEN ASKING
SINCE THE BEGINNING TODAY IS, IS
WHY FOR THREE YEARS, IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO BALANCE TWO, SOMEONE
HAS A DIFFERENT ANSWER. MEGAN
ZUBIATE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
IF I COULD JUST QUICKLY NOTE,
FIRST ON THE NUTRITION ITEM JUST
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S AWARENESS,
AND I'M NOT AT ALL TRYING TO
MAKE LIGHT OF OR OF THIS CUT,
OR. EXCUSE ME, THIS PROPOSED
SOLUTION. I DO WANT TO QUICKLY
NOTE THAT THE MAY REVISION IS
NOT PROPOSED TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE 52.5 MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDS FOR NUTRITION THAT
WERE INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
2021 BUDGET ACT. IT IS PROPOSING
TO REDUCE THESE ONE TIME FUNDS
AND THEN TO GET TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WHY WE'RE SOLVING FOR OUT
YEARS, SO WHILE WHILE WE ARE
MAKING REDUCTIONS FOR BUDGET
YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR ONE, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE PROBLEMS
AREN'T GOING TO GO AWAY. THIS IS
PROBABLY NOT A 1 OR 2 YEAR
ISSUE. THESE SHORTFALLS, SO THE
GOAL HERE AND PART OF THE GOAL
OF THE BROADER STRUCTURE OF THE
MAY REVISION IS REALLY TO SET UP
THE STATE ON A STRONGER FOOTING.
SO THAT WE HAVE A MORE FISCALLY
SOUND STRUCTURE MOVING FORWARD.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SEEING
SOME SOME SOLUTIONS AND PASSED
BY ONE, WHY CAN WE COME BACK TO
THE TABLE NEXT YEAR TO SAY,
OKAY, NOW WE DO NEED A I'M, I'M
VERY SORRY. I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU. NO, NO, NO, THAT
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD,
THIS IS WHAT THE MAY REVISION IS
PROPOSING. AND, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
THESE ARE PROPOSALS. OKAY. AND,
MADAM CHAIR, JUST MARK BECKLEY,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING,
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR, I JUST
WANT TO ADD SOME ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HELPING,
PROVIDING OUR TRIPLE A'S, THERE
IS IN THE CURRENT YEAR, $68
MILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
MODERNIZATION FUNDS, 15 MILLION
IS SPECIFICALLY FOR NUTRITION.
THAT FUNDING WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO THEM THROUGH MARCH 2026. SO
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO DRAW UPON
THOSE. THERE'S ALSO A SECOND
ALLOCATION OF 51 MILLION THAT'S
INTENDED FOR OTHER COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS FOR THE TRIPLE A'S.
WE'RE LOOKING TO ACTUALLY FLEX
THAT FUNDING TO ALLOW THAT TO BE
USED FOR NUTRITION AS WELL, SO
THAT THE TRIPLE A'S WILL HAVE AN
OPTION. THEY CAN DECIDE BASED ON
THEIR OWN PRIORITIES, WHETHER TO
USE THAT FOR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
OR IF THEY HAVE MEAL GAPS TO USE
IT FOR NUTRITION AS WELL. OKAY,
SO I HEARD 166 MILLION FROM LIKE
FEDERAL ALL REMAINING COVID
FUNDS, 15 MILLION UNTIL A COUPLE
FOR A COUPLE MORE YEARS RIGHT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. YEAH WHICH IS
AVAILABLE UNTIL MARCH 2026. AND
THEN 52.5 OR MEGAN, RIGHT? NO,
NOT MEGAN. I INCLUDED THAT IN
THE TOTAL ALREADY INCLUDED. THE
166 INCLUDES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE STATE AND FEDERAL COMBINED.
SO DO YOU FEEL THAT THESE KIND
OF SERVICES CAN STILL CONTINUE
IN PROVIDING A GOOD AMOUNT OF
MEALS FOR A GOOD AMOUNT OF
SENIORS? YES, AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR TRIPLE
A PARTNERS. THEY THEIR
RESILIENCY AND INNOVATION AND
CREATIVITY IS REMARKABLE.
THEY'VE SEEN FLUCTUATIONS GAINS
OVER THE YEARS WITH NUTRITION
FUNDING. SO, WHETHER IT'S MORE
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. SO THEY
HAVE ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND MORE
EFFICIENCY. IF THEY PARTNER WITH
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY
LOOK AT HOW TO REDUCE THEIR
NUTRITION COSTS, AND, YOU KNOW,
SOMETHING THAT I WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR ALSO IS WE INVESTED $40
MILLION IN NUTRITION
INFRASTRUCTURE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. SO MANY OF OUR
PROVIDERS HAVE PURCHASED NEW
REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS, NEW
TRUCKS AND THINGS THAT HELP THEM
REACH THEIR POPULATION MORE
EASILY AND TO SERVE, MORE A
LARGER POPULATION MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. OKAY. THANK YOU.
AND I JUST WANT TO BECAUSE THE
WORD ELIMINATION IS WHAT I'M
GETTING STUCK ON. BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S NOT ELIMINATING LIKE
THESE SERVICES AREN'T COMPLETELY
GETTING ELIMINATED. CORRECT?
YES. THIS WAS AN INTENDED
AUGMENTATION THAT HAS NOT YET
BEEN PROVIDED TO THE NETWORK. SO
THESE ARE NOT FUNDS YET THAT
ANYONE HAS COME TO RELY UPON.
OKAY. I GUESS THAT'S WHERE I GOT
STUCK. THIS WILL STILL CONTINUE.
WE'RE JUST ELIMINATING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. YES. THE
AUGMENTATION. OKAY ON THE, OLDER
ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAM
CAN. WHAT HAVE WE SPENT HERE? SO
ON ON THAT INITIATIVE, THE THREE
YEAR INITIATIVE, THE TOTAL
FUNDING WAS $50 MILLION, IN THE
IN THE FIRST YEAR, WE HAVE SPENT
FOUR, $14 MILLION ON ON
EXTENDING THE CONTRACT FOR THE
FRIENDSHIP LINE, FOR THREE
YEARS. SO THAT'S IN PLACE. AND
WE HAD NO DISRUPTION OF SERVICE
THERE. AND WE'RE VERY, VERY
PLEASED WITH THAT COMING OFF OF
THE COVID CONTRACT. AND WE'VE
ALSO EXTENDED A CONTRACT FOR AN
ETHNIC MEDIA CAMPAIGN THAT WAS
THE SECOND PRONG OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
THE THIRD PIECE OF IT WAS
INTENDED FOR COMMUNITY CAPACITY
BUILDING GRANTS. THAT IS THE
PIECE THAT WE THAT IS PROPOSED
FOR ELIMINATION, THAT TOTALS
ROUGHLY $30 MILLION. IN
ADDITION, OUR STATE OPERATIONS
OF CLOSE TO $5 MILLION, ARE
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION. SO,
GENERALLY SPEAKING, $15 MILLION
HAS BEEN SPENT OR CONTRACTED AND
$35 MILLION REMAINS. AND THOSE
ARE THE DOLLARS THAT ARE SLATED
FOR. AND IT'S MOSTLY ON THE
CAPACITY GRANTS ENTIRELY. THE
MEDIA CAMPAIGN ALREADY KICKED
OFF. IT'S UNDERWAY. IT IS UNDER
CONTRACT AND IN PROGRESS. OKAY
OKAY, SENATOR, I'M JUST CURIOUS.
YOU KNOW, THE I AM, I ASSUME,
AMONG OUR SENIOR POPULATION,
SOME, IF NOT MANY, ARE PLACE
BOUND AND DEPEND ON MEALS TO BE
PROVIDED TO THEM. DO WE HAVE ANY
IDEA? WHAT PERCENTAGE WE CAPTURE
IN TERMS OF THE SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED THROUGH THIS SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM? ARE WE HOW
MANY DO WE LEAVE ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD, SO TO SPEAK? I CAN
TELL YOU THAT LAST YEAR WE
SERVED 325,000 OLDER ADULTS
THROUGH OUR NUTRITION PROGRAMS,
ONE OF THE ADVANTAGES OF THE
STATE CHEN GENERAL FUND, THE $60
MILLION, IS WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO OUR PROGRAMS THAN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALLOWS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REALLY
FAVORS CONGREGATE SETTINGS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO TRAVEL TO AND
VISIT, WE CAN AFFORD MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR HOME DELIVERED
MEALS, GRAB AND GO MEALS, AND SO
THAT IT'S A GOOD COMBINATION TO
WORK WITH THE OLDER AMERICANS
ACT AND THE STATE GENERAL FUND.
AND WHEN WE WHEN WE APPROVED,
SOMEONE PROPOSED AND WE
APPROVED, I ASSUME THIS
AUGMENTATION THAT'S BEING
ELIMINATED. WHAT WAS THE PLAN
FOR THAT? WHAT WAS THERE? WERE
THERE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL SENIORS YOU WERE
GOING WE WERE GOING TO TOUCH
SERVE. I JUST I'M TRYING TO GET
AN IDEA. AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
MY CHAIR WAS GETTING AT. WHAT
WHAT ARE WE WHAT ARE WE DOING
WHEN WE DO THIS REDUCTION AND
WHO ARE WE DOING IT TO THE IT
INITIALLY IT WAS A STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND THE RATIONALE BEHIND,
EXTENDING THE FUNDING FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS WAS IN
ANTICIPATION OF THESE FEDERAL
DOLLARS ENDING THAT THIS, MODERN
MOD OCA FUNDING WOULD STEP IN
WHEN THE FEDERAL COVID DOLLARS
ENDED. THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
ANTICIPATING. THE WAY THAT THE
AREA AGENCY ON AGING ARE
ORGANIZED. AND, SENATOR ROTH,
YOU'RE CARRYING A BILL THAT
LOOKS TO PROPOSE, CORE PROGRAMS
AND PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE LOCALS TO
DETERMINE COMMUNITY NEEDS. SO
NOT EVERY TRIPLE A FUNCTIONS IN
THE SAME WAY, SO WE DON'T HAVE A
TARGET IN TERMS OF A NUMBER OF
POPULATION TO BE SERVED. BUT
EVERY TRIPLE A SHARES IN COMMON,
A TARGET POPULATION OF PEOPLE
WITH THE GREATEST SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC NEED. BUT THE FEDERAL
MONEY'S GONE AWAY. THE FEDERAL
COVID MONEY HAS GONE AWAY. BUT
WE STILL HAVE OVER $100 MILLION
IN BASE FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS
ACT MONEY FOR NUTRITION. BUT THE
BUT THE IF I UNDERSTAND IT, THE
AUGMENTATION WAS TO REPLACE THE
FEDERAL MONEY AND ANTICIPATION
OF IT GOING AWAY. THAT'S RIGHT.
TO REPLACE THE FEDERAL COVID
DOLLARS. THERE'S A LOSS OF
SOMETHING SOMEWHERE IN THERE,
RIGHT? YEAH. WE'RE JUST WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE TRIPLE A'S CAN
BE INNOVATIVE AND CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT THEY DO WITH LESS. RIGHT.
AND OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS,
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT, WE'VE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS, 52.5
MILLION FROM THE LEGISLATURE,
TOWARDS OLDER ADULT NUTRITION
BASED PROGRAMS AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION OF $15
MILLION IN OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO
OVERALL, WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS, $67.5 MILLION
INCREASE OR 68% INCREASE IN
OLDER ADULT NUTRITION FUNDING
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS, WHICH
IS JUST PHENOMENAL. THAT'S
ALLOWED US TO SERVE OVER 3
MILLION ADDITIONAL MEALS TO OVER
100,000 ADDITIONAL OLDER ADULTS.
SO IT REALLY HAS MADE A
DIFFERENCE, EVEN WITH THE
TEMPORARY COVID RELIEF FUNDING
GOING AWAY, THESE ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS HAVE ALLOWED US TO
STILL CONTINUE TO SERVE MORE
CALIFORNIANS AND K¾T EVER HAS
BEFORE IN ITS HISTORY, THE OTHER
THING I'LL NOTE, JUST A
TECHNICAL THING ON THE 166
MILLION, THE 52 MILLION IN
SUPPORT OF SERVICES FUNDING, THE
15 MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR OCA
MOD AUGMENTATION THAT IS OVER
AND ABOVE THE 166, THE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IS CAPTURED
IN A DIFFERENT LINE ITEM. SO WE
WOULD BASICALLY ALLOW THE TRIPLE
A TO SPEND AGAINST THAT LINE
ITEM, IF WE PROVIDE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. SO I JUST AND WE
CAN WORK IF WE. I'M SORRY YOU
SAID IF, WILL WE ALLOW THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE, WE, WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS OF JUST
AMENDING CONTRACTS WITH THE
TRIPLE A'S, AND WE'LL BE TALKING
TO THEM ABOUT WHAT THEIR
PREFERENCE IS. OKAY. WELL, THANK
YOU FOR THE RESPONSE. WE'LL I'M
SURE WE'LL HEAR ABOUT IT IF
THERE'S ANY DIMINUTION IN THE
SERVICE THAT WE PROVIDE, WE'LL
LET YOU KNOW WHEN WE DO. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, IF I MAY ADD
ONE EXTRA THING TO FOR BACK TO
THE OLD ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT WITH
THE PASSING OF PROP ONE,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT,
THERE, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS HAVE
BEEN FLAGGED AS A PRIORITY FOR
THOSE FUNDS SO THAT IT WILL BE
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING STREAM TO
HELP SUPPORT THOSE POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU. AND ANOTHER QUESTION
ON THAT. JUST TO CLARIFY, THE
10.5 THAT WAS SET ASIDE FOR THE
MEDIA CAMPAIGN, ALL OF THAT HAS
BEEN USED. IT'S BEEN ENCUMBERED.
IT HASN'T ALL BEEN SPENT YET.
ENCUMBERED FOR WHAT, TO DO THE
STATEWIDE MEDIA CAMPAIGN. SO WE
ENTERED INTO A CONTRACT WITH A
CONSULTANT TO DEVELOP AND TO
IMPLEMENT THE CAMPAIGN. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE WORKING ON CAMPAIGN
STRATEGIES, MATERIALS, THINGS
LIKE THAT, BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
FULLY INVOICED AGAINST THAT
AMOUNT. OKAY, LEO, ANY COMMENT
ON THIS ON THESE ISSUES ON OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE, SO
YEAH, WE'RE STILL IN OUR INITIAL
REVIEW OF THE OF THE PROGRAM AND
KIND OF REFLECTING THE GENERAL
QUESTIONS, THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED ALREADY, SOME OF OUR
QUESTIONS REVOLVE AROUND THE
ELIMINATION OF THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA MODERNIZATION ACT,
SPECIFICALLY SPECIFICALLY JUST
WHERE WE AT WITH THE SERVICES,
THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
PROVIDED AND WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THIS AUGMENTATION WILL HAVE ON
THOSE POPULATIONS. ALSO, I THINK
IT MIGHT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED, BUT HOW MUCH IS
EXPIRING IN FEDERAL FUNDS? WE
WANT TO ANSWER ON THAT AS WELL.
OKAY I CAN JUST SAY YES.
ABSOLUTELY. YEAH. IT'S 155 AND,
COVID ERA FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY FOR NUTRITION. AND
THEN OVER AND ABOVE AT THE END
OF THE YEAR, WE IT WAS IN
SEVERAL DIFFERENT PACKAGES FCRA
CARES AND NOW ARPA IS EXPIRING
AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER. IN
ADDITION TO THAT, WE HAD $20
MILLION IN SENIOR NUTRITION
FUNDS. THROUGH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SPENDING PLAN.
SO IT'S BASICALLY 175 MILLION
OVERALL IN TEMPORARY COVID
NUTRITION FUNDING, AND THE HCBS
FUNDS EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. YEAH OKAY. OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM UP.
AND NOW WE CAN GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. OKAY. WHICH ONE IS
THAT. WHICH ONE'S NUMBER TWO. OH
GREAT. SO THIS IS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE, ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
BUDGET, THE FIRST ONE IS A BCP
TO, ALLOW US TO REDIRECT,
INTERNALLY GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT A NEW FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT THAT WE PERFORM
LEVEL OF CARE REVIEWS FOR
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
MULTI-SERVICE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM, THESE THESE REVIEWS ARE
PREVIOUSLY DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, BY LOCAL MSSP PROVIDERS,
THE FEDS NOW REQUIRE THAT THE
STATE ASSUMES THIS
RESPONSIBILITY, SO THAT'S AN
INTERNAL REDIRECTION. AND WE'LL
BE HIRING APPROXIMATELY FIVE
NURSES FOR THAT PROPOSAL. THE
SECOND ONE IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WE'RE RECEIVING VIA, THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR THE CAL FRESH HEALTHY LIVING
PROGRAM. THIS BASICALLY ALLOWS
US TO SERVE MORE CLIENTS THROUGH
THAT PROGRAM. ITS HEALTH
EDUCATION, PROMOTION AND
NUTRITION EDUCATION. AND THEN
THE FINAL ITEM IS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT THAT REALLY JUST
SCREWS UP OUR FEDERAL FUND
AUTHORITY WITH OUR FEDERAL
GRANTS, AND THAT JUST AVOIDS US
HAVING TO DO WHAT'S CALLED
BUDGET REVISIONS EVERY YEAR TO
PULL IN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS
INTO OUR BUDGET, AND THEN FOR
CHAPTER LEGISLATION, WE, ARE
RECEIVING 130,000 TO HIRE A PART
TIME POSITION TO BASICALLY
COLLECT AND SECURE DATA AROUND
OUR LGBTQ PARTICIPANTS. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE COLLECT
THIS INFORMATION AND THAT WE
ENSURE THAT IT'S SECURE. SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT REQUEST IS FOR.
AREN'T WE ALREADY COLLECTING
DATA THAT SURVEY WAY NOW? RIGHT
YES, CDA CONDUCTED A STATEWIDE
SURVEY OF LGBTQIA+ OLDER ADULTS.
WE HAD 4700 RESPONDENTS, THAT
WAS OUTSIDE OF THE DATA THAT OUR
TRIPLE A'S AND OUR CBAS CENTERS
AND OUR MSSP SITES AND OUR,
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
COLLECT. SO THIS WOULD BE THE
DATA COLLECTION FOR OUR AGENCIES
THAT WE OVERSEE ON THE CLIENT
SPECIFIC DATA. OKAY, BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MANDATE THOSE
CENTERS TO SEND THIS INFORMATION
OUT. YES. DO YOU ANTICIPATE ANY
PRIVACY ISSUES HERE? THE
COLLECTION OF DATA WOULD BE
VOLUNTARY. SO WE DON'T REQUIRE,
YOU KNOW, WE ASK THE QUESTION,
RIGHT. BUT WE CAN'T REQUIRE THE
PARTICIPANTS TO PROVIDE US WITH
THAT INFORMATION. AND THEN IT'S
REALLY THE REASON FOR THE
RESOURCES IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT INFORMATION IS SECURE, THAT
WE OVERSEE OUR LOCAL PROVIDERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
COLLECTING IT IN A SECURE WAY,
THAT THE INFORMATION IS
DE-IDENTIFIED, YOU KNOW, AND
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THERE'S
PROPER SAFEGUARDS INVOLVED. IF
THE STATEWIDE SURVEY WE JUST
DID, IMAGINING WE'RE SENT TO ALL
OUR PARTNERS AND THAT WAS
VOLUNTARY, WHY ARE WE DOING THIS
AGAIN? DO YOU THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO NOW WANT TO, FILL OUT A
SURVEY? THE SURVEY WAS, MORE
ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVED
EXPERIENCES, THEIR PREFERENCES
AND THEIR DESIRES AS THEY AGE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS WOULD BE
MORE CLIENT LEVEL DATA AT THE
PROGRAM SIDE, IT WHEN WE ASSESS
AN INDIVIDUAL VERSUS QUALITATIVE
. YES, EXACTLY. THE
QUANTITATIVE. EXACTLY. EXACTLY
OKAY. ANY QUESTIONS? THANK YOU,
LEO, ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON
THIS ISSUE? JOANNE CHARLES
LEVANA'S OFFICE WILL STILL
REVIEWING THESE ISSUES. SO
WE'LL, NOTHING MORE TO ADD AT
THIS TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU. MOVING ON
TO OUR NEXT DEPARTMENT. DDS.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY NANCY BARGEMAN,
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATOR
ROTH, I'M HERE TODAY WITH CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR KARLA CASTANEDA.
I'M STARTING ON ISSUE ONE, I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO REVIEW THE
SOLUTIONS, THAT ARE LISTED ON
PAGE, STARTING ON PAGE SIX OF
THE AGENDA. SO STARTING WITH THE
FIRST ONE, HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, THAT
IS ACTUALLY OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY, ABILITY TO DO
ADJUSTMENTS TO RATES IS NOT
GOING AWAY. SO THAT STILL
REMAINS. SO THIS PROPOSAL, IS
ELIMINATING THE DEDICATED
FUNDING THAT WAS TARGETED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS, IN
TARGETING FOR, PRIMARILY
NON-ENGLISH SPEAKERS. SO WHILE
THE ELIMINATION OF THIS
DEDICATED FUNDING, IT DOESN'T
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS IN
HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO I'LL STILL
NOTE THAT WE HAVE CONTINUED
FUNDING ON OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS
DOLLARS. AND SO WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
LANGUAGE ACCESS, IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS, I THINK THIS IS
LIKE A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
HONESTLY, I WISH WE COULD HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF MORE, BUDGET
SOLUTIONS LIKE THIS WHERE I GET
IT. IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THE
ADVOCATE TO WALK YOU THROUGH THE
PROCESS, RIGHT? MAKE IT EASIER
FOR YOU. BUT AT LEAST THEY CAN
STILL GO THROUGH THE PROCESS. I
JUST WANT TO KNOW, LIKE IT'S A
REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE. OKAY, SO
THEN FOR THE SECOND ITEM, FOR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS, SO THIS
AGAIN WAS PART OF THE 21, 22,
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD ORIGINALLY.
IT WAS, WE HAD AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF 4.3 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN 2122, BUT THE
OUT YEARS WERE, FUNDING AT THE
1.1 MILLION GENERAL FUND. SO
INCLUDED IN OUR ORIGINAL EFFORTS
IN 2122 WAS ALSO OUR EMERGENCY
COORDINATORS AT EVERY REGIONAL
CENTER, AND THEN THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT WAS TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE GO BAGS TO ALSO THEN DO
SOME ADDITIONAL, SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS, REGARDING BATTERIES
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY. SO WHILE
THE ELIMINATION OF THIS FUNDING
IS THERE, WE DO HAVE THE
EMERGENCY COORDINATORS AT EACH
REGIONAL CENTER. AND THIS IS
ALSO GOING TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY
WHERE THE, COORDINATORS CAN WORK
ALSO WITH OUR EMERGENCY
COORDINATOR, WE CAN SEEK MAYBE
FEDERAL FUNDING. WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT LOCAL FUNDING THAT MAY
BE AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSES, SO WHILE THERE IS THE
ELIMINATION, WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE VALUE OF THIS
WORK. AND WILL BE SEEKING
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
SUPPLIES ARE WERE PRETTY GOOD,
RIGHT? BUT AS THEY CONTINUE TO
BE UTILIZED, WE'LL HAVE TO COME
BACK AND SEE HOW WE CAN
SUPPLEMENT. YEAH, WE'LL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR IT. SO BACK IN 2122,
WE WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT ABOUT
7000 INDIVIDUALS AND 28,000 WITH
GO BAGS. SO WE DID DO A VERY
LARGE INVESTMENT BACK THEN, SO
AND LIKE I SAID, WE'LL CONTINUE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE ADDITIONAL GRANTS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS. WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S SOME THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SOMETIMES LOCALLY
. AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
THAT. OKAY SO THEN ON THE NEXT
ITEM IS ON THE DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. AND THAT WAS IN 2223.
IT WAS SKIPPED THE TRIBAL ONE.
DID I SKIP IT OKAY. WELL I WILL
GO RIGHT TO THAT ONE. SO THE
TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT AND OUTREACH
FOR EARLY START SERVICES, THAT
WAS IN 21, 22, WAS THE ORIGINAL
FUNDING THAT WE HAD FOR $500,000
FOR THAT, OUTREACH FOR ENGAGE
WITH THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
FOCUSED ON EARLY START AND SO IN
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET THIS
YEAR, WE HAD ACTUALLY, INCLUDED
A PROPOSAL FOR AN ADDITIONAL
750,000. WE FAILED TO ACTUALLY
PRESENT IT AT THE LAST BUDGET
HEARING. AND SO WHILE THIS IS,
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE IT FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
OF THIS YEAR, IT DOES RETAIN THE
EXISTING SERVICES OF THE 500,000
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN PLACE.
OKAY SO THEN TO THE DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. AND SO
AGAIN, IN 22, 23, AND THIS WAS
PART OF A, A PACKAGE OF EFFORTS
ON THE WORKFORCE. SO THIS
REFLECTS A DELAY THAT AN UPDATE
BECAUSE WE HAD A DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL PROGRAM.
WHILE IT DOES SHOW A REDUCTION
OF 20 MILLION, IT RETAINS 2.5
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE CURRENT
CONTRACT. AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ABOUT 16 INTERNS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY PLACED WITH PROVIDERS.
AND WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THE TRAINING AND SO THE
2.5 MILLION WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS. THEN I
WAS ASKED TO GIVE AN UPDATE ON
THE COORDINATED FAMILY SUPPORTS
OF THE MAY REVISION, ADJUST THE
TOTAL EXPENDITURES BASED ON
UPDATED CLAIMS DATA. AND I ALSO
WANT TO JUST GIVE A REAL QUICK
UPDATE ON THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE THE
AGENDA NOTES CORRECTLY. IN
DECEMBER, WHAT OUR NUMBERS FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND ALSO
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SERVICES
THROUGH THE COORDINATED FAMILY
SUPPORTS UPDATED AS OF MARCH. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE 52 PROVIDERS AND
WE HAVE 365 INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING THESE SERVICES. AND
WHILE THIS IS UPDATED, I WILL
NOTE THAT ON GOING THAT WE WILL
BE REFLECTING A CONTINUING TO
EVALUATE THIS WORK AND IN FUTURE
, BUDGETS WILL BE, NOTING IT IN
OUR SUPPORT SERVICES LINE ITEM,
SO THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL UPDATES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. SO THIS IS THIS ONLY
HAS FUNDED THROUGH, HCBS UNTIL
THE END OF THE YEAR. THAT'S
CORRECT. BUT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
POTENTIALLY DOWN THE LINE. YEAH.
SUPPORTING THE SERVICE. SO WE
HAVE CONTINUED SERVICES THAT
BECAUSE IT'S APPROVED THROUGH
OUR HEALTH AND OUR HCBS WAIVER.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE APPROVAL
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
SERVICE. AND SO THE CONTINUED
WORK AS WE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
IT WOULD BE, LINE ITEM IN OUR
SUPPORT SERVICES BUDGET. WE'RE
GOING TO BE GETTING SUPPORT
FROM. GOT IT. GREAT PLEASE. AND,
MADAM CHAIR KARLA CASTANEDA,
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES, JUST TO ADDRESS YOUR
FUNDING QUESTION, IN THE CURRENT
YEAR, IT'S BOTH HCBS AND GENERAL
FUND RIGHT NOW. GOT IT. THANK
YOU. I BELIEVE THOSE WERE THE
BUDGET SOLUTIONS ON THE ISSUE.
ONE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, YES, CAN WE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES CAN I
KNOW WE? I BROUGHT THIS UP LAST
TIME REGARDING THE DSP TRAINING
STIPENDS, TUITION
REIMBURSEMENTS. I KNOW WE MAY
NOT HAVE AN ACCURATE AMOUNT OF
HOW MUCH WE CAN SCORE, BUT THERE
MUST BE A SAFE NUMBER. WE CAN
SCORE IN THIS FISCAL YEAR THAT
WE KNOW FOR SURE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THIS SAVINGS. I REALLY WANT
TO SEE WHERE WE CAN SCORE NOW.
SO I'D LIKE I'D LIKE WHEN WE
COME BACK NEXT WEEK TO COME WITH
A SAFE NUMBER. BE VERY IT COULD
BE VERY CONSERVATIVE. BUT WE GOT
TO SCORE SOME FROM THE POTENTIAL
UNSPENT BECAUSE I KNOW THERE
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN UNSPENT
HERE. YEAH. EXCUSE ME.
KRISTOPHER O'NEILL, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THAT'S ACCURATE.
SENATOR I KNOW WE'VE UPDATED
STAFF ON WHERE WE'RE TRACKING
EXPENDITURES AND WHAT THOSE
POTENTIAL SAVINGS COULD BE. WE
DID NOT SCORE SAVINGS AT MAY
REVISION ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
TWO PROPOSALS, WHEN LOOKING AT
THE 22 WORKFORCE PACKAGE, I
MEAN, THE PART OF THE REASON THE
DSP INTERNSHIP PROGRAM ROSE TO
THE TOP WAS BECAUSE THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE, BUT
CERTAINLY IF THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO LOOK AT THOSE TWO OTHER
PROGRAMS TO SCORE SAVINGS,
THAT'S THAT'S AN AREA WE CAN
LOOK 100. THANK YOU, AND THEN
DIRECTOR, THOSE, YOU KNOW, THESE
ARE I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THESE
ARE EASY TO SWALLOW, BUT LIKE,
THESE ARE ON THE IN TRIAGING A
LITTLE EASIER NOW THE ONE THAT
THE HARD PART IS DDS RATE REFORM
DELAY. I MEAN OVERALL I WAS LIKE
NOT EVEN MY TEARS BROUGHT
ANYTHING BACK FROM WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IN THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS, SO DISHEARTENING TO SEE.
BUT, I MEAN, I EVEN LIKE A 6 OR
9 MONTH DELAY. JUST SOMETHING
FOR THIS. AS WE'RE LOOKING TO.
AND AGAIN, I KNOW THERE'S NO WAY
I WISH I CAN GO TO MY LEADERSHIP
AND SAY, I FOUND MONEY IN HHS,
SO KEEP IT IN HHS. LIKE, I WISH
I COULD BE LIKE THAT. SO
SOMETIMES I'M LIKE, I DON'T EVEN
WANT TO FIND THIS SAVINGS.
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE. BUT THIS IS WHY I
WANT TO SCORE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO SAY, HEY,
LET'S NOT DO A FULL DELAY. THIS
IS I THINK IT'S JUST REALLY
DETRIMENTAL, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW,
THEIR STORIES THAT WERE BEING
TOLD, THE COMPETITIVENESS WITH
EVERYONE ELSE PAYING SO MUCH
MORE. I MEAN, I JUST VISITED
TIERRA DEL SOL IN MY DISTRICT,
AND I WAS JUST BLOWN AWAY ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND HOW MUCH
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST AMAZING THE
WORK THEY'RE DOING. AND THEY
NEED SUPPORT. THEY'RE LOSING
EMPLOYEES. EVERYONE'S LOSING
EMPLOYEES. I MEAN, THIS IS SUCH
A HUGE PRIORITY, AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT AT LEAST MY BUDGET
CHAIR LOOKS AS THIS AS A HUGE
PRIORITY AS WELL, WE NEED A
LITTLE TINY Kò. WE NEED A WAY TO
BRING SOME RATE REFORM. WE
DEFINITELY DO. WE THIS IS,
AGAIN, A POPULATION THAT HAS SO
MANY DIFFERENT BARRIERS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIX THROUGH YOUR
LEADERSHIP, THROUGH, YOU KNOW,
REGIONAL CENTERS, X, Y, Z, WE
GOTTA WE GOTTA GIVE THEM ONE
BACK SCRATCH LIKE, WE CAN'T
JUST, LIKE, PUT THEM OUT. WHAT
YOU SAY, PUT THEM OUT TO THE
RIVER, WHICH IS WHAT WAS YOUR ON
THE STREET COMPLETELY. SO ON
THIS ONE, I'D LIKE AS WE
CONCESSIONS. EVERYONE'S SAYING
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON WHAT WE HAVE
LEFT AND THE 1 TO 2 WEEKS ON
THIS MATTER, LEO, ANY COMMENT?
KARINA HENDREN LEO, JUST WANTED
TO NOTE SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
SOLUTION FOR THE DSP INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM, WE FIND THIS SOLUTION
TO BE REASONABLE BECAUSE IT
TARGETS ONE TIME FUNDING RATHER
THAN ONGOING BASED PROGRAMS. AS
YOU HAD NOTED, AND THEN FOR THE
COORDINATED FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES, MORE AS AN OVERSIGHT
ITEM, THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
STATED THAT IT'S BEEN COLLECTING
FEEDBACK EVERY QUARTER, FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF AS WELL AS
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS. AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE MAY BE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THAT INFORMATION. ALWAYS
INTERESTED. OKAY. SENATOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GREAT. DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER ISSUE I WANT YOU YES,
YOU DO ISSUE TWO. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. KARLA CASTANEDA,
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES, FOR THE OVERVIEW OF
THE MAY REVISION, THE DDS BUDGET
INCLUDES $15.4 BILLION, 10
BILLION GENERAL FUND, THAT'S A
1.9 BILLION TOTAL FUND INCREASE
OVER THE REVISED CURRENT YEAR,
THE AGENDA LISTS THE NUMBER OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS. SO I'LL
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT ONES AND THEN
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA, WHAT WE HAVE IN THE THAT
TOTAL ADJUSTMENT IS REFLECTING
SUPPORT FOR APPROXIMATELY
465,000 INDIVIDUAL. THAT IS
ABOUT A 6900 MORE INDIVIDUALS
THAN PROJECTED AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, AND ABOUT 35,000 MORE
INDIVIDUALS COMPARED TO THE
CURRENT YEAR, THERE ARE TWO
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS, AND
THESE ARE BOTH FOR IT PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PROGRESS. THE
FIRST ONE IS OUR REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM PROJECT, AND THIS IS
SUPPORTING OUR FEDERAL FUNDS
COLLECTIONS, THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS A LEGACY SYSTEM. SO THIS IS
NEAR COMPLETION. THERE'S TWO
PARTS TO THE REQUEST. ONE IS
REQUESTING SOME NEW GENERAL
FUND, 3 MILLION. BUT THEN THE
REST OF IT, WHICH WOULD BE
CONTINGENT UPON APPROVAL OF THE
NEXT ITERATIVE PROJECT REPORT.
THE OTHER PIECE IS 5 MILLION.
THAT HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED, BUT
IT HAS NOT BEEN SPENT YET. GIVEN
THE DELAY IN THE PROJECT. SO IT
WOULD BE A TECHNICAL
REAPPROPRIATION. AND THE OTHER
IT PROJECT IS OUR UNIFORM FISCAL
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION AND THE
CONSUMER ELECTRONICS RECORD
SYSTEMS. SO WE ARE STILL WORKING
ON APPROVAL OF THE ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS. BUT DURING THAT, FOUND
SOLUTIONS WILL LIKELY BE
FEASIBLE TO COMBINE THE PROJECTS
. SO THEY ARE BEING COMBINED,
THIS REQUEST ALLOWS THAT
PLANNING TO CONTINUE SO THAT
THERE COULD BE A REQUEST FOR A
PROPOSAL NEXT WINTER, SO IT'S
SLIGHTLY LOWER THAN THE CURRENT
YEAR FUNDING JUST BECAUSE OF THE
RECOGNIZING THE BUDGET SITUATION
, WE TALKED ABOUT THE TECHNICAL
THERE ARE ALSO TWO ADJUSTMENTS
IN OUR STATE OPERATED PROGRAM,
THE FIRST ONE FOR THE COMPLEX
NEEDS PROGRAM, GIVEN THE DELAY
IN THAT CONSTRUCTION, WE ARE WE
HAD A PHASE IN PLAN FOR STAFF
ASSUMING THAT THE HOMES WERE
COMPLETED. AND, WE ARE NOW
BRINGING THAT DOWN IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. SO BY APPROXIMATELY 28
STAFF AND $7 MILLION, THE
ADDITIONAL ITEM IS A TECHNICAL
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT COMPONENT.
CAN WE STICK ON THE COMPLEX ONE?
OKAY. SO IT'S APPROXIMATELY 7
MILLION FOR 28.8 POSITIONS.
PHASED IN WHEN? YOU'RE ASKING,
WHAT'S THE TOTAL AMOUNT HERE?
WHAT ARE WE WHAT NUMBER ARE WE
DECREASING FROM? WE ARE, I
BELIEVE IT WAS 12 MILLION AT
GOVERNOR'S FIVE, RIGHT? YES.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REMEMBERED
12.5. AND RIGHT NOW YOU'RE
ASKING TO, ONLY USE ABOUT FIVE
FOR THE NEXT FOR 24. 25. CORRECT
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE OF THESE
BUILDINGS? SO WE HAVE ENTERED
INTO THE LEASE AGREEMENT WITH
FAIRVIEW MANAGEMENT COMPANY TO
IDENTIFY THE LOCATION. SO WE
WOULD EXPECT THE COMPLETION OF
THE HOMES WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR.
WE ARE IN REGULAR CONVERSATION
WITH DGS AND WITH THE CITY OF
COSTA MESA TO STAY ON TOP OF THE
PROJECTS, JUST FOR AWARENESS,
GIVEN THE CITY'S WORK AT
FAIRVIEW. SO WITH THAT, THE
PHASE IN OF INDIVIDUALS STAFF
PRECEDES THE COMPLETION OF THAT
SO THAT YOU CAN BEGIN SOME OF
THE TRAINING BEFORE LICENSING OR
CERTIFICATION. OKAY. SO BECAUSE
I WAS GOING TO MOVE MY QUESTION,
I WAS LIKE, WHY ARE WE HIRING
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A BUILDING
YET? SO WE'RE DOING THIS FOR
TRAINING. YES. WHICH WE
TYPICALLY DO WITH HOME
DEVELOPMENT. SO THE STAR HOMES
ARE LOCATED AT THE FAIRVIEW SITE
AS WELL. SO THERE IS CAPACITY TO
DO SOME OF THAT BEFORE HOMES ARE
COMPLETE. AND WE'RE ANTICIPATING
ANTICIPATING COMPLETION OF THESE
HOMES IN APPROXIMATELY A YEAR.
CONSTRUCTION IS APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR UNLESS THERE ARE OTHER
DELAYS. OKAY, CONSTRUCTION AND
THEN ANYTHING ELSE OUTSIDE OF
THAT, LIKE THE SYSTEMS BEING
BROUGHT IN, ANY, ANY, ANY
ANYTHING RELATED TO THAT THAT
WOULD EXTEND THAT TIMELINE PAST
ONE YEAR. THERE ALWAYS CAN BE
THERE ALWAYS CAN BE. I'M JUST
LOOKING AT THIS AS THIS. CAN WE
PUSH IT OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE?
IS THAT POSSIBLE JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE ALREADY DELAYED A WHOLE
YEAR, RIGHT. WE'RE DELAYED A
WHOLE YEAR. I THINK, SO IN
LOOKING AT ALL THESE THINGS, IS
THIS SOMETHING AGAIN, WE CAN
PUSH OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
WHETHER IS THIS A SIX MONTH
PUSH? NOT MAYBE NOT A FULL YEAR,
BUT A SIX MONTH PUSH WHERE WE
SAVE SOME OF THIS TRAINING
STARTS. I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW IF THESE QUESTIONS ARE
ASKING ARE FEASIBLE. I'M JUST
ASKING, YEAH. THE PROPOSED
FUNDING IS PUSHING THEM OUT A
ADDITIONAL QUARTER COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WHAT IS
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME. SORRY. COULD
YOU REPHRASE THAT FOR ME? YES A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE HAD
ALREADY RECOGNIZED A DELAY, AND
I THINK WE HAD PUSHED IT BACK A
QUARTER. AND SO WE'RE PUSHING
ANOTHER QUARTER. SO FOR HIRING
STAFF, WHEN WHAT QUARTER ARE WE
PUSHING IT TO, THAT WOULD BE THE
LAST QUARTER OF 24, 25. SO WE'RE
STARTING THIS TRAINING IN LIKE
APRIL, STAFF HIRING IN APRIL.
YEAH. OH, SO THE 7 MILLION IS
ONLY GOING TO BE USED FOR APRIL
TO JULY. THE FIVE. CORRECT. OH,
SORRY. THE FIVE. YEAH. THE FIVE.
WE'RE ONLY ASKING FOR APRIL.
JULY. OKAY. OKAY. SENATOR ROTH,
ANY. WAIT. NO, WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED EVERYTHING. GO AHEAD,
THE NEXT ITEM IN STATE OPERATED
WAS FOR REIMBURSEMENTS, AND THAT
IS REFLECTING OUR MORE RECENT
EXPERIENCE, ORIGINALLY WE. SORRY
I'M SO SORRY. I'M SO SORRY. SO
SORRY. STILL STUCK ON THIS?
SURE. BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION CAN
STILL EVEN GO PAST, RIGHT? I
THINK I STILL I THINK I'M STILL
INTERESTED IN SEEING IF TRAINING
COULD POTENTIALLY START NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. IT COULD
POTENTIALLY AND STILL HAVE
ENOUGH TIME WHILE CONSTRUCTION
IS HAPPENING. BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED YOU'RE STILL LOOKING
FOR A LOCATION, RIGHT. CORRECT
SO WE HAVEN'T EVEN FOUND A
LOCATION. SO WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHEN CONSTRUCTION IS EVEN GOING
TO START. SO PROBABLY
CONSTRUCTION LIKE CONSTRUCTION
COULD START IN DECEMBER AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A FULL YEAR
RIGHT. SO I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
ROOM FOR THIS TO BE IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. SENATOR CHRIS
O'NEIL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
CAN TAKE THAT BACK. OKAY. THIS I
MEAN, THE PROPOSAL YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU ALIGNS WITH OUR
CURRENT ASSUMPTION ON HOME
DEVELOPMENT. AND WHEN IT THE
TIMELINE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
START THAT TRAINING FOR STAFF.
BUT THAT'S KNOWING YOUR INTEREST
IN IT. WE CAN WE CAN TAKE THAT
BACK AND TAKE A LOOK OKAY. THANK
YOU. OKAY. YOU CAN PROCEED, STAR
HOME, FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS HAD
BEEN, PROJECTED USING THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICE EXPERIENCE.
WE ARE NOT COLLECTING AS MUCH
BECAUSE THE REIMBURSEMENTS DO
DEPEND ON ELIGIBILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS. SO, THIS IS A
TECHNICAL FUND SHIFT. ASSUMING
MORE GENERAL FUND, YOU HAD A
QUESTION IN THE AGENDA ABOUT THE
PORTERVILLE CHANGE IN
EXPENDITURES THE CURRENT YEAR,
$20 MILLION REDUCTION. SO IT'S
NOT AN INCREASE IN 24, 25 TO
HISTORICAL BUDGET, BUT IT IS AN
INCREASE COMPARED TO 2324.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE BROUGHT DOWN
THE CURRENT YEAR, WITH THE
CURRENT VACANT VACANCY
EXPERIENCE, WE WOULD RECRUIT TO
ANTICIPATE FULL, FULL USE IN 4
OR 5. SENATE-TV MEMBER I THINK
JUST TO, MAYBE TO HELP EXPLAIN.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT THERE WERE SOME
HIRING CHALLENGES AT
PORTERVILLE. SO WE SCORED WHAT,
YOU KNOW, ONE TIME SAVINGS OF 20
MILLION. AND NOW WE'RE BRINGING
IT BACK. CORRECT. BECAUSE WE'RE
BUT BUT THAT REPRESENTS THE
FULLY BUDGETED STAFF COST AT
PORTERVILLE NEXT YEAR. SO IT'S
NEXT TO WHAT THE AMOUNT THAT
YOU'RE SEEING NEXT YEAR IS 20
MILLION OVER CURRENT YEAR. BUT
THAT'S, THAT'S THAT'S RETURNING
TO THE FULLY BUDGETED AMOUNT
THAT IT WOULD BE FOR STAFF AT
PORTERVILLE. AND I, I THINK
GIVEN THAT THERE'S ALSO SOME
MORE GLOBAL, PROPOSALS AROUND
SAVING, IDENTIFYING SAVINGS,
REDUCTIONS WITH DEPARTMENTS, I
WOULD JUST SAY, YOU KNOW, I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN PAST INTEREST IN
THIS 20, THIS 20 MILLION, THIS
20 MILLION AMOUNT. BUT, GIVEN
THAT WE'RE ALSO BEGINNING, WE'RE
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
SOME OF THESE OTHER GLOBAL
SAVINGS REDUCTIONS, I THINK WE
WOULD MAINTAIN THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT 20 MILLION
TO REMAIN IN THE BASE BUDGET,
WHILE THOSE PROCESSES ARE GOING
ON, IF THAT'S HELPFUL. YEAH. NO,
NO, NO, I SEE WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM 100. BUT I STILL WHY
ARE WE GOING TO FUND BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL AMOUNT. BUT WHEN WE'RE
SEEING A DECREASE OF CLIENTS IN
THESE PORTERVILLE HOMES, WE'VE.
SENATOR, I THINK I CAN ALSO LET,
MAX IS WAS 211 CORRECT. 211 IS
THE 211 CAPACITY. WHERE ARE WE
LIKE 170? I'M TRYING TO MEMORIZE
ALL THESE NUMBERS. YEAH RIGHT.
YEAH. WE COULD GET YOU THE
CURRENT NUMBER, BUT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN JUST RIGHT AROUND 185,
190, BUT WE, YOU KNOW, THAT IS
OFTEN FLUID, YOU KNOW, AS FAR AS
BEING ABLE TO, TRACK IT. BUT WE
CAN GET YOU A CURRENT AND TREND
AND WHAT THE NUMBER IS IN OUR IN
ANYTHING AS FAR AS, HOW MANY ARE
PROJECTED TO ENTER INTO
PORTERVILLE? BECAUSE IF I
THOUGHT I IN WHAT I READ WAS WE
WERE LIKE AT 185 AND THEN THE
RECENT NUMBER CAME OUT LIKE IN
THE 170. SO WE CONTINUED TO SEE
A DECLINE, SO THAT'S WHY IF
FURTHER CONTINUED MY INTEREST
AND IN THIS, IN THIS, IN THIS
TOPIC, IN THIS SECTION, I THINK
MAYBE TWO, CLARIFICATIONS AND I
CAN LEAN ON DDS HERE, BUT I
BELIEVE THE, THE POPULATION
AMOUNT, THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS YOU SEE AT
PORTERVILLE IS A POINT IN TIME
MEASURE. SO I MEAN, IT'S GOING
TO IT'S GOING TO FLUCTUATE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. IT IS
CAPPED AT, I BELIEVE, 211, AND
BUT, JUST GOING BACK TO THE, THE
CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS THAT, THAT
THE SAVINGS AREN'T REFLECTING OR
AREN'T, AREN'T DRIVEN BY ANY
KIND OF POPULATION SHIFTS AT
PORTERVILLE. IT'S, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF FACILITY
IT IS, IT HAS A CERTAIN STAFFING
LEVEL TO PROVIDE SERVICES. AND,
JUST GIVEN SOME HIRING
CHALLENGES THAT THAT'S WHAT
DROVE THE IDENTIFICATION OF
CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS. IT WASN'T
NECESSARILY IT WASN'T TIED TO
FLUCTUATIONS IN POPULATION AT
PORTERVILLE, YOU KNOW, AND I'M
NEVER GOING TO WANT TO REDUCE
OUR RATIO. ARE WE IN VIOLATION
OF RATIOS AT PORTERVILLE? I AM
NOT AWARE OF ANY. WHEN WE HAVE
THE STAFF VACANCIES, WE MAY
SUPPLEMENT THOSE STAFF WITH
REGISTRIES TO MAINTAIN THOSE
RATIOS AS THE OUTSOURCING THAT
SOMEONE ELSE SAID ABOUT PUBLIC
COMMENT AND DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT. OKAY, THAT COST US MORE
. GOT IT. OKAY, OKAY. I THINK
THAT WAS THE LAST QUESTION ON
THIS, ELIO, DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT? KARINA
HENDREN LEO, JUST A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS. GOING BACK TO THE IT
PROJECTS, SO THE FIRST ONE IS
THE REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM. WE
CONSULTED WITH OUR ANALYST WHO
COVERS IT PROJECTS AND, HE
INDICATED THAT FOR PROJECTS THAT
ARE IN EITHER THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OR THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS PHASE
OF SORT OF THE IT PIPELINE, OUR
OFFICE VIEWS THAT FUNDING AS
NON-DISCRETIONARY, SO THAT WOULD
APPLY TO THE REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM PROJECT BECAUSE THIS IS A
PROJECT THAT'S IN THE PROCESS OF
MOVING FROM DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION INTO MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS, FOR THE SECOND
IT PROJECT, THE I DON'T THINK I
GOT YOUR FIRST POINT. OKAY. SO
THE FIRST POINT IS BASICALLY
IT'S ALREADY PRETTY FAR ALONG.
SO ALTHOUGH THERE'S GENERAL FUND
GOING TOWARDS IT, WE VIEW IT AS
NON-DISCRETIONARY BECAUSE THE
PROJECT IS IN PROCESS ALREADY,
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE? YES. OKAY.
FOR THE OTHER IT PROJECT, THE
FISCAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND THE
ELECTRONIC RECORDS, THAT PROJECT
IS EARLIER IN THE SORT OF
OVERALL PLANNING PROCESS, SO IN
GENERAL, OUR OFFICE WOULD VIEW
THAT AS DISCRETIONARY SPENDING,
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
PROJECT IS TIGHTLY INTERWOVEN
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF RATE
REFORM. AND SO ALTHOUGH IT'S
DISCRETIONARY, WE DON'T FIND ANY
CONCERNS WITH IT BECAUSE IT'S,
IMPORTANT TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF RATE REFORM, THESE RATE
REFORMS. YES AND SENATOR, IS
THERE A DELAY BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE SYSTEM READY FOR, WHICH
SYSTEM, THE FISCAL SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION, CONSUMER. WE'RE
IN THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS AND
WORKING ON THE PROCUREMENT. SO
IT REALLY WE'RE STILL IN THE
PLANNING PHASE OF THAT PROJECT.
NÓ, BUT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'RE HAVING A DELAY OUTSIDE
OF THE MONEY PART, EVEN IF WE
HAD THE MONEY TO DO THE NO, IT'S
NOT ONE OF THE REASONS. NO DELAY
ON THIS ONE. I THINK THE DELAY
WAS ON THE REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM
PROJECT WHILE WE WERE WORKING
THROUGH TESTING. CORRECT. BUT I
THINK YOUR QUESTION, THE DELAY,
THE PROPOSED DELAY FOR RATE
REFORM, THAT'S THAT'S NOT THAT'S
NOT TIED TO ANY KIND OF DELAYS
WITH THE IT PROJECTS. I THINK WE
HAD THE MONEY. WE'D STILL BE WE
DON'T NEED THE SYSTEM UP TO DO
THAT. YEAH. I THINK IN WE CAN
JUMP IN BUT I THE TIGHTER RATE
REFORM IS LARGELY I MEAN IT'S
ALSO DATA DATA AND INTEGRITY.
AND AS WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS A
SYSTEM THAT IS MORE OUTCOMES
FOCUSED AND QUALITY, AND LOOKING
AT QUALITY LIKE THAT, THAT'S,
THAT'S WHERE THE, THAT'S WHERE
THE SIGNIFICANT TIE IS AND
WORKING TOWARDS THAT. AND, AND
JUST ALSO TO POINT OUT AND THIS,
THAT, THAT THE INTENT OR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTIVELY
LOOKING AT TRYING TO SECURE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROJECTS AS WELL. SO, I THINK WE
MAY HAVE NOTED, BUT THE COST OF
THIS BCP COMPARED TO THE ONE FOR
CURRENT YEAR IS BROUGHT DOWN IN
LIGHT OF THE BUDGET SITUATION,
BUT INTENDED TO KEEP SOME
PROGRESS MOVING ON. THIS WHILE
THOSE DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE OTHER
PROCESSES. SO, THE, THE FIRST
TWO I KNOW ARE TIED TOGETHER,
ONE LIKE ONE SYSTEM. THE SECOND
ONE IS A SEPARATE SYSTEM. Dð
DOES THE SECOND SYSTEM START
WHEN THE FIRST ONE FINISHES OR
YOU WORK ON THEM? SIMULTANEOUS
ORPHALI THEY'RE WORKING
SIMULTANEOUSLY BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT ONE
STARTED AHEAD OF TIME AND BUT IT
WOULD BE INTEGRATED INTO THE NEW
ONE SO THAT THEY WOULD MATCH THE
DATA THAT WE COLLECT IN THE
MODERNIZED SYSTEM. WITH THE
FEDERAL CLAIMING, OKAY, DID YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE? I KNOW I
THINK I CUT YOU OFF, OKAY. OR
INTERFACE TO MY INTEGRATED
INTERFACE, BUT THEY WILL WORK
TOGETHER. TOMATO, TOMATO. OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THE LAST ISSUE IS
FOR THE MAYOR VISION TRAILER
BILLS. THE. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS.
THE FIRST ONE IS FOR PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY ASSESSMENTS, WHEN
THIS PROGRAM WAS INITIATED, IT
APPLIED FOR THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD CHILDREN, IN SEEKING FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT ELIGIBILITY FOR
THIS, IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT WE
EXPAND THAT. AND SO THE CURRENT
BUDGET HAS THAT FOR BIRTH
THROUGH FOUR AS WELL, IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS, THE REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE EXPERIENCED
CHALLENGES WITH SOME OF THE
LIMITED CLINICAL RESOURCES TO
COMPLETE THOSE ASSESSMENTS AND
THE STATUTE, TIMING OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS FOR CHILDREN HAS
BEEN CONFUSING. SO THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WOULD ACCELERATE THAT
SCREENING AND ASSESSMENT TO MAKE
SURE THOSE CHILDREN RECEIVE
SERVICES AS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND THE NEXT TWO TBOS
ARE RELATED TO WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT. ANY SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT YOU WANT TO JUST
POINT TO, I THINK WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF POSTING THOSE DRAFTS,
BUT REALLY THE INTENT IS THOSE
THOSE TWO ITEMS, CURRENTLY ARE
REQUIRED TO BE FUNDED IN STATUTE
. SO IT'S REALLY INSERTING SOME
LANGUAGE TO REFLECT THAT IT YOU
KNOW, IT WOULDN'T BE IT WOULDN'T
BE REQUIRED. IT WOULDN'T BE
REQUIRED TO FUND THOSE PROGRAMS.
DON'T ADD ANY MORE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE. NOT THESE AREN'T
TRIGGERS. NO OKAY. LÀ ANY
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE? OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MOVING ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
SIT DOWN. JUST BLOOP BLOOP. IT'S
REALLY SHORT. THIS CHAPTER
LEGISLATION CAME UP IN LIKE,
EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT. ON.
THERE WE GO. SO I'LL MAKE THIS
BRIEF. HI. MEGAN RIVERS, ADMIN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. WELCOME TO STEP
THREE, I DON'T THINK HAVE YOU
EVER, THIS IS MY FIRST TIME, SO
THANK YOU, I'LL KEEP IT FREE.
PASS YOUR FIRST TIME. I'M NICE
THE FIRST TIME. AND AFTER THAT.
ALL RIGHT. AND I'LL KEEP IT
SHORT. SO YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT IT? THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING $943,000 IN GENERAL
FUND IN ORDER TO MAKE CHANGES TO
THE STATE LEVEL THIRD PARTY DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM. AS WELL AS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL OF 60 COMMUNITY
SERVICE SUB COMMUNITY SERVICE
BLOCK GRANT, CDBG SUB GRANTEES.
THE COST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WILL
LIKELY VARY. WE'RE REQUESTING
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION MANDATES ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS BEYOND THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEMOGRAPHICS
AND DATA COLLECTION. SO USE OF
FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THIS PURPOSE,
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. I'M
HAPPY TO FORESEE ANY PRIVACY
ISSUES IN COLLECTING THIS
INFORMATION. WE DON'T. SIMILAR
TO WHAT CDA SPOKE TO, IT'S
VOLUNTARY INFORMATION, AND SO
IT'S AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL. IF THEY WILL BE
ASKING THAT QUESTION LIKE YOU
CAN YOU'LL AROUND THE DEPARTMENT
WILL BE ASKING THE QUESTIONS,
AND THEN IT'S UP TO THE
INDIVIDUAL TO, TO CORRECT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. YES. THE CDBG SUB
GRANTEES WOULD BE ASKING THIS
INFORMATION. IT'S AT THE
CLIENT'S DISCRETION WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO DISCLOSE IT.
GREAT. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT?
OMAR SANCHEZ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
THANK YOU. ANGELA SHORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THIS
PROPOSAL, BUT NOTHING TO RAISE
FOR TODAY. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANKS MOVING ON TO DR.
BETTER. WILL NOW BE KNOWN AS
D.W.
SO ON. OH, SORRY. SORRY GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. AND, JOE
XAVIER, DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY, JESSICA
GROVE, WHO IS OUR WHO IS OUR
DEPUTY FOR PALI AND RESOURCES,
DIVISION. SO I WILL SHARE, ABOUT
OUR FIRST BUDGET ITEM HERE, IN
THE AGENDA. DOES A GOOD JOB OF
DESCRIBING IT. SO I'M JUST GOING
TO EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF KEY
POINTS ON THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST
OFFICE. IT'S A REQUEST TO
TRANSFER THE OFFICE FROM OUR
AGENCY TO OUR DEPARTMENT. AND
THE ASSOCIATED $1 MILLION. WE
ARE ALSO ASKING, TO ESTABLISH
THREE POSITIONS THAT WILL
SUPPORT THIS NEWLY CREATED
OFFICE. THIS ALIGNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN ON CAREER
EDUCATION AND THE MASTER PLAN ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES, AND IT FURTHERS OUR
AGENCY, AND OF COURSE, OUR
COMMITMENT TO PUT INDIVIDUALS
INTO COMPETITIVE, INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT SETTINGS. SO, THIS
WILL HELP ELIMINATE
FRAGMENTATION AND STREAMLINE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES ACROSS,
ACROSS ALL OF THE RELEVANT
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS, AND,
THIS ALSO NØ GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE LEVERAGE
THE WORK THAT WE DO AS OUR
PRIMARY MISSION, WORKING WITH
OTHER SYSTEMS SUCH AS THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM, OUR WORKFORCE
SYSTEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, AT
THE STATE LEVEL, OUR LABEL AND
WORKFORCE AGENCIES. AND SO THIS
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. WE, OF COURSE, ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OUR PARTNERS THAT PROVIDE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, SUCH AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES, AND DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. SO I WILL STOP
MY COMMENTS THERE. GLAD TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THAT
ITEM. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT?
OMAR DEPARMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. THANK
YOU, KARINA HENDREN LAO NO
COMMENTS ON THE OFFICE OF
EMPLOYMENT FIRST. OKAY CAN MOVE
ON TO THE SECOND ONE. THANK YOU.
SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION, THE USE OF THE
WORD REHABILITATION, IS, REALLY
CHANGED OVER TIME, IT'S MORE
FREQUENTLY RECOGNIZED AS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS,
REHABILITATION, DRUG
REHABILITATION AND
REHABILITATION FOR PEOPLE THAT
MAY HAVE ACQUIRED AN ILLNESS. SO
WE HAVE CONDUCTED SOME EXTENSIVE
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR COMMUNITY
ACROSS REPRESENTATION OF ALL
DISABILITY TYPES OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF PARTNERS, INCLUDING
OUR YOUTH AND ADULTS, THAT WE
BOTH SERVE. AND WHILE THE
ENGAGEMENT DID NOT PROVIDE A
MANDATE FOR A NAME, IT VERY,
VERY MUCH INFORMED, DISABILITY
WORKS CALIFORNIA, THE NAME THAT
WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD. IT
DEFINES THE NAME, DEFINES THE
POPULATION OR DESCRIBES THE
POPULATION THAT WE SERVE. AND
OUR TAGLINE WILL BE, DESCRIBING
THE END RESULT OF THE SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR THOSE THAT
COME TO US FOR OUR SERVICES. AND
THIS WILL NOT REQUIRE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE DOLLARS FOR US
TO DO THIS. OKAY TÊ BEALL. SO
DEPENDING. SORRY, TBL'S BEEN
POSTED. YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU.
I'M TRYING TO KEEP UP. IT'S ALL
COMING REALLY FAST, RIGHT? IS
THERE A COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE?
NO. GREAT NOTHING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU. MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT DEPARTMENT. CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES
.
GOOD AFTERNOON, DAVID KILGORE,
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES. WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUICK ITEMS TO COVER
TODAY. NO GENERAL FUND. NO
GENERAL FUND. THIS IS JUST A
SHIFT FROM LINE ITEMS ON THE MAY
REVISE. SO THERE'S NO ISSUES
THERE, WITH DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES, WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUICK TRAILER BILL
ITEMS, THESE ARE KIND OF
CLEARING UP REALLY OLD ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN SITTING OUT THERE
FOR A LONG TIME. THE FIRST IS ON
THE CHILD SUPPORT AUTOMATION
SYSTEM. THIS WAS IMPLEMENTED IN
2008. IT'S BEEN FEDERALLY
CERTIFIED. AT THIS POINT. WE'VE
WRAPPED UP ALL OF OUR, MAJOR
CHANGES, THE SYSTEM IN 2014. SO
WE'VE JUST KEEP REPORTING.
NOTHING NEW, NOTHING NEW,
NOTHING NEW FOR TEN YEARS. SO
WE'D LIKE TO REMOVE THAT
EXPECTATION OF A REPORT. THE
SECOND ITEM IS ON THE IMPROVED
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE REPEAL. WE
HAVE BEEN, CONTINUALLY SINCE
2002, 2003, ASKING FOR THIS TO
BE SUSPENDED BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
INCENTIVIZING SOME OF OUR MORE
AFFLUENT COUNTIES IN THE STATE
AND PROVIDING THEM ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR GREAT PERFORMANCE.
BUT IT'S, INAPPROPRIATE IN THE
WAY THAT THAT WAS BEING FUNDED.
SO WE'VE HAD THAT BASICALLY,
ELIMINATED FOR 20 PLUS YEARS. WE
DON'T NEED THAT ANYMORE. WE'VE
GOT DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING
THAT. AND WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FULL PASS
THROUGH, THE WAY THAT WE COLLECT
MONEY JUST DOESN'T EVEN MAKE
SENSE FOR THAT ANYMORE. WE'D
LIKE TO REMOVE THAT. OKAY. OMAR.
ANY COMMENT? OMAR SENATE-TV,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE CONCUR
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND HAVE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. ANGELA
AGAIN, WE'RE STILL REVIEWING
THESE PROPOSALS, BUT NO
IMMEDIATE CONCERNS TO RAISE.
OKAY. HOLDING THE ITEM OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
OH, WAIT. WE JUST. SORRY JUST
KIDDING. WE DID THAT. THAT WAS
ALL OF THEM. THANK YOU. YEAH, WE
DID. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
DO PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT NOW ON
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS WE'VE DONE
UP TO DSS BEFORE DSS YES, ON ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS EXCEPT DSS. IF
YOU HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT, THE
DEPARTMENTS WE WENT OVER, COME
ON UP. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, CATHY
MOSSBERG WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CDA CUTS TO SENIOR NUTRITION
SPECIFICALLY. I THINK WE TOTALLY
AND I'M SORRY, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA, THE TRIPLE A'S, WE
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
NUTRITION MONEY FOR SENIORS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS WAS
TO AUGMENT THOSE DOLLARS BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. WE KNOW
THAT WITHOUT THESE DOLLARS, WE
WILL SEE A 60% DECREASE IN THE
SENIORS WE SERVE. WE KNOW BASED
ON STUDIES POST PANDEMIC, DURING
AND POST THAT WE WILL SERVE WITH
THESE DOLLARS. WE WILL HAVE A
MEAL GAP OF 370 MILLION MEALS.
THAT IS A YEAR WE ALREADY KNEW
BEFORE THESE DOLLARS. WE WEREN'T
SERVING ALL THE SENIORS. SO
THESE WERE TO HELP US GET TO
SERVING MORE SENIORS. WE KNEW
WE'D STILL HAVE A MEAL GAP, BUT
THIS WAS TO GET US THERE.
WITHOUT THESE DOLLARS, WE WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE TO STOP SERVING
AS MANY SENIORS. WE HAVE NO
INTENTION THAT THEY WILL ALL BE
ABLE TO GO TO THE FOOD BANK.
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS IN CAL
AIM AGAIN, ANOTHER GROUP THAT WE
WORK WITH. GREAT. BUT THAT
DOESN'T SERVE EVERYONE. THAT'S
AN INCREDIBLY IT'S A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE AND A MEAL
PROVISION THAT JUST ISN'T THE
SAME. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. JUST JUST MAKE SURE
THIS IS OH NO, YOU WERE FINE.
THIS PUBLIC COMMENT FOR EVERY
DEPARTMENT EXCEPT SOCIAL
SERVICES. CORRECT. DARBY KERNAN,
ON BEHALF OF TWO DIFFERENT
ISSUES, ON TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES
FOR THE FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WERE OPPOSED TO
THE CAL WORKS HOME VISITING CUTS
THAT WILL NÓ SOCIAL SERVICES.
YEAH. SORRY, I YEAH. OKAY.
SORRY, FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
NOURISH CALIFORNIA ARE OPPOSED
TO ELIMINATION. SEE YOU NEXT
TIME. GOOD AFTERNOON. AMY
WESTLING ASSOCIATE DEAN OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES. FIRST
AND FOREMOST, SENATOR MENGIBAR
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT RELATED TO
THE PROPOSED DELAY TO PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES. AS YOU KNOW, WE
AS A SYSTEM ARE STRUGGLING TO
SUPPORT THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE'RE SERVING TODAY. AND WITH
THE EXPECTED CONTINUED
POPULATION GROWTH OF OUR SYSTEM,
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. IT'S ABOUT WORKERS,
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT GETTING
CRITICAL SERVICES TO PEOPLE THAT
THEY SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AMY. MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR
ROTH AND MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF
AVIANA HEALTH CARE, GOING BACK
TO YOUR POINT EARLY ON ABOUT
CORE SERVICES, THE DDS RATE
DELAY IS GOING TO CAUSE A CUT IN
CORE SERVICES BECAUSE WE WON'T
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THAT THESE PEOPLE
DESPERATELY NEED. WE URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THAT CUT IN
THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU. RENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR ROTH,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO COME OUT
HERE EARLY AND ALL YOUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE LEFT TOWN AND
YOU'RE HERE WITH YOUR DUE
DILIGENCE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU KNOW WHAT CAN BE SAID.
EVERYBODY HAS SAID IT. WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTS. BUT WHERE HAS BEEN THE
IMPACT ASSESSMENT TO THE
POPULATION? MR. ROTH AND I
SERVED ON HEARINGS AND HE'S COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS AND ALL OF THE
STRUCTURES THAT GO ALONG WITH
THAT. SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S A FEDERAL STATUTE THAT
WHEN THERE IS FEDERAL MONEY INTO
A PROGRAM, THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
AN IMPACT ASSESSMENT TO
UNDERSTAND THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
YOUR CUTS. I WOULD HOPE THE
COMMITTEE CAN WORK TOWARDS THAT
AND WORKING ON THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THIS ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO CONTINUE ON THIS PATH,
THE HARM THAT IT WILL CREATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR ROTH, BARRY
JARDINI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
HEARING TODAY, FOR THE HEARING
TODAY, AND FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES RATE.
RATE PROPOSED RATE DELAY,
OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AND KNOW THAT
ULTIMATELY IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF LIES TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, RIGHT? AS
CALIFORNIANS, WE HAVE A LONG AND
PROUD HISTORY, 50 YEARS OF THE
LANTERMAN ACT, 50 YEARS PLUS,
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES IN OUR
HISTORY AS CALIFORNIA THAT WE'VE
MAYBE NOT QUITE HONORED IT. AND
THEN WE HAD THIS RAY OF HOPE
RIGHT THROUGH THE RATE MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET BACK TO THE TO RIGHT
SIZING THE RATES. AND NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT A PROPOSED DELAY. A
DELAY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IS MOVING BACKWARDS
RIGHT. THE WORLD IS MOVING ON
WITHOUT THEM. AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO LIVE THEIR
FULL AND INCLUSIVE LIVES. WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE
FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THIS PROPOSAL, AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON,
EDWARD HERSHEY WITH HOME OF
GUIDING HANDS. WE'RE ONE OF THE
LARGEST PROVIDERS OF SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
SAN DIEGO, SERVING ABOUT 10% OF
THE POPULATION IN SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT THE RATE
REFORM AND THE NEED FOR IT. I
WANT TO JUST PUT SOME NUMBERS TO
THAT FOR YOU, LAST MONTH ALONE,
WE TURNED AWAY 250 CLIENTS THAT
WE COULDN'T SERVE, MY DAUGHTER
GETS SERVICES. I DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT A LOT, BUT SHE GETS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. SHE COULD
NOT GET TO A MEDICAL APPOINTMENT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T HAVE SUPPORT.
SHE'S ON HER FIFTH SERVICE
PROVIDER IN TWO YEARS. AND JUST
THE ROTATION AND TURNOVER, IT'S
ACTUALLY CAUSING HER TO HAVE TO
GO TO THERAPY NOW BECAUSE SHE
THINKS THEY'RE LEAVING HER AS AN
INDIVIDUAL, NOT FOR A BETTER JOB
OR GETTING A HIGHER PAY. SO I
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU DO. THIS
IS MY FIRST TIME AT SUB THREE
AND YOU GUYS ARE A HOOT OVER
HERE. OH, SO I NEED TO COME OVER
MORE. IS IT ALL MY JOKES? YEAH,
YEAH, BUT I LIKE THAT YOU HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND I HOPE
THAT'S A DEFENSE MECHANISM. YOU
KNOW? YEAH. SO I HOPE WHEN YOU
GUYS MAKE THE VOTE NEXT WEEK
THAT YOU HOLD TRUE TO THE
PROMISE. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW,
I'VE ALSO HEARD, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE ARE PUSHING OUT. I MEAN,
I HAD A LADY COME INTO MY
DISTRICT OFFICE WHO IS A
CARETAKER, A PERSON ID, AND
SHE'S PUSHING OFF HER RETIREMENT
. OH, YEAH. BECAUSE SHE KNOWS IF
SHE LEAVES HER, THERE WON'T BE
ANOTHER SERVICE PROVIDER TO COME
IN AND CARE FOR HER. WE DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF TO ITS. AND I
LOOK AT THIS WOMAN AND SHE'S
LIKE OLDER THAN MY MOM AND I'M
LIKE, YOU CAN'T RETIRE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW NO ONE'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO COME REPLACE. SO LIKE
IT'S A REAL MISTER JARDINI
TALKED ABOUT OUR HISTORY A
LITTLE BIT AND TALKED ABOUT THE
INSTITUTES AND THE TIME HOME OF
GUIDING HANDS HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR 56 YEARS BEFORE THE
INSTITUTE OR BEFORE THE CLOSURE
OF THE INSTITUTES, BEFORE THE
LANTERMAN ACT, BEFORE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. I'M REALLY
AFRAID WE'RE GOING TO REPEAT
HISTORY AND THAT THE TERRIBLE
SITUATION THAT THE INSTITUTES
WERE ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS TO THAT WERE CUTBACKS,
RATE CUTS, RATE FREEZES. THANK
YOU. WE'RE DOOMED TO REPEAT
THAT. THANKS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR
RATH, STAFF JORDAN LINDSAY WITH
THE AKA CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION. THÀNH. I CAN'T
SAY MUCH MORE THAN MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUES HAVE STATED, SO LET
ME JUST WANT TO PAINT ONE MORE
PICTURE YOU MENTIONED ABOUT
STAFF NOT BEING ABLE TO RETIRE
THE PARENTS ALSO AS WELL, WHO
AREN'T ABLE TO WHO ARE AGING
THEMSELVES, AND THE ADULT
CHILDREN THAT THEY HAVE NOW ARE
NOT RECEIVING SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES. THEY WERE MAYBE BEING
SUPPORTED IN A PLACE OF LIVING
BY THEMSELVES OR IN A CARE HOME.
NOW THEY'RE HAVING TO COME BACK
HOME WITH AN AGING PARENT
THEMSELVES AND THE MENTAL HEALTH
TO THE PARENT, AS WELL AS THE
MENTAL HEALTH. NO, NO ADULT
WANTS TO BE WITH THEIR PARENT.
24 OVER SEVEN IN THE HOUSE. YOU
NEED A LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH IF
THAT HAPPENS. AND SO THE IMPACTS
ARE COMPOUNDING WITH THESE CUTS.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
AND WE BEG YOU TO MAKE A STAND
TO PUSH BACK AGAINST THOSE
DELAYS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YASMIN. PILATE, ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND AGING,
REGARDING SOME OF THE ITEMS
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF AGING, WE
ARE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROPOSED CUT TO SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS UNDER THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT MODERNIZATION.
IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT THE BACKFILL
IS AND HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT
OLDER ADULTS REALLY GET THE
NUTRITION AND THE MEALS THAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO STAY AT
HOME AND IN THE COMMUNITY, ALONG
WITH THE CUTS THAT WILL BE
TALKED ABOUT IN THE NEXT SECTION
, WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT,
SENIOR NUTRITION ACCESS. AND SO
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S
COMMITMENT TO CONSIDERING
ALTERNATIVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. COME ON UP, REBECCA. GOOD
AFTERNOON. REBECCA GONZALES WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY JUST BRIEFLY ON CHILD
SUPPORT. WE HOPE TO SEE TRIGGER
LANGUAGE. WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING SOCIAL SERVICES YET. OH
CHILD NÓ CHILD SUPPORT IS.
THAT'S ON ME. SORRY. AS YOU
WERE. THAT'S OKAY. WE JUST STILL
HOPE TO SEE TRIGGER LANGUAGE TO
FUND FULL PASS THROUGH IN FUTURE
YEARS. THANK YOU. THANKS. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. OKAY ANDREW, SHANE,
GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY. I WILL
ALIGN WITH THE WESTERN CENTER.
THIS ISN'T THE YEAR WE CAN
ACHIEVE THE PASS THROUGH, BUT WE
CAN'T GIVE UP ON THIS PROMISE.
THANK YOU. THANKS, ANDREW. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M WENDY PETERSON
WITH THE SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY,
REPRESENTING 40 CBOS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OLDER ADULTS
IN OUR COUNTY, WE REALLY URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT MODERNIZATION
FUNDING, WE HAVE TO PROTECT THE
OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES NOW IN OUR COUNTY. THAT
FUNDING IS USED TO FILL A GAP,
IT'S PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED EXTRA
CAPACITY IN, SENIOR NUTRITION IN
ORDER TO SERVE THE NEED IN THE
COMMUNITY, IF THAT FUNDING GOES
AWAY, WE KNOW THAT MULTIPLE
CONGREGATE DINING SITES WILL
CLOSE AND SEVERAL HUNDRED MEALS
ON WHEELS RECIPIENT WILL NO
LONGER RECEIVE THEIR SERVICES.
THESE ARE OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE
THEY'RE THEY'RE HOMEBOUND AND
THEY DON'T HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
SO I URGE YOU TO REJECT THAT
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. HI, I'M
JOSH TAFF. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY RELATIONS WITH ETA IN
LOS ANGELES, AND WE SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE SUPPORT OVER 175 INDIVIDUALS,
AND WE HAVE OVER 220 PRECIOUS
STAFF. AND I WE'VE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY ALREADY, AND THANK YOU
FOR WHAT SEEMS LIKE REALLY
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT TO OVERTURN
THE RATE IMPLEMENTATION, DELAY,
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT WE IT
HAS TO BE DONE. I KNOW THAT THIS
IS THERE'S SO MANY THERE'S SO
MANY NEEDS RIGHT NOW AND THAT
BUT THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT COULD SET US BACK, YOU
KNOW, A DECADE OR MORE, TO WHERE
WE WERE, BECAUSE RATES WERE
NEVER WHAT THEY NEVER WHAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. AND JUST THIS
IS A PROMISE THAT THAT THAT WAS
MADE. AND I'M REALLY WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT COULD CONTINUE
AND THAT THAT WE COULD, THANK
YOU, ASK YOU TO BE OUR CHAMPION.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING. KEVIN
ESTÁN COALITION, CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION. WE
OPPOSE THE NUTRITION CUTS AND
SUPPORT THE PASS THROUGH FOR
CHILD SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE ONE
LAST, DEPARTMENT HERE WHERE MY
HEART LIES. THIS IS WHERE MY
SOCIAL WORK HEART LIES. AND I'M
GOING TO SAY THIS AGAIN. 28
CUTS. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO GOING TO DISCUSS 28 CUTS FROM
JANUARY. THE ONES ON TOP THAT WE
GOT IN THE MAY REVISE THE
SUMMARY OF THE BUDGET, TALKED
ABOUT HOW WE SEE LOWER PERSONAL
INCOME TAX REVENUE. YOU KNOW,
HOW WE INCREASE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX BY HELPING PEOPLE GET INTO
JOBS, DDS RATE REFORMS. THIS
WILL BRING ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
OUR STATE ON JUST LIKE THE
FISCAL ASPECT IN CASE YOU HAVE
THE SIZE OF GRINCH HEART FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE MOVIE, AND
FISCAL IS WHAT MOVES YOU TOWARDS
SUPPORTING THESE PROGRAMS,
DIRECTOR JOHNSON, I DON'T ENVY
YOU RIGHT NOW. THIS IS SUCH A
TOUGH TIME TO BE IN RIGHT NOW,
SO COME ON UP. LET'S DO THIS. SO
THIS IS THE PLAN. AS I SHARED IN
THE BEGINNING, WE'RE GOING TO DO
CHILD CARE ISSUES ONE THROUGH
THREE. THEN WE'RE GOING TO DO
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'RE GOING TO
GO INTO CALWORKS. THEN WE'LL DO
DO IHSS. THEN PUBLIC COMMENT.
FOOD PROGRAMS COMMENT. PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOSTER I MISSED, I
MISSED, I MISSED THE FOSTER
FOSTER PUBLIC COMMENT. SO EACH
TOPIC AND I KNOW WE HAVE TO WAIT
FOR EACH LÀ Ó Dð O F TO SWITCH
OUT AS WELL. SO THAT WILL ALSO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SWITCH OVER
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE. FOR
EACH ITEM. LET'S DO THIS. HERE
WE GO, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KIM JOHNSON,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND APPRECIATE ALL
REMARKS YOU HAVE MADE IN THIS
SPACE AND JUST REALLY
RECOGNIZING JUST HOW CHALLENGING
THESE PROPOSALS ARE. YOU'LL SEE,
AND I WILL BE VERY CLEAR FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO IDENTIFY WHICH OF
THE REDUCTIONS ARE, DEFERRALS,
REDUCTIONS OR ELIMINATIONS AS WE
GO FORWARD. I DO ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE DID AIM TO PRESERVE
THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC SUPPORTS, CASH
SUPPORTS, AND CALWORKS GRANTS,
SSI, SSP, TAX CREDITS AND
SEVERAL OTHER PLACES. WE'LL ALSO
TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE GOING
FORWARD. SO FOR A TWO YEAR
AGENDA THAT WE WANT TO COVER, WE
WILL START OUT, AS IDENTIFIED ON
PAGE 18 OF THE PROPOSALS RELATED
TO THE CHILD CARE SLOT
EXPANSION. AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR TROY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, JENNIFER TROYA,
ON BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES, I WILL BOTH
ADDRESS SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS
THAT WERE RELATED TO CHILD CARE
SLOT EXPANSION AND KIND OF GIVE
THE QUICK OVERVIEW AT ONCE, SO
FOR CONTEXT, BEGINNING IN 2122,
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AGREED TO A MULTI YEAR PLAN TO
EXPAND CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES BY
200,000 ADDITIONAL SLOTS. SINCE
THAT TIME, AROUND 118,000 OF
THOSE SLOTS HAVE MATERIALIZED
FOR THE TWO LARGEST CDSS FUNDED
PROGRAMS. THIS INCLUDES ABOUT
153% INCREASE IN ENROLLMENTS IN
THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
VOUCHERS, AND 20% INCREASE IN
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE
CONTRACTED SLOTS AT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO CONTINUE TO
FUND THOSE 118,000 NEW SUBSIDIES
, WHILE PAUSING FURTHER
EXPANSIONS FOR THE CAP
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT, OR CTR
GENERAL CHILD CARE PROGRAM TO
ASSIST IN CLOSING THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL. 118 OR 119 ONE.
SORRY, GO AHEAD. TAMAR WEBER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, IT'S
ACTUALLY 119 OKAY. 119 FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM OR
CAP, THE PAUSE RESULTS IN A
REDUCTION OF 184 MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN 2425 COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES.
THIS REFLECTS AN ESTIMATED
16,000 CAP SLOT PAUSE FOR
GENERAL CHILD CARE, OR CTR. THE
PAUSE RESULTS IN A REDUCTION OF
278 MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
2425, WHICH REFLECTS AN
ESTIMATED 12,000 SLOT PAUSE WITH
RESPECT TO THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM. THE VOUCHER
SIDE. THOSE CONTRACTORS HAVE 24
MONTHS TO ENROLL FAMILIES WITH
THE PRIOR YEAR'S AUGMENTED
FUNDS. THERE ARE NO CHANGES
BEING PROPOSED TO HOW THEY
UTILIZE THOSE PRIOR YEAR FUNDS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN CONTRACT.
MANY OF THOSE CONTRACTORS ARE
STILL ENROLLING FAMILIES WITH
FISCAL YEAR 2223 AND SOME WITH
2324 FUNDING. SO WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING TO CHANGE THAT WITH
RESPECT TO CTR OR GENERAL CHILD
CARE APPLICANTS FOR THE MOST
RECENT RFA RECEIVED IN LATE
MARCH OF THIS YEAR. VERY
RECENTLY, TENTATIVE AWARD
NOTIFICATION OPTIONS NOT
CONTRACTS. NOT AWARDS. TENTATIVE
NOTIFICATION FOR THE PROGRAM
WITH PROPOSED AWARD AMOUNTS TO
BEGIN THIS SUMMER. THOSE
TENTATIVE NOTIFICATIONS
REFERENCED THAT IT'S NOT A
CONTRACT AND THAT THAT THEY
WON'T BE FINALIZED UNTIL
CONTRACTS ARE FULLY EXECUTED AND
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION
. AND OUR INTENT IS TO NOTIFY
CONTRACTORS OF THE MAY REVISE
PROPOSAL WITH THE PAUSE FOR
THEIR PLANNING PURPOSES LATER
THIS MONTH. I GUESS I'LL PAUSE
THERE. OKAY. I'LL ASK QUESTIONS
AFTER JACKIE. LET'S DO JUST THE
FIRST THE SLOT COMMENT. SURE.
WHAT WE WOULD. JACKIE BURROUGHS,
A LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE.
WHAT WE WOULD FLAG THAT AT LEAST
WITHIN THE MULTI YEAR BUDGET,
WE'RE SEEING THAT THE PAUSE IS
INDEFINITE. THERE IS NO FIXED
RESTART DATE. AND THEN AS WAS
MENTIONED, THE PAUSE WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE WITHDRAWING THOSE SLOTS
THAT HAVE BEEN AWARDED AND THAT
WERE PROPOSED TO BE IMPLEMENTED
IN 2425. BUT AS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS NOTED, THESE SLOTS ARE NOT
IN CONTRACT, BUT THERE WERE
TENTATIVE AWARD LETTERS SENT OUT
AS A RESULT OF THIS, THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES A $489
MILLION IN SAVINGS IN 2425, AND
THEN THOSE WOULD INCREASE TO
$1.5 BILLION ON AN ONGOING BASIS
BEGINNING IN 2627. WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND, WHY THE $489
MILLION SAVINGS NUMBER, SEEMS TO
BE $30 MILLION HIGHER THAN WHAT
WAS INITIALLY BUDGETED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR SLOTS TO
BE IMPLEMENTED IN 2425. AND
WE'LL FOLLOW UP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE LATER WHEN WE GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THAT, WE
WOULD NOTE, ALSO THAT THOSE
AWARD LETTERS THAT WERE
RELEASED, AS WAS MENTIONED, THEY
TOTALED $277.7 MILLION FOR ABOUT
12,000, NEW GENERAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS. SO IF THE PAUSE WAS
APPROVED AND INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET, THAT WOULD JUST
MEAN THAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
HAVE TO RESCIND THOSE AWARD
LETTERS AND THEY WOULD NOT BE
PUT INTO CONTRACT, NOT
IMPLEMENTED. AND THEN IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE MORE CONTEXT ON THE
STATUS OF SLOT EXPANSION ACROSS
THE ENTIRE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FIELD, WE WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MAINTAINING NEW STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS THAT SIMILAR TO THE
GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS, WERE
ORIGINALLY AUTHORIZED IN 2122
AND IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL
SPACE. THOSE ARE EXPECTED TO BE
AWARDED AND IMPLEMENTED IN 2425
AS WELL. THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE GENERAL CHILD CARE
AND THE STATE PRESCHOOL SLOT IS
THE FUND SOURCE STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS. THEY'RE FUNDED WITH
PROPOSITION $88, LASTLY, WE WERE
ASKED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT AROUND WHERE, AT WHAT
POINT DID THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE 12,000 NEW
SLOTS? AS I MENTIONED, THESE
TECHNICALLY, FROM A CURRENT LAW
PERSPECTIVE. 122 RIGHT. YES.
THEY WERE ORIGINALLY AUTHORIZED
IN 2122 BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
CATCHING UP TO THOSE, PRIOR SLOT
AUTHORIZATIONS, SO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MAY WANT TO ASK,
AND IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS HOLDING OFF ON
COMMITTING THOSE SLOTS INTO
CONTRACTS UNTIL, THE
DELIBERATIONS OF THIS BUDGET
PROCESS ARE COMPLETE AND WE HAVE
A SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
PROPOSED PAUSE WILL ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED. SO THEN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MAY WANT TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION THE RATIONALE
BEHIND HALTING IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES OF THESE SLOTS, BUT
THEN ALSO, HOW WOULD THAT IMPACT
THE POTENTIAL IMPLEMENTATION
ACTION DATE IF THE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET, WE DID DECIDE TO, AT
LEAST MAINTAIN OAN FUNDING FOR
TO HONOR THE TENTATIVE AWARD
LETTERS. THANK YOU. OKAY, I MEAN
, CÁC AND MY DISTRICT IN MY AREA
HAS 18,000 KIDS ON A WAITLIST,
18,000 KIDS TALKING ABOUT, LIKE,
WE WANT MORE PEOPLE TO WORK, PUT
MOM MAJORITY MOMS. THEY NEED
THIS CHILD CARE SUPPORT. I THINK
THIS IS SUCH A SLAP IN THE FACE
TO THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AS LIKE,
THEIR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY, LIKE,
WE'VE WE'RE ABOUT TO HIT 58
WOMEN, NEXT YEAR. AND I'M LIKE,
THE ONE THING WE'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR IS CHILDCARE AND THIS HUGE
DEAL OF COMMITMENT TO 200,000,
WHERE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
WE'RE LIKE, YES, WE'RE ON. WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO 200,000. WE'RE
WE'RE NOT DEVIATING FROM OUR OUR
PROMISE TO 100,000. JC THIS IS
IT IS AN INDEFINITE CUT AT 119
TÍNH, I THINK THAT'S AGAIN SUCH
JUST JUST A, JUST A SLAP IN THE
FACE FOR OUR, OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE WE PROVIDE CHILDCARE
SUPPORT. YOU KNOW, FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS, MOST OF THIS HAS
BEEN FUNDED, MAJORITY OF IT FROM
FEDERAL FUNDS. AND THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE THE
BILL WHERE WE CHICKENED OUT ON
THIS PRIORITY AND THIS IS JUST
SUCH A HUGE PRIORITY FOR US.
SAME QUESTION. I'LL JUST KEEP
ASKING EVERYONE IS WHY? WHY
SCORING SAVINGS FOR MORE THAN
TWO YEARS? WHY CAN'T THIS BE A
DELAY OF SLOTS FOR TWO YEARS?
AND WE COME BACK TO KEEP GOING?
AND THEN MY NEW QUESTION IS, IS
THE 12,000 POTENTIAL SLOTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TENTATIVELY, I'LL USE
YOUR PHRASE, TENTATIVELY AWARDED
. IS THAT ON TOP OF THE AM I
SUBTRACTING THAT FROM THE 181 19
FROM THE 119? IF WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THOSE. TAMAR WEBER,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO, THE
119 IS WHAT WE THINK OF AS LIKE
CURRENT SERVICE LETTERS. THOSE
HAVE BEEN AWARDED AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THOSE 12,000 WOULD BE ON TOP OF
THAT. SO WHY CAN'T WE JUST DELAY
, WELL, THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
SET A TIME FOR WHEN SLOT
EXPANSION WOULD RESUME, BUT THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT IT DOES NOT
RESUME WITHIN THE OUT YEARS. SO
I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S BEING
SEEN AS NOT A DELAY, BUT I THINK
IT WAS IT'S FAIR TO CONSIDER
LIKE, HOW IS THIS, WHY CAN'T WE
JUST DELAY? WHY? YEAH, I THINK
THE UNCERTAINTY OF THE POTENTIAL
LACK OF LANGUAGE IN HERE THAT
HAS NO VERBIAGE ON WHEN THIS
COULD START UP AGAIN, IS CAUSING
EVEN FURTHER CONCERN ON THIS BIG
CUT. AT MINIMUM, AT MINIMUM,
OBVIOUSLY I WOULDN'T WANT TO I
THIS IS I THINK WHERE I'M WELL I
FEEL LIKE I CAN'T RANK ANYTHING
ANYMORE. IS LANGUAGE FOR WHEN
THIS WILL COME BACK ON I THINK
IS NUMBER ONE. WE SHOULD DO, TO
EASE SOME CONCERN. BUT NUMBER
TWO IS THE TENTATIVE AWARD
LETTERS. FOR THOSE 12,000 I GET,
WE CAN PAUSE. I GET THE BUDGET
SITUATION, I'LL BE ON BOARD.
LET'S PAUSE THE REMAINDER OF IT.
BUT THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS I'M
INTERESTED IN. JUST TO BE ABLE
TO COME BACK AND GET TO THE
200,000, MARK. Ó. HE LEFT. HE'S
OUT OF THE CHILD BEARING YEARS.
SO HE'S TOTALLY OKAY WITH THAT,
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT? GABBY
SANTORA, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE AND
EMPHASIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR CHILD CARE
ACROSS THE STATE, AND THEN DOES
NOT WANT TO DISMISS THE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT
PROVIDERS HAVE MADE TO DO
119,000 EXPANDED SLOTS. THAT IS
GREAT PROGRESS. THIS IS THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT A REFLECTION ON
THE NEED OR THE PROGRESS MADE.
THIS IS REALLY, TRULY TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL. AND GIVEN
THAT WE ARE PROJECTING THAT THIS
SHORTFALL IS AN ISSUE ACROSS THE
MULTI YEAR PERIOD, THAT THAT IS
THE REASONING FOR OUR PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER, WE, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT ALTERNATIVES,
IN ORDER TO, TO MEET OUR
OBLIGATION AND TO SUPPORT THE
FIELD. I HOPE YOU CAN GO BACK TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN SUB FIVE AND
SAY 46 HOUSING UNITS TO SAVE 81
MILLION FROM CDCR IS NOT ENOUGH.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO
SHAVE MORE. I THINK IT WAS LIKE
46 TO 48 HOUSING UNITS, AND I
HAVE 28 THINGS TO LOOK AT IN
CUTS. BUT CDCR ARE CLOSING DOWN
VACANT HOUSING UNITS AND ONLY
SHAVING 81 MILLION LIKE A TIP OF
THE ICEBERG OF THEIR THEIR
BUDGET. AND I HAD A BRIEFING
LAST YESTERDAY WHERE WE CAUSED
126,000 ANNUALLY TO, FOR A
PERSON IN PRISON AND OUR PUPIL
FUNDING IS NOW LIKE 12,000. I
THINK CHILD CARE. I KNOW I'M
DIRECTOR. I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS.
YOU KNOW, JUST IF WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET,
WE ARE, I KNOW WE ARE AND ARE
THERE ARE WAY MORE OTHER CUTS WE
CAN MAKE IN OTHER PLACES THAT
CAN BE DELAYS. AND THIS IS IN A
POPULAR OPINION, I THINK. BUT
PUBLIC TRANSIT, I THINK WE WILL
SURVIVE IF WE DELAY PUBLIC
TRANSIT FOR A YEAR OR TWO.
THAT'S NOT MY SUBCOMMITTEE, BUT
I'M JUST SAYING, LIKE WE COULD
SURVIVE, YOU KNOW, DELAYING 1 OR
2. THESE ARE JUST LIKE, REALLY
LONGITUDAL. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S A WORD. THAT'S A WORD.
THANK YOU IMPACTS RIGHT WHERE
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR US JUST TO
COME BACK FOR SURE. IF YOU
WEREN'T HERE. I WAS WAITING TO
SEE IF I'VE MADE IT TO FIRST
PLACE. AND MOST TALKATIVE
LEGISLATOR I THINK I JUST GOT UP
TO LIKE THE FIRST PLACE ON CAL
MATTERS. IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW I
WAS IN NUMBER TWO BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STARTED, I THINK
I'M NUMBER ONE NOW. OKAY AND
THEN THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE IS
RELATED TO WHAT JACKIE MENTIONED
ABOUT THE SLOTS OF THE 12,000
ONES WAS THAT FUNDING ALLOCATED
FROM THREE YEARS AGO, 2122 AND
IS THAT WHERE WE'RE PULLING
FROM? TAMAR WEBER, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THE FUNDING WASN'T
ALLOCATED IN 2122. WHAT HAPPENED
IN 2122, RIGHT, IS THAT THAT'S
WHEN THE PLAN WAS DEVELOPED. AND
THERE WERE GOALS SET OF HOW MANY
SLOTS WOULD GET INTRODUCED IN
EACH YEAR. BUT THE ACTUAL
FUNDING WAS ALWAYS JUST ONE YEAR
APPROPRIATION, AN ESTIMATE OF
HOW MUCH TO GET TO THIS TARGET
THE FOLLOWING YEAR, AN ESTIMATE
OF HOW MUCH TO GET TO THIS
TARGET. SO WE ALLOCATED NUMBER
OF SLOTS PER YEAR. RIGHT. YEAH.
SO THERE IS NO FUNDING THAT WAS
APPROVED IN PRIOR YEARS. WERE
SLOTS APPROPRIATED THOUGH. THERE
WERE SLOT TARGETS BUT THERE,
THERE WERE NO THERE'S NOTHING IN
STATUTE ABOUT THE SLOTS. IT WAS
LIKE WE HAD A PLAN AND THEN WE
ESTIMATED HOW MUCH IT COST. AND
I DIDN'T WANT TO CODIFY THE
200,000, CHAIR, IF I COULD, I
WOULD JUST CLARIFY THAT LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET, AN APPROPRIATION
WAS MADE TO CONTINUE TO FUND MAC
AT THE MAXIMUM LEVELS. THE
INTENDED GOALS FOR THE 2122 AND
THE 2223 SLOTS, THE DOLLARS WERE
APPROPRIATED, FOR A TOTAL OF
50,000 SLOTS IN THE CTR PROGRAM.
AT THIS TIME, ONLY 22,000 HAVE
BEEN FILLED, SO THAT 12,000
WOULD STILL COUNT TOWARDS MAKING
GOOD ON THE PRIOR 50,000, WHICH
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND UNDER THE
2324 BUDGET, THOSE DOLLARS WERE
APPROPRIATED. HOWEVER, THEY WERE
NOT ALLOCATED BECAUSE THOSE
12,000 HAVE NOT BEEN PUT INTO
CONTRACT YET. SO I JUST THINK
IT'S LIKE APPROPRIATION VERSUS
ALLOCATION THERE WERE
ENCUMBERED. WERE THEY
ENCUMBERED? NO, BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IN ORDER TO BE
ENCUMBERED A FUNDING COMMITMENT
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE BEEN MADE TO
PROVIDERS. THEY WERE
APPROPRIATED. AND DSS, THE
REASON WHY WE DID THE ONE YEAR
DELAY LAST YEAR WAS TO ALLOW,
THE FIELD TO CATCH UP AND TO
MEET THAT 50,000 SLOT NUMBER
THAT WE'VE APPROPRIATED IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS. OKAY SO THIS I
THINK WE HAD WAS THERE A BCP
PREVIOUSLY AROUND PUSHING OUT
THE APPLICATION TIME FOR. NEVER
MIND. DOES IT MATTER? IT'S
TOTALLY OKAY. OKAY, NO FURTHER
COMMENT ON THIS. FIRST ONE. WE
CAN GO ON TO THE SECOND ISSUE.
THE SECOND ITEM, THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE, PROGRAM IS
AIMING TO FACILITATE IMMEDIATE
PLACEMENT OF CHILDREN WITH
WITHIN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND TO A STABLE CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT SETTING BY HELPING
RELATIVES PARENTING YOUTH
RESOURCE FAMILIES OBTAIN CHILD
CARE SERVICES UPON PLACEMENT. SO
THERE'S VOUCHERS, ACTUAL CHILD
CARE SUBSIDIES AS WELL AS CHILD
CHILD CARE NAVIGATOR SERVICES TO
ASSIST WITH FINDING FAMILIES,
CHILD CARE OPTIONS, AND THEN
ALSO TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING
AND COACHING FOR THE WORKFORCE.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
REDUCE THE BRIDGE PROGRAM BY
34.8 MILLION. GENERAL FUND TO
MORE CLOSELY ALIGN WITH PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES. THIS REPRESENTS
40% OF TOTAL STATE FUNDS, AND OF
THE PROPOSED SOLUTION, $9
MILLION IS PROPOSED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ALLOCATION, 25.8
FROM THE VOUCHER ASSISTANCE AND,
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
LEGISLATIVE ACTION FIRST
APPROVED IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
2022 FOR 2223 EXPENDITURES, THEY
WERE APPROXIMATELY 59% OF
APPROPRIATION. JACKIE, ANY
COMMENT ON THIS ONE? YES. I
WOULD JUST FLAG THAT, IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE
REDUCTIONS GENERALLY MIRROR
WHAT, AN AUGMENTATION. THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND
AUTHORIZED IN THE 22 BUDGET ACT.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE JUST
ROLLING BACK THOSE AUGMENTATIONS
ON THE VOUCHER SIDE, IT DOES
SEEM LIKE THE SAVINGS GENERALLY,
GENERALLY ALIGN WITH HOW MUCH
FUNDING HAS GONE UNSPENT IN
RECENT YEARS. THAT TENDS TO
RANGE BETWEEN 13 MILLION TO 40
MILLION. HOWEVER A QUESTION IN
THE AGENDA IS TO WHAT EXTENT
WILL FUTURE DEMAND, COME IN AT
PREVIOUS LEVELS? IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING, JUST ANECDOTALLY,
TALKING TO FOLKS THAT PERHAPS
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
VOUCHER SLOTS HAVE COME IN LOWER
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASES IN THE
OTHER CHILD CARE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ABLE TO THEN ABSORB THE
DEMAND AMONGST THOSE FAMILIES.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE
PAUSING THE FUTURE SLOT
INCREASES AND THE OTHER CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS, THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THE DEMAND FOR
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
SLOTS MAY BE HIGHER THAN
PREVIOUS TRENDS. WE HAVE NO
INSIGHT ON ACTUAL TRAINING COSTS
AND HOW THAT COMPARES TO THE
REDUCTION IN THE TRAINING
PROGRAM, BUT WE'VE ASKED FOR
THAT BACKUP AND WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH STAFF WITH ANY CONCERNS.
RIGHT? YOU KNOW, I, I THAT'S
WHAT I THOUGHT AS WELL. YOU KNOW
THE EMERGENCY VÆ IS TO, YOU
KNOW, CAN'T FIND IT. BUT THE
SLOTS INCREASES HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO MEET THE NEEDS.
NOW IF WE REMOVE INCREASE OF
SLOTS AND REMOVE THE EMERGENCY
OPPORTUNITY VOUCHERS, IT'S
REALLY LEAVING THEM WITH
ABSOLUTELY NO OPTION ON ON THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE. JUST
TO CLARIFY, SENATOR, WE DO THE
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS A
REDUCTION NOT AN ELIMINATION.
THIS WILL CONTINUE AND IT WILL
CONTINUE. AND IN FACT, IS,
ESSENTIALLY FUNDING THE PROGRAM
AT THE CURRENT AROUND THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF EXPENDITURE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE ACTUALLY
DON'T ANTICIPATE, AN ACTUAL
IMPACT OF OR DISENROLLMENT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT HERE. THANK
YOU. DIRECTOR. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT? KRISH MALHOTRA,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT THE
DIRECTOR SAID, THERE'S STILL $59
MILLION OF FUNDING IN THIS
PROGRAM UNDER THE PROPOSAL, 48.6
MILLION OF THAT BEING GENERAL
FUND, 6.5 MILLION BEING FEDERAL
FUND AND 3.75 MILLION BEING PROP
64. THANK YOU. FINAL ITEM ON
CHILD CARE. GABBY SANTORO,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THIS ITEM
, COVERS, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO SCORE SAVINGS BASED
ON PROJECTED UNSPENT FUNDS AND
MAXIMIZATION OF OTHER BALANCES
TO CREATE GENERAL FUND SAVINGS,
FIRST, THERE IS AN ESTIMATED
$206.7 MILLION FEDERAL FUND
BALANCE PROJECTED TO GO AND
SPENT BY JUNE 30TH OF THIS YEAR.
THIS ESTIMATED BALANCE IS
COMPOSED OF 97 POINT SORRY,
206.7 MILLION, WITHIN THIS
BALANCE, IT'S COMPOSED OF 97.2
MILLION AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT, OR ARPA DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS, 100.8 108.4 CHILD CARE
DEVELOPMENT FUND, OR CDF, AND
1.1 TITLE 20 FUNDS. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO SWAP
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES,
EXPENDITURES WITH UNSPENT
FEDERAL FUNDS IN CURRENT YEAR
BEFORE THEIR LIQUIDATION
DEADLINE TO SCORE THE BALANCE OF
SAVINGS IN THE CURRENT YEAR, WE
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
ALSO AN ADDITIONAL ESTIMATED
71.6 MILLION CDF BALANCE,
PROJECTED TO GO UNSPENT BY JUNE
30TH. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
EVALUATING ELIGIBLE OBLIGATIONS
TO CONDUCT A FUND SWAP WITH
GENERAL FUND. HOWEVER WE DO WANT
TO NOTE THERE IS NOT A RISK OF
REVERSION THAT WOULD REQUIRE RE
OBLIGATION OF THIS BALANCE BY
THE 24 BUDGET ENACTMENT POINT IN
TIME. SO THAT AGAIN, THE LAST
PART. SURE, SO, SO WE'RE NOTING
THERE IS A PROJECTED UNSPENT
BALANCE. THIS IS FOR CDF, WHICH
IS MORE OF WE CONSIDER THE
TYPICAL FEDERAL AWARD, UNLIKE
THE FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS THAT WE
HAVE TO LIQUIDATE BY SEPTEMBER
OF THIS YEAR, WE DO HAVE MORE
TIME TO DECIDE HOW TO USE THESE
FUNDS WITHOUT HAVING RISK OF
REVERSION. WE DON'T HAVE TO
DECIDE RIGHT AT THE 24TH WHEN,
WHEN, UP TO WHAT POINT DO WE
HAVE TO DECIDE, I DON'T HAVE
THAT AT MY FINGERTIPS, BUT IT'S
AFTER WE CAN MAKE THAT DECISION
AFTER THE 24 BUDGET ENACTMENT,
AND 12,000 SLOTS. THERE WE GO.
THAT'S WHERE WE PULL IT FROM.
RIGHT. BUT HAPPY TO CONSIDER
THAT THAT OPTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE, THE, AND THEN JUST
WANT TO NOTE REGARDING THE
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS OF THE 5.3
BILLION FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS THE
STATE RECEIVED FOR CHILD CARE
FOR COVID RELIEF, ABOUT 19
MILLION IS PROJECTED TO REVERT
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OKAY, LET'S HOLD IT RIGHT THERE.
HOLD ON. 19 MILLION IS GOING TO
GO BACK BY SEPTEMBER. THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE PROJECTING. YES. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW I DON'T
UNDERSTAND 19 MILLION IS GOING
TO BE CLAWED BACK. BUT WE CAN'T
FUND SOME 12,000 SLOTS. SO WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE IS DO AN
EVALUATION OF ELIGIBLE USES FOR
THE BALANCE THAT WERE PROJECTED
TO GO TO CHILD CARE FUNDS.
RIGHT? CORRECT. YES. I'M SORRY,
I'M SORRY, I'M SO SORRY. IS
THERE A PROBLEM? I DON'T SEE
THE. WHAT PROBLEM AM I MISSING
HERE? YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
ELIGIBLE OPPORTUNITIES TO USE
THE FUND. THAT IS CORRECT. BUT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO NOT FUND
12,000 SLOTS. YES. I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS IS, SLOTS
WOULD NOT BE AN ELIGIBLE USE FOR
THIS. SO THAT'S A PROBLEM. WE
CAN'T USE THAT. CORRECT? CORRECT
BUT WE CAN USE IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE IN THE CHILD. CAN YOU USE
IT FOR EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM? NO. YOU'RE
SAYING NO. WHAT CAN WE USE. WHAT
CAN WE USE IT FOR? WHAT IS THE
LIST? AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
LIST, I WOULD LIKE TO. YES
HAPPY. HAPPY TO HAVE ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS. RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS A
IT'S A SHARED INTEREST BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAXIMIZE ALL
FUNDS THAT STAY IN FOR SURE
CHILD CARE BECAUSE I THINK YOU
ALL TOLD ME WE WERE GOING TO USE
IT ALL. WE THINK THAT'S WHY YOU
ALL SAID TO ME AND THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE WORRIED THAT
EVERYTHING WAS GOING TO BE USED.
AND IF 1 MILLION OF IT IS IN
USE, THAT'S ONE I HAVE THINGS ON
HERE TO CUT THAT ARE $2 MILLION
I JUST DON'T LIKE. WE CAN'T HAVE
A SINGLE PENNY BE CLAWED BACK.
Y'ALL TOLD ME YOU WERE GOING TO
SPEND IT. WE. I KNOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO YOU TOO. I CAN SEE
IT. PLEASE. LET'S LIKE NEXT
WEEK. LET'S THAT LIST. AND IF WE
NEED TO MOVE AROUND, THIS SHOULD
GO INTO THE SLOTS AND IT. AND
JUST FUND THE 19 MILLION TO
SOMETHING. WHAT IS ELIGIBLE IN
CHILD CARE. BUT WE'VE ALSO YOU
KNOW WE HAD THOSE OTHER CLOSE TO
1 BILLION SAVINGS IN CHILD CARE.
THAT'S IF I'M NOT TELL ME IF I'M
WRONG HERE BEING SWEPT TO
GENERAL FUND, NOT BEING USED FOR
CHILD CARE. SO THE CHILD CARE
COMMUNITY, WE LOST ALMOST $1
BILLION BECAUSE THE GENERAL FUND
IS BEING USED. AND NOW WE'RE
PROPOSING NO, THIS CUTS TO THE
CHILD CARE COMMUNITY. LIKE THEY
CAN'T BALANCE THE BUDGET AND NOT
GET ANYTHING OUT OF THIS. THANK
YOU. HAPPY HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
THAT. THANK YOU. SO WE'LL GET
THE LIST AND COME UP WITH A WAY
TO REINVEST THE 19 AND HAVE
NOTHING GO BACK. AND UNLESS,
UNLESS, UNLESS YOU'RE SAYING
LIKE THERE'S IT'S TOO LATE AND
WE CAN'T WE CAN'T SEND OUT THE
FUNDING. I THINK WHAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO IS ENGAGE AND, WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO, TO
DETAIL THE PROCESS THAT WE WENT
THROUGH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
MAXIMIZING, FUNDS SO THAT AT
LEAST JUST A STARTING POINT. SO
THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
WE BECAUSE I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF TIME. I JUST, I DON'T I
DON'T WANT THIS I KNOW, I KNOW
Y'ALL FOLLOW UP ON A LOT OF MY
QUESTIONS AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
LIKE OUTSIDE OF SUB THREE. BUT I
DON'T WANT THIS TO FALL THROUGH
THE CRACK AND THEN IT'S JULY
1ST. AND YOU KNOW, WE COULDN'T
FIGURE IT OUT. SO I REALLY WANT
US TO PRIORITIZE IN THIS SPACE.
THE CHILD CARE LIKE THAT 19
MILLION TO BE ABLE IN TRACKING.
IF YOU COULD HELP US HOLD HOLD
THIS ACCOUNTABLE I WANT TO FIND
THIS A WAY TO MAKE SURE NOTHING
GETS CLAWED BACK. OKAY. SO,
SENATOR, ANYTHING ON CHILD CARE
YOU DON'T NEED CHILD CARE
SERVICES. OKAY? WE'RE GOING TO
DO PUBLIC COMMENT ON CHILD CARE
SERVICES. ONLY CHILD CARE ONLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PASSION IN CHILD CARE. MY NAME
IS DENISE KELLER. I AM A FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDER. FOR THE
PAST 24 YEARS OUT OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. AND THIS IS A
PROFESSION THAT I LOVE. I SPOKE
LAST MONTH AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AT THE CARE CONVENING AND I SAW
YOU LAST, LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO OVER, WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS
WE'VE MADE SO MUCH PROGRESS.
PLEASE DON'T STOP NOW. DON'T
TAKE THESE FUNDS AWAY FROM US.
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE SLOTS TO BE
LET GO. WE WERE PROMISED THIS IN
20 2021 AND 2022. I TELL YOU, I
HAVE COUNTLESS FAMILIES WHO NEED
SUBSIDIES TO COME, AND I TURN
THEM AWAY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT. THE NEXT ISSUE IS
REALLY QUICKLY BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T A LOT OF TIME LEFT. YES,
MA'AM. THE NEXT ISSUE IS WE WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE FOR THEM
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR RATE
REFORM. WE ARE ONLY BEING PAID
FOR THE REGIONAL MARKET RATES
FROM 2018. SO PLEASE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. JUST AS YOU KEEP ALL YOUR
COMMENTS UNDER A MINUTE, PLEASE.
SURE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A CHAMPION.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROSS. THANK
YOU, DIRECTOR. MY NAME IS HORSE
TURNER, CHILD CARE PROVIDER OUT
OF STANISLAUS COUNTY, A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE CPU, UW 3930. WE
ARE HERE AS A PROUD CHAMPION.
FIGHTERS AS PROVIDERS, AS ON THE
ON THE FLOOR, IN THE TRENCHES
FIGHTING FOR THESE SLOTS. DO NOT
TAKE THESE AWAY. THEY WERE
PROMISED TO US BECAUSE IT'S NOT
FOR US. WE'RE ALREADY TAKING THE
ON OUR BACKS AND OUR SHOULDERS
TO PROVIDE CHILD CARE AT THE LOW
RATES THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
2015. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A REAL
TRUE RATE REFORM GOING ON. BUT
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES, IF THERE
WAS A DAY WITHOUT CHILD CARE, IT
WILL CRUMBLE THE ECONOMY.
THERE'S TOO MANY PROVIDERS. SO
THESE WORDS ARE ARE HEARD AND
FELT. BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
IT'S FOUGHT FOR. THANK YOU FOR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RATE REFORM. WE
MUST FOLLOW THAT AND CONTINUE
THE PROCESS. YOU KNOW, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY SECOND,
SIR, I GOT YOU THE FUNDING OF
$70 MILLION THAT'S GOING TO BE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA. MAKE SURE
CPU IS AT THE TABLE TO
DISTINGUISH HOW THAT'S GOING TO
BE DISTRIBUTED. SO PROVIDERS CAN
HAVE A RESOURCE AND MAKING SURE.
THANK YOU SIR. FOURTH, THANK YOU
. THANK YOU KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER
WITH SEIU. ON BEHALF OF CPU. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ON
SLOTS. NOT ONLY ARE THERE A
MILLION CHILDREN THAT QUALIFY,
BUT DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
100,000 WAS A STARTING POINT AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
COMMITMENT, REJECT THE PAUSE AND
CODIFY THE COMMITMENT IS OUR
ASK. AS WELL AS ADOPTING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT REFLECTS THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THE NEW
METHODOLOGY IN ORDER FOR IT TO
BE TIMELY AND SEAMLESS. WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU WILL HEAR AND HAVE LATER ON
AROUND CALWORKS WITHOUT
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES, MANY WILL
HAVE EVEN LESS ACCESS. ONLY
CHILD CARE RIGHT NOW. CHILD CARE
RELATED. JUST WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN STAY IN THE
WORKFORCE. THEY NEED ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE. THESE ARE ALL
RELATED. APPRECIATE THAT. WE
WANT TO REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY AND
COOPERATION IN DECIDING ON THE
ALLOCATION COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. THERE'S 77
MILLION TO COME AND THAT'S MEANT
TO SUPPLEMENT, NOT SUPPLANT.
FINALLY, WE WANT TO REESTABLISH
THE CHILD CARE REVERSION ACCOUNT
TO PROTECT INVESTMENTS,
INVESTMENTS IN CHILD CARE. AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER CPU IS
ABLE AND READY TO HELP EXPEDITE
THE RELEASE OF THOSE ARPA
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THEY GET TO
THE PROVIDERS AS INTENDED. SO WE
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA. I JUST WANT
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH OUR
AFSCME AFFILIATE, UW LOCAL 3930.
AND OUR PARTNERS AT SEIU AND
CPU, AND A REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY ABOUT
PRIORITIZING CHILD CARE FOR
THOSE IN OUR STATE. THANKS,
JANICE. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
DIRECTOR ANDREW SHANE FROM GRACE
AND CHILD POVERTY WILL ALIGN
WITH CPU PARENT VOICES AND
OTHERS AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
WE SHOULD BRING BACK THE
CENTRALIZED LIST. I THINK THAT
GOES BACK TO SCHWARZENEGGER SO
WE CAN REALLY KNOW WHAT THE
UNMET NEED IS. THANK YOU.
MARIAM. YOU KNOW, CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER PAYING CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS A FAIR WAGE IS AN
ANTI-RACIST POLICY THAT IS
ESSENTIAL AND LONG OVERDUE. WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMPLEMENT, IMPLEMENT AND FUND
THE ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. PAYING
PROVIDERS BASED ON THE FULL COST
OF A WRENCHING CARE IS A
CRITICAL STEP IN WRITING
HISTORICAL WRONGS. CHILD CARE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THRIVING FAMILIES
AND JUSTICE AND COMMUNITIES AS
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES LANGUISH
ON CHILD CARE WAITING LISTS, WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP ITS
COMMITMENT TO ISSUE THE 200,000
SPACES BY 2627 AND REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUT OF
AUTHORIZED SPACES. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CODIFY ITS
COMMITMENT IN STATUTE AS WELL,
AS WELL AS WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO REJECT CUTS TO
THE CHILD CARE BRIDGE FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE FAMILIES
NEED AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KRISTIN POWELL WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS. I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE CUTS TO THE CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAM, SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS CASE, THE EMERGENCY CHILD
CARE BRIDGE, WHICH SUPPORTS OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN FOSTER
CARE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
KIM LEWIS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW AND JUST WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE COALITION
ABOUT REJECTING THE CUTS TO
CHILD CARE AND NON-EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE. I WOULD NOTE
AT THE TIME THE ADMINISTRATION
IS LOOKING TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE INCREASED PLACEMENTS WITH
RELATIVES. THE BRIDGE PROGRAM
HELPS US TO ALLOW THAT IN 40% OF
BRIDGE PARTICIPANTS SURVEYED
SAID THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCEPT THE
PLACEMENT IF THEY HADN'T BEEN
OFFERED THE BRIDGE PROGRAM. SO I
WOULD URGE YOU TO REJECT THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MONIQUE
RAMOS, ON BEHALF OF THE EC
COALITION, WE WANT TO THANK YOU
AND ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS.
FRANKLY, YOU'VE ALREADY MADE
TODAY. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE
WAS $1 BILLION COMMITTED TO
SPACES AT SOME POINT. SO WE ARE
SWEEPING $1 BILLION FROM SERVING
CHILDREN AND WE HAVE REAL
HEARTACHE AS A FIELD ABOUT WHAT
THAT DOES TO FAMILIES AND THE
LARGER ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT
THAT'S HAVING. ADDITIONALLY WE
BELIEVE THERE ARE $77,000,000
MILLION COMING IN FROM THE FEDS,
AND THAT COULD BE USED FOR
SPACES FOR ONGOING. AND THAT'S
NOT A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION TODAY,
AND THEN FINALLY, WE'RE WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
TIMELINE FOR THE RELEASE OF THE
200,000 SPACES. WE TOOK EVERYONE
AT THEIR WORD AND A PROMISE THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE DONE, AND
IT HASN'T BEEN DONE, AND WE'RE
ALSO FOLLOWING UP WITH TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR A COMMITMENT
ON THE ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY,
AND APPRECIATE ALL THIS
COMMITTEE'S HARD WORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATOR ROSANNA
CARVACHO ELLIOTT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM, I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE COALITION AND
WITH YOU. MADAM CHAIR, I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR TIME AND
EFFORT ON THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES AND YOUR PASSION. I DON'T
KNOW THAT I CAN SAY IT BETTER
THAN YOU, BUT WE ARE VERY
OPPOSED TO THE INDEFINITE PAUSE
OF THESE OF THE SLOT EXPANSION.
VERY DISHEARTENED AS JUST LIKE
YOU ARE TO HEAR THAT THERE'S $19
MILLION THAT WILL BE GOING BACK
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
YEARS AS WELL, AND GETTING THE
SAME ANSWER THAT NO, WE WILL
SPEND EVERYTHING, SO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND REALLY HOPE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WILL REJECT THE
PAUSE AND HAVE A REAL TIMELINE
FOR THE ALTERNATIVE RATE
METHODOLOGY. SO WE DON'T FALL
OFF THAT CLIFF IN JUNE OF 25.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS. KATHY
MOSSBERG WITH THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION. JUST WANT TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS BY
THE COALITION AND REALLY DO
REJECT THE PAUSE AND CODIFY THE
COMMITMENT. THANK YOU. REBECCA
GONZALEZ, WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. I WANT TO THANK
YOU, CHAIRMAN HAVAR, FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SLOTS. AND WE
REALLY OPPOSE, OPPOSE THAT
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EILEEN KOMANSKI WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
REDUCTIONS TO THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM, WHICH
IS A CHILD CARE PROGRAM. IT'S
ALSO A FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. WE
USE IT TO BRIDGE THE TIME
BETWEEN HAVING A CAREGIVER, A
YOUTH COME INTO CARE SUPPORTING
THAT CAREGIVER RIGHT AWAY WITH
CHILD CARE NEEDS UNTIL THEY CAN
GET A SLOT. SO ALL OF THESE CUTS
ARE ALL RELATED, AND I DO
ANTICIPATE THAT UTILIZATION WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW FOR THAT
PROGRAM, IN LIGHT OF THE OTHER
CUTS IN THE CHILD CARE SPACE. SO
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THAT PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO, MARIA ROMO WITH
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. I
HAVE FOUR THINGS THAT I WANT TO
SAY. ONE, WE NEED TO SECURE THE
TIMELINE AND IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
FOR THE COST OF CARE RATE LAUNCH
IN 2025. TWO. WE NEED TO RESTORE
THE PROMISE TO MOVE 200,000
SLOTS OVER TIME AS THE BUDGET
ALLOWS. GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
BROKE HIS PROMISE TO US FROM
2021, AND NEARLY 2 MILLION
FAMILIES, FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
WILL SUFFER THE COST, THE
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE OF IT.
THREE WE NEED TO RESCIND THE
ONGOING CUT TO THE BUDGET
PROGRAM, AND FOUR, WE NEED TO
RESTORE THE RESCINDED GENERAL
CHILD CARE CONTRACTS. WE CANNOT
PIT PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES
AGAINST EACH OTHER BECAUSE BOTH
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED AND
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
KATHY SONDERLING MCDONNELL FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY EXPRESSING
CONCERNS ABOUT BOTH THE
OVERARCHING PAUSE ON THE 200,000
SLOTS, ALONG WITH NO TIMELINE ON
WHEN THAT WOULD BE ACHIEVED AND
NO COMMITMENT, AS WELL AS HOW
MUCH, AS MS. KUBINSKI SAID, FOR
QUDAH, THAT WILL EXACERBATE THE
NEED FOR THAT EMERGENCY BRIDGE
HOUSING PROGRAM IN FOSTER CARE,
HITTING THE SAME FAMILIES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WILL ONLY MAKE
THE PROBLEM WORSE OVERALL. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CLOSES
OUT. KEVIN KEVIN ESTÁN COALITION
COALITION CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION OPPOSING THE
CHILDCARE CUTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
NEXT ONE BECAUSE IT STANDS ALONE
ALL WITH CALWORKS AS WELL
BECAUSE IT'S A YEAH. SO WAIT FOR
EVERYBODY TO MOVE AROUND
.
THANK THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS KIM JOHNSON, CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO, AS YOU KNOW, IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, JANUARY
BUDGET, WE HAD PROPOSED SOME
DELAYS FOR THE THREE HOUSING
PROGRAMS SPECIFIC TO THREE
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THAT WE
FOCUS ON. THOSE PROPOSALS WITH
THE MAY REVISION AND THE DEFICIT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED FOR
REDUCTION. SO I'LL GO THROUGH
THOSE VERY QUICKLY. THE HOUSING
AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM
IS ASSISTING INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS, WHO ARE LIKELY
ELIGIBLE FOR DISABILITY
BENEFITS, WE'VE SPOKEN TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSED
THE REVERSION OF FUNDING FROM
THE 2022 BUDGET ACT, ON GOING,
EXCUSE ME, OF $50 MILLION
GENERAL FUND. THERE IS ONGOING
FUNDING FOR DAP OF 25 MILLION
THAT'S UNAFFECTED BY THIS
PROPOSAL. 25 MILLION ONGOING IS
UNAFFECTED. THAT'S CORRECT. AND
I'LL JUST NOTE FOR THE
COMMITTEE, H.R. ESTIMATE IS THAT
11,126 FEWER ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES WOULD BE IMPACTED
BY THIS PROPOSED REVISION. WHAT
DO YOU MEAN? SO, OF THE 50
MILLION THAT'S BEING PROPOSED TO
BE REVERTED, THAT'S WHO WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN SERVED. IF
WE WERE ABLE TO DEFER
INDIVIDUALS. THAT'S CORRECT. FOR
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME, THIS
PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
, FAMILIES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WHO ARE EXPERIENCING AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS, WITH THE
GOAL OF INCREASING FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND AVOIDING
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT. AGAIN,
THE MERRY VERSION PROPOSES
REVERSION OF FUNDING FROM THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2022 OF $80
MILLION. GENERAL FUND. WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL, THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM
WOULD SUNSET ON JUNE OF 2025, WE
ESTIMATE, AGAIN, 11,000, 363
FEWER FAMILIES INVOLVED IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS PROPOSAL. WAS
THIS A ONE TIME ALLOCATION? YES
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME WAS A ONE
TIME MULTIYEAR APPROPRIATION. SO
IT WAS GOING TO SUNSET. IT WAS
GOING TO SUNSET. CORRECT IT
SUNSET IN A YEAR EARLIER OR IT'S
ACTUALLY SUNSETTING AT ITS
ORIGINAL SCHEDULE. THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE EXTENDED THE PROGRAM
FOR 25. GOT IT. OKAY. AND THEN
FINALLY HOME SAFE, FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING, PREVENTING OR
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS FOR
THOSE IN OUR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES POPULATION AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SERVED BY
TRIBAL SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES
WHO APPEAR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES ELIGIBLE, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES REVERSION OF
THE FUNDING. FUNDING FROM THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2022 AT $65
MILLION. AGAIN, THIS WAS ALSO A
ONE TIME APPROPRIATION.
MULTI-YEAR SCHEDULED TO SUNSET.
SO HERE, FUNDING FOR HOME SAFE
WOULD SUNSET JUNE 30TH OF 2025.
ALSO WE ESTIMATE THAT 15,564,
INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
BEEN SERVED IF THE FUNDING WAS
TO EXIST. IS THAT ALSO ON TRACK
WITH THE PREVIOUS SUNSET? THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY. THOSE ARE THE
THREE HOUSING PROPOSALS FOR THE
MAY REVISION. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO DO WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO
CALWORKS. OKAY. YEAH OKAY.
CALWORKS, SO SORRY, DIRECTOR, I
TOTALLY FORGOT TO TURN TO YOU.
IF YOU HAD ANY COMMENTS ON THE
HOUSING ONES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. JINNEY BELLA WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. AS
YOU HAVE HEARD, THESE WERE
PROPOSALS THAT IN JANUARY WE
WERE HEARING WERE DELAYS. AND AT
THAT POINT, THE THOUGHT WAS THAT
IT WOULD THE AMOUNT THAT WAS
DELAYED WOULD LEAVE THESE
PROGRAMS WITH A ROUGHLY THE SAME
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THEY WOULD
NEED TO GET THROUGH THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND WE DID HEAR SOME
COUNTY BY COUNTY VARIATION OF
THAT. AND AT THAT TIME, WE WERE
IT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING WE
WOULD HEAR BACK AGAIN WITH AN
UPDATED ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH
WOULD BE AVAILABLE, BECAUSE TIME
HAS PASSED, MONEY IS BEING
SPENT. AND SO AT THIS POINT, WE
REMAIN HAVING THAT QUESTION WITH
THESE, WITH THESE REDUCTIONS,
WHAT IS LEFT FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR FOR THE PROGRAMS, HOW MUCH
IS LEFT, AND IS THERE ANY SORT
OF COUNTY VARIATION IN IN TERMS
OF WHAT COUNTIES WOULD RUN OUT
FASTER OR SLOWER THAN OTHERS?
AND WE HEARD DIRECTOR 25 MILLION
FROM BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
WOULD BE LEFT AT $25 MILLION FOR
DAP IS AN ONGOING APPROPRIATION
THÀNH DAP. I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY
I ASKED. OKAY, SO WE DON'T KNOW.
FOR THE OTHER TWO PROGRAMS WE
CAN'T WE CAN SHARE THAT. GO FOR
IT. SO TO ADDRESS OR SORRY
ITALY'S DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
TO ADDRESS THE LIU'S QUESTION ON
THAT, WE HAVE UPDATED
EXPENDITURES FOR THE THREE
PROGRAM TEAMS WHEN LOOKING AT
JUST LOCAL ASSISTANCE, THE
REMAINING BALANCES FOR EACH OF
THE PROGRAMS FROM THE 2022
APPROPRIATIONS IS BASED ON
REPORTED EXPENDITURES THROUGH
MARCH OF 2024. WE NOTE THAT NO
EXPENDITURES HAVE BEEN MADE TO
THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME AND
HOME SAFE ALLOCATIONS. NOW, WHEN
LOOKING AT THE AMOUNTS BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME, IT REMAINS 87.8
MILLION. HOME SAFE IS 87.8
MILLION AS WELL, AND DAP IS
140.5 MILLION. THAT REMAINS FROM
THE 2022 APPROPRIATION. OKAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WILL CARRY US
INTO THE DATES THAT YOU
MENTIONED. OKAY SO AGAIN, THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IN THE PROPOSAL
FROM JANUARY TO MAY IS THAT WE
HAD BEEN WORKING WITH COUNTIES
AND WITH IDA TO ASSESS KIND OF
EXPENDITURE RATES PROJECTED
ÓRDENES. COULD WE EVEN DO
DISTRIBUTIONS FROM SOME COUNTIES
THAT ARE OVERSPENDING TO THOSE
WHO WHO MIGHT NOT FULLY UTILIZE.
AND SO, AGAIN, I JUST WOULD SAY
FROM THE POINT IN TIME DATA
THAT'S GOING TO REFLECT
EXPENDITURES DÍAS POINT IN TIME
BASED ON CLAIMS, CLAIMS ARE
ALWAYS IN ARREARS. SO WE DON'T
HAVE REAL TIME INFORMATION ON
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES. AND THAT'S
THE WORK THAT WE WERE DOING WITH
COUNTIES AND IDA. SO JUST WOULD
NOTE THAT IF YOU'RE HEARING
DIFFERENT NUMBERS ONCE A POINT
IN TIME, BASED ON WHAT WE HAVE
IN CLAIMING ANOTHER MIGHT BE
MORE SPECIFIC, BASED ON
PROJECTIONS FROM THE COUNTIES
THEMSELVES AND WHAT THEY COULD
EXPEND. GOT IT. OKAY. ANY
ADDITIONAL. OKAY. LET'S GO INTO
CALWORKS CALWORKS HOME VISITING.
THIS IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM,
SUPPORTING POSITIVE HEALTH
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL-BEING
OUTCOMES FOR PREGNANT AND
PARENTING PEOPLE, FAMILIES AND
INFANTS BORN INTO POVERTY.
PARTICIPATING IN OUR CALWORKS
PROGRAM. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TOTAL FUNDING OF 58
MILLION FOR THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. IT'S REFLECTS A
REDUCTION OF 47.1 MILLION IN
2425 AND ONGOING TO ADJUST TO
FUNDING UTILIZATION. THÀNH, I
WOULD NOTE THAT IN TERMS OF
SERVICE, THE PROGRAMS
IMPLEMENTED BY 41 OF THE 58
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE SERVES
AN AVERAGE OF 3400 FAMILIES PER
MONTH. AND THAT'S BASED ON 2023
NUMBERS. SO AGAIN, WE ARE HERE.
THIS WAS ALSO DONE IN TERMS OF
THE ACTUAL DOLLAR AMOUNTS WITH
POINT IN TIME DATA UTILIZATION.
WE ARE SEEING THAT COUNTIES ARE
SPENDING AT A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
CLIP. SO BASED ON THAT CHANGE
OVER TIME, THERE IS POTENTIAL IN
THIS PARTICULAR PARTICULAR
REDUCTION, PROPOSED REDUCTION
THAT FAMILIES CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SERVICES COULD BE
IMPACTED. SO AGAIN, BECAUSE IT
WAS A POINT IN TIME, THIS IS
WHAT THE UTILIZATION RATE WAS
SHOWING US, THERE'S A POTENTIAL
WITH THE AMOUNT PROPOSED THAT IT
COULD IMPACT EXISTING. HOW LONG
DO THOSE SERVICES LAST? SO CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING HAS A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT MODELS.
EACH MODEL IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. SO EVIDENCE BASED. WE
HAVE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP,
HEALTHY FAMILIES AMERICA.
THERE'S A FEW DIFFERENT OTHERS.
AND SO MOST AROUND 18 MONTHS TO
TWO YEARS APPROXIMATELY IN TERMS
OF THE DURATION OF THE
PARTICIPATION. BUT BUT THEY VARY
A LITTLE BIT DEPENDING ON THE
MODEL. SO AND DEPENDING ON THE
COUNTY, I'M ASSUMING EACH COUNTY
IS OPERATING A DIFFERENT I MEAN,
THERE'S CERTAIN I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME. 30
SOME ODD ARE OPERATING NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
WHICH WE'RE BRINGING DOWN LESS
MONEY. THE COUNTIES HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO HEY WE WANT TO
SERVE MORE PEOPLE. SO WE'RE JUST
GOING TO DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF
MONTHS, RIGHT. IF THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION, GOES THROUGH AND WE
ACTUALLY SEE THAT IT IMPACTS
CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS AGAIN,
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA
FOR, WE PROBABLY WE'D LIKELY
GIVE DISCRETION TO COUNTIES TO
SAY WE'LL CONTINUE SERVING
VERSUS NOT ENROLLING NEW
FAMILIES. THOSE KINDS OF
CONSIDERATIONS WOULD BE PART OF
OUR CONVERSATION. OKAY. SO WE
WILL BE TRACKING THIS THEN. YES.
YOU CAN GO ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
OKAY. CALWORKS. MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE, THIS IS A
PROPOSED ELIMINATION. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO REDUCE
FUNDING HERE BY 126.6 MILLION.
IN 24, 25 AND ONGOING, JUST IN
TERMS OF SERVICE LEVELS IN 2020
2223, A MONTHLY AVERAGE OF 5628
INDIVIDUALS WERE RECEIVING THESE
SERVICES, WOULD NOTE HERE, THAT
THE INTENT OF THESE PARTICULAR
FUNDS WAS TO BE THE NON-MEDICAL
COMPONENTS OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. SO THOSE THAT
WOULD FIT WITHIN THE MEDI-CAL
AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES WOULD
BE ADDRESSED. BUT THESE ARE
INTENDED TO FULFILL AND ADDRESS
ANY GAPS, IN TERMS OF
UTILIZATION THÀNH EXPENDITURE
HISTORY, FOR THIS PARTICULAR
FUND, EXPENDITURES IN 2122 WERE
AT 87 MILLION. OF THE 126.6 AND
2223, THEY WERE AT 89 MILLION,
IN IN CURRENT YEAR, WHICH OF
COURSE IS STILL CLOSING OUT.
THEY WERE AT 41 MILLION AT OUR
LAST COUNT. SO THAT'S A THAT'S A
THAT NUMBER WOULD BE UPDATED
BASED ON FINAL EXPENDITURES. SO
THERE IS SOME UNDERUTILIZATION,
BUT AGAIN THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM RIGHT. YOU
KNOW, I LOOK AT THIS ONE, I MEAN
, IF YOU CAN'T ASSUME EVERYONE
ON CALWORKS IS ON MEDI-CAL, BUT
A GOOD PORTION ARE RIGHT. AND
MEDI-CAL SHOULD COVER THESE
SERVICES, I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY, THEY ARE CATEGORICALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI-CAL SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY ASSUME ASSUME THAT,
THAT THAT SAID, OUR INSTRUCTION
TO THE COUNTIES IN THE PAST HAS
BEEN THAT THIS FUNDING IS TO BE
UTILIZED FOR THINGS THAT ARE NOT
COVERED BY MEDI-CAL. SO THEY MAY
CONTRACT THAT EITHER THEMSELVES
PROVIDE OR CONTRACT WITH CBOS
WHO PROVIDE OTHER KINDS OF
SERVICES THAT WOULD NOT
TYPICALLY HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY, AND BELOW
MEDI-CAL. SO NOW, THAT SAID, WE
HAVE RECENTLY MADE SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSIONS UNDER THE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ARENA. AND SO IT IS OUR
HOPE THAT SHOULD THIS RESOLUTION
BE ENACTED, THERE WOULD BE
BETTER AND GREATER CONNECTIONS
TO THOSE EXPANDING SERVICES THAT
ARE EXISTING ON THE DCS. AND
HOPEFULLY WITH PROP ONE ALSO
THAT'S FOCUSING ON SUD AND SO
FORTH. YEAH, I MEAN, THIS ONE
MAKES MAKES MAKES SENSE AND THEN
WE WON'T HEAR MUCH OF THAT ON
OTHER ISSUES. BUT UNDERSTOOD,
AND THEN FINALLY THE CALWORKS
SINGLE ALLOCATION PROPOSAL, THIS
IS A ONE TIME PROPOSED REDUCTION
IN EMPLOYMENT SERVICES OF $272
MILLION, I WOULD NOTE HERE THAT
AND JUST BACKING UP A LITTLE
BIT. RIGHT. WE KNOW THE CALWORKS
SINGLE ALLOCATION IS FUNGIBLE,
MEANING THAT THERE'S THREE
COMPONENTS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
ONE OF THOSE ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATIONS AND OTHER. AND
THEN CAL LEARN, WHICH IS FOR
TÍNH PARENTS. THEY CAN BE MOVED
ACROSS EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE
ALLOCATIONS WITHIN EACH ONE. AND
SO WE WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE
THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
CALWORKS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND
FAIRLY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
UTILIZATION IS, IT WOULD HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HAVE AN IMPACT TO
THE ELIGIBILITY OFFERINGS AND
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THAT
FUNGIBILITY, JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE, EXPENDITURES FOR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES, 49%
EXPENDED IN 21, 22, 51% FROM THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION. THIS IS JUST
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. I'M GOING
TO GIVE YOU BOTH. SO THIS IS
JUST EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
EXPENDITURE HISTORY 49% 2122 51%
AND 2223 AROUND 51% IN 2324
CURRENT YEAR. BUT OF COURSE,
THAT WILL BE UPDATED FOR THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION IN TOTALITY,
K¾T EXPENDITURES WERE AT 80% IN
2122, 88% IN 22, 23 AND 71%
CURRENT YEAR. OF COURSE, AGAIN
TO BE UPDATED. SO WE'VE TAKEN
EARLY ACTION ON THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION, AND THEN THERE'S THE
41 MILLION ONGOING. AND THEN
THERE'S THIS ONE TIME FOR
INCOMING FISCAL YEAR OF 272,
ADDING ALL THOSE WONDERFUL
NUMBERS UP. WHAT IS GOING TO BE
THE NEW PROPOSED ONGOING SINGLE
ALLOCATION FUNDING ACROSS OUR 58
COUNTIES? I HAVE THAT FOR YOU
BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE ONE POINT,
WHAT WAS IT, 1.2 BILLION, 1.7
BILLION BEFORE? I FEEL LIKE YOU
GOT IT. WE HAVE, EMILY MARSHALL,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THE 41
MILLION IS THE ONGOING. WE DID
THE EARLY REVERSION OF THE 278
POINT IN TIME. AND NOW, WE WILL
TRUE UP THAT NUMBER, BUT AND
THEN WE HAVE THE NOW PROPOSED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. SO THE 41
IS THE ONGOING THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING. OKAY. SO ONGOING
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT FOR 41
MILLION MINUS THE 1.7 BILLION
ONGOING SHOULD BE THE NEW
NUMBER. BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
THESE ARE JUST PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND JUST FOR THIS UPCOMING YEAR,
THE MAY REVISION DOES ASSUME A
$1.3 BILLION TOTAL FOR THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION IN 2425. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE, THE DECREASES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THERE'S ALSO
ADJUSTMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE.
SO WHILE WHILE THERE IS A $272
MILLION REDUCTION THAT WAS MADE
AS A REDUCTION, THERE'S ALSO AN
INCREASE. SO THERE'S AN OFFSET
TO THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES CASELOAD
GROWTH THAT WE'RE ACCOUNTING
FOR. SO THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES FUNDING IS
NOT NECESSARILY CHANGING BY THE
272, EVEN THOUGH THE 272 IS THE
272 REDUCTION. AND JUST IT IS IN
OTHER WORDS, NET OF MULTIPLE
THINGS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME. AND IT'S A DECREASE OF
$162 MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
JUST TO GIVE YOU THAT FIGURE AS
WELL DIRECTOR, I THINK I MIGHT
HAVE BEEN LOST WITH ALL THESE
NUMBERS. YEAH OKAY. BECAUSE AND
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES, ARE WE
TALKING, ARE WE THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR SINGLE
ALLOCATION IS THAT THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT OR THE
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM,
THOSE ARE ADDITIONAL. NO, I
KNOW, BUT THERE'S FLEXIBILITY.
ALL SINGLE ALLOCATION RIGHT.
SURE. SO LET ME TRY THIS. SO WE
HAVE THE CALWORKS ALLOCATION
AGAIN CAL LEARN ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION AND EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY AS A
SERVICE COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM
WE HAVE THE EXPANDED SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT. THAT'S THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL THAT'S CONTINUING TO
MAY REVISION, IN ADDITION, AS WE
WERE DOING METHODOLOGY FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE OF THE CALWORKS
ADMIN, WE LOOKED AT INTENSIVE
CASE HOURS, SOMETHING ELSE
THAT'S BASICALLY SAYING HOW MANY
FOR INTENSIVE CASES, HOW MANY
HOURS SHOULD WE BE RESOURCING.
AND WE'VE PROPOSED TO HOLD THAT
AT 8.5 HOURS AS OPPOSED TO GOING
UP TO TEN HOURS, WHICH IS WHAT
WE PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED. OKAY,
SOME COUNTIES UTILIZE ALL THEIR
FUNDING, SOME COUNTIES DON'T.
HAVE WE GOTTEN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING? IS THIS ARE THESE
CUTS ACROSS ALL COUNTIES? IS
THERE FLEXIBILITY TO
REDISTRIBUTE TO THE COUNTIES
THAT ACTUALLY USE ALL OF IT? WE
FREQUENTLY DO REDISTRIBUTE
FUNDING FOR COUNTIES. WE DO A
MID-YEAR REDISTRIBUTION BASED ON
HOW EXPENDITURES ARE GOING. BUT
AGAIN, WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IN
TOTALITY, WHEN YOU LOOK IN
TOTALITY OF THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS, AS
WELL AS WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN
MAY, WHILE THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES PARTICULAR PROPOSED
REDUCTION IS EQUIVALENT TO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING ON UTILIZATION,
BECAUSE OF THE FUNGIBILITY AND
BECAUSE ELIGIBILITY IS ALMOST
ALWAYS OVERSPENT, WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE SOME ANTICIPATED
NEED, YOU KNOW, ISSUES WITH
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION. THE
272 PROPOSED. CORRECT. AND ARE
WE PROPOSING A TOP SWEEP REMOVAL
OR ARE WE PROPOSING A SWEEP
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY SIZE AND
SO FORTH? NO, IT'S WE WOULD WE
WOULD, WE WOULD DISTRIBUTE
TOWARDS OUR OWN METHODOLOGY OF
CASELOAD BY COUNTY. GOT IT.
OKAY, AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT,
IT'S STILL. THE ONE, TWO, THREE
ADDITIONAL CALWORKS PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING. I MEAN,
DIRECTOR LUTZ, I MEAN, I WANT TO
FOCUS ON TWO THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT. I MEAN, DID WE GO BACK
THE FAMILY STABILIZATION PROGRAM
? WE WENT BACK AND WE JUST
THOUGHT, NOT THOUGHT. IS THERE
NOT NUMBERS TO, TO SUPPORT THE
NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM? DID WE
FIND NUMBERS THAT LOW
UTILIZATION? DID WE. SO EACH OF
THESE PROPOSALS HAS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT STORY. SO FOR FAMILY
STABILIZATION IT IS FULLY SPENT
FULLY SPENT. YOU KNOW I AND
CORRECT ME SEE IF I GOT THESE
NUMBERS RIGHT FOR 2324. OUR
STATE ALLOCATION IN GENERAL FUND
MONEY FOR CALWORKS WAS $1.4
BILLION. THE PROPOSED STATE
ALLOCATION FOR CALWORKS FOR THE
NEXT YEAR, $240 MILLION. THAT IS
A HUGE CUT. AND TELL ME IF I'M
MAKING THAT NUMBER UP. LET ME
LET ME GIVE YOU THE WE HAVE THE
FEDERAL FUND AND ALL THAT. SURE.
YEAH. THE SO THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES 5.7 BILLION TOTAL FUNDS
FOR CALWORKS, 2.6 BILLION OF
WHICH IS GENERAL FUND. THAT'S A
DECREASE OF 440.5 MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND THAT REFLECTS THE REDUCED
FUNDING FOR CALWORKS EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES, HOME VISITING, MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE, AND
THEN ALSO HAS THE LOWER CALWORKS
ASSISTANCE EXPENDITURES IN
INCREASES IN THE SHARED
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDI-CAL. SO
THAT'S 5.77 BILLION IS A TOTAL
RIGHT, 5.7 BILLION TOTAL FUNDS,
2.6 OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND, IS
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL FOR
CALWORKS OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION. SURE DO I HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT GRAPH? YES. THIS
IS THE THIS IS THE CDSS
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY. WE'RE GLAD TO
ENSURE THAT YOU ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. LÀ COMMENTS
ON CALWORKS. YES. THANK YOU.
SONIA LARUSSO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
WOULD FIRST NOTE THAT WE'RE IN
THE INITIAL STAGES OF OUR
ANALYSIS AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
SO OUR COMMENTS TODAY PRIMARILY
REFLECT KEY QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THAT WE INTEND TO ENGAGE WITH
THEM ON IN THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS. MANY OF WHICH HAVE
ALREADY BEEN RAISED, BUT THAT I
WILL RE HIGHLIGHT AS NECESSARY.
SO TURNING FIRST TO THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS TO HOME VISITING AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES, AS MENTIONED,
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES REDUCTION IS AN
ELIMINATION OF ALL FUNDS FOR
THAT PROGRAM. WHEREAS THE HOME
VISITING PROPOSAL IS, JUST A
REDUCTION AND SOME FUNDS WILL
REMAIN. HOWEVER AS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON MENTIONED, THERE ARE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE AS WELL
THAT THIS MAY CUT INTO LOCAL
SERVICE DELIVERY LEVELS, GIVEN
THE HISTORICAL EXPENDITURES
WITHIN THE HOME, VISITING
PROGRAM. SO OUR QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THESE TWO
REDUCTIONS, CENTER AROUND
CASELOAD AND UTILIZATION, AS
WELL AS HISTORICAL EXPENDITURES.
AND THEN ADDING ON TO THAT,
GIVEN THÀNH THE UNUSUAL NATURE
OF THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, HOW
CAN WE LOOK FORWARD AND
ANTICIPATE? WILL WE SEE CHANGES
IN EXPENDITURES AND UTILIZATION
GIVEN WE'RE MOVING BACK INTO A
SEMI-NORMAL SITUATION AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL? WE'RE ALSO
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS THAT THESE REDUCTIONS
MIGHT HAVE ON THEIR CURRENT
RECIPIENTS. A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED
AROUND FOR EXAMPLE, THOSE
RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES. GIVEN
THIS IS A PROPOSED TOTAL
ELIMINATION, WILL THEY JUST ONE
DAY NO LONGER RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES, THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HOPE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
OPERATIONAL ASPECTS OF THESE
PROPOSALS. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, AS YOU HAD
HIGHLIGHTED, IN TERMS OF
SPECIFICALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE, PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS, ARE THERE AREAS THAT
COUNTIES CAN TAP INTO TO POINT
THEIR CALWORKS RECIPIENTS TO
RECEIVE THESE SERVICES AT A
LOCAL LEVEL? IF THESE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS WERE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED, AND THEN FINALLY ON
ON THE FRONT OF THE HOME,
VISITING AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROPOSALS. WE DO
HAVE QUESTIONS AROUND HOW THESE
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS MIGHT IMPACT
THE STATE'S PERFORMANCE, IN THE
POTENTIAL PILOT THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS, GIVEN THE FOCUS THAT
THE PILOT HAS NOT ONLY ON WORK
OUTCOMES BUT ALSO ON FAMILY
STABILITY. SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT
AS WE CONSIDER THESE MORE
PROGRAMMATIC REDUCTIONS. TURNING
TO THE PROPOSED REDUCTIONS TO
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION, IT WOULD
MAKE A COUPLE OF CLARIFICATIONS
THAT I'M NOT 100% SURE HAVE COME
THROUGH IN THE CONVERSATION YET,
THE EARLY ACTION ITEM THAT YOU
MENTIONED IS NOT NECESSARILY, A
REDUCTION THAT IMPACTS THE
BUDGET YEAR FUNDING, IT'S FROM A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING TO NOTE. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, ANOTHER ITEM THAT
I THINK HAS NOT BEEN MENTIONED
QUITE YET IS THAT OUR INITIAL
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE WILL
ALSO BE A ONE INCREMENT DECREASE
IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
ELIGIBILITY COMPONENT OF THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION, WHICH COMES
ALONG WITH CASELOAD DECREASE.
REYES. SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE AND THE ADMINISTRATION, BASED
ON OUR UNDERSTANDING, HAD
ANTICIPATED. OF COURSE, GIVEN
THAT'S HOW THE METHODOLOGY
WORKS, THE ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION, YES, YES, FOR
THAT'S HOW THAT METHODOLOGY HAS
HISTORICALLY WORKED. AND
CONTINUES TO WORK. BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY LISTED IN THE ITEM
BY ITEM LIST OF REDUCTIONS, BUT
IS SOMETHING THAT COUNTIES WILL
FACE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO IT
DOES RAISE CONCERNS FOR US AND
QUESTIONS AROUND WHAT LOCAL
SERVICE DELIVERY WILL LOOK LIKE,
NOT ONLY ON THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES FRONT, BUT ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND ELIGIBILITY
FRONT. OKAY, THE ONLY QUESTION
I'D LIKE TO PULL OUT FROM THAT
FOR, FOR, FOR NOW IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION PART. I THINK I
WAS INTERESTED IN KNOWING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE SERVING, ARE IN
SERVICES FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUD. WHAT DOES THAT LOOK, WHAT
DOES THAT TRANSITION LOOK LIKE?
I'LL SAY A COUPLE THINGS,
PLEASE. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ARROYO, PLEASE ADD ON, YEAH. SO
I THINK THE COMMITMENT TO YOUR
POINT OF ENSURING THAT ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT
EXISTING MEDI-CAL SERVICES CAN
BE EASILY BRIDGED, WE WOULD WANT
TO MAKE SURE BOTH DEPARTMENTS
WERE SUPPORTING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AND OCCUR. BUT THIS THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS A
PROPOSED ELIMINATION. SO IT
WOULD REQUIRE US TO DO POLICY
GUIDANCE OUT TO THE COUNTIES.
THE COUNTIES WOULD THEN HAVE TO
DO NOTICE OF ACTIONS TO THE
INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED. RIGHT.
THESE ARE TYPICAL PROCESS STEPS
THAT WE'D HAVE ON CHANGES TO ANY
POLICY. SO IT WOULD TAKE US SOME
TIME TO, PUT PUT THOSE THINGS
FORWARD. THIS REMINDED ME IN THE
HEALTH SECTION, MR. MYMP. MR.
MYP MR. MYP, THERE'S A PROGRAM
CALLED MR. MYP. AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO ELIMINATE IT. AND
THERE'S PEOPLE ON HEALTH
INSURANCE RIGHT NOW, AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO ELIMINATE IT AND
TRANSITION THOSE PEOPLE TO LIKE
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND WHAT HAVE
YOU. SO THIS REMINDS ME OF THAT.
AND THE QUESTION I ASKED IS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
TRANSITION. SO ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SCORE ALL OF THIS
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR IF IT
POTENTIALLY TAKES US SOME TIME
TO TRANSITION? I'LL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF THEY WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING HERE, SO FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
SERVICES, THESE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE
THROUGH EXISTING FUNDING AND
INITIATIVES CURRENTLY UNDERWAY.
AGAIN, IT IS NOT THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE MERITS OF THESE
PROGRAMS. IT IS BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO FILL THIS BUDGET
SHORTFALL. AND WE LOOKED YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, I GET THAT
PART. BUT PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
SERVICES RIGHT NOW, I DON'T
THINK JULY 1ST THEY'RE GOING TO
FALL OFF. SO SAY SOMEONE'S IN AN
INPATIENT TREATMENT CENTER,
THROUGH CALWORKS AND, YOU KNOW,
WE PASS THIS BUDGET AND THIS
GOES THROUGH JULY 1ST. DO THEY
GET KICKED OUT, SO I THINK THIS
IS OUR ESTIMATE FOR THE SOLUTION
, SORT OF ESCORTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. I THINK AS WE
WORK TOWARDS OPERATIONALIZE
EASING, ANY OF THE SOLUTIONS, IF
ADOPTED ULTIMATELY BY THE
LEGISLATURE, WE THINK THROUGH
THOSE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE SORT
OF SCORE APPROPRIATELY. SO WE
YEAH. BECAUSE SO THERE'S
POTENTIAL THAT THE FULL 127
WON'T BE SCORED THIS UPCOMING
FISCAL YEAR. IF THERE'S GOING TO
BE A TRANSITION TO GET PEOPLE
OFF OF SERVICES THAT ARE THAT
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
RIGHT NOW IN SERVICES AS
ENVISIONED ARE SORT OF OUR GOAL
IS TO SORT OF SCORE THOSE
SAVINGS. IF ADOPTED, AS I
MENTIONED. BUT WE WOULD SORT OF
SEE BASED ON SORT OF THE TIMING
OF ACTIVITIES LAID OUT BY THE
DIRECTOR TO SEE WHAT SORT OF
SOLUTIONS ARE ULTIMATELY
REALIZED. I THINK I GOT GOT A
SOMEWHAT OF AN ANSWER. DIRECT
OUTLOOK, YOU KNOW, AS PART OF
HIS BUDGET PROCESS AND UPDATE ON
HOW THAT TRANSITION PROCESS IS
GOING, YOU KNOW, IF I'M, SAY A.
CALWORKS PERSON TWO HOURS AGO
STARTED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES,
IT'S LIKE A MINIMUM OF TEN
SESSIONS, RIGHT? THAT'S TEN
WEEKS. THAT'S PAST THE INTO THE
NEW FISCAL. I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THAT IN
THOSE KIND OF SITUATIONS AND
PERHAPS GETTING A HOLD OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. RIGHT, SEE HOW THAT
TRANSITION THAT. YEAH, THE
TRANSITION LOOKS LIKE PAST
BUDGET CONVERSATIONS. OKAY. SO
THAT WAS, ANYTHING ON CALWORKS
PUBLIC COMMENT ON CALWORKS NOW?
YES. KEVIN ESTÁN COALITION,
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION, A COUPLE OF
ISSUES. ONE IS THE TRANSITION
FOR, MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. THAT'S A MEDICAL SERVICE.
MOST OF THE FOLKS ARE IN PREPAID
HEALTH PLANS, AND THAT SHOULD BE
MANDATED THAT THEY GET THAT
SERVICE. AND THAT'S HOW I MEAN,
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE PROBLEM
IS, BUT WHY DO WE HAVE TO SPEND
MORE MONEY WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE
PREPAID PREPAID HEALTH PLANS?
THE OTHER THING WE OPPOSE THE
CAL WORKS CUTS. THE CALWORKS
BUDGET HAS $9.4 BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR IT. ONLY 4.4 IS
USED FOR PAYMENT TO FAMILIES. OF
THAT 5 BILLION THAT IS
AVAILABLE, 2.8 BILLION IS USED
IN THE BUDGET. AS FOR NON
CALWORKS PROGRAM RAIMES, THAT
MEANS WHEN THEY BUILD A BUDGET,
FIRST OF ALL, THEY RIP OFF $2.8
BILLION FROM CALWORKS AND START
BUILDING THE BLOCKS. THANK YOU
KEVIN. AND I THINK THAT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
EVERYONE, ANDREW, SHANE, GRACE
AND CHILD POVERTY CALIFORNIA. WE
DEEPLY OPPOSE THE CUTS. I COULD
SPEND MY WHOLE TIME ON IT, BUT
WE HAD YOUTH IN TEARS YESTERDAY
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THEY ARE
AT THEIR WIT'S END, AND I KNOW
YOU KNOW THIS, BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THE TOTAL CUTS THAT WE
SCORE IS 764 MILLION. THE 440 IS
THE MAY REVISION. THAT'S ON TOP
OF, AS YOU NOTED, THE EARLIER
CUTS, WHICH IS ABOUT ANOTHER 300
MILLION. RIGHT. SO IT'S THREE,
764, GIVE OR TAKE. I WOULD
UNDERSCORE THAT ALTHOUGH IT'S
OVER MY BODY, IF WE DO CUT
FAMILY STABILIZATION, WE WILL
DEMAND A HOLD HARMLESS BECAUSE
THAT THEN SUBJECTS FOLKS TO
SANCTION. IN ADDITION TO TAKING
AWAY THE LIFE SAVING SERVICES ON
THE WINDS, I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THIS CREATES A HUNGER
CLIFF. THIS IS A REAL BENEFIT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING RIGHT NOW.
AND WHY TAKE IT OUT OF STATUTE?
WHY TAKE IT OUT OF STATUTE ON
TOP OF DEFUNDING? WE DEFER TO
CDVA, BUT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS BY THE DIRECTOR IN LEO
THAT WE DO THINK THAT THE SINGLE
CUTS ARE DEEP ENOUGH TO GET INTO
ACTUAL SERVICE PROVISION ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. ECHOING KEVIN, WE DO
THINK THAT THERE'S POTENTIAL
THROUGH CALUMET UNDER FUNDING
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES. BUT HOW
ARE WE GOING TO NOT JUST HAVE
THE TRANSITION BUT AT THE CASE
MANAGEMENT LEVEL? HOW IS THE
COUNTY WORKER GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE HEALTH CARE IS THEN
GETTING RIGHT THOSE THOSE
NON-MEDICAL SERVICES? THANK YOU,
ANDREW, ON THE FRA, WE'RE SO
EXCITED FOR THE PROVISIONAL
AUTHORITY. WE THINK WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE ON FAMILY CENTERED.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING, REBECCA
GONZALES WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. WE'RE STILL
CONCERNED AND OPPOSE THE JANUARY
CUTS TO THE CALWORKS PROGRAM,
ESPECIALLY TO THE FAMILY
STABILIZATION PROGRAM AND THE
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM,
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WHAT MAKE OUR
CALWORKS PROGRAM REALLY WORK,
AND THEIR ELIMINATION RUNS
COUNTER TO THE STATED DESIRE TO
BE PART OF THE FEDERAL PILOT
PROGRAM. IN THE MAY REVISE, WE
OPPOSE THE DEEP CUTS TO THE
CALWORKS HOME VISITING PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM HAS REALLY GOOD
OUTCOMES AND IT PREVENTS CHILD
WELFARE REFERRALS. IS ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CALWORKS
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SERVICES PROGRAM, ANOTHER
CRITICAL PROGRAM WHICH
STABILIZES FAMILIES, IMPROVES
CHILD SAFETY AND PREVENTS CHILD
WELFARE REFERRALS. LASTLY, WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK CDSS
FOR REQUESTING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE AND FUNDING FOR THE
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY ACT PILOT
PROGRAMS, WHICH CAN MAKE
CALWORKS LESS PUNITIVE AND MORE
FAMILY CENTERED. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO FINALLY REALIZE LONG OVERDUE
REFORMS TO THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. VANESSA KAHENA ON BEHALF
OF THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP,
ONE OF THE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING MODELS THAT IS
DELIVERED IN ABOUT 22 COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY,
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, JUST FOR
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. WE
HAVE QUERIED SOME OF OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS, AND WE HAVE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THEM THAT THE CALWORKS
CUT, AT 47 MILLION ONGOING,
WOULD RESULT IN A CEASE OF
OPERATIONS. AND SO WE HAVE A
PROGRAM IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR NURSE HOME
VISITORS WORKING THROUGH A
MEDICAL OFFICE WITH 100 FAMILIES
THAT THEY'RE SERVING THAT IS
CONCERNED THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
TO ENTIRELY CEASE SERVICES. SO
FOR THAT REASON, ACROSS THE
BOARD, ALL THESE CALWORKS CUTS
HURT REALLY VULNERABLE FAMILIES.
WE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THEM.
THANK YOU. HI, EVERYBODY, DARBY
KIERNAN, ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION, WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE CALWORKS HOME VISITING CUTS
AS WELL, THEY'LL HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN'S AND
FAMILIES WHO DEPEND ON THIS
CRUCIAL PARENTING AND FAMILY
SUPPORT. THE PROGRAM WORKS TO
STABILIZE FAMILIES, AND THIS CUT
WILL DO THE OPPOSITE FOR THOSE
FAMILIES CURRENTLY BEING SERVED.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING, MARION
SUZANO CHILD CARE LAW CENTER
EVERY PERSON HAS THE RIGHT TO
PROVIDE THE BEST FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND RAISE THEIR
CHILDREN WITH DIGNITY. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT ANY
CUTS TO THE CALARTS PROGRAM.
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THE GREAT
COMMENTS MADAM CHAIR MADE TODAY,
EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
CHILD CARE. THANK YOU. THANKS
KIM. KIM LEWIS AGAIN WITH
CHILDREN. NOW, I JUST WANTED TO
ECHO OUR COMMENTS WITH THE END
CHILD POVERTY AROUND CUTS TO
CALWORKS AND SPECIFICALLY TO THE
HOME VISITING PROGRAM, AND KNOW
THAT, THESE CUTS WILL HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ONTO OUR
PROGRAMS. AS WE'VE JUST BEEN
COMING OUT OF THE POST PANDEMIC.
AND, WE HAVE TALKED TO SOME OF
OUR FAMILIES AND PROGRAMS
ALREADY IN MONTEREY COUNTY, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY'RE ON TRACK TO
FULLY EXHAUST 100% OF THEIR
FUNDING, SERVING 107 FAMILIES,
THEY WOULD IMMEDIATELY HAVE TO
INSTITUTE A WAITLIST AND LIKELY
HAVE TO MAKE OTHER DRASTIC CUTS
COME IN THE NEW YEAR. SHOULD
THEY HAVE TO PROCEED. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON OTHER CUTS FOR
THE PROGRAMS AND HOW THIS WOULD
BE IMPACTED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. KATHY SONDERLING
MCDONNELL FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THE COMPONENTS OF CALWORKS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY
WERE LAYERED ON OVER THE LAST 26
YEARS WHEN WE SAW GAPS IN THE
PROGRAM. WE'D FIND THE GAP, WE'D
FILL THE GAP HOME. VISITING
FAMILY STABILIZATION, THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND THINGS AND
EVERYTHING THING THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. SO IN ONE MOVE,
THEY'RE SWEPT AWAY HERE WHERE
IT'S KIND OF LIKE WE'RE
REINTRODUCING THE SWISS CHEESE
ALL AT THE SAME TIME. AND PEOPLE
WILL LOSE SERVICES. COUNTIES
CAN'T SPEND MONEY THEY DON'T
HAVE IF THEIR ALLOCATION GOES
DOWN BY THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
THAT IT WOULD GO DOWN IN EVERY
COUNTY, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE CUTS. AND SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE REAL IMPACTS TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RECEIVING THE SERVICES.
THERE'S JUST NO WAY AROUND IT.
SO YES, OF COURSE THERE'S THIS
IS A HORRIBLE BUDGET YEAR. THIS
FEELS LIKE A SITUATION WHERE ALL
OF THESE CUTS HAPPENING AT ONCE
DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF SENSE FOR
THIS PROGRAM. I KNOW WE'RE IN A
TERRIBLE BUDGET YEAR, BUT WE
URGE MORE CONVERSATION AND
THINKING TOGETHER. WHAT'S THE
PROGRAM WE WANT TO SEE, AND HOW
DO WE FUND THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DELIVER IT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL? THANK YOU. THANKS
EILEEN KAMINSKY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ACROSS THE HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT MY MEMBERS
ADMINISTER, THE MAY REVISION IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET COMBINED CAN
CONTAIN A TOTAL OF $1.3 BILLION
IN CUTS. AND THIS IS JUST THE
PROGRAMS THAT MY MEMBERS
ADMINISTER. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT IS IN CALWORKS. IT'S TO
ANDREW'S POINT, OVER $750
MILLION, MUCH OF THAT ONGOING
AND IT'S GOING TO DECIMATE THE
CALWORKS PROGRAM FOR THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION. WE'RE LOOKING AT
YEAR OVER YEAR REDUCTIONS OF
$355 MILLION IN AVAILABLE
FUNDING OVERALL THAT MASKS
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
COMPONENTS. THE ELIGIBILITY
COMPONENT IS UNDERFUNDED BY
ABOUT 400 MILLION. IT'S HALF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SHIFT.
I'M SO SORRY. I HAVE TO GET A I
HAVE TO DO A QUICK RECESS. OH,
OKAY. I HAVE TO DO A QUICK
RECESS. WE'RE WE STAYED IN THE
BUILDING. JUST. YEAH, WE HAVE TO
TAKE A QUICK RECESS, STAY IN
PLACE. YEAH, DON'T LEAVE THE
AREA FOR YOU. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. JUST STAY IN YOUR SEATS,
OKAY? YEAH ALL RIGHT. DON'T
LEAVE THIS AREA THAT DOESN'T.
I'M GONNA MOVE MY STUFF. DID YOU
. KNOW COOL, COOL. YOU CAN'T GO
ANYWHERE. YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
LEAVE NOW. I DON'T TAKE SECURITY
ISSUE. YEAH. SEE YOU.
SPECULATING. WHAT IS? YEAH. YOU
HAVE TO STAY
.
BUDGET'S UP. THREE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HAS TO ADJOURN.
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO CONTINUE,
FURTHER. WE WILL GET BACK TO YOU
ON OUR AVAILABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS AGAIN. SO SUB THREE
HAS ADJOURNED. YOU COULD TURN
OFF THE TV